foreign
welcome to this exciting live video
series on data science by simply loan we
are going to have daily live sessions
this week that will cover all the
important skills to help you master data
science in a week we are going to learn
the leading data science skills and
Technologies each day with our highly
experienced instructors
we will focus on programming with python
and R data visualization SQL machine
learning and more
so without any further delay let's begin
with day one of our data science week
so in this session we are going to Learn
Python Programming and understand the
mathematical Concepts required for data
science jobs
python is the most popular programming
language for data science and machine
learning and provides a collection of
libraries such as numpy pandas
matplotlib scikit-learn Etc to analyze
data and build prediction models you
will learn all the basics and advanced
concepts of Python Programming such as
Loops functions object oriented
programming Etc mathematics is equally
essential for creating efficient models
you need to learn statistics probability
calculus and linear algebra to
understand the working of machine
learning algorithms so let's dive deep
and Learn Python from scratch that's
the core readability and English like
commands that make coding a lot easier
and efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language python
has interpreted high level general
purpose programming language developed
by Widow and rossim at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that python was named
after display python was actually named
after the show Monty Python's Flying
Circus Guido and Rossum formulated
python in the late 1980s as a successor
to the ABC language in 1994 python
version 1.0 was released with features
like exception handling Lambda map
filter and reduce python 2.0 released in
2000 introduced features like list
comprehensions and a garbage collection
system capable of collecting reference
Cycles python 3.0 was released on the
3rd of December 2008. undoubtedly Python
2.x and 3.x have proven to be the most
used versions as of today python 3.7.4
is the latest stable version released in
the summer of 2019. python is popularly
used for development scripting and
software testing top ID companies like
Google Facebook Instagram Spotify and
Netflix among others use Python some
major applications of python can be seen
in the fields of machine learning
artificial intelligence data science and
iot python also offers many libraries
like numpy sci-fi Keras tensorflow
Django and flask pep 8 is the official
style guide that defines the styling
conventions for python code a few
popular open source python projects
include fit EnV statistics solving the
traveling salesman problem using
self-organizing math and python to BPF
converter some of the trending python
repositories on GitHub today include NLP
ml from scratch pytotch Transformers 100
days of ml code among others popular
websites on the internet like Reddit and
quora are built using python
civilization 4 Battlefield 2 Sims 4 and
World of Tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the US is around 124
000 US Dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonous pythony stars and pythonians
since its Inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry so what
really is Python programming language
python is an object-oriented high-level
programming language that supports
built-in data structures and dynamic
semantics
it's supposed multiple programming
paradigms such as structured object
oriented and functional programming
python is often described as batteries
included language because it has a
comprehensive collection of standard
libraries
python supports different modules and
packages which allows program modularity
and code reuse
python was developed by Guido van Rossum
and its implementation started in
December 1989.
python 1.0 version was released in the
year 1994 python 2.0 came out in October
2000 while python 3.0 was released in
December 2008.
now that you have got an understanding
of the Python programming language let's
now look at the top 10 reasons why you
should learn python
so at number 10 we have ease of use
one of the most common reasons to
listen is that it is quite easy to learn
and code
it provides a simple syntax that
improves readability and makes it easier
to understand so developers can create
any desktop or machine based application
using this language
python is very versatile and is
instrumental in artificial intelligence
and machine learning
we will talk about this later in the
session compared to Java or CC plus plus
it has fewer lines of codes
in the example here we are printing a
hello world program in Java as you can
see
if you have to write a program in Java
you first have to declare the class name
along with its scope
next using curly braces you need to pass
the main method along with its arguments
and then using system.out dot printlnm
method you can print hello world that's
quite a tedious task isn't it
the same task for printing hello world
can be done using just one line of code
in python as shown here you can write
the print function and pass whatever you
want to display inside the brackets and
that will print the output it is so
simple
that is why python is considered as a
high level language and its open source
you can just download it from the
website and start using it
at 9 we have active community
you need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language python has large
community support
it has an extensive and active Community
to assist Engineers developers analysts
and data scientists with expert support
in case of programming errors or issues
with the software
you can just go ahead and put your
queries in the community forum the
community members will address your
queries in real quick time
communities like stack Overflow also
brings many python experts together to
help learners
python enhancement proposals or pep is
where the proposals and the improvements
are announced
also there are a set of recommendations
or core values called the design of
python written by Tim petos that
represents the guiding principles for
python development
up next at 8 we have portable and
extensible
multiple cross language operations can
be performed effectively because python
is portable and extensible in nature
for example if the users have a python
code written on Windows and they want to
execute on a Mac operating system or
Linux operating system or Solaris they
can easily do it without any Amendment
they can also run this code on any
platform flawlessly and without any
interrupt
due to its extensibility feature you can
integrate other programming languages
such as java.net C and C plus plus codes
with python
the components of other programming
languages can be used with python and
thus it can be used to make a
cross-platform suitable application too
so it is a really good feature that
python provides
the next Reason To Learn Python is
testing Frameworks
python supports several built-in
Flawless testing tools and Frameworks
that help in debugging and speeding up
workflows
some of the tools and Frameworks
supported by python are by test selenium
and Splinter
this is the reason for bits every tester
tries to use Python based tools and
Frameworks to test any application or
code or to validate it in an easier
manner
Pi test is the most recommended testing
framework for functional integrational
and unit testing
you can run selenium test scripts using
Python programming language to automate
various tasks and Splinter is an open
source tool for testing web applications
using python
it lets you automate browser actions
such as visiting URLs and interacting
with their items
at number 6 we have libraries and
packages
another reason why python has become so
popular in the industry these days is
that it has a massive collection of
libraries and packages that make your
task simple and easy
it has a range of libraries packages
Frameworks and modules for data
manipulation statistical calculation web
learning data science
python programmers have developed tons
of Open Source libraries that you can
use
you can find many of them via pythax the
repository provides the default packet
Anaconda is a third party python
ecosystem other examples include numpy
scipy and xango
then we have scripting and automation
python is not just a programming
language it can also be used for writing
scripts for automating tasks and
workflows without human intervention
the code can be written in the form of
scripts and executed later for it is
interpreted by the machine and checked
for errors at runtime the machine is
used to read and interpret the code
once the developer checks the code it
can further run or be used several times
without any interruption
this allows you to automate a set of
certain tasks within a program or the
same code can be used with other
applications as well
at number 4 we have web development
another reason to Learn Python is that
it makes the web development process so
much easier
it provides a wide collection of
Frameworks that make it easier for
developers to develop web applications
some of the examples are Django flask
pyramid turbo gears cherry pie Etc
these Frameworks are written in Python
which makes the code a lot faster and
stable
the task which used to take hours in PHP
can be finished in minutes using python
python is also used for web scraping
Django offers many elements of intricate
programs such as template design
management panel signing in signing up
signing out URL routing Etc
once the user establishes the framework
all these features become ready to use
flask
is a microwave framework written in
Python
of all the components that are part of
this module they are all ready to
execute in the server context
Pinterest and Linkedin use flask
pyramid offers more attributes than
flask it will assist users with URL
routing and authentication support
turbo gears is a highly recommended and
scalable framework that supports
features such as authentication caching
identification management of sessions
and pluggable applications
up next at number three
we have machine learning
the growth of machine learning has been
phenomenal in the last five years and
it's rapidly changing the world around
us
python is one of the most preferred
programming languages for machine
learning because of its simple syntax
and support for several machine learning
libraries
using different libraries and functions
in Python the system can learn and train
itself from past data
once the system is trained it can then
learn to adjust itself to new inputs
finally it can make predictions and
perform human-like tasks automatically
at number 2 we have data science
machine learning and data science go
hand in hand
python is robust scalable and provides
extensible visualization and Graphics
options hence it is widely used in data
science
python is libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas for
operations to manipulate data on
numerical tables and time series it also
provides simpi for symbolic computation
and sci-fi for Technical and scientific
computations
it has another Library called Pi brain
which is sought for python-based
reinforcement learning artificial
intelligence and neural network
liability scikit-learn is the machine
learning library for creating
classification regression and clustering
algorithms and finally it provides Pi
torch and tensorflow for deep learning
finally coming to the most important and
the top reason to Learn Python which is
career opportunities and salary
Python language provides a variety of
job opportunities and Promises a high
growth graph with huge salary prospects
it has been used by most of the tech
Giants
industry leaders using python are Amazon
Google Facebook IBM NASA Netflix and
YouTube
next you can see the Google Trends
but I have considered three programming
languages python Java and C plus I have
compared them for the past 12 months you
can see it clearly on your screens that
python has become a front runner in
terms of popularity and web search
volume
it means people are interested in Python
they want to learn it and use it in
their work
you can also check for the YouTube
search
there also you will find that Python
programming language is the most
searched language on YouTube
now on your screens
you can see the report of pypl which is
popularity of programming language index
it is created by analyzing how often
language tutorials are searched on
Google
it is a leading indicator the raw data
comes from Google Trends
the bar graph depicts that python is the
most popular and widely used programming
language across the globe followed by
Java then JavaScript and c-sharp
the popularity of programming language
index can help you decide which language
to study or which one to use in a new
software project
the next graph shows the popularity of
python and Java over the years starting
from 2004 till the current period which
is 2020 worldwide python is the most
popular language
python grew the most in the Last 5 Years
by 19.4 percent and Java lost the most
by minus 7.2 percent
now let's talk about the different
career opportunities and the job roles
that you can get into If You Learn
Python language
first
you can become a python developer
where you will be asked to write and
test codes debug programs and integrate
applications with third-party web
services
second you can become a web developer
here you will be responsible for writing
server side web application logic python
web developers usually develop back-end
components connect the application with
third-party services and support the
front-end developers by integrating
their work with the python application
you can also become a data analyst if
you know python as a data analyst you
have to gather data from multiple
sources using scripts analyze that data
develop and Implement databases and data
collection systems
you can become a data scientist
as a data scientist you need to
understand the challenges in business
and come up with the best Solutions
using modern tools and techniques to
analyze visualize and build prediction
models to make business decisions
lastly you can be a machine learning
engineer where you can develop
intelligent machines that can learn from
vast volumes of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
so there's a lot of Scopes If You Learn
Python
now let's have a look at the salaries of
some of these job roles
so if you become a python developer you
can earn an average salary of 76 526
dollars per annum in the United States
while in India you can earn an average
of 4 lakhs 98 000 rupees per annum
also
If You Learn Python and become a data
scientist
you can expect an average salary of 113
000 per year in the United States while
in India you can earn an average of 10
lakhs 28 000 rupees per annum
let me now go ahead and call out the 10
reasons for learning python once again
at number 10 we had ease of use at
number nine we had active community at 8
we had the portable and extensible
feature of python at number seven we saw
the testing Frameworks
at six we had libraries and packages
then at 5 we saw scripting and
automation followed by web development
then we had machine learning and data
science at number three and number two
respectively
and finally at number one we had career
opportunities and salary
so who is a python developer let's
answer this so here are some of the
Technologies used by a python developer
pandas Anaconda tensorflow python Ides
Django web framework and patreon a
python developer is one Who develops
backend components of a web application
using python when working as a web
developer now the web Frameworks like
Django and flask are used for this
purpose
a python developer is also the one who
writes effective testable and scalable
python code he also performs data
analysis when working in the field of
data science
so basically a python developer develops
deploys debugs and maintains a project
so let's go through the skill set of a
python developer now the core python
skills that a python developer possesses
are data structures like arrays list
stack queues trees and graphs there's
oop Concepts like inheritance classes
and objects and abstraction this
packages and functions that is importing
external packages into a python code
database and its connection that is
connecting a python backend to a
database like MySQL when it comes to
data science skills there's numpy that
is a library for performing mathematical
calculations
let's pandas that is the library for
storing and manipulating data
efficiently this SCI pi and then there's
matplotlib which is a library for
plotting charts and graphs for a given
data and finally there are machine
learning algorithms which consists of
models like supervised learning
unsupervised Etc now coming to web
developer skills there are Frameworks
like Django and flask for back-end
development of web applications
and then there's web scraping which
includes taking data from websites and
converting that data into usable format
there's API handling which is basically
handling API requests for a web
application to perform server-side
operations and finally there is back-end
connection which basically involves the
back-end part of a web application
usually handled by python Frameworks
now moving on let's look at the python
developer job roles
first up this python web developer now a
python web developer usually writes
server-side code works on the web
Frameworks like Django and flask
collaborates with the data team to
gather end users requirements develops
the server-side platform deploys
applications performs tuning usability
Improvement and automation
moving on next job role is data analyst
now a data analyst generally works on
python libraries including matplotlip
numpy pandas Etc carry out data analysis
collect by using the scripting language
explore data sets gather requirements
tune in applications analyze problems
communicate findings with the team or
stakeholders
the next job role is automation test
engineer
now an automation test engineer usually
works on python test framework tools
including Pi test Pi unit perform
complex system tests troubleshoot code
issues create test scripts design the
automation framework perform a b testing
next up is machine learning engineer
now a machine learning engineer has the
following roles to perform statistical
analysis of data put machine learning
models into production research and
transform data science prototypes
research and Implement appropriate ml
algorithms and tools perform ml tests
and keep updated with the ml trends
the last job role is software engineer
now a software engineer is expected to
write server-side code collaborate with
the design team to gather end users
requirements develop the server-side
platform deploy applications perform
tuning usability Improvement and
automation
moving on to the next topic let's look
at the python developer salary Trends
now software Engineers with python
skills are offered better salaries
across the globe
the average salary of a python developer
in India is around 7 lakhs 55 000 rupees
per annum the average salary of a python
developer in the US is about 79 000 US
dollars per annum
moving on to our last segment python
developer resume
so let's go ahead and understand what a
python developer resume should portray
just keep a few things in mind when
you're preparing your resume
your resume should be clear updated and
concise
you should prioritize the skills
according to the job role you're
applying for and do not write anything
extra that's a big no the recruiters are
smart enough to know that so do not lie
and do not write extra firstly let's
look at the fresher resume so if you're
a fresher these are 10 profile link and
also your GitHub repository link if you
have next up is the projects now clearly
to pick the goal of your project so just
in case you worked on like C5 projects
make sure you keep it concise and crisp
next up is your education do not lie
here make sure you give a relevant
education with grades next you have the
certifications if you have any
certifications or achievements go ahead
and write them down next you have the
technical skills now again prioritize
according to the job role and lastly you
have your non-technical skills this
could be your communication analytical
skills problem solving skills Etc moving
on to an experienced developer so again
mention the resume header
then you have the summary again very
crisp and clear go ahead and mention
your portfolios and your links coming to
experience now here you'll have to
clearly depict your work you'll have to
make sure that you write down all your
responsibilities in that company do not
go overboard and write extra keep it
very concise
again relevant education and your grades
you have technical skills the same goes
for this as well prioritize according to
the job Rule and finally you have your
non-technical skills now let's go over
some of the features of python and these
features are actually why it's
considered that using python is
advantageous over using other languages
so let's start with some of these points
now as we mentioned python is very it's
a very readable program code readability
is very important it's one of the design
philosophies behind this when it was
being developed it's very easy to learn
which is why python is an entry point
for many people that are just beginning
to learn programming and as I mentioned
earlier it's a high level language in
Python we since python is open source as
as I had already mentioned so it gets it
benefits from all the the benefits you
get from any open source technology now
it's also portable so what this means is
that if we create a code in in Python
and we create in a particular system on
Windows we don't need to make any
changes if we wanted to use the same
script or this that same piece of code
on some other system say on a Linux
system or a Mac system python itself
comes with a very large standard Library
this this facilitates us a lot because
we don't need to create our own
libraries or modules or have to download
very specific libraries most of the
problems that we do encounter quite
commonly can already be solved by the
standard libraries that have already
been provided by the developers of
python right right from the beginning
now later later on during the course we
will encounter what is the meaning of a
data structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and as as
you will see later python has one of the
most user-friendly data structures that
can be found in any language especially
compared to some of its contemporaries
now python is a dynamically programmed
language and this is very important and
what this means is that in most
compiler-based languages we there are
certain processes that can only happen
during the compilation stage so what a
dynamic programming language does is it
takes all those compilation specific
tasks and processes and it does it for
us as we actually type the code so we
don't need to waste time or spend extra
time to do something that would
otherwise be needed to be only done in
compilation we would have to set out
specific runtime just for that so this
allows us to create our programs and
solutions much faster and allows us to
debug much easier and yeah so it's a
it's a very important feature about
python Now quickly I will just go over
some of the areas of python where like
areas of or different domains where
python is very heavily implemented and
the first one the first few ones that
come to reminder like web development
and Ai and machine learning so you have
Technologies like Django and Flash that
are built on top of python that I use
extensively for web development when it
comes to something like artificial
intelligence or machine learning you
have distributions such as Anaconda you
have pandas and many other libraries
like scipy and numpy that are used
extensively too so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
used in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays because of again some
of the libraries that I have already
mentioned such as sci-fi interestingly
if you are into game development or
gaming in general you would see that
python actually has certain libraries
and certain technologies that facilitate
game development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python some of the other
applications are of course desktop be
creating desktop guise image processing
graphic design applications and
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses uh there are many Technologies
in the environment of python that were
almost designed for the specific purpose
of being able to present certain
Concepts or to be able to teach certain
classes and I can't think of too many
programs or too many environments
outside of python that are better to
solve these Education and Training
course related problems and situations
let's uh let's get to actually
installing python so now that so I will
show you how to install python on
Windows since I have a Windows system
however I will also point out the way
you you would have to install python on
a on Mac OS or Linux or even on mobile
so yeah let's get started so to install
python on your Windows computer it's as
simple as going to the website
python.org and selecting the download
section when you reduce click on
downloads you get redirected to this
website that this webpage that I'm on
out here it by default it will ask you
if you want to download python 3.9 which
is the latest version but of course if
you for whatever reason if you needed a
particular version of python you can
download that as well by just scrolling
down and choosing the option that you
want now it's important to note that
whatever option you choose of course I
would recommend the latest one but no
matter what option you choose I would
recommend you choose a version of python
three point something because previous
versions of python namely Python 2.7 and
uh and basically every version of python
two point something has it will not
receive any more maintenance and updates
because the developers have decided that
python will that trying to shift towards
the maintaining and updating python
three point whatever completely right
now so yeah let's not delay this uh any
further and let's download python 3.9 so
once you select the option out here uh
you'll be you'll get an installer all
you have to do is click on that and
it'll give you two options to customize
installation or install now I would of
course recommend this blue install now
since you're a beginner do not worry
about what a custom installation is if
you have multiple drives in your system
by default the python will be downloaded
into the drive where your windows is
actually installed your your main drive
so as you can see now that once my setup
is done it should give me a pop-up soon
so my setup is done for Python and this
is essentially how you would download
python on your Windows system but what
if you had Mac OS or if you were using
Linux well for Mac it's a it's actually
almost as simple you just go if you see
our here below this download button
python option you get the website asking
you are you looking for python on a
different OS and it gives you the
options of Linux Mac and even other os's
but for Mac if you wanted you would just
open this tab and just like the windows
option you would choose a version and
you would choose an installer for that
version so if I wanted to say python the
latest one I would just download this
installer and I would install in my Mac
system now when it comes to Linux I
cannot show you exactly how you would
install it there are certain commands
that you have to execute but essentially
again if you would just choose the Linux
option out here it would take you to a
page with a different installers and
essentially packages for Linux systems
in specific what I would recommend to
you if you are a Linux user and you need
python is to go over to the
realpython.com website and they have a
very good uh essentially instructions on
how to install Python and since I don't
have a Linux system them I cannot
directly show you how to install python
on Linux so yeah if you do have Linux
please head over to this website and
this should be of a lot of help to you
now as I had mentioned you can actually
install python on your mobile devices as
well so if you were say an iOS user you
would go to the iOS App Store and
download an app called the python is the
app for iOS it essentially is like a
full-fledged python environment where
you can develop in Python on your iPhone
or even iPad and if you're an Android
User you could you would go and download
an app called the pi Droid 3. there's a
free version and a paid version for this
app and of course the difference between
the free and paid is that the paid
supports uh code analysis and code
prediction these are certain details you
don't have to worry about right now and
honestly if I wouldn't worry too much
about installing python on your mobile
devices currently since I am assuming
most people would be learning program
programming and programming in Python on
their PCS or laptops what I had actually
shown you was installing what is called
an implementation of python on your
system and implementation is essentially
a program or a software or an
environment that allows you to actually
work in Python so what I showed you was
how to install the by default or the
most basic or reference implementation
that has been created by the developers
which is actually called C python even
though you would not you would not have
seen the word the letter c or the prefix
C but yeah that implementation that I
had I had downloaded myself and I had
shown you to download is actually the C
python implementation which is python
built on top of C the the C language
essentially there are other
implementations such as iron python
which uses the.net framework and J
python that uses Java virtual machines
that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that I would not worry about too much
right now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python I want to introduce what is
called a distribution to you this
distribution is called Anaconda Anaconda
is a very important distribution
especially if you are looking to use
python in data science and machine
learning and AI which I am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards moving
towards data science and if that is your
goal or in any case whatever your goal
may be I would recommend that you
install Anaconda distribution now do not
get confused between anaconda and python
their Anaconda is python with in the
form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that I had shown you to
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and Technologies and software
as well so of course this means that
what you need to download both of course
not if you download a python you do not
need Anaconda to work on Python and if
you have already downloaded Anaconda
which I will show you how to do it in
some time if you have already downloaded
Anaconda you don't need to download
python separately so I'll just speak
about Anaconda little briefly so as I
said it's a distribution it it contains
a bundle which includes the basic python
implementation and a lot of Technologies
and softwares and applications that have
essentially help us to use python in in
in specifically managing Big Data
applications and data science related
projects so so now I will show you
actually how to install python I mean
anaconda on your system it's as simple
as it's actually as simple as
downloading just this thing so if I did
a quick quick Google Anaconda
so the website that I'm looking for is
anaconda.com and I'm looking at products
and I'm looking at individual Edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial Team edition these are for
companies usually or uh for more
professional sort of projects so of
course we are looking at the individual
Edition and if you selected this page
you would be taken to this particular
web page where It'll ask you if you want
to download and again there are options
depending on which machine you're using
if you're using a Linux you would choose
one of these two if you are using Mac OS
you would use one of these two and since
I am a Windows user and I have a 64-bit
system this is the option I would use so
again it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been downloaded so upon
opening it it will open up this
installation thing you can you can just
click next on most of these again if you
want to specify your destination folder
you can change it here mine will be with
a default folder in the C drive and you
can leave this unticked you can you can
change these options much later so this
is how you install Anaconda windows and
it's pretty much the same on other
systems as well now once it's done I
will show you what exactly what are some
of the things that Anaconda contains
that are not there if you installed
python like the way I had shown you
earlier just the bare bones python
implementation so as you can see here my
installation is actually complete and
now I will open anaconda and I'll show
you what how you can actually use this
Anaconda so if I search for an account
on my system I would look for something
called Anaconda navigator to actually
get started with this and when I open
that it should open something like this
so this is what opens when you click on
the Anaconda Navigator and as you can
see there are a bunch of applications
you don't need to worry about what these
mean right now just understand that this
this is essentially a bundle of
different applications and technologies
that come along with just the normal
installation of python that you get when
you install Anaconda Navigator now now
that we have actually tackled where
we've seen how to install and I'm hoping
and I would recommend definitely that
everyone is watching this video installs
Anaconda not just the normal python
installation or implementation now that
we have gotten all the introductions and
the basics and the installations
regarding python aside let's get right
let's get down to actually creating our
first script so now the question is how
do we actually start doing this task of
creating our first python script how do
we how do we realize uh now that we've
installed uh python like uh now let's
how do we start doing something so the
answer to that question is that
typically when you're working on python
the one of the most basic thing that you
can do is create a python script and
execute a script script is a essentially
a sequence of commands and instructions
that you give for python to run and
execute to give you a certain result so
I will show you how you can create a
python script now there are multiple
ways of creating a python script you can
create it directly from command line
which is obviously something I would not
recommend because it is not convenient
and easy and it's not very useful for a
beginner another way is using a text
editor such as the one I have opened
right now which is the notepad plus plus
text editor now it's very important to
not get confused between notepad plus
plus and the standard notepad that comes
with your windows or wordpad for that
matter in fact text editors such as
notepad and wordpad that you are more
familiar with create text and files in a
form that is called Rich Text Now Rich
Text is something is text that contains
formatting thing and fonts which is
actually a hindrance when it comes to
creating actual code so what we need is
a text editor that creates or writes
text in what we call as plain text plain
text is obviously text which does not
contain these fonts and these
formattings and it only respects white
spaces and indentations those two being
actually useful towards creating code
unlike fonts and formatting which are
only a visual thing so notepad plus plus
is obviously a text editor that creates
a plain text documents that is very that
was actually created with programming in
mind obviously you can use a bunch of
other text editors such as vim and atom
and you can Google for these there are
plenty of them so without any further
Ado let's create our first python script
so one of the most common one of the
most famous examples of a first program
in any program for that matter not just
item is creating a print statement that
gives us a statement saying hello world
so enter in Python this is how you would
go about oh this is the syntax you would
use to create the statement
all right now weight is very important
when you are saving your Python program
that you use the dot py prefix so so if
I were to save this I can choose
whatever folder I am going to choose
yeah this folder seems fine so now I
give the file name over here as say I
want to keep it as test I need to prefix
this with Dot py and this uh tells any
uh sort of interpreter or anytime we
need to read the script to know that
it's a python script we need to add a
DOT py otherwise it will not be treated
as a python script it'll be treated as
some normal document sort of a thing so
now that I have stored it as dot py I
have created my first python script now
obviously the next question is I need to
see what happens when I execute this
line when I run this script essentially
so to see that there are multiple ways
the first way that I will show you is a
command line method which is obviously
again before we get into it it's not
something that I will be using to teach
you it's not something I would recommend
you to immediately start using
um but for the sake of showing I will
show you how to execute a script in
command line well to do this you go
since I have installed anaconda in my
system and I will be using Anaconda to
work in Python what I will look for is
something called the Anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that I
get Anaconda prompt this will
essentially open you a command line
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this now I am already in
the folder I believe that had my script
so how do I call this script or how do I
run this script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so I enter test.py if you if
this was in a different folder you would
have to change your folders in command
line which is again something that I
might show you later but since my file
is already in the folder that I am in in
my command line I would just have to
enter this Command right now so if I
execute this as you can see it's given
me an output of hello world which is
which is what I wanted I wanted it to
print this uh these two words and of
course the command line is now waiting
for the next command for me so this is
uh one of the most simple ways for the
most rudimentary ways of executing a
python script now another question would
be well this isn't the most visually
appealing or not the easy to read or
easy to use way of executing scripts and
I would agree and that's why I'm going
to introduce a another technology or a
software called the IDE so the IDE in
python or in any programming language
stands for integrated development
environment it's essentially a software
that not only allows us to run scripts
but it allows us to create the scripts
it allows us to debug it allows us to
see outputs it allows us to see
intermediary outputs it allows us to do
a wide variety of tools and tasks and it
comes with a bunch of robust features to
enhance our Python programming
experience so let's let's see so I will
show you a an IDE called spider which
comes bundled along with the Anaconda
distribution that I had mentioned
earlier so if I open the Anaconda
Navigator as you can see the Anaconda
Navigator shows me a bunch of
Technologies and options and I'm looking
for something called the spider IDE
which is over here as you here it's a
Scientific Python development
environment this is exactly what I'm
looking for so I am looking to launch
this so now that I've launched it you
can see out here this is what an IDE
looks like now this looks very
sophisticated and it's a it's a one and
any almost any IDE is a wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider ID in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
console console essentially
so now that we have we have already
created our script in notepad plus plus
and I want to open that script and I
want to see uh how an i how it would the
result of that script would look in an
IDE so let's just open it so we can
browse for our file and as I had named
it test this is the file over here I
open this and as you can see out here in
the left hand pane my script has opened
and the commander had given or had
written is out over here now if I want
to run this application I press this
green button and as you can see the
result of my my execution essentially is
over here it's in slightly small font
but as you can see over here it says
hello world and its way and the next
line is essentially it's it's waiting
for me to do another execution of the
script and then it will give me new
results so let's actually give the
system new results so now that I have
printed something called hello world
let's let's change what's written over
here let's say I will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what I'm exactly doing these things that
we will actually cover in the in
upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a let's store a
number three let's create a variable B
Story number five all right let's create
another variable C uh which will store
the result of what's in a and b in the
addition of A and B all right and let's
print the result or print what's in uh
this variable C or what's the result of
a plus b I will print a statement saying
the result of the addition of three and
five is all right and I will put my
result over here as you can see I should
get the result in this pane so let's
execute this and you can see uh my first
line is executed saying I will perform
basic maths and the next line says the
result of the addition of three and five
is eight so this in this script what
I've done is I have performed uh two
print statements and I performed a basic
expression some variable assignments all
of these things we will be doing later
this is what I what I'm essentially
trying to show you is that Ides are a
very convenient way of not only creating
the scripts but actually seeing the
results and then making adjustments as
well we can come we can create a
completely new script we don't need to
create a script from some special file
or text editor I can just create a new
file here and this is my new script
essentially so I can start working on
with this new script right over here
from the get go so Ides are very
powerful spider IDE comes bundled with
Anaconda there are other ideas such as
the idle IDE it stands for
indicated development and learning
environment so the idle IDE comes as
part of the basic python implementation
that I had shown you in the previous
video where if you just installed a
basic uh python implementation it would
come along with a basic IDE known as
Idle or integrated development and
learning environment but of course since
we are using Python and this is what I
would recommend it comes with a more
robust IDE called spider which is
actually very very helpful for
scientific and numeric applications and
was designed specifically with that in
mind now this is not the only way we can
actually work with python there's
another very interesting and a very
educative method of it in Python let's
say python programs and it's something
that I will be using extensively
throughout this course to explain
different concepts so this technology is
called or the software is called uh
notebooks now before I get into the
details I will state I will just open
node a basic notebook so the notebook
that comes as part of anaconda is called
the Jupiter notebook and when I open
when I launch the Jupiter notebook this
is what I get now a very important
feature or a a feature of notebooks is
that notebooks are a web browser or a
web-based application so you it's not
something that you can use if you are
offline or disconnected basically if
you're disconnected from the internet it
is something where which for which you
would need an active internet connection
however it is way more robust and it has
very very good properties that allow it
to be used in education or for
presentation and such so as you can see
this is my Jupiter notebook these are a
bunch of folders don't need to worry
about what these are right now I will
show you how to create a fresh notebook
so if you go here and you go to new and
you select under notebook the Python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see this line is
essentially waiting for me to enter some
sort of a command or a statement that I
would give in a normal python thing now
if you would have noticed the diff in uh
until now everything that we were doing
involved us creating a script which was
the whole series of commands and
functions so if I go back to my spider
IDE as you can see like this is a whole
script and this script contains multiple
different tasks and functions that are
individually being performed so this is
a separate print function this is a
separate Edition another separated print
function and for longer programs or
larger program like you'll have multiple
different tasks being done and if you
were using a script you can only see the
result of something like this by
executing the whole thing at once you
cannot see exactly like what is the
result of just this print statement or
just this uh it's not typically what an
IDE is used for and this is where
notebooks come in super handy if I had
to break down my previous script
essentially where I first did a print
statement where I said some random thing
say hello
yeah so if I execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now I want to do what is 5 plus 3 it
should give me the result over here
eight now in the next another part of
your program might be storing five and
three into variables so I can do this
and I can do this so now this line will
store the variables now I want to do the
addition of what is five plus three but
I want to use the variables and I want
to see what's the result as you can see
a plus b means 5 plus 3 which is 8 and
I've essentially broken down various
different parts of my previous script
into into its individual tasks and I'm
able to see what each part of that
script does and this is very good when
it comes to making presentations or
trying to teach a class so I will
personally be using notebooks a lot to
explain different different concepts of
um different concepts when it comes to
Python and I would recommend that you
get used to notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to Learn Python
Programming or programming in general in
fact and again as I had mentioned
earlier notebooks are something that
it's an online application it's a
web-based application so I will have to
need a active internet connection to be
able to work on a notebook which could
be a disadvantage if you do not have a
consistent internet connection and in
that case you would probably use your
Ides or text editor which you can be
used offline as well in this video we
will be introduced to the concept of
variables and expressions let's start
with Expressions well an expression in
Python is anything that results in a
value its difference although the
difference between an expression and a
standard statement in Python is that a
statement in Python is something that
results in an action or an execution of
a command there is no calculation per se
or any sort of manipulation or as I said
audio calculation resulting in between
two different say numbers or other
objects that results in a value and this
happens in the case of an expression so
for example if I were to add two numbers
say 5 plus 10 this is an expression
which should where two objects 5 and 10
are being added and a result has been
given to me which is 15. now let's see
an example of a statement well a
statement could be something like a
print statement so when I ask python to
print something for me it's not
calculating anything it's not evaluating
anything it's simply performing an
action that I have or a command that I
have given the system which is to print
whatever I have entered over here as you
can see so this is a statement similarly
there are another type of statement
known as assignment statements which we
will learn actually right in the next
section well let's move on to variables
right now now earlier you might have
learned about objects in Python so
objects are essentially data that we can
work with a manipulate in Python now
variables are a place to store these
different objects
usually it's much easier to store
objects in Python instead of using the
objects explicitly themselves because
objects may be very compute complicated
whereas variables are very simple to use
and very simply very named in a very
simple manner so that we can use them
quite often in our programs now it's
important to note that in Python we do
not have to explicitly declare or Define
a variable to create them in fact
variables are created in the same
statement where we assign some object to
the variable in Python the assignment of
variables happens using the assignment
operator which is the equals design so
if I were to if I wanted to assign a
number say 100 to a variable say B well
it would be as simple as doing this now
anytime I want to know what is stored in
B I just have to enter B and I will get
the value that is stored in it and we
can store different types of objects
inside any variable let's say I store I
want to store this particular word in
the form of a string now this is stored
in X and if I want to know what is an X
I can just see what is here and it's a
string hello which I had stored earlier
now it's very important that we follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown errors or we might get
some problems in our program
so the first rule is that you cannot
start your variable name with a number
so if I were to give a variable name
like 4 num is equal to something say the
same string hello this would be an
illegal variable name and I would get an
error when I try this so if I were to
choose a num 4 is equal to hello this
would be perfectly fine I won't get an
error the second rule is we are not
allowed to use any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if I were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and I
stay I said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if I
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if if I have a variable called num or
say n-u-m if this was one of my
variables and I stored say the value 50.
this is not the same as me writing num
all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in Python is
that you're not allowed to use what we
call Reserve words in Python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are used as identifiers
for certain special functions in Python
that we that have a special purpose like
that particular word has a special
purpose within the Python programming
language and you cannot use them to name
our variables so a list of them as you
can see over here some of them are like
false def if Del Rays and there are like
are there are around 33 of them and
sometimes some of these words are taken
out sometimes there are more words added
as python gets updated now let's let's
move on to a concept uh where we try to
really understand what do we mean by
storing data inside a variable now when
I say that we are storing something
inside a variable you get an image or
you get an idea in your head that this
variable is like a container where we
store or we put a particular object
inside it so does this mean that
variables have a place in the memory are
they are also an object that is placed
in the memory where we can put other
objects inside of well I'll show you an
example where this idea is kind of
disproven or where I'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say I'm storing the same object I
will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and I'm going to
store it into two different variables so
I take X is equal to 100 over here and
in the next line I will store 100 in y
as well now if objects were I mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then X and Y should have two
different IDs but let's see what happens
when I check the ID of X and the ID of Y
they should be different in case
variables were their own objects however
as you can see the ID of X and the ID of
Y are exactly the same so well obviously
we know that two different objects in
Python cannot have the same ID so does
this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in Python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
I said X is equal to 100 and Y is equal
to 100 what I am actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called X that I want to refer or
Point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and I do the
same thing with another variable y so I
am not exactly creating a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when I do ID of X and ID of 5
it's not giving me the idea of something
called X or the ID of something called Y
is giving me the ID of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in X and Y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what I'm trying
to say and similarly if if I were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see I've used the value of 50 to explain
my point so as you can see initially X
and Y are pointing towards this value 50
because I have stored 50 and 50 in both
X and Y now what if I changed the object
that is stored in X well that means X is
now pointing towards this new object and
I have stored this new object called
hello the string called hello as you can
see here so now X is pointing to a new
object in the system and it's called
hello and I haven't changed anything
with respect to Y so y will Point
towards the same thing and I can also
make the pointer of Y different or what
I'm trying to say is I can store
something else and Y say I stored this
list in y 50 1600 and when I do that now
Y is pointing towards a different object
in Python and X is also pointing towards
something else so what happens to this
object 50 well now that there's no
variable referring to this object 50 it
becomes what we call an orphaned object
and we can actually see that when we do
the ID of X now let's go back to my
example on the right where I stored X is
equal to 100 so as you can see it gives
me some ID represented by this number
now let's say I stored x i stored
something different say 200 now if I do
the ID of X it should give me a
different ID because as you can see the
values are different and this is because
this object 200 is what is stored in X
and when I do the ID of X I'm actually
getting the ID of this new object now
200. so as you can see Point as you can
see variables are they should be and
they are treated more like references or
pointers instead of containers for a
particular object in this video you will
be introduced to the concept of objects
in Python now what are objects in Python
well all the data that we manipulate or
use in our operations in our code are
represented as objects or relations
between objects so if you want an
example two numbers that you add in your
code well both of them are objects and
the usually numeric type objects
similarly if you want to store someone's
name or an address of your hometown in
your code you usually stored in a form
of text and that text is also an object
usually a string similarly you might
want to create a container of different
smaller objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the Boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
then we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in Python has three
important properties that kind of Define
that particular object they are its
ident entity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change one at once it has been
created so for example if I took an
example of say a string called hello I
can use the ID function which is this is
how you use the ID function to find out
the ID of this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer so as you can
see the ID of hello is this integer 2 3
2 6 4 7 6 6 23024 similarly all objects
in Python have an identity we have
another operation with regarding the
identity of an object it's the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially what
defines what kind of values and
operations that that object can have so
for example in numeric data type in
Python such as an integer would allow us
to do arithmetic operations and
similarly string object type in Python
will allow us to do concatenation
operations much like its identity the
type of an object cannot be changed as
well now let's see what's the type of
that particular object that I had shown
you above as you can see it should be
string Str stands for string similarly
if I did a type for a number say 50 it
should give me int as you can see now
the third property of an object in
Python is its value now the value is the
actual data that is contained in the
object it's the thing that we use that
we display that we can manipulate and
that we can perform operations on so for
example if I were to talk about this
string this string is hello so the value
of the string is the word or the
sequence of letters that spell out hello
and similarly this particular object is
a numeric object with the value of 50.
let's see in this in this pictorial
representation I have shown you that you
can assume this dodge Blue Area as the
memory of the system now within this
memory we have objects created called 50
and hello and this list containing
smaller objects called cat pen and 40.
now what I'm trying to show you here is
each of these objects have a type an ID
and a value and let's see what they are
if I wanted to see as we had already
seen the type of 50 now let's find the
ID of 50 as you can see we get this
unique ID for the object 50 which is
obviously not the same as the ID of the
object hello above and the value of this
object is the value of s50 itself so
that was a brief and introduction into
objects in Python in this video we will
cover the topics of numeric object types
and type conversions in Python now let's
get started numeric object types in
Python are a broad classification of
objects plenty of common real life
applications that we associate with
numerals such as arithmetic operations
and calculus are done in Python using
numeric object data types there are
three main types of numerals or numeric
data types in Python they are integers
float and complex integers as the name
suggests represent all integer values in
Python these can be such as 100 minus 3
to 305 and so on floats are used to
represent new builds that contain
decimal points such as 100.3 3.9 4.8
minus 6.8 and so on then there is the
complex object type which is used to
represent complex numbers in Python and
this is an example of a complex number 3
plus 7j okay this is a complex number
three plus seven J where the real
component is 3 and the imaginary
component is 7. all complex numbers have
a real and an imaginary component and
this is how we denote them now it's
important to note that this J is a very
common symbol in maths and Engineering
used to denote the imaginary portion of
a complex number and it's the same in
python as well so moving on let's talk
about type conversion in Python type
conversion refers to the conversion of
an object from one data type to another
for example from string to an integer
and there are different types of
conversions and let's go through some of
them first of all let's consider the
conversion of something to an integer
and more specifically let's consider the
example where we convert a string to an
integer so let's consider my example
string to be some something called 145
and I'm sewing this within a string for
a reason because I want to convert is
string to an integer so as you can see I
have stored this one for 5 within my
within a variable X and if I were to
confirm that is actually an integer I
can use the type function and see that
it is actually an integer Str now let's
convert this into an integer using the
int function so how would we use it is
simply passing the End
by passing the variable that we want to
convert into the int function and as you
can see this is what I've done over here
but before this I will also store it
into another variable all right now
let's see what's in y well y gives us
145 but are we sure that it's an end we
can just check it by using the type
function and as you can see the type
gives us the answer end that means that
we've converted the string to an end
interestingly we can convert something
and also specify what base we have to
treat the number as by default when we
pass something in the in function the
programmer python will treat whatever we
have passed within the string as
something in base sub decimal but what
if we were to pass something that is
well not in a decimal maybe we could do
it like this now let's store Y and in y
the store let's do this and I will show
you what this means X and I will give a
comma and eight what this does python is
well I want to convert the string in X
into an integer but I want to treat
whatever is an X as a number of Base 8
so 145 is actually 145 in the base 8 now
when we see what's in y we get 101 which
is different to 145 because well 1 0 1
is actually the decimal equivalent of
145 in the base 8. similarly if we were
to give it in the base 2 we would just
replace 8 with 2 over here now next
let's talk about converting something to
a float now as we know float is just
simply something that has a decimal
point so let's convert an integer into a
float how would we do that simply by
using the float function so if I give
120 and I pass this integer through the
float function I should get 100 120.0
and these two are not the same though
they may mean the same things to us but
in for python 120 is an integer and
1.120.0 is a different object which is a
float and this is how we convert
something to a float now what if we
wanted to convert an integer to a string
well we can use the Str function we can
also use the hex and the OC function if
we want to convert a particular number
to a hexadecimal or an octal string
respectively let's look at all three
examples say I have a number 688 and I
want to convert this into a string I
just use the Str function around this so
as we know just to confirm let's see
what the type of 688 is this is this
should be an end as we can see but when
we pass when we let's say we convert it
into a string 688 and let's store it
into some variable let's call it a all
right now let's see what it's an a it
gives a 688 in the form of a string but
we can confirm by checking the type of a
it is an Str so it is a string similarly
we can use hex if we wanted to convert
an integer into its hexadecimal
equivalent in the in in as an output of
a string as you can see this comp this
uh this sort of complicated thing is
actually telling us that we have
converted 688 in terms of hexadecimals
now how do we read this output this zero
should not be treated as anything it's
more like a an identifier which says
that the letter after this first 0 is
the base of this whole number so it's
saying that x x stands for hexadecimal
so it's saying that 2 B 0 is to be
treated as a hexadecimal number and if
you did basic maths you would find that
the decimal equivalent of 2b0 is 688
similarly if I did opt if I use the oct
function for 688 it will give me the
result something like this so again how
to read this the first 0 is to be
treated as an identifier and not part of
the number what it's saying is the
letter after the first or after this 0
is the base of the number of the fourth
character I enter 4 here so as you can
see it gives me A R A and D which is
everything from the fourth character of
my string random to the left similarly
if I wanted something to the right of it
I would just do it like this I would
enter some index here and I would leave
the portion to the right of the colon
blank so this will give me everything
including the third character since this
is how we treat the indexing in Python
everything including the third character
all the way to the right so this is Dom
as you can see now another perfectly
valid um slicing is say I want to slice
or take out different characters from
the string but I want to skip certain
characters like I want this one then I
want to skip one and I want to take the
next one and then I want to skip one
well in that case we have to introduce a
step so one way of doing this is now how
do we read this so as you can see I've
written 0 colon six colon two so what
this is telling python is I want every
character from my string test uh
starting from the zeroth character up
until the sixth but not including the
sixth after skipping or taking two at a
time taking two at a time can also be
assumed as skipping one at each step or
skipping one character at each step so
what this will do is it will go to
random it will take the zeroth one it
will take R and then it will skip the
next one so it will not consider a and
then it will pick n and then it will not
consider D and then it will consider o
upon until the sixth character whichever
that may whichever that may be and if
you see the output it gives us R and O
which is exactly what we wanted we
wanted R we wanted n we wanted o where
we skipped uh A and D or we skipped the
every second character essentially so
this is the way of
um slicing strings while also skipping
certain characters or skipping's
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in Python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of a sequence or
a string we can use negative indexes so
if I were to for example show you let's
see what this what this gives me test
what what is the minus one index it
gives me the character M now remember a
string Is Random so minus 1 gave us the
last character of the string random
which was m so this is a way of using
negative indexes and similarly if I used
test minus 2 it would give me the second
last character which should be the
character o as you can see here now
there are some other important functions
that you may use in Python for that
let's create another let's get another
string let's call it upper lower all
right I'm sorting it again in the same
variable test let's see what happens
when I use the upper function and what
happens when I use the lower function
now I'm going to use the lower function
for this so these two functions will
respectively give out or give us the
result or give us our string in
uppercase and lowercase respectively so
as you can see the upper function
created the first string in full upper
case and the second one created this
this string in four lowercase now
another important and probably one of
the most important methods that we use
for Strings especially when it comes to
data science is the split function so
let's see what I mean by split function
let me create another string let's call
it hello world
all right I'm going to use a split
function and I'm going to see what
happens when I use this function
essentially so what I'm doing in these
in this these three lines is I'm
creating the string hello world I am
storing it in test and then I am using
the split function on the test and
whatever result I get I'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
I'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that I have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and I've stored
both of these into what we call a list
now you might ask well how does python
know that it has to separate at a blank
space well the split function by default
will break up a string at its blank
spaces but if we wanted we could break
it up using or add every comma so for
example if I wrote hello world using
comma and if I put a comma inside over
here and now if I try to execute this
like for example I am going to find I'm
going to look for commas in the string
and I'm gonna try to split it as you can
see there's no splitting happening I
have one list with my original string
itself because it's not found a comma
what if I introduced a comma over here
now let's see what happens as you can
see the splitting has happened it's
found this comma and is caused a split
between hello and World similarly if I
in my string if I put this comma again
and I put something else it should give
me the split over there again so we can
Define our split using some whatever we
put between these Circle brackets after
the split function it's just important
to note that by default if in case we do
not enter anything over here it will use
blank spaces to do the splitting another
very important operation and very common
operation in strings is what we call
concatenation so if I have two strings
first and say another string second and
I want to join these together well the
operator I would use to do this is
called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
Strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing and let's see
what is the result as you can see what
uh this has done is it has combined the
first string first and the string second
into one string called first second so
this is the concatenate concatenation
operator now finally uh the last Topic
in this lesson is the topic of Escape
sequences now Escape sequences are
special commands that tell python to
either suppress special meaning of some
character or symbol in a string or give
or give the special or give some special
meaning to an otherwise ordinary
character in a string so let's look at
the first example now remember my in my
for earlier in this video where I was I
was telling you like what what is the
way of writing or how do we introduce
single quotes or double quotes into a
string and I had told you the trick if I
want to use single coat in my string I
just close it using double quotes or if
I want to use a double quote I close it
using single well another way of doing
this is using what we call an escape
sequence and an escape sequence in
Python is the backslash character all
right so let's see what happens when I
use the backslash character where I want
to introduce my single code so if I use
my previous example where I wanted to
introduce a single quote and say I am
going to close it using single quotes as
well so I'm gonna go back to my error
example so as to speak now this would
throw me an error right as you can see
it has thrown me an error so what if I
used the escape sequence that I
mentioned the escape sequence is
backslash character now this is the
point of the string where I want my my
single code so I introduce a backslash
now I have my single quote and I
continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backside character store python do not
read this special character or the
single quote to not treat it specially
and let it be as a part of the string so
as you can see that's what's happened
here now the next case or the other uh
use case of Escape sequences is when we
want to give a particular character that
is otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so let's take the example of the
character T and the character n we use
the character T to introduce tab space
and Views a character in to introduce
what we call line break well let's see
by an example so normally the character
T has no special function so the
character T within a string will just be
outputted as the character T itself
however as you can see here I'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t
let's see what it does it introduces
this thing that we called a tab space
which is a larger than normal space
similarly if I were to use the backslash
n combination this would introduce what
we call a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where I have this combination of
backslash m a line break has occurred so
uh there are plenty of other Escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and uh these are just two of the
probably the most common ones that are
used in this video I will give you an
introduction into lists and tuples
starting off with lists lists are a
collection of ordered orbit arbitrary
objects that are similar to what we call
an array in other programming languages
but lists are way more flexible when it
comes to python python lists are a type
of sequence and we might have you might
have seen what the sequence is when we
were learning about strings and much
like in sequences or any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever you want to
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we Define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a way or a simple
list that I have just created and
assigned to a variable a which contains
three objects one two and three let's
talk about some of the features of
python lists python lists are ordered
and what this means is that even if two
lists contain the exact same elements if
they if the elements are placed in a
different order the two lists are
actually unique and different and I can
check that over here I have created a
list one two and three and see if I
create another list two and one and
three the same elements were in
different order I will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when I use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they are not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see I
get the value false because even though
I have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where I
show you list operations the next
property is lists are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists a dynamic and what this means
is that as we are making or as we are
programming we can actually make changes
to an already created list as we are
programming without having to go through
a compilation stage so if we had to say
increase the or we had to add certain
elements to an already created list that
original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can contain
any arbitrary objects so if I created a
list right now where say if I want to
store some numbers
say some floating Point numbers now
and I can put strings as well into my
list all of these are valid uh when it
comes to objects that can be put inside
a list we have no such restrictions so
we can put any arbitrary objects inside
our list the final property that I want
to talk about is that lists are they can
be nested to any arbitrary depth what
this means is that I can put a list
within a list and I can keep nesting it
essentially by putting as many lists I
want within my list and I'm only
essentially restricted by my systems
memory so if I created a list like this
within this say I put any other list and
within this list I put another list I
can keep going on to by keep going on
doing this and I'm only restricted by
the memory of my system that I'm using
so moving on let's move on and talk
about some important list operations
that we will be doing when it comes to
lists so let's create a basic list
called a where I'm storing six numbers
so now say if I want to retrieve a
particular element say if I want to find
out what's on the index 3 this is how I
would do it if I wanted a slice of my
original list and much like strings I do
it the same way so what this does is it
tells python that I want all the
elements of list a from index 1 to index
4 but not including index 4. so it'll
give me one two and three index uh
objects so it should give me 2 3 and 4
in this case as you can see here two
three and four I can do the same thing
by considering elements say two at a
time if I wanted to consider elements or
consider every second element what I
would do is this syntax I would use this
syntax and when I give this command to
python what it tells what it understands
is I want every element from a from
index 1 to index 4 but not including
index 4 but I am gonna considered to
every second
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here and then it will skip
one and then go here and then Skip One
and that's essentially what we uh what
it's essentially what we call
slicing by using strides so I'm taking
strides I'm not considering elements
consecutively but I'm skipping certain
elements in between if I wanted to
consider every third element I would
change this to three and fourth element
I would change this to Fourth all right
so let's see what happens when I take
every second element it should give it
should give me uh it will consider say
from one to index three right so you
should consider essentially this section
but since it's going to skip one it's
going to consider this skip this and
then consider this it should give me two
and four as you can see it has given me
two and four and like in other sequences
we can use negative indexes as well
negative indexing essentially starts
looking from the right hand side of the
list so when I say A minus y one it's
essentially looking at the last element
of the list so it gives me the sixth or
the last element which is the which is
object six if I did a minus two it gives
me the second last element similarly
another neat trick that we can use for
sequences is the following syntax double
colon and we give a minus one what this
tells the what this tells the system is
I want the list a but with all the
elements reversed as you can see I get
my element uh my list a but the elements
have been reversed right now let's move
on to uh concatenation and replication
well concatenation much like in strings
is done by using the plus sign so as we
know on either side of the plus sign
should be two similar objects so if I'm
doing a plus something a being a list on
the other side it should be a list as
well so let's add a list like this now
let's see what's in a
as you can see my origin list has a 789
added to it and I can also add things to
the beginning of a list similarly so if
I wanted to add say zero you know at the
beginning for this I just do it like
this
and I get the element 0 added to it it's
very important to note that I I actually
added 0 within a list because if I did 0
like this
it will throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an end object and it's
not a list but when I put the square
brackets I make it a list and then this
concatenation becomes valid because a is
also a list similarly if I did a star 2
this is essentially replication or a
replication function where I'm repeating
the values in a twice if I did a star 3
it's the same function but now I'll have
the elements repeated Thrice as you can
see here let's move on to modifying list
values uh this also shows the mutable
property of lists that I had mentioned
earlier so let's consider this example
so I created a list with elements where
there's the three strings eggs apples
and carrots and I have five int objects
one two three four and five now if I
wanted to change say the first element
all I have to do is take the 0th index
and say if I want to replace eggs with
same mango this is how I would do it now
replace eggs with mango if I check
what's in B you can see the eggs have
been replaced with the element mango
similarly I can use the slice syntax to
replace a particular slice from my list
with a slice essentially so let's look
at this I'm replacing I want to replace
the first three elements I want to
replace mango I want to replace apple
and carrot so what I will do is I will
consider this since this carrot is the
second index so I would consider 0 to 3
because third is not counted now I'm
going to replace this with three
different
um let's see kiwi
and say sponge now let's check what's in
B you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact I don't have to
replace like for like if I want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if I want to replace the first three
elements kiwi orange and sponge
with um just one element this is how
I'll do it let's say wine now let's
check what's here as you can see three
elements have been replaced with one
mine I can double vice versa as well I
can replace smaller number of elements
with a larger number of elements but
here there is a slight caveat that I
want to show you so an obvious way of
doing this would be say if I wanted to
replace the first element wine with
three different elements an obvious way
would be just consider that elements
index and then put whatever objects you
want say I want to add instead of wine I
want to add beer I want to add ball and
say Club yeah well let's see what
happens now if I say B check what's
inside my you can see my elements have
been added but they seem to have been
added as is you know I had entered a
list over here and that whole list has
been replaced uh or this wine has been
replaced by this whole list in the first
position but that's not exactly what I
want wanted I wanted the elements within
this list to be individually placed into
my list and the way to do that is not
this syntax but actually what I'm going
to show you now if I want to replace one
if I want to replace the index of the
object at index 0 I would give this
statement a slice statement where I will
give 0 colon 1 so when I do this and if
I
um so let's create my old scenario again
where I had wine and I had one two three
four and five now if I do this B 0 but I
give a slice then this slice is
essentially a single object slice it's
essentially the zeroth index again but
because of this formatting or this this
type of syntax that I'm using what
python will do is now when I say peer
and ball and club now what python will
do is it will not consider this whole
list and add it to in place of uh wine
or whatever I want to replace it will
actually consider the elements inside of
this individually and then replace so if
you see here now if you see my list I
actually have the I've removed wine and
in place of it I've put beer ball in
club but these three are actually
individual objects within my list and
not objects within a list that is then
placed within my original list so this
is an important caveat that you should
take note of so moving on let's talk
about certain methods Associated to
lists let's take a simple list now one
two and three the first operation that I
want to show you or the first method is
the append method so I do a append and
say if I want to append the list by one
object called four I just do it like
this now let's see what's in a I put so
as you can see the append has put the
object 4 into my original list now say
if I wanted to append three different
objects I want to append five six and
seven now let's see what append function
does oh no as you can see it's done a
similar operation to what we have seen
earlier when we gave a single index or
the single element replacement uh that
we saw earlier it essentially put this
whole list into this particular spot
into the list and this is not what I
wanted I wanted five six and seven to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what I'll
show you next now if I want to extend
Say the original list by three different
elements eight nine ten when I use the
extend function it will not put this
whole thing it will consider each object
inside this thing individually and then
add it to a so if you see my result this
is exactly what I wanted now the next
method that I want to discuss is the
remove method so the remove method is uh
what you how you use it is within the
parenthesis you put the object that is
present in the list that you want
removed so you don't give an index over
here you give the object itself so if I
want the object eight all right this
number if I want 8 itself removed what I
will do is put the value 8 here and it
will remove it from my list so if I
check my list a as you can see the value
8 has it's gone an X another similar
function to remove is the pop function
now the pop function by default will
remove the rightmost value from the list
but unlike remove the pop function
actually outputs a value and that value
is what we have popped out of the list
so by default it will pop out the right
route right most value of a list all
right most element of a list and in this
case that element is 10 so it should
give me 10 but of course if we want to
pop out any particular object in this
case we will not give that particular
object we give its index so now say if I
want to remove this uh this list object
from my bigger list
um as I can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4.
it's the fourth index so if I want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index I give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for lists let's move on to tuples next
so tuples are another ordered collection
of objects much like lists but they
differ from lists in two Key Properties
first of all there are tuples are
defined using parenthesis instead of
square brackets so this is how I would
Define a tuple with elements one two and
three and the next very important
property that is different or that
differentiates tuples from lists is that
tuples are immutable and what this means
is that once we create an object of type
Tuple we cannot make any modifications
to it we would have to only create
create a new object if we wanted
something different and this is
obviously a key difference between a
tuple and a list but apart from this
every operation that we have done on
lists are actually possible to do in the
case of tuples as well so any operation
that we did to lists that did not modify
the list or that does not do any
modification we can actually apply to
tuples as well so if I wanted the first
element of this difficult all I have to
do is call it by the index 0 it should
give me the value 1 as you can see if I
wanted a slice I can do that as well it
should give me two and three and if I
wanted to reverse my Tuple well I can
use my same neat technique that I've
used for lists and that I can use for
the sequence I mean strings as well so
it gives me my old Tuple but with the
elements reversed so now the natural
question is why do we use Tuple server
lists well one important difference is
that when we con when we make a program
execute where or where we are
manipulating a tuple if we did the same
thing for the exact same objects in uh
that if it were present in a list it
would be much faster in a tuple
essentially program execution is just
faster on tuples when compared to an
identical list so use tuples over this
when we want to be efficient while we
are creating an ordered list of objects
so whenever we create an order ordered
list of objects that we don't need to or
we don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is when we are using
dictionaries dictionaries as we will see
later is a data type in Python that
needs an immutable component while we
are creating the dictionary so if we
want to use something that is like a
list but since lists are mutable we can
use a tuple instead and use that when we
are creating our dictionary and we will
see like what what I mean by the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use a tubers
over a list a brief section on Tuple
unpacking and packing is what I would be
doing right now and what that means is
that when I create when I give this sort
of a statement
you can assume this to be me packing
this Tuple into a object or a
variability now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that I can unpack a tuple
onto another Tuple so let me show you
what I mean by that so now that I have
packed one two three and four Tuple into
T let's unpack it into another Tuple
let's call this let's uh put these
elements into this Tuple and I put this
into T alright now let's see what I mean
by unpacking something onto something
let's see what's the what what happens
when I put a if I just want to see
what's in a it actually gives me the
value one if I see what's in B it gives
me the value 2. if I see what's in 3
give me value three and D gives me value
four so essentially if you think of it
what I have done is I have matched this
Tuple then put it into T and then put
that Tuple T into this Tuple a b and c d
so what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been or
a better way to say this would be the
element one has been packed onto or
unpacked onto a two has been unpacked on
to B three has been unpacked onto C 4
has been unpacked onto D to show you
what I've done in a single line is
essentially this this is essentially
what I've done
I have assigned 1 to a 2 to B 3 to C 4
to D I have matched these two tuples
together like this and this is a very
neat feature of tuples the only only uh
important thing that you have to keep in
mind is the elements of this Tuple and
the elements of this Tuple uh should be
equal so if there are four elements here
there should be four elements here all
right in fact another very important
thing about or a neat feature is that we
don't really need to mention the
parenthesis when we're doing this uh
unpacking or packing so if I did X comma
y comma Z if I did it like this if I put
say 5 and 6 and 7 this is also a valid
way of packing and unpacking so now if I
see what's the value in X it is actually
five if I see what's a value in y it is
six if I see what is the value of x and
z it should give me a tuple containing
five and seven as you can see over here
so this is a neat feature of tuples
called packing and packing in this video
we will cover Concepts surrounding
dictionaries dictionaries are another
type of composite data type in Python
there are also a collection of objects
much like tuples and lists and like
lists they are also mutable Dynamic and
can be nested however a key difference
and property of dictionaries is that
they are unordered items and
dictionaries are paired using keys
unlike enlists and tuples where the
objects are assigned numerical indexes
to define a dictionary we use curly
braces each key value pair in this
dictionary in a dictionary is separated
using commas and the key and values
themselves in a pair are separated using
a colon let's look at an example this is
a dictionary where I have three key
value pairs as you can see they have
been separated by colons and each
repaired themselves are separated by
commas and these are enclosed in curly
braces to define the whole dictionary in
this example d these are the keys banana
apple and grape and their respective
values are yellow red and green so this
is very important that in this
particular data type we have what we
call a key and that key is assigned a
value and we can have multiple such
pairings and we have three such pairs in
this particular example another example
or the or another type of way to define
a dictionary is using the dict function
this is how we use it as you can see I
have inputted two value or two object
tuples this is a tuple this is atopal
and this is a tuple and when I use it in
a dict function when I place it within a
list what python will do is it will
consider the first element of each Tuple
as a key and the second element of each
Tuple as its respective value now if I
check what's in D as you can see the key
banana has a value yellow the key apple
has a value red the key grape has a
value green so this is another way of
defining dictionaries an important note
over here is that the the objects that
we use for Keys have to be of an
immutable data type so we cannot use for
example lists as an example of keys but
we can use say integers or strings for
our dictionary Keys also Keys have to be
unique when it comes to a dictionary you
cannot have two different keys with uh
or should I say the same key having two
different values you can have only one
key and that one key will have a unique
value assigned to it duplicate keys are
not allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have immutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if I
created a dictionary with a key say
banana and if I give if I associate it
with it
a value green I cannot create another
key banana and Associate a value yellow
let's see what happens when I actually
do this if you actually see what has
happened here is python has considered
the second case so it's it first looks
at the first pair it goes okay so my
dictionary has a key banana with a value
green but right after it it sees another
key banana with a value yellow so it
overwrites my first key banana with the
second key and it overwrites the first
value green with the second value and we
essentially get one key banana with the
second value yellow so obviously this is
a python does this to avoid duplicacies
however if I created a dictionary with a
key banana again if I created I gave it
a value yellow or say green if I created
another
key and if I give this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not nothing special will happen in
this case because values do not have to
follow such rules let's speak or let's
see certain dictionary operation
operations and functions now so let's uh
bring back our original dictionary which
we had created earlier with the three
pairs all right so what if I wanted to
we can use keys to essentially do these
operations and functions let's see what
happens when we so much like how we use
sequence how we use indexes in example
of sequences we use Keys when it comes
to dictionary so let's see what happens
when we use a key over here so we as we
know banana is a key in this dictionary
let's see what happens when we do where
we give this command it actually gives
the value associated with that key which
is yellow what if we wanted to change a
particular value Associated to a
particular key I would give I would do
this I would give the key and assign it
uh the value that I want to change it
with all right now if I check my
dictionary you can see the key banana no
more has yellow value but the value gold
what if I wanted to add a new pair you
know a new key with a new value
completely I would do it pretty much the
same same way as I did in the previous
step I would
um essentially write my new key whatever
I wanted say if I wanted a new key
called watermelon I would assign it a
value red and now if I check my
dictionary at the end of the dictionary
you will see that my new key pair key
value pair has been added watermelon red
as as you can see over here now what if
I wanted to remove if I wanted to remove
a key value pair from my dictionary I
can use the delete function which is
called by using this the Del function
now how do I do it see if I want to
remove the key value Apple in Red so all
I have to do is do del d and within
square brackets I have to only mention
the key I don't even need to mention the
value just the key so you can probably
draw parallels in how we use indexes
when it comes to lists and tuples and
even strings and how we use Keys when it
comes to dictionaries they are quite
similar so if I did this and if I
um oops I think red is actually not a
key as you can see red is a value my key
is Apple actually it's not red it's
apple as you can see now if I see my
dictionary the key apple and its value
red has been removed so these are some
of the operation questions that we can
do for dictionaries using keys what if
we wanted to use certain inbuilt
functions that are associated with
dictionaries well some of the examples
are as follows there is a get function
when we use the get function all we have
to do is enter a key inside the
parenthesis and it will get the value
associated with that key so if I gave
the key grip let's see what value is
associated with it as you can see it's
green there is also a function called
items that Returns the key and value
pairs in our dictionary as a list of two
object tuples where the first object is
the key and the second object is the
Tuple so let's see what it does as you
can see it gave me a list and in this
list the objects inside the list are two
object pupils where the first object is
always the key and the second is the
value and and it's the same for each of
the tuples so this is what items
function does let's see what uh the next
so the next function is Keys let's see
what the keys function does as you can
see it returns a list of all the unique
Keys within our list I mean within our
dictionary similarly we can there is a
function for values as well and as you
can see it returns all of the different
values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say a
particular value say I had another key
where its value was green again so I
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the pop function in list it
gives us the last entered key value pair
that is present in our dictionary so the
last centered pair was watermelon key
watermelon with the value red and that's
what has popped out when we give this
function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so say
if I had a dictionary let's say I'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where I have say some key
called key V so as I had mentioned I
will use two object tuples in this case
and say I give this also a value green
all right and another pair would be say
mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with a
key called kiwi with value green and
another key mango with a value yellow
and I already have a dictionary D with
uh these values all right now if I want
to merge these two dictionaries I can
use the update function what I do is say
if I want to merge D with X or x with d
only the ordering will change and that
doesn't really matter when it comes to
dictionaries so if I want to merge D
with X I use D update and then inside it
I put my target dictionary now when I
check what's in D I have the the
dictionary X and its key value pairs uh
merged inside my original Dictionary d
as you can see I have my original ones
here and I have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function in
this brief video I will explain what we
call the type hierarchy or the standard
type hierarchy and item it's also known
as the data model in Python and it
probably has other names so essentially
in what we do or what we speak about in
this is uh how the different types that
we use in Python are categorized and
classified and what are their subtypes
so it's important to note before we
continue further that there in future
versions of python there might be new
types that are introduced or the
existing ones may be modified but it's
safe to say that what I will speak about
in this video will still form the core
of what we call python standard type
hierarchy so let's begin so the first
type is the non-type uh it's accessed
through the built-in name none its truth
value is false it's essentially used to
denote
um functions or it's you it's returned
as the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it uh then there is the
ellipses uh ellipse is something that
you might encounter later uh it is
accessed through the built-in name
ellipses
um it is used to indicate the presence
of this particular
um syntax this particular symbol or
expression uh or syntax in a slice its
truth value is true again don't worry
too much about ellipses right now next
is numbers and numbers is something that
we are very familiar with we've seen
we've worked with numbers a lot they are
an immutable type they are created
through numeric literals and they are
the outputs of arithmetic expressions
and built-in arithmetic functions its
subtypes are integers floating Point
numbers and complex numbers
um within integers you have plain
integers that represent numbers in the
range this number and this number so
this this number is basically the
largest positive value that you can
represent using 32 bit notation in two's
complement and this is the equivalent a
for the the negative the negative side
long in teachers on the other hand are
used to represent numbers in an
unlimited range that is only subject to
the available memory of your system so
these are two types of integers and as
we know floating Point numbers represent
Machine level double Precision floating
Point numbers or numbers with a decimal
point and a component after that complex
numbers are numbers that contain a
floating Point number that represents a
real part and a floating Point number
that represents a an imaginary part so
these are the types of numbers then we
have sequences sequences are finite
ordered sets indexed by natural numbers
so each element in a sequence has an
index and that index is a natural number
the different types of sequences are
based on the mutability whether the
objects can be changed or not is
essentially what we mean by mutability
right once we create an object whether
we can modify I don't know and that is
how we differentiate different types
sequences so they're mutable and there
are immutable types now the different
types of immutable ones are strings we
know what strings are they are sequences
that contain characters Unicode is the
other immutable sequence and then there
are tuples uh tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are sequences that contain Unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and uh there is only one
currently there is only one built-in
mutable sequence in Python and that is
lists lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects finally we have
well not finally but next we have
mappings and mappings are again
um sets of objects but these objects are
now indexed using arbitrary index sets
you know the difference between a
mapping and a sequence you could
consider sequences are ordered but
mappings are not ordered and the index
is given to the objects in sequences are
always numbers they're natural numbers
whereas in mappings they are not natural
numbers but they are certain arbitrary
objects that we can set for ourselves
again in Python there is only one built
in standard mapping type that is the
dictionary dictionaries are there they
represent finite sets of objects indexed
by nearly arbitrary values the only
condition is that these indexes must be
of an immutable data type so these uh so
what I have mentioned until now are
probably the most common data types that
we encounter or that we have encountered
now so next types are like callable
types such as user defined functions
user defined methods built-in functions
built-in methods classes and class
instances so again callable types as a
whole are referenced using the call
function and this is something that we
will learn when we start learning about
functions when we learn about object
oriented programming and methods and
functions and such the other type of
modules so modules are model objects or
modules essentially are referenced or
called using the import function again
modules can be considered as these large
libraries or larger pieces of code or
applications that we that contain
various different methods and functions
and objects and classes within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will well during the course of this
tutorial we or during the course of this
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using uh the
function open or some other certain
specific functions where we create file
objects out of these files these are
what we call file data types finally
there are internal types that are used
by python interpreter again this is
something that does not concern us right
now but just know that The Interpreter
for python uses these data types for its
functioning in this video I will show
you some of the categories of operations
that are possible in Python so let's
start off so the first category of
operations are arithmetic operations and
as you can see in this table there are
different types such as addition
subtraction multiplication so let's go
over them one by one so so a simple
addition operation would be like five
plus six giving me the value 11 I can do
5 minus 3 that's subtraction similarly I
can do a multiplication using five say
five into two there's division where I
use the backslash so say I did division
of 8 divided by 2. now you might
encounter another type of division which
is called the flow division where we use
a double backslash and what this does is
it returns us the largest whole number
that is lesser than the result of our
division so the division difference
between the float Division and and the
normal fluid and the floor division or
the single and the double backslash is
this say I did 9 divided by 2 using a
single backslash it should give me as
you can see 4.5 right so this is the
actual value now let's see what happens
when I do 9 double backslash 2 it will
give me 4 which is the largest number
lesser than or equal to 4.5 that is also
a whole number so this is what we call
flower division essentially finally we
also have if we want to raise something
to the power or something so if I want
to do fire say 6 raised to the power 3
because I would use double asterisks and
this is how I would do it it'll give me
216 as you can see uh if I wanted
remainder between the division between
two different numbers I will use the
percentage sign so if I wanted the
remainder of the division between seven
and three this is how I would do it I
get the answer 1 as you can see so next
category of operations are logical
operations the first one is the logical
and operation where we use the operator
end all right so let's see what we mean
by this I am creating so as we know the
and operation returns a value true if
both the operands are true so let's
actually let's actually do this for an
example let's give this variable the
value true and this is the value false
so it should be done like this false so
now think of it like one and zero so a
one and zero is obviously zero right so
if I did A and B I should get the answer
false or zero because I'm doing true and
false so it's like doing one and zero so
if you see this I should get the answer
false if I change this to true as well
now if I do this I will get the answer
true as you can see uh the next logical
operation is the or operation where well
logical or is if either of the operands
are true then we should get the answer
to our or operation as true as well so
in this case obviously if I did or over
here it will naturally give us true if I
change this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us faults if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is The Logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the value that we get is true
if the operand is false so let's take a
as we know a is false over here so if I
did not a I should get the answer true
but if I change this to true now if I do
not a I should get false as you can see
so this was The Logical operations let's
move on to the next set of operations
that is comparison operations so there
are a bunch of them let's go over them
one by one if I want to check if two
operands are equal so if I did X is say
equal to 2 and now Y is equal to 3. if I
want to check if they are equal I will
use the double equals to sign and if
they are equal I will get the value true
if they aren't either I'll get value
false as you can see since X is 2 and Y
is 3 as you can see X and why are not
the same so there's false they are not
equal if I change this also to 2 now I
will get the answer to another the next
comparison is the not equal to or where
we use the exclamation sign so over here
this is this um the result of this is
true if X and Y are not actually it's
the same so I should get false over here
as you can see but if I change this to
say 5 now I will get true because X is
not equal to Y in this case the next one
is greater than so if I did X greater
than y as we can see 2 is not greater
than 5 I will get false over here
similarly there is a lesser than if I
did X less than y I should get true over
here as you can see well there's also a
greater than or equal to and lesser than
or equal to we simply add the equal to
sign here so let's see now if I say x is
less than or equal to 3 I should get
true because X is 2 and if I put 2 here
I should also get true but what if I put
1 here since X is equal to 2 and 2 is
not less than equal to 1 this is a false
statement and I can do the same thing
with like this using the greater than
equal to now it's true because 2 is
actually greater than equal to 1. and so
this was comparison operations the next
set of operations that we can do in
Python are assignment operations we've
already seen a whole bunch we've already
been assigning values to variables we've
been doing assignments throughout
already but let's go over them and see
some of the assignment operations so as
we already know the equal to operation
is assigning everything that is on the
or the value on the right hand side of
the equal to sign to what is on the left
so if I did a is equal to 5 plus 6 it
will assign the value 5 plus 6 or 11 to
a let's check what's in a as you can see
it is 11. there is a plus equal to sign
and what this does is so for example if
I did say a now since a is 11 let's
create another variable called B and
call this 5 all right so now if I did a
plus equal to B what this will do is it
will add B to a and then store it in a
so let's see what this does once I do
this now let's check what's in a it
should be 5 plus 11 as you can see 16.
so this a plus this is this plus equal
to sign is essentially the same as doing
a is equal to a plus b it's essentially
the same thing they're both the same uh
there's a similar thing for this the
negative symbol or subtraction as well
minus equal to so now that a is 16 and B
is still 5 of course if I did minus
equal to B now I'm subtracting the value
5 from 16 so I should get a is equal to
11 again as you can see here and this is
the equivalent of doing a minus B A is
equal to a minus B I mean as you can see
so uh the next similar like assignment
operation let's create a is equal to say
6 in this case and say B is equal to I
will say 2 right now if I do a star star
equal to B what this does is it
multiplies B to a and then assigns it
back to a so if I see what's in a now it
should be 12 as you can see here
similarly there is similar thing for
subtraction as well so if I did a is
equal to 6 and B is equal to 2 and if I
did a sorry for division so if I did a
division symbol and equal to sine and
then if I give B what it will do is it
will divide a by b or 6 by 2 and it will
assign that back to a so my value in a
should be 3 as you can see here 3.0
obviously this is a single uh single
backslash so this is a float division
the resultant of a single backslash is
always a float I can do the same thing
with a double backslash so let's see if
I did a is equal to 7 now and then B is
equal to 3. now if I did a double
backslash equal to B now it will do the
same division but uh it will do a floor
function so it should give me 2 in this
case if I did the same thing with a
single backslash just to show you the
difference between single backslash and
double backslash division in this case
it will give me
um the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modulus sign as well with this
assignment uh say a is equal to say 5
now B is equal to 2 now if I do a
percentage symbol equal to 2 I mean the
it should give me it will assign the uh
it will take the modulus in both sides
and then assign it to the left hand
upper end now let's see what's in a as
you can see it it did a divided by 2 the
modular symbol is basically the
remainder of the division between two
objects so in this case it will divide a
by B and then give me the remainder and
then put the remainder back in a and as
you can see the remainder of 5 divided
by 2 is 1 and we get that over here
similarly we can also do exponential so
if I have a is equal to say so 5 b is
equal to 2 and I want to raise a by if I
wanted to raise the value of a by the
value of B and then store that back in a
this is how I would do it so it should
be 5 to the power 2 which is 25 as you
can see here so this is assignment
operations so finally we move on to uh
two special sets of operators one is the
identity set identity operators and the
other is the membership operators uh
let's look at the identity operators so
when we talk about identity operators
what we when what we mean is the is and
the is not operator so what the is
operator does is it checks whether two
operands uh have the same location in
the memory essentially this does not
mean that it does not check for whether
two objects have the same value and this
is very important so let's look at this
if a is equal to one thousand and one
and B is equal to
1000 plus one all right if I did a is
equal to 2. this is an equality check
are they the same values true now if I
say a is B let's see what happens as you
can see it's false this is because this
object and this object are not the same
and this is what the is Operation does
uh we can confirm this by checking the
ID of a the ID of a gives us some value
like this and the ID of B gives us as
you can see a different value so the two
objects are not located in the same
place the memory as we have seen using
the ID function and that is what we
check uh through the is operator and the
is not is essentially just the opposite
of that so so that is the identity
operator now the membership operator is
used for checking whether something is
present in a sequence or not so let's
create a sequence I will create a list
to show in this example my list is one
two and three basically simple list with
three integer objects one two and three
I will check whether now say 2 in a so
H2 in a if it is it will give me true as
you can see is 5 in a it should give me
false because 5 is not in a and the a
naught n operator is just the opposite
of that it checks the other condition
essentially so this is the membership
operators in Python in this video we
will be looking at the math module in
Python and we will look at some of the
math functions that are associated with
this module in Python so starting off
what is this math module well uh the
python map module is an important
library or a feature that is uh designed
to deal with mathematical operations
this math module is part of the basic
python installation so you don't have to
install this separately to use this math
module all you have to do is import this
module and this is how you would do it
you just do import math and this will
import your math module for you to use
in your programming and in this in the
course of this video I will be showing
you certain Concepts surrounding the
math module such as what are the
constants that come with the mass module
some of the arithmetic functions the
logarithmetic functions power functions
and even trigonometric functions that we
can do using this math module and the
function inside the math module so
starting off let's look at some of the
constants that are part of this so as
you can see the standard constants are
available in this module are Pi there is
Tau there is Euler's number Nan which is
a special it's a it's a programming
specific concept and infinity so let's
look at this one by one so starting off
our first constant is pi
um Pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circles circumference
to its diameter and Pi is an irrational
number you know the value of pi is 3.14
something since it's an irrational
number it does not we cannot Define it
in terms of a specific fraction but it
can be approximated to the fraction 22
by 7. so how do we access this by
constant is as simple as this once you
have imported maths uh the match module
all you have to do is do match dot pi
and it will give you the value as you
can see so as you can see the value
returned to us is a float this is
important to note and the number of
number of decimal digits uh the number
of digits after the decimal point that
we can see here are 15 and this is like
a by default thing for python that if
you call the pi a constant it will give
you the value of pi correct up to 15
decimal points so an example of where we
can use this thing is say we have the
radius of a circle 3 it can be an N
units three meters or whatever you want
and you want to find out it's say
circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is 2 pi r so
if I had to find the circumference of a
circle in my C in my code for some
application with the radius 3 however
all I would have to do is use the
formula 2 pi r and to call the value 2
pi r instead of specifically writing
3.14 something I can just use this
function math dot pi over here and then
I can enter the r as you can see it will
return me the radius as you can see so
moving on uh the next constant that we
will talk about is Tau Tau is similar to
Pi in fact tau is the ratio of a circle
circumference to its radius Pi is the
ratio of a circle's circumference to its
diameter and tau is the ratio for
circles circumference to its radius so
important to know this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
2 times the value of pi this is by
definition and much like Pi if you call
the Tau constant in you from the math
module it will also return you a float
number and to find that this is the
function that we use this is the syntax
so as you can see this is this is
actually two times the value of pi 6.283
and even this is returned correct up to
15 places to the right of the decimal
point and this is by default uh next
constant is the Euler's number the
Euler's number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of uh in the scientific community in the
mathematical Community
um you will be using the Euler's number
probably a lot as a if if you move into
data science or AI or something like
that so what is the Euler's number it is
uh it is the base of the natural
logarithm if you know what the natural
logarithm is it is used to calculate
rates of growth or rates of Decay and as
with numbers or constants like pi and
Tau even the Euler's number is an
irrational number with infinite decimal
places uh the value of the Euler's
number in short it's denoted by the
small letter e so this value of e is our
usually approximated around 2.718 so how
do we call this constant is simply as
math dot e this is how we do it so you
get this value again this is also a
float and it's correct up to 15 decimal
places so the next concept that we will
be talking about is infinity now
Infinity is a it's more of a
mathematical concept and this is very
important to note because Infinity
doesn't is not really a number there is
no number called Infinity it is it is
used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive Infinity is something that is
higher than any known number to us and
the negative Infinity is lower than any
known number to us so this is the
concept of infinity and how do we call
this uh function well so let's see what
happens when we call the math function
math constant Infinity so this is how we
do it and as you can see it will return
us this it might look like a string to
you but this is actually a special type
in Python
um which is not a string this is all
also a float it's a type of a float in
fact this Infinity value it's it's a
it's like a special data type it's a
special data type that you can you can
consider as an equivalent to a float but
um it's not it's not a typical float
that we know like you know 3.14 or 2.71
the value of method.in will give us INF
and this is this INF is actually not a
string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when I do a
type when I check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in Python 3.5 a special
type known as math.inf it returns this
INF data type which is equivalent waste
float so this is this is how we use
Infinity if you wanted to get the value
of say minus infinity all you would have
to do is match dot INF with a minus sign
preceding this constant and you will get
minus INF now let's check if the
concepts or the properties of infinity
are maintained you know like every a
positive Infinity is greater than any
number that we know and negative
Infinity is greater than any number that
we know so let's just confirm this
um so I will take method in and I will
do a check is this greater than say some
really large number something that comes
off the top of my head immediately okay
so let's see if it's if this is true
then this is conceptually correct and as
you can see it is true in fact I can
change this number to anything as large
as I want this will be true because
Infinity is true is larger than any
number that we know and similarly if I
did minus math dot in INF and I checked
some very small number you know a very
very small negative number so just
consider some minus uh 10 to the power
something right this should also be true
uh sorry it should be a smaller sense
symbol this should also be true because
I'm checking minus infinity is smaller
than any known number it was and it is
true as you can see so it's very uh also
if you did a if you did something like
so let's say if we do let's add
something to this you know it's a number
so we should be able to do arithmetic on
this let's actually see what happens
when I add say 10 to positive Infinity
it actually gives us the same value back
infinity because uh intuitively we know
that infinity plus anything is still
going to be Infinity right and this is
exactly what python does for us even if
we add a number to this the math dot INF
or the infinity constant in Python it
will still give us uh the same value the
same data type of INF or Infinity
similarly if we subtracted something
from the negative of maths.inf you know
say minus say again let's say minus 100
so if you subtract something from minus
infinity we're technically still minus
infinity itself so this will again give
us minus and then minus INF as you can
see and this is absolutely what we need
and this is a very very interesting
feature in Python uh finally the last
constant that we will discuss is the na
a n or the not a number constant so this
is not really a mathematical constant
there is no constant in maths called not
a number this is a computer science
related concept that it's used to is
used to denote invalid inputs or in is
used to indicate a certain places where
say a variable that should have a number
it's been corrupted for whatever reason
and it it now has a text or a symbol and
our code throws an error then in these
in these cases where python expects a
number from us or from your code and it
does not get it it will throw you a n a
n value and this is usually used in
cases where you have errors in your code
so again just to check like what this
this constant like how to call it this
is how you actually do it maths.nan and
it will give you a data type called Nan
also much like the infinity cons
constant let's see what's the type of
this this constant again might look like
a string to you but of course this is
not a string this is enough a numerical
concept and as you can see it's still a
float so this is like um it's another
special uh data type that was created
for specifically this case where uh it's
some it's the equivalent of a float but
um it's not really the typical float
that we are that we associate with so
this is a constants in the math module
so our next topic will be arithmetic
functions that we can do in the using
the math module so some of the common
arithmetic functions that are available
to us are factorials the ceiling
operation floor operation uh there's
permutations there's combinations you
can find the greatest common divisor or
the gcd and the LCM or the least common
multiple and you can truncate numbers so
let's look at them one by one so
starting off with the factorial
operation the factorial operation is
done using the factorial function as you
can see here actually is defined like
this math dot factorial all right so now
what we pass in between the parenthesis
will be uh what we calculate the
factorial for as you know factorial is
so factorial is always for a positive
integer and the factorial for say a
number 10 would mean 10 times 9 times 8
times 7 so on until the number one
obviously factor is only defined for
positive integers uh it is not defined
for negative values or it's uh and it's
also not defined for decimal values so
let's see let's look at an example so as
we know um so let's say we pass match
dot factorial for six and let's see
what's the value so this is exactly what
we expect so we expect the value of 6
times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 uh that
is actually 720. let's see what happens
when we pass 0 this should give us one
since we know zero factorial is one now
let's see in error case where we pass a
minus 5 as you can see this will throw
us an error because factors are not
defined for negative numbers now Moving
On Let's uh so the next function that
we'll talk about is the ceiling function
so the ceiling function is defined using
math dot CL as you see here so again we
pass the number that we want the ceiling
for in between the parenthesis so what
is the Searing function it gives you the
largest uh sorry excuse me it gives you
the smallest number that is uh greater
than or equal to what we pass over here
so for an example if I gave you 6.6 and
I asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for 6.6 it should give you 7
because 7 is the largest integer in
integral value that is greater than 6.6
or equal to it obviously if you give the
ceiling function for an integer it will
give you the integer itself so let's
look at an example 7.8 so this should
give me the value 8 as you can see here
let's look at it now a negative number
so minus 12.3 uh an integer that is
greater than minus 12.3 is minus 12 the
smallest integer that is greater than
minus 7.3 and this should give you 12 as
you can minus 12 as you can see here a
similar function is the floor function
which is defined like this again the
floor function what it does it gives you
the greatest number that is smaller than
whatever value we pass between the
parenthesis so if I gave it 2.3 it
should give me the value 2. again if we
pass integers it will just give us the
integer itself again it is to reiterate
this ceiling and flow functions uh they
give you into integer values so the
floor function will give you the largest
integer that is smaller than what we
pass over here so let's look at 6.7 so
the largest integer that is smaller than
6.7 is 6 and as you can see this is our
answer over here uh the next function
that we will look at is the truncate
function the transcript function is
defined using this truncate is very
similar to what we have seen this is how
we Define the rocket function uh it is
very similar to the ceiling and floor in
the truncate function what we do is
um we pass a decimal value a float
number to the between between the
parenthesis and what we get back is the
number without the decimal component so
only the integral component so if I gave
it 7.8 for example it will give me only
the seven part it will return me only
the seven part and it will chop away the
point eight part if I gave it minus 12.3
uh it will chop away the 0.3 part and
give me only minus 12 back so let's look
at an example 8.9 it should give me only
8 as you can see here see I did minus 8
or minus
6.9 it should give me -6 so you can
think of truncate function as it does
the floor function for positive values
and it does the ceiling function for
negative values because it rounds down
and rounds up respectively for positive
and negative values so now let's look at
the next set of arithmetic functions
let's move on to permutations
permutations are defined using this as
you know so in between the parenthesis I
have to pass two values n and K okay so
I have to pass n n and a k the K has to
be less than or equal to n because the
permutation as you know is uh the number
of ways in which we can permute from n
objects K Tire K different objects uh so
what this mathematically what this is is
um permutation of N and K is n factorial
divided by n minus K factorial so if I
pass say 10 and 6 it will give me the
permutation of 10 and 6. so let's look
at what's the value as you can see it's
a very large value fifteen one fifty one
thousand two hundred similarly there is
a combination function and this is a
combinations of permutations are used a
lot in probability so if you're going to
move into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in machine learning AI
you will be using these functions quite
a bit
um so the combination function again you
pass an n and a k again the N should be
greater than or equal to this K what
this evaluates is n factorial divided by
n minus K factorial times K factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and 6. so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section
um our gcd and LCM as we know gcd is the
greatest common divisor LCM is least
common multiple so as of the newest
version of python in three point python
3.9 the math module gets these two new
functions that were very lately added
actually
um since uh I cannot show you that
because I don't have the absolute latest
version of python on my system but using
the
math.gcd function this is the function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
will do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if I give these say for
example if I gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the LCM
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst
whatever we pass over here so if I
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
the value of 60 which is the LCM of 20
and 30. so again these are it's
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or a if you have python 3.9
or after that uh you will have access to
these functions as well if you when you
import the math module so that was for
the arithmetic functions let's move on
to the next section which are power and
logarithmetic logarithmic functions so
let's start off with the power function
um there are two there are uh multiple
ways you can actually do a power
function in math in Python so you can do
something like this which is the
equivalent of 2 to the power 3 or you
can use the inbuilt uh module math and
you can use the pow or the power
function which is this is how you do it
and if I had to do same 2 to the power 3
I would just pass 2 and 3 has arguments
like this and it should give me the
value as you can see 8 over here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is uh not part of the math module
it's a function not part of the math
module but it's still part of the base
python use this as well and you can do
the same thing pow 2 and 3 should give
you the value 8 again the now you might
ask what's the difference between these
two functions well it's not much for at
least in a beginner standpoint it's not
that much just note that the maths dot
power function is slightly
computationally faster than the simple
power function so yeah moving on their
next topic would be the next function
that we'll discuss is the exponential
function which is defined like this
again exponential function is again e to
the power something so if I did
exponential of 3 this would give me e to
the power 3. so as you can see oh of
course I did not Define the module
beforehand so math.exe now when I do
this it should it will give me some
value which is basically Euler's number
or e to the power 3. so this was the
exponential function and let's look at
an example so we will look at the
example of rate of DK and we will use
the uh this function in that example so
the exponential rate of Decay
um uh for uh is used to calculate the
amount of radioactive elements that is
present in a substance after a certain
amount of time so the the the the the
expression is uh something like the
initial amount of radioactive elements
that were present uh right at the
beginning times the exponent of minus
693 times t t for time divided by the
time period the half-life time uh so
let's just write it down to make it
simple so again as you can see the uh so
this will give me the remaining amount
of radioactive elements right so let's
uh let's write down remaining let's
assign this to a variable remaining so
the initial again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100
um the time let's assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
um Half-Life is around I don't know
let's give some value say three or
something again this is uh the details
are not important so this will I'm using
the math dot exponential function over
here as you can see and for these values
uh now when I check what's the value of
remaining after I calculated something
uh so this is it's basically what this
tells me is that I started off with 100
units of some radioactive element
um and in 10 years if this is what is
left so yeah so this is how we would use
say the X exponential functions in a
particular example of ours so next the
next type of again functions are
logarithmic functions so let's look at
some of the logarithmic functions that
are part of the math module so basic log
function would be written like this math
DOT log in in between this I would pass
the number that I want the log for by
default if I just pass one number it
will it will calculate the log of 8 to
the base of e as we know e is the
Euler's number so let's see what it does
in this case gives me some value what if
I wanted to specify a particular base
well I would pass this second argument
in this case I want to find the log of a
to the base 2 this should be the value 3
as you can see over here uh there are
two specific functions that are also
provided in this math module that is log
2 uh what this will do is again it will
again I have to just pass one argument
and this will automatically find the
value of the log of 8 to the base 2 as
you can see here similarly there is a
math DOT log 10 function if I give if I
did this I will find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was a logarithmic functions
then you have the finally you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math the square root function is Max
dot sqrt again we passed what we want
over here if we want the square root of
say 49 this should give me the value 7
as you can see finally maybe move on to
the final set of functions that we can
do using this math module uh they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so let's start off
with some of the trigonometric functions
as we know
um we can do sine we can do cosine and
tan uh some of the basic functions the
way we would do it is math DOT sign in
between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular angle
and this angle must be passed in radians
and this is very important to note we do
not pass it in degrees but in radians so
if I say past sine of 3.14 as we know
3.14 is an approximation of the value by
sine Pi is supposed to be in fact it's
supposed to be 0 so let's see we get
something close 0 again since this is an
approximation it won't give us the exact
value similarly we can use math dot cos
to find the value of a particular angle
if you want to find yeah if you want to
find the value of the sorry the cost of
a particular angle we can use the tan
function in case we wanted to find the
tan similarly we have the next set for
arc sine and the arc cosines of the
certain of angles so to use to find the
arc sine for example we would use a DOT
sign I mean sorry a sign for R cosine we
would use this and for r10 we would use
this the next set would be hyperbolic
functions again hyperbolic functions are
basically the sine and the cosine and
the time calculated not circles but on
hyperbolas again the details don't have
to be you don't have to know the details
you just should you should know that if
you wanted to say for example find out
the hyperbolic sign of n and a of an
angle we would use math dot sine H and
we would pass what we wanted between
this similarly if we wanted to find the
cosine it would be cos H tan it would be
tan H and if we wanted to find the
inverse of the hyperbolic inverse we
what we would do is what we would do is
use a so we would use a tan H if we
wanted to find the hyperbolic inverse uh
of sine we would use a sine H and
similarly for cos it would be cos a COS
H in this video we will learn about
conditional statements and we will learn
about how do we create these control
structures where we have these
conditional statements we will learn
about the keywords if we use in Python
to create a conditional statement block
the if keyword the alif keyword and the
else keyword we will also learn about
indentation and its importance in Python
so let's get started so the basic uh
syntax if you will for a if statement in
Python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this pictorial if there's an if
statement there is a expression uh there
is this a block of code which if you can
actually see is slightly indented to the
rest of the code uh and then we have the
rest of the rest of our code after that
so what we're looking at is this so this
is our if statement block
um now let's let's break this down so
what is this expression that we're
speaking of uh an expression in this
context is a Boolean expression which
evaluates to a true or false statement
so when we are speaking about the if
statement we have an expression and if
this expression evaluates to true then
we ex execute everything below the if
statement otherwise we skip that portion
as you can see if the statement is true
we execute this statement or these
statement blocks uh otherwise if it's
false we move on to the next the next
statement block or the beginning of a
new statement uh so let's look at an
example to further understand this let's
take this if statement over here as you
can see in this if statement I have this
expression 50 greater than 30. so what
python is going to do now is it's going
to check whether 50 is greater than 30
and it's going to check in a Boolean
context if this is true then we can move
on to the next portion which is this but
if it is false then we will skip this so
let's see what this uh what happens over
here so since we know that 50 is indeed
greater than 30 this is a true
expression we move on to this block of
code which is saying that print 50 is
indeed a larger number than 30. so let's
see if this actually gets printed so as
you can see we get this uh the result
which is this is a true statement and we
get our print statement getting executed
what if we give a false expression over
here so let's look at what happens if I
gave a false expression now I'm checking
if 50 is lesser than 30 which is a false
statement so if it's a false statement
we do not move on to this portion of our
if statement block and we we directly in
fact we directly skip so if I have to
execute this you will see nothing gets
executed and in fact my print statement
is just not executed because we never
entered this because our expression over
here was indeed false so yeah this is
how a basic if statement block looks
like in Python and this is how the uh
how we move on to how we check for the
true the truth truthfulness or the
falseness of a particular expression in
the if statement so moving on
um let's move on to the topic of
indentation in in Python so as you can
see this uh this if statement is an
example of a control structure so
without moving without defining a what a
control control structure is in detail
control structures consists of these
conditionals or Loops or iterations if
you will uh so all of these control
structures involve heavy indentation so
so what does an indentation mean well
what if I gave you an example say I gave
you some variable called H and I wrote
20 over here now if I give you an if
statement saying if age is greater than
10 now uh it's very important to note
that when I'm defining an if statement I
need this colon otherwise this if
statement is not defined so this colon
is important uh anyways so now I'm
checking this expression if age is
greater than 10. now what is this what
happens if H is greater than 10 now what
if I want python to do something only if
age is greater than 10 well how do I
tell python that there is a piece of
code or a section of code that I want
executed only if this condition is met
well this is where indentation comes
into play so if I want say if I want
this line this person is an adult again
this is some random line where I'm
assuming age is pertaining to this adult
all right or this person so if I have
this variable age where I write this
number 20 which denotes the age of some
person and I'm doing a check if age is
greater than 10 actually let's be
specific here well the adult age for
most people is 18 in most countries so
let's see if age is greater than 18. now
if I'm doing this check uh I want to
print this statement only if this person
is a person's age is above 20 above 18
so how do I tell python that I only want
this statement to be uh executed only
during this if this condition is met
whereas this is the indentation comes
into play and as you can see exactly as
you can see uh this part this portion of
the code is slightly indented compared
to the if statement so when this
condition is met then only do we move on
to this if this condition is not met we
move on to whatever the next section of
code will be like whatever whatever code
that we have after this if statement so
let's see so this since this condition
is actually met as you can see this
print statement is actually executed so
this is the importance of indentation
now we will see uh in as we move as we
learn more about if statements and else
statements and alif statements how
indentation plays a key role in defining
what we want as an output when a certain
condition is met all right so for now
it's very important to understand that
this is how indentation is used in
Python in other languages we might use
uh we probably don't use indentation in
fact popular language the C language
does not use indentation at all but some
languages and python in probably the
trademark language for indentation and
programming so you might say that so
different people have different opinions
on an indentation the general consensus
is that indentation helps make the code
look very presentable and very readable
and this actually is one of the facets
of Python Programming is the indentation
and the easy readability of it anyways
moving on so what if we have
um multiple conditions in our code or if
in our if statement block that we want
to see so let's create this list or
let's actually just copy this example
that I have written over here as you can
see what I am doing in this piece of
code is I have a list X where I have
this integer 50 I have two strings cat
and apple now I want to check a bunch of
things so I want to check if 60 is an X
and I also want to check if the string
cat is an X and I want a final sort of
like if none of these conditions are met
I want something to happen so how do we
do that well we start off our state our
if statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have one
more condition that we want met then we
can use the L if which is kind of a
short form for else if so we use the L
if keyword so it so what this python
what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is a keyword used
in our blog to tell python that if none
of our earlier Expressions have been
true then do what is in the uh there
that is within the else keyword that is
indented within the else keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is only we only reach
this error else statement in case all of
the earlier conditions have not been met
or have come to be false and not true so
let's look at uh this particular code
example so we have a list of 50 cat and
apple and I'm my first expression that
I'm checking is uh is 60 in X so this is
how we check actually so if 60 and X
should be read as is 60 in the list X so
is this 16 elix list X well actually no
we don't have the object 60 so this part
is not executed we move on to the next
condition is the string cat in X well
actually it is the string cat is indeed
in X so we move on to this statement
block which is within the condition that
is met which is print cat is in list X
and you will see that none of the other
statement blocks will be executed
because we have met our condition over
here so if I execute this as you can see
that the print statement cat is in list
X is what is actually executed and we do
not execute this obviously because it is
false and we do not even check or we do
not even move on to the statement
because well we have a condition mat
over here so it's a one thing that is
important to note is that we can use as
many alif statements to check for as
many conditions that we we want to check
for but it's very important that we only
use and if we are using that we only use
one else statement and only at the end
of our block okay so moving on now I'm
going to show you a very neat example
about how python actually does its uh
these condition checkings so it's very
important to know that once a condition
is met none of the other conditions are
even checked for so
um we do not even consider the next
statements and we directly leave this if
statement block so let's look at this
example over here now in this example
that I have over here is where I've
stored the string cat in X now I have
three uh I have three conditions that
I'm checking I'm checking is 50 greater
than 60. I am checking if the value of x
is indeed cat and I'm checking I'm some
random expression 1 divided by 0. this
is not even a check this is literally
just checking if 1 divided by 0 is true
or false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by zero so let's see what
happens when I execute this statement
now typically if I wrote 1 divided by 0
python would throw me an error because 1
cannot be divided by zero that is an
error error statement so let's see what
happens when I do this actually as you
can see I have a statement being printed
but I have no error even though I gave
it wrong I gave an error statement in 1
divided by 0 well now you might ask why
is that so well it's simply because I
have actually never reached this
condition I have not even python is not
bothered looking at this because if you
actually see there is a condition
previous to this uh over here which is
met and which is true so we move on to
this block we execute this block and we
forget about the rest of the code so we
don't actually get to this error
statement which is an interesting thing
and which is an example that I have
shown uh to show you that once a
condition is met in an if statement
block we do not look at any of the
further conditions that are being
checked okay so finally
um I have one uh one small topic that I
would like to share with you is the
conditional expressions or the pythons
ternary operator now this is slightly
different to the if statement that we
have talked about up until now uh in the
sense that it is not a control structure
so what this actually is is more of an
operator that defines some EXP question
so let's see what I'm trying to say over
here so as you can see over here
highlighted is the Syntax for what I'm
trying to talk about this ternary
operator so let's look at this example
and let's see what I'm trying to do over
here so I have this variable age all
right and this age is 26. now X now just
just read this statement X is equal to
adult if age is greater than 18 else
child now I could have done an elaborate
control structure with an if statement
and an indentation within that if
statement and then
um I could have written else and then
another indentation and I would have
written another statement over there but
instead of that I have used this
operator to assign a particular value to
the variable X and this uh what value
I'm assigning to X depends on if this
condition is true or false so as you can
see the condition says is age 18 uh
greater than 18. so if this is true then
I assign this particular string if it is
false then I go over to the else
statement and I assign this so since age
26 is greater than 18 I should assign
the string adult to X and as you can see
if I execute this and check what is an X
you can see adult is indeed in X so this
is a very neat a very needable readable
and a very um it's a it's probably a
more it's it's a better looking way uh
to perform simple else uh Sim simple if
and else statements where you don't want
to create a whole um if stay if if else
statement control structure block so
yeah this was the ternary operator
finally we let's uh we we make a short
note on the pass statement uh in Python
so the path statement or the pass
keyword is a a place where it is is a
placeholder of sorts so what if I had an
if statement and I'm writing a piece of
code but I don't know what to do with
this if statement so if if a statement
is correct if a statement is true
um but I don't know what to do if this
statement was true how do I tell python
well let's just keep it a hold for now
and I might put something into this
block later in the future well I would
use the pass statement so if I had this
say this some condition again if I'm
checking age is greater than 18 but I
don't know what to do with this I would
just simply use this past statement and
this basically does nothing uh it it's a
way to it's it's like a way to create a
placeholder where maybe in the future I
might have I might write some sort of a
say a print statement or some sort of a
different function or something else
within this indentation so but in the
meantime like currently I don't have
anything to place over here so I just
leave it with a pass statement so this
is a way where you can use a pass
statement in if and as statement or if
Finance control structures in this video
we will be I will introduce you to the
concept of iterations in Python and we
will be speaking in specific about the
indefinite iteration in Python otherwise
known as the while loop so let's look at
what an iteration means an iteration is
uh executing the same block of code over
and over potentially many times a
programming structure that implements an
iteration is called a loop now in
programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
in definite iterations in Python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to Define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the wire keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
the psych NFL statements a set of
statements where what happens here is
following the while keyword we have this
expression where this expression is
evaluated in a Boolean context again we
check if this expression evaluates true
or false and if it is true we execute
all the statements or the statement
block that is indented below this file
statement this is another example of
control structure much like FNL state in
blocks where we use a lot of indentation
so let's look at a basic example now of
while loop so let's copy this example
and let's see what this does so I have a
variable n where I am assigning it a
value 0. this is called an initializing
process and it's very important to note
that most while Loops consist of an
expression which contains a variable a
control variable uh which is usually
initialized prior to starting the loop
and then this control variable is
typically very modified somewhere within
the main Loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and I am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0 so let's move into the loop now
so the loop has this while keyword as
you can see followed by a an expression
n lesser than or equal to 5. now what
this is is an expression which is going
to check if it's true or false is n
lesser than or equal to 5 and as long as
this expression is true we will continue
when you're doing whatever is indented
below this y statement and what is below
this y statement is a print statement
first of all which says value of n is
and it basically prints a value of n in
that particular iteration and as you can
see this uh compound assignment where we
add the value of n by 1 and we assign it
back to n so what this is uh let's see
what this does actually let's execute
this and see what this does uh important
to note the value of n again is
initialized at zero so this while while
loop will keep going on until the value
of n remains lesser than or equal to 5.
so as you can see I have the execution
of this uh particular block of code or
this while loop where I get the multiple
different iterations of this print
statement that you can see here the
first iteration it says value of n is 0
then it's the value of n is 1. what I'm
doing is I am writing I am assigned I am
writing uh the value of n multiple times
uh and each time the value of n is
written over here based on what
iteration it is so what is happening
actually is uh the initially the value
of n is 0 and I print the statement
value of n is 0. now I add uh the value
of what is In N by 1. so now what is the
value of n so again we do this check so
after this first iteration we come back
or like once this whole code block of
code is executed we again come back to
this expression and we again check if
the statement is true so now that the
value of n is actually 1 if this
statement is still true so again we
execute this and that you can see over
here value of n is 1. now again we add
the value of n by 1 and again we go back
here once this uh this block is executed
and we check if this statement is true
again and as you can see the value of n
when it's 2 is still uh making sure that
this expression is true and this keeps
happening until the value of n is
greater than 5. so once the value of n
becomes 6 this condition is no longer
met and finally we do not execute the
statement because this expression
evaluates to false and we do not do this
anymore and we finally leave our while
low so let's check what the value of n
is just to confirm this as you can see
the value of n is indeed 6 and that is
why we have left this while loop over
here so this is an example of a basic
while loop where we check for this uh an
expression if it evaluates to true we
evaluate everything within it once this
is done we go back and we evaluate this
expression again if it is again true we
again go back into whatever is indented
within it and we keep doing this until
the expression gives us false and
interestingly we don't uh we don't
necessarily have to Define these control
variables always we can actually use uh
iterables and we will learn about
iterables actually in a future video but
we can use intro bills and an example of
an iterable is the list so let's look at
this list and let's look at this whole
block all right so I created this list a
which contains five objects one two
three four and five all integer objects
and I have another variable level X
where I store the integer one now I'm
this while statement now it might look
confusing now it says it says while a
now what is a well a is not uh your
typical expression where you're making
sure if some condition is being met or
not but this the way you read this is
while a exists so in the context of a
list as long as a which is a list
contains objects within it a is true if
it does not have any objects within it a
is false so while a basically what it
means is while a has objects within it
and if it does have objects within it or
as long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this y
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we uh do like we
we have this value X where we
um we're doing this this we're printing
this is iteration number and we pass X
so the first iteration obviously pass X
is equal to 1 and then we add X by 1 and
then the then second iteration should
pass this is iteration number two and
then so on and finally we have another
statement within this block called the a
called the pop statement where we're
popping the elements of a now as if you
would have seen the list the video on
list the pop statement removes the
rightmost value uh from a list so if I
do a DOT pop initially it will remove 5
from this list and I will have the rest
of them again if I do pop it will remove
4 from this list and then you will have
the rest of these so let's actually see
we'll actually check what's left in this
list each time we do this pop statement
so that I'll also print the list a it's
uh it's during each iteration and let's
see what happens over here as you can
see what is happening out here is while
a or while a has elements we are going
to continue doing this y statement
whatever is within it so in the first
iteration obviously we have all of it
and it is iteration number one and as
you can see the list contains everything
then I pop it then iteration number two
it again has elements but it has lost
its most rightmost element and this
keeps on happening until the list
finally has no elements left and once
the element or invents a list has no
elements left we this expression while a
evaluates to false and we do not execute
this anymore and we leave the while low
and again let's check what is in a a
should have no elements as you can see
it's an empty list when a check written
a it's an empty list and that is why
while a return near false and we do not
print any further so this is an example
of using a wire statement using lists
and of course the next topic would be
discussing nested while loops and this
is a broad topic what I mean by this is
that when when I'm saying nested while
Loops I'm actually talking about nested
control structures so we can have while
Loops within while Loops not only that
we can have FNS statements within while
Loops we can have while Loops within if
and L statements and we can have FNL
statements within FNL statements so if
you think of all of these loops and we
will even speak about for Loops in the
in the in in a in another video for
Loops again in a type of control
structure so all of these are control
structures while Loops are control
structures for Loops or control
structures if and as statements are
control structures all these are control
structures and nesting can happen within
them and it does not matter uh which is
the like the parent of the nest and then
the child of the nurse we can have a
while loop within an ifnl statement you
can have for Loops within a while loop
all of this is valid in Python and uh
it's one of the one of the great
features of python that is very flexible
in this way so let's look at an example
where I have a while loop within another
while loop so I am copying this piece of
code where I have this list one two
three four five and another list first
and second now my first while loop I
print I print what is pop from a so I
take a then I pop the zeroth index so
basically from the left hand side and I
print what is that all right and then I
have another while loop where I have
this list B and I'm doing the same thing
but this while loop is within the first
while loop and let's see what happens
out here so as you can see my first uh
my first iteration of this parent while
loop causes me to pop what is the first
element which is one then I do these
while loops and this is completely
executed and only then do I go back to
this first one and then I come back and
do all of this again then I go back to
this one and then I come back into all
of this again and that's why you can see
this repetition so I have this first
iteration and then I do uh the second
while loop then I have the second
iteration and then I do the second while
loop and I keep doing this and this is
an example of a nested while loop okay
so our next Topic in this second this
video would be break in continue
statements now break in continue
statements are ways to abruptly end
iterations uh in in a particular Loop
now you can use break in continue
statements not only in while loop where
you can use it and also in for Loops so
let's look at how we use it in while
loops and let's look at what we mean by
breaking contain new statements first of
all well the break statement terminates
the loop entirely so once the break
statement is found the the complete
while loop that we are using is
completely terminated and the continue
statement on the other hand terminates
only the current Loop iteration and it
goes back to the beginning or the
expression and it checks whether the
expression or the or the controlling
expression is again reevaluated and it
is checked whether the loop will execute
again or terminate this pictorial that
you can see here actually emphasizes or
it shows the difference between break
and continue so I have this while loop
and I have an expression all right I
have a bunch of statements and I have a
break command over here and I have a
continue command over here so if I
encounter the break command it will not
execute any of this in fact it will not
execute this wire statement at all and
it will move on to the next piece of
code that we have but a continuous
statement if a continuous statement is
income about it in a while loop will not
completely break away but it will not uh
it will not execute the the rest of the
statements in that iteration only these
two but it will go back here it will
check this expression again and again we
will do this all over again so this is
this small uh difference between the
break and continue statements but both
are used to abruptly end an iteration in
a loop so let's look at an example of
how we use the break statement so I will
use this example where I have again I
have initialized some controlling
variable n to 0 my first Loop will check
whether n is less than equal to 5 if
this is true then I will print this
statement then I will what I'm doing
over here is I am incrementing it by one
now in my previous my earlier example
using a similar uh using the similar
example I had no like this this part was
not there so what you got was I was
printing the value of n so it was
printing as like value of n is 1 I mean
0 and then one and then two and then
three four 4 and 5 but over here I've
included a small I've nested an if
statement and within that I put a break
statement and this if statement is
checking if if n is equal to equal to 2
so once n is 2 I move on to this and I
do the break statement so let's see what
happens now as you can see once so when
I have executed this I don't get the
whole value of n is 0 and then 1 and
then two three four five I I stop at one
and that is because once n is equal to 2
I actually do not execute this while
loop again I do not go back and execute
print value of n is 2 now in fact I
break from this whole while loop and my
while loop terminal is right then and
there and that's why you only get these
two iterations value of n is 0 and then
value of n is one okay so now I'm going
to show you a neat example of what
happens or what is the difference
between a break and a continuous
statement okay so let's uh go back to
our initial example where we're printing
this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4 and so on
but I have added one more statement
where I print hello at each iteration so
let's see see what happens when I do
this as you can see it will print hello
after each of whatever I was doing
already now let's introduce our break
statement first of all so when I do
break well let's go back to this if
statement if his if we check this
condition then we break let's see what
happens now as you can see something
interesting has happened where we have
this first iteration completely being
executed but the second iteration kind
of stops where there's no hello and that
is because we have broken from this
while loop before the second iterations
hello was printed let's see the
difference between a break and continue
now so now I have this continuous
statement instead of a break let's see
what happens here as you can see it
seems familiar to our first example
where we do not have any break or
continue but there is a small difference
that I want you to catch and that is
very important about this continue uh
statement so as you can see the first
iteration has value of n is 0 and then
hello and value of n is 1 but there is
no hello and this is because this is
because once this condition is actually
met we do not move on to this statement
but we go back to this expression and we
will evaluate this expression and then
once we evaluate this expression again
and it's found to be correct we do
everything the same again when we print
hello but except for that one step where
this if statement was met and we did
continue and this following statement
was not executed and that happens only
for one iteration and that is when n is
equal to equal to 2 and as you can see
that is what happens over here in one of
the iterations we may say hello and that
is the difference of the continue
statement between uh there is a
difference of the continuous statement
with the break statement this video will
be an extension into that topic where we
will be looking at three examples where
we are using while Loops along with
other stuff like say FNL statements so
our first example will be where we
calculate the factorial of a number in
this example as you can see here we are
first going to ask the user to enter a
particular number for us now this number
is supposed to be an integer once we
have this integer we store it to a
variable called number now we have this
you can say this variable called fac
which stores 1 and you we will see how
we are using it later now we know that
the factorial of 0 is 1 that's how it's
just defined so we have an if statement
checking whether our entered number is 0
and if it is 0 we say that the result is
1 or the factorial is one however if we
enter a number that is greater than 0 we
must calculate the factor oil for this
number and that is what we are going to
do in this else statement block over
here now in this else statement block we
have a while loop in this while loop the
condition is checking while number is
greater than or equal to 1. so as long
as this condition is true everything
within that while loop will be executed
so as long as number is greater than
equal to 1 we are going to execute these
two lines now what do these two lines do
let us see so the first line takes the
variable fac where we had the number one
stored and we are going to store FEC
times number into it number being the
number that we have inputted so in case
for example we we entered 8 then what
this will do this line will do is 1 into
8 and it will store that back into fac
now once that is done we move on to the
next line where we are decrementing the
number variable by one so if we have
stored 8 or we have entered 8 into our
input it will become 7. now as we know 7
is still greater than or equal to 1 so
this condition is still being met and
then we do this process again where we
are going to multiply fac this time fac
stores the value 8 and we multiply it
times the new number which is 7 now so
we do 8 into 7 and then again we
decrement this uh also once we do 8 into
7 we store it back into fac and we keep
doing this where we keep multiplying 8
times 7 and then we decrement the number
variable uh by one and then we check
this condition again so what ends up
happening is we are going to keep doing
8 into 7 into 6 into 5 into 4 into 3
into 2 into 1 and once we are at 1 again
when we do this document operation the
number variable we store the value is 0
and then this condition will no longer
be met so number will be 0 and this
condition will be false and we can move
out of this while low then finally we
store the result into a variable called
result which stores the result of 8 into
7 into 6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2
into 1 this is of course if we did enter
8 when we were asked to give an input so
let's see this
um in real time once we execute this so
I'm executing this the first thing it
asks me is to enter a number so let's
say I enter my number 8 as I was
speaking about 8. all right now that I
went at 8 as you can see the result that
it gives me is factorial of 8 is 4 0 3 2
0 which is correct and you can check
this for yourself where it will show you
um 8 times 7 or 8 factorial is basically
this this number okay so now in our next
example we will be looking at how we can
generate Fibonacci numbers for this
example we will be using bunch of if and
else if statements along with a while
loop so let's look at this piece of code
where we are actually doing this so as
you can see the first part of the code
is basically an input statement asking
us how many Fibonacci numbers we would
like to generate and then the user it
would be asked to give an input which is
stored as an INT into a variable count
now in this if a statement the first if
statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
FIB next if our entered integer is 1 we
just store the value 1 in this array
called FIB if our enter number is 2 we
store 1 and 1 in the array FIB all of
these are different sets of Fibonacci
sequences this obviously an empty an
empty array shows that well there is no
numbers to be generated in this sequence
if we have one we just print the first
number of the Fibonacci sequence which
is one itself if it is 2 we print the
first two numbers which is one and one
now the actual calculations happen when
we say we want a Fibonacci sequence for
more than two numbers now in that case
we move on to this block in this
statement block we initialize the FIB
variable with the first two Fibonacci
numbers one and one and we store in this
very in this array now we are going to
do a while loop within this and in this
while loop we're going to keep executing
this statement block as long as this
condition is met or this condition is
true and what this condition is is it's
checking this variable I which we have
initialized as 1 over here and we're
going to check whether that is lesser
than count minus 1 count being the
number that we have been asked to input
if the statement is true and as long as
this statement is true we will be
executing this statement block which is
basically us appending this expression
into the array FIB now what this
expression is is basically it's going to
keep adding so each subsequent numbers
and we are going to store each
subsequent numbers back into the array
Fib so in this case if you see the
fourth the first step will do is it will
take the value at the first portion of
the array film and it will add it to the
value at the 0th position of the array
fib and both of these values since they
are 1 and 1 when we add them we get 2
and we append that to Fib so now our FIB
will look like 1 comma 1 comma two then
we increment this by 1 and what we do is
we do the same process again so in the
next step what will be what we would do
is we would do 2 plus 1 so we would get
three now this would keep going on until
this condition is met or basically until
uh the numbers that we actually want to
generate in our sequence so let's say
let's let's uh execute this and let's
see an example of what happens so it
asks me how many Fibonacci numbers I
would like to generate and I will say I
want the first let's say six Fibonacci
numbers so I execute this as you can see
this gives me the first six numbers in
the sequence which is 1 and 1 and then 2
which is basically one plus one and then
three which is one plus two and then 5
which is 2 plus 3 8 which is three plus
five so if we wanted more numbers we
would just enter over here like say if
you wanted the first 10 numbers it would
give us the first 10 numbers in the
sequence as you can see here now in our
next example what we are going to do is
we are going to write a program which
takes two digits that represent the
dimensions of an array so for example if
we want a three by three array we will
enter three comma 3 and we are going to
generate a two dimensional array in
which each of the elements of the array
are basically the row times the column
position of that particular element and
what I mean by this is say we have a
position I comma J on the array the
value of the element at that position
would be I times J so for example if I'm
looking at something at the third row
and the fifth column or say the third
row and the third column for example the
value of the element would be 3 times 3
and if I'm looking at something at the
second row and the fourth column I am
going to do 2 times 4. so let's uh let's
see how we can do this using Code so if
you look to the right over here I have a
piece of code where I'm going to uh in
where it asks me to input two numbers
two integers to represent the dimensions
of my uh example my sample array now
once we have done this we are going to
store these uh these dimensions in the
inputs in in a variable called input
string so obviously when we enter say 5
comma 5 that will be stored as an in in
this particular string or this variable
what we want is we want five save a
enter 5 comma five we want five as a
separate integer and the other five as
another separate integer and that is
what we do in this particular statement
where we are going to split up our input
string based on the comma separator and
we're going to store the first part of
that string into the zeroth position of
Dimensions which is an array and the
next dimension in the first position in
this particular array now we are going
to store the number of rows as row
number and that is the zeroth position
of this array and we're going to store
the number of columns as the first
position of Dimensions or whatever we've
mentioned in the input so now we we have
this our results array called multi list
which is basically what what our final
array is going to look like and we are
going to store into multi-list and in
this example we will be using for Loops
to do this or to create this particular
array so as you can see here our first
uh we have initialized our multi list
saying that um we're going to have only
zeros in our sample array so initial
really once we have initialized this
array all multi lists will contain is a
say for example we have inputted a five
by five array it will have basically a
5x5 array with all elements as zero and
that's what this line does once we have
done this we are going to move on to the
for Loop portion where we are actually
going to create our array that we want
so as you can see we are our first for
Loop is going to say four row in range
row number so obviously uh range will
generate a an iterator which can be
iterated over and since it says range
row number and say our the number of
rows that we entered were five what it's
going to do is it's going to create an
iterator containing the value 0 1 2 3
and 4. so for row and range it will
basically basically row will take the
value 0 1 2 3 and 4. and a similar thing
is going to happen in this nested for
Loop which is within this where we're
going to again uh create a an iterator
using this range function and for the
column number once we have this we're
going to do the simple process of
multiplying the uh the value of the
element based on its position so if it's
at the position 3 comma 4 we are going
to store the value 3 times 4 into that
particular position of the array and
we're going to do this for every
position which is what happens in these
two for Loops we are going to first go
by each row and then within that we're
going to check each column and we're
going to perform these calculations and
finally we print our result so let's
look at an example now I'm going to say
I want a 3 by let's say a 2 by 4 Matrix
so let's see what the results will be
when I give this as uh so what I'm
saying is I want two rows and four
columns now as you can see here it might
not be very clear to you right now but
what you can see here is this is the
first row and this is the second row and
each row contains four columns so these
are the this is the my final array that
I get so what you can see here is this
is the zeroth position and the uh or you
can say this is the first row First
Column first row second column and since
python is zero based so this is actually
the zeroth row and this is the first row
so as you can see uh this this value
basically is zero times one this value
is zero times two zero times three zero
times four and over here it is one times
zero one times one one times two one
times three so similarly if I did for
example a five by five Matrix what you
will get is five rows now five rows and
five columns and for example like this
particular value is uh one two three or
zero one two three so zero one two three
and the First Column so this is three
times one
um if I took this value this is like the
fourth row for example fourth row times
the um zero one two three third column
so this would be four times three which
is twelve so and each value of this has
been generated in the similar process so
this is an example of how we can use for
Loops
um for a particular exercise that I have
shown you right now in this video we
will be covering the topic of definite
iterations using for Loops in Python so
starting off we know that there are two
types of iterations in programming a
definite and indefinite we have already
covered indefinite iterations in the
form of while Loops definite iterations
on the other hand are done using the
keyword for and the basic syntax or the
standard Syntax for a basic for Loop in
Python is as you can see over here we
have this four keyword we have some
variable we have the in keyword and we
have this iterable and we of course
Define this control structure with the
colon and then indented we have this
statement block so once this for Loop
has started we execute all of these
statements within the statement block as
part of the for Loop iteration so yeah
let's uh now let's to understand like
how for loops work uh exactly let's look
at the concept or meaning behind what we
call iterables and iterators so so think
of it in a stepwise manner all right so
we in Python we have different objects
that can be used as iterables and an
iterable is basically some object that
uh it's it's a collection of other
objects so you know think of your lists
uh think of dictionaries and sets so all
of these are essentially collections of
objects so once we have these collection
of objects we can create an iterator out
of it uh how do we do that is we use the
iter function so for example if I pass
this list a if I pass this list a
through the iter function and I store it
in some variable either underscore a and
I see what is item underscore a it is
actually a list iterator at some random
memory location which we don't really
care about similarly if I gave a tuple
and I did the same thing I will create a
tuple iterator and in the left if you
can see over here I've done the exact
same functions with sets and
dictionaries as well so I'm creating
iterators out of these uh levels so as
to speak uh now what is an iterator well
an iterator is an object that yields
values successively so if my list
contained five values or five objects an
iterator of this list will yield these
values uh one after the other and that
is kind of how or that is the basis for
which we do we create Loops let's see
what we exactly mean using this uh using
another function that we call the next
function so the next function keeps
moving from object to object within an
iterator so since I've created this list
iterator let's just do it once again so
as you can see I've created this list
iterator underscore a now with this item
underscore a what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use this next function what
next function does is starting from the
leftmost object within this iterator I
will keep yielding or keep producing the
values so let's let's just see what
happens when I do next iterate when I do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when I do it again now it
gives me the object second what if I did
it again it gives me third now if I kept
doing this it will keep giving me the
different objects that were initially
stored in a that is first and then
second third fourth and fifth one after
the other so let's actually perform that
now I get fourth now I get fifth now an
actual question is now that I've
exhausted all of these values what will
happen if I perform the next function
again but let's see what happens I get a
uh an error or and this error is the
stop iteration function error which
basically is telling me look you have uh
exhausted all of the objects that were
initially present in this list a and you
cannot you cannot keep doing the next
next function anymore you cannot keep
going further so yeah so this is what
the next function does when it comes to
the concept of iterators all right so
now we've learned two things what is an
iterator and what is the how do we
create an iterator out of different
collections of objects like a list or a
tuple and we've also learned how to use
the next function now let's uh move or
let's come back to our for Loop that we
started off this video with so our for
loop again let's consider our for Loop
over here
as you can see some for loop with the
objects again one two three four and
five all right this is a list now I'm
going to do for X in a print X and let's
try to see what happens when we do this
okay as you can see when I have executed
this it gives me one two three four and
five so I have first of all let's look
at this for loop I in this for loop I
Define a new variable X and then I say
for X in a print X and what's happening
well in each iteration I am printing
whatever the value of x is at present so
in the first iteration it is the first
object one in the second iteration it is
the second object two then three four
five and then finally uh on its own like
uh this for Loop knows that okay now
once I have exhausted all of the objects
within my iterator I can stop doing this
for Loop and I can move on with the rest
of the code all right so think of it
like a three-step process uh a for Loop
in Python the first step is it calls an
iter function to obtain an iterator for
whatever we pass over here this iterable
second step it calls the next function
repeatedly in each iteration all right
to keep getting the next item from the
iterator so it gets one then it calls
next then it gets two then it calls next
and it gets three and then four and then
five and so on and then finally the
third step is determination step is when
after we do the final next where we get
this error as you can see the stop
iteration error or exception finally
this does the for Loop function or the
for Loop that okay we have reached the
end of our definite iteration or the end
of our definite for Loop and this is
where we must terminate our Loop and
then continue with the rest of the code
all right so this is how a for Loop
Works in Python now it's very important
to note that whatever we have discussed
when it came to while Loops such as
nesting of while loops and nesting of
other control structures is also
applicable in the case of for Loops so
if I had a for Loop in another for Loop
that is perfectly fine if I had a while
within a for Loop that is perfectly fine
so all of these are valid statement
blocks that we can do and again for Loop
is another control structure and so we
must follow the concept of indentation
when it comes to writing our statement
blocks within a for Loop okay so now I'm
going to speak about in specific I'm
going to speak about the this uh
something called the range function that
is uh quite you could say it's used
definitely it's used in other areas of
programming but it's widely used in
Python uh I mean I mean the for Loop in
Python uh what I mean by this is that um
Range this range function is very
important for the for Loop and we will
see why okay so let's look at one of the
examples of using the range function so
what does the range function do is if I
give range 5 let's see what it does it
gives me range 0 to 5. what this
basically tells me is that this will
create an iterator that contains uh
integers from 0 to 5 so it will contain
the object 0 1 2 3 4 and 5 and we can
use this as an iterator so let's let's
look at this uh I have Range Five let's
store this in X okay now let's do a type
just to see what happens when we do Type
X it should give me the type of range as
you can see and this is a type of an
iterator in Python now let's see what
happens when I do for I in X print I
okay let's see what happens as you can
see it prints the number 0 1 2 3 4 an
important caveat when it comes to the
range function is when we say range 5 it
creates an iterator from 0 to 5 but it
contains the objects 0 1 2 3 and 4 only
it does not contain the object 5 itself
okay this is something that is very
important to so once again I created I
use this range function to create an
iterator from iterator five objects from
zero to four zero one two three and four
uh I use that in my for Loop and that's
what that is what you are seeing here
now let's use this range function in the
context of something else for example
let's see so I had my earlier list a
right look at my list a here
so you can see list a contains these one
two three four five five objects okay
let's see what length of a is length of
a is five okay uh let's use the range
function on top of the length of this
list a and this is uh like I can't show
you an example right now without any
context but this uh this form of using a
for Loop is used is widely used in uh
Python Programming you will use it so
much in data science you will use so
much in machine learning and AI I cannot
tell you uh this is so this is a very
important like sort of uh for Loop
expression so you have four let's say I
in range Len a let's see what's going on
here first I create first I do length of
a that gives me 5 then into range of 5
that creates an iterator between 0 and 4
right when you do Range Five it gives
you an iterator of zero one two three
and four as we saw earlier and this is
what we're doing over here we have
created an iterator out of the length of
a list now when I do print I it should
give me again one two three four zero
one two three four of course so as you
can see here it will give me zero one
two three four and this is a very neat
way of using the range function on top
of the length of a particular collection
of objects in this case we're using the
list a this is something that you will
use a lot so I I would recommend that
you get used to this form of creating a
for loop as well using the range
function also of course
um there are uh the you can use break
and continue statements as you have in
the case of while Loops uh exactly this
it works exactly the same in the case of
for Loops wherein the break statement
will abruptly stop the for Loop
completely and we will move on to the
next piece of code whereas the continue
statement will break that particular
iteration and then we will resume with
the next iteration so yeah that was
break in continue statements and for
Loops finally I would like to show you
something about uh how to use
dictionaries as an iterator or or as an
iterable when it comes to for Loops so
let's create our dictionary let's go we
have a dictionary already here in fact
create this dictionary again we'll store
it in a okay so I created this
dictionary a all right so I have
dictionary a uh what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pass it through the iter
function as you can see and now I'm
going to just for the sake of showing
you it will show I'll show you that it
is actually an iterator of type of a
specific key iterator type all right so
now let's uh let's do something on this
so as you can see in the dictionary I
have the key first that has a value one
I have the key second that has a value
two I have the key third that has a
value three and then fourth for four
fifth for five now a good question would
be when I do iteration or when I do a
for loop on top of this a well what is
it going to pick up is it going to pick
up first uh is it going to pick up the
keys like these or is it going to pick
up the values or is it going to go one
by one key and then value on the key in
the subsequent value uh let's see what
actually happens let's do 4 I in iter
underscore a print I let's see what what
is The iterations Happening upon using
this so as you can see we're using the
keys so by default when we do this when
we perform when we create an iterator
out of a dictionary we use only the keys
as our uh iterator elements or at
iterator values but of course like if
you wanted to use values all you would
have to do is pass a DOT values over
here and if you remember from a
dictionary video this uh a DOT values
gives us a list of or it it gives us the
essentially a list of the values in our
dictionary so when we pass this to the
iterator uh iter function and we create
an iterator out of it let's see what
happens over here now let's see what is
ETA underscore a you can actually see
it's now the dict value iterator at a
particular memory location in so it's
not the dick key as we saw earlier it's
a dict value iterator so now that we
have this dictionary value iterator now
let's print what are our iterator
elements and as you can see now we are
printing values and not the keys so this
is how to this this is basically two
different ways of iterating through a
dictionary one through keys and one
through values in this video we will be
doing a small exercise on if statements
now in the previous video you might have
already seen some of the basic concepts
surrounding if statements however in
this video just to drive home the point
or the purpose of an if statement we
will be doing a small exercise so let's
first revise some of the concepts of an
if statement so basic if statement can
be something like this we have a small
condition where we are checking if a
variable X is greater than 5 or not and
if it is greater than x we print a
statement over here so if this condition
is met we print this statement as we
move to the statement log now our
variable X has the value 5. now since X
is not greater than 5 what this will do
is it will check the statement and since
this will be false we skip the statement
block and move on to this statement so
as you can see here similarly we can do
something where we are checking multiple
statements we use the L if statement in
such a case so now in this block we are
checking in one of the one of the
conditions we're checking is if x is
equal to 5 or if x is greater than 5 and
then finally if both of these conditions
are not met we say else and we print
whatever or we do whatever is in this
particular statement block which is a
simple print statement so as you can see
X is indeed good is equal to 5 so this
is the block that will get executed as
you can see here now another example our
nestative statements so nestled FL
statements are if else statements within
if else statements so let's look at an
example as you can see here we have a
string stored in a variable called
orange quality and the string is fresh
now we have an integer or a float in
this case 4.0 stored in Orange price now
our first statement is checking whether
orange quality the variable orange
quality is it equal to the string fresh
now within that if the statement or if
this condition is met we do another
check where we're checking what is the
price is it lesser than 5 if it is V2
this block else we execute this block
finally if our initial uh statement our
initial condition is not met we move on
to this else block now when I execute
this what should happen is I will enter
this block because this is true and
finally I will enter this block because
this condition is also true so I should
have this printed I will buy five dozens
as you can see here now let's move on to
our main exercise for this video so this
was all just the revision now we're
going to use some or all of these
Concepts in a sample project or a sample
exercise to for your further practice so
in this exercise what we're going to do
is we're going to request the user to
enter a number between 1 and 20 and our
our code is going to check whether this
number entered is an even number or an
odd number so as you can see there are
two sets of checks that we're going to
do in this code the first check is going
to be whether the number that is entered
is between 1 and 20 or not and if it is
not we have to say it's an invalid
number but if it is entered between 1
and 20 we have to move on to the further
checks which is whether it is an even or
an odd number so let's see how we do
that so in this piece of code what we
start with is a print statement saying
please enter a number between 1 and 20
and then we add an input command this
input command will open a box where we
can enter whatever number that we want
to enter now we use this int keyword to
make sure that whatever we have entered
into the input box is stored as a int
data type in the enter num variable once
we do that our first if statement is
going to check whether the entered
number is greater than or equal to 1 or
lesser than equal to 20. sorry and less
than equal to 20. so both of these
conditions have to be met if this
condition is true then we have a valid
input and this statement is printed that
we have entered a valid number and then
we move on to the rest of the statement
block within this if statement which is
another set of if and else if statements
if our number is not between 120 we move
to this block and this block prints that
we have entered in invalid number now
once we have say entered a valid number
we move on to this block this is in if
else if LF statement block now what this
block is checking is whether the entered
number is an even number or not now as
we know an even number is divisible by 2
1 leave the remainder 0 when divided by
2. so this is what this check is doing
if this check is true that means our
number is even and we get printed that
our number is even the other other check
or the other if statement is checking
whether it's an odd number and that
means when we divide by 2 we should get
the remainder 1 as you can see here and
we get printed your number is odd so
let's execute this and see what happens
when we enter a number now it's asking
me to enter a number let's say I enter
17.
now that I've entered 17 as you can see
it's a valid number that I have entered
and the code is telling me that my
number is indeed odd let's look at some
other what if I entered something else
here let's say if I enter 16 now since
it's an even number as you can see 16 is
also a valid number as it's between 1
and 20 and my number is even the code
checks for that let's see if what
happens when I enter an invalid number
let's say 25 now when I enter 25 as you
can see it says I have entered invalid
number and in this case what has
happened is this condition itself is not
met and I have moved on to this
statement block so to give you a
breakdown as to how our code has
executed this let me show you an example
for the number say 9 when I enter nine
the first check that happens of course
is this check whether it's a valid
number or not and since it is between 1
and 20 we move on to this block and in
this block it's checking whether our
numbers divisible by 2 or not and since
it is is not it will remain it will
leave a remainder 1 and we execute this
block it says our print our number is
Odd as you can see here in this video we
are going to learn about the topic
called file handling now file handling
is basically needed because so most of
the times when we are handling large and
different types of data in python or in
general we cannot store everything into
a variable and we will have to use files
now there are two types of files that we
are going to deal with they are binary
and text files so binary files are some
of the files that we most of the files
that we commonly encounter like document
files image Files video files Etc now
all binary files are encoded in a
particular format and they cannot be
read by a normal text editor and we
would be needing certain specific
softwares for specific files text files
on the other hand do not have any
specific encoding and they can be opened
in the normal text editor itself and
they are like XML CSS HTML files and so
on now there are four main operations
that we can do you on file in Python on
files they are open read write and close
um there are certain other operations as
well though like rename delete so some
of the most basic operation that we can
do is obviously creating and opening a
file and the syntax is as you can see
here where we store where we use the
open command and we give a file name and
we give a mode and we store that in a
particular variable now a mode is uh
basically telling python how to handle
this opening so we can have a read-only
mode which is done by this letter r a
write-only mode which is done by letter
W and for there are a bunch of other
modes such as read or write mode which
is done by R plus and we're going to see
them as we encounter them now the it's
important to note that what I just
mentioned is for text files if we are
going to do for binary files we are
going to do this file handling then we
would be using the letter B in front of
whatever we were using in the case of
text files so if we were doing a
read-only mode for opening a binary file
um we would be using RV and if we were
doing read and write mode a read or
write only mode for a binary file we
would be using RB plus so basically just
adding the b in the case of binary files
let's look at a basic example when we
want to open a particular file we are
going to open like in this example I'm
going to open some file called
firehandling.txt in a read and write
mode read or write mode and I'm going to
store it in fo so this is as simple as
it gets similarly if I wanted to do it
for the binary file since I'm using a
binary file I will use the letter B as
well in the mode and that's how you do
it here now let's look at different ways
in which we can read from a file and
there are three commands that we can use
we can use the read command followed by
a optional number of characters we can
use the read line command followed by an
option number of characters and the read
lines command so this optional number of
characters denoted by n over here
um and basically telling us how many
characters we want to print so let's
look at a simple example of where I'm
going to print something called
so I'm going to take this and I'm going
to do a print on top of this so I have
done first I've opened it and I've
stored it in my file and then I'm going
to do a uh a method or a function called
read and I'm going to say like in this
example just read the whole thing so as
you can see my file that I have opened
has all of these lines this is like the
whole file basically but now what if I
wanted to open only the first five
characters of this file which is
basically this well in that case let's
open this once again now let's do the
same read command except we will give
the character number which is five as
you can see it's only printed five now
let's do a print read command and try to
read the whole thing again and you will
notice something very interesting now
when I do the read command you can see
it's kind of picked up from where we
left off you know from our previous
command and that is the nature of how
python handles files so if I wanted to
again take the cursor back in such an
example I will have to open this again
and then I use this read command once
again to get back to where I started
from as you can see here now another
command that we can use is the read line
command so let's uh once again next time
if I do it it should say big data as you
can see here okay so this is the read
line command now within the realign
command also we can enter uh characters
and that will tell us basically
um that we want these number of
characters from the next line so if I
want the first six characters of the
next line I will say six I've learned to
six here and it will give me the first
six characters of this particular line
which is the next line that is to come
as you can see here now another way in
which we can print whatever is there in
our file line by line is by using a for
Loop so again I'm going to open this
file I'm going to store it here now I'm
going to use a for Loop saying that well
for a line in my file and what this does
is basically at each each iteration it's
going to take each line and store it in
this variable that we enter over here
which is called line itself and we're
going to print that at the end of the
loop we what we'll have is all of the
lines have been printed one by one and
another thing that we can do right now
is um say we want to read a particular
line see I wanted you to read the fifth
line of my file I can use this technique
where
um I just say okay I'm going to store 5
in this variable called line number and
I have this another variable called
current line which I'm going to
initialize with one and I'm going to any
I'm gonna what I'm going to do is I mean
but I'm gonna add a condition saying
that only if current line when it's
equal to line number am I going to print
the line and then I'm going to break out
of this whole thing and at the end of
each Loop I'm going to say current line
is going to be incremented by 1 until
basically these two variables are equal
so when I do this I get my result which
is machine learning which is the fifth
line of um my which is the fifth line of
or whatever file I had now we're gonna
move on to the topic of um image file
handling so we saw how we handled and we
we saw certain operations around text
files and text files are obviously
something that we're going to use a lot
but we are also going to be using files
such as images a lot and let's look at
certain examples and certain use cases
around image file handling so my first
step is going to be importing a bunch of
modules and packages now the details of
these modules and these packages are not
important as of right now because they
will be covered in a future video but
just keep a note of some of these
packages such as um let's say numpy and
image the image package so once I've
done this let's move on to my example so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
store certain file locations in two
variables so it's basically two strings
I've attached the uh this prefix R to
say that this is a read-only uh sort of
a prefix so the next topic that we're
going to be handling is image file
handling now we have already seen many
examples pertaining to text files so
text files are obviously something that
we're going to be using a lot but image
file handling is something very
important as well and we're going to see
certain operations that we can do around
image file handling so starting off I'm
going to import a bunch of packages and
modules what these packages exactly are
and what these modules exactly are are
right now not of that important of not
are not that important to you right now
but it's something that will be covered
in a future or future videos it's
important to just keep note of what
these are such as numpy and image so
once I've done that what I'm going to
store is I'm going to store two
particular file locations into variables
location one and location two and I've
prefixed them with r just to say that
these are raw strings so once I've done
that I'm going to use the image from the
image package I'm going to say open and
I'm going to say open from this
particular location and this particular
location and I'm going to store these
image images in I M1 and im2 over here
very similar to a normal text file
opening now once we've done this we can
access certain properties of this image
using say format which tells us the
format of the file it attributes the it
identifies the source of an image and if
the image will not read from a file it
is set to none we can also see the size
of the file using the size attribute and
we can see the mode which basically
defines the number and names of the
bands in the image and also contains a
pixel type and depth certain common
modes are like L for luminescence RGB
for true color images and CMYK for
pre-press images so let's look at them
so when I access this you can see my
first file is of jpeg of this size and
an RGB format image and my second image
is another jpeg slightly bigger image
and again RGB now we can also of course
display these images and to do that we
can use the PLT again PLT is the is
supposed to and for a matplotlib DOT
pipelot it's a particular for a
particular package that again you don't
need to know the details of right now
but this is how we would do this so I'm
going to use a bunch of commands and
methods such as figure and subplot and
then I am sure so once I have done this
as you can see both of my images with
this being im1 this being im2 have been
produced on the screen as you can see I
can also use display this display
function followed by the name of the
file and this will simply display my
image as you can see here now I can
obviously save a particular image using
the save function which is as simple as
just doing this so I'm going to save the
image as I am underscore save.jpg over
here now if I wanted to crop an image I
can do that as well so I initially I
stored the dimensions that I want
cropped in the form of a tuple as you
can see here and I'm gonna pass that
Tuple to the crop function and I'm going
to apply that on top of im1 and I'm
going to store that to region once I've
done that as you can see so basically
what I've done is I've cropped this
image based on whatever I've passed here
and I've stored it into region and now
if I wanted to see what was actually in
that crop I can just do the IM show
function and I'm going to pass the
particular cropped image which is
denoted by region as you can see here
and you can see my cropped image is
basically a certain a left portion of
this whole image has been cropped out
and I have produced it over here now I
can also use the copy function using
it's a simple basically copy basically
you use the copy function and it copies
an image onto another variable that you
have assigned and when I use the IM show
function I am going to show you the
copied image which is basically the same
now we can do the transpose operation as
well so let's see some of the let's see
what we have done here so in this
transpose opposite operation so in this
basically I've done a bunch of operation
patients such as rotating by 90 degrees
rotating by 180 rotating by 7 270 and
finally once I've done with all of these
multiple operations I am going to show
you the final output which is basically
a certain transposed image like this
which is basically the result of
whatever I have done before this so this
is it for this video on file handling I
have shown you two slightly more
comprehensive examples on text files and
even certain examples on image files
however we can use file handling in
different libraries pertaining to file
handling for audio files and even for
like stuff like PDF files and this is
like this is just only the beginning and
I'm sure you will encounter a lot of
different use cases different examples
as you continue learning Python
Programming this video is going to be
the first of a part of a series on
object oriented programming so to start
off with let's try to understand and get
an introduction into what is object
oriented programming well as the name
suggests object oriented programming is
all about creating objects an object is
a group of interrelated variables and
functions variables can be referred to
as the properties of the object whereas
the functions can be referred to as the
behavior of an object so if we were to
treat say for example a car as an object
its properties would be its color its
model its price and its brand whereas
Its Behavior or functions for that
matter would be like accelerating gear
change braking similarly if I give you
an example of a dog as an object we
could consider the properties of the dog
as its weight or its name its breed its
color whereas its functions could be say
barking playing eating walking Etc
objects provide a better and a clear
structure for a program now let's move
on to what is a class and an instance
now a class is like a blueprint or a
template of certain functions and
entities whereas an instance is a
particular realization of a class
classes are used to create user-defined
data structures and Define certain
functions called Methods within the
class whereas instances are realizations
of these classes and when we are
speaking of classes and instances
classes don't contain any real data they
are just merely templates instances on
the other hand contain real data to
think of an example of the difference
between a class and an instance think of
a class like a empty form or a
questionnaire now an empty form of a
questionnaire does not have any
information but it does have a template
to it it tells you to fill in certain
information and based on who is filling
in the information that information or
the data on a particular form will be
different so an instance is like a
filled out form with its own a unique
set of information that is one way of
treating or understanding what is a
class and in instance now for our first
example on classes I will be taking you
through a class where I've defined based
on the circle object so this class is
going to define basically information
about your general circles such as this
radius and this area so let's go through
it now obviously to define a class we
need a keyword well in the case of
classes we use the class keyword
followed by a name for that class so in
this case my name is circle now after
the colon every every information that
is part of the class has to be obviously
indented as is typical for python now
you can see over here A bunch of Dev
keywords followed by something that you
might not be familiar with and I will
try to get you through this so if you
see here you have a def keyword followed
by init and this init is prefixed by a
double underscore and it suffix by
double underscore and you can see the
same thing for Str and repr well this
double underscore is called a Dunder and
any method these are of course methods
this is a method this is a method this
is a method this is a method now any
method that is prefixed and suffixed by
double underscores are called Dunder
methods these Dunder methods are or can
be thought of like predefined or
built-in methods for any class that you
define so these we have like three
Dunder methods over here and we have one
user defined method that we will get to
so this first method that you see here
is the init method or the initialization
method and this is invoked or called
whenever we create an instance of this
class Circle and what we do here is
basically we pass when we create this
instant Circle we are what what happens
is that we are we get an option to pass
an a value for a what what is this uh
keyword or variable radius so if I pass
so you will see me later on creating an
instance where um I will be passing a
value and that value is basically stored
as the radius and by default the radius
that will be passed whenever we create
an instance for this class is one the
Str method is basically used to return a
descriptive string for the the instance
of class
um our API is not something that you
have to bother with right now and uh now
get area is something that you should
follow because if you see here I have
not used any double underscores so this
is a user user defined method user
defined methods are some methods that we
Define and these are like tasks that we
Define on our own so in my user defined
method called get area I will be
returning the area of this circle based
on the radius that I pass to it now if
you notice here before every in every
method I have the self keyword before
any other attribute so like this has
self this herself even the get area
herself now what this means
um self is like an optional keyword that
is used to improve readability of a
program for first of all and it's also
the function of the self keyword is
basically
um telling python that well any of the
methods that we are invoking in this
class or the instance of this class has
to refer to attributes and variables
within that instance of that class so if
I'm going to use get area function I am
going to get values and attribute values
and variable values based on only the
current instance of that particular
class self is obviously optional we
don't really need it but basically the
first attribute of any method is is
basically the is basically what the meth
is is the instance that the method is
invoked upon so if I say self I am
telling this particular function that
okay all the value that you're going to
get for performing whatever task you
want is going to be found in that
particular instance where you have been
invoked itself now don't worry if all
this is very confusing
um this might be in the beginning but
just try to understand that this is
something that we do for good practice
and you will understand uh when when to
yourself or when not to yourself as you
learn about objective oriented
programming so if you see here my get AF
function is supposed to return the value
radius times radius self dot radius is
basically telling um whatever value I've
passed for radius for that particular
instance you can read this as radius
times radius times pi as well so
obviously this is pi R square which is
the area of a particular circle now let
me show you an example where I am going
to perform some of these functions so if
you see this first line I have created
an instance of the class Circle where
I've passed 2.1 for the radius of the
circle so now the value of the variable
radius in this particular instance is
going to be stored as 2.1 and this
particular instance is going to be
stored in the variable C1 now the print
C1 function invokes the Str self defined
or predefined function now if you
remember Str was it's basically used to
return a particular string that
describes like what the class will do
and this is something that we Define on
our own in our example Str will return
the uh the string saying this is a
circle with radius of and then it will
return the radius that we passed so in
this case it should say this is the
circle of radius 2.1 as you can see over
here so if I execute this you can notice
this line This is a circle with radius
2.1 and this is invoked by the print
function the print basically invokes the
dunder Str function which does all of
this now in the next line we say print
C1 dot get area so this is going to
print the value of the or what what gets
returned when we invoke the method get
area for this particular instance C1 so
obviously in this particular instance
our radius is 2.1 so the get area
function should do pi times 2.1 square
and the value is as you can see here is
some 13.85 so that is the area that we
got now if we want to print a particular
radius we just say print C1 dot radius
so this will print the value of what is
what is stored in radius for the
particular instance C1 now you might
notice me using a DOT whenever it comes
to defining a certain function or a
keyword well any time that we want to
invoke or use a method of a particular
class we have to use the dot keyword so
we use the instance name C1 dot followed
by whatever method that we want to use
so if we want to use the get area
function we say C1 dot get area if you
want to find out what is there in the
radius key radius variable of a
particular instance we say C1 dot radius
now before we move on let's talk about
some of the naming conventions class
names are initial capitalized so if our
class name is for example
um like for example if it's camel case
well each word that is part of this
class has its first letter capitalized
variables and Method names are in lower
class so if my class was called Circle
we say class circle with C being in
capital now moving on let's talk about
how we initialize or Define instance
variables now instance variables are
declared within the init method if you
remember from the earlier example of
circle init is a Dunder method it's
followed and it's preceded by double
underscore as you can see here now if
you see in this particular case I have
again used the self keyword and as I
mentioned earlier the self keyword is
the first parameter of all member
methods
um and it this basically binds that
particular method to the particular
instance itself during invocation so
every time a new Circle object is
created the dot init function sets the
initial state of the object by assigning
the values of the object's properties so
if the init function basically
initializes each and every new instance
of um whatever of our class so we can
give in it any number of parameters but
the first parameter must always be a
variable called self now when a new
class instance is created the instance
is automatically passed to the self
parameter in init so that new attributes
can be defined on the object inside the
init method the self.radius basically
means that we want the value of radius
based on the current instance itself so
as you can see radius defines an
instance variable radius and we're going
to use the particular instance and its
value of 4 radius in our variable radius
now instance uh the inner I mean the
init function is not a Constructor but
it is an initializer to create instance
variables the init function also will
never return a value and it is optional
and can be omitted if there are no
instance variables now let's move on to
class variables so now as we mentioned
earlier all the attributes that are
created inside the init function are
instance specific attributes and the
instance attributes are obviously
specific to a particular instance of the
class for example all objects now if we
have a class called dog then all dog
objects have a name and age but the
values for the name and age will vary
depending on which dog we are talking
talking about or basically which
instance of the dog are we talking about
now class attributes are attributes that
have the same value for all class
instances and we define a class
attribute by assigning a valuable value
to a variable outside of the init
function so if you look at this example
over here we have created another class
called Circle and we have this
initializer again where we have class
specific variable called radius which
whose value will change depending on
whatever we pass for that particular
instance however if you look before the
initial the init init function or the
initializer function if you see here we
have another variable called shape
object which stores the string Circle
and this variable is going to be the
same and constant for every instance of
the class Circle and unlike the variable
radius we will not have different values
depending on a particular instance okay
now let's talk about instantiating an
object and let's see what happens when
we create two different instances of the
same class so as you can see here I've
created an instance C1 for class Circle
and I'm going to check its ID well if
you see the ID is something like this
now if I create it another instance over
here called C2 and if I check its ID
well it's something different now so if
you see each instance basically has a
different memory location in our memory
and each instance is this is how each
instance is different each time we
create it and they are created in
different memory locations finally
before we conclude this topic on the
introduction into oop let's talk about
class methods instance methods and
static methods now class methods are
usually declared are actually declared
with the at class method operator or
decorator as you can see here it accepts
the class as its first argument so in
this case I am gonna say I'm going to
define a class called my class I'm gonna
use this at class method decorator to
say that whatever follows here is going
to be a class method and I've defined a
class method called hello that takes in
a um that uses again self and a name
attribute so what this does is it prints
um whatever I have passed to it in the
form of hello from self.name now what
this this is going to do is basically
it's going to give out a string saying
hello from name of the whatever class we
have and whatever we pass the attribute
name so oh in this my particular in this
case I'm going to invoke this method
using the class name itself I'm not
going to use an instance name because I
have no instance in this particular
example and since this is a class method
it can be invoked using the class name
itself so I'm going to pass Rakesh and
let's see what happens when we do this
as you can see the first print will
basically give us the information of the
class itself it's saying that the class
is called my class and the second print
statement is basically a string saying
hello from uh the string name my class
with a comma and then whatever we passed
initially which was Rakesh next is then
instance methods and these are the most
common types of methods um these are
invoked by an instance object so we have
to create an instance to actually use an
instance method and it takes the
instance or the keyword itself as its
first argument so if I say class dot
class if I define a class my class in
this example and I'm going to Define
another function called hello as you can
see I have not used any decorator like
at class method so this is going to be
an instance method and it's going to be
invoked by the particular instance so in
this case it's going to print hello from
and it's going to basically say the name
of the class again so I create my
instance called my instance one and it's
an instance of this class and then I'm
going to invoke the instance method by
using this dot dot operator in the
instance name and the result will be
basically this string over here as you
can see now finally we have another type
of method called the static method which
is declared using the add static method
decorator so a static method does not
know its class and is just attached to
the class for convenience it does not
depend on the state of the object and
could be from a separate function of a
module a static method can be invoked
via a class object or an instance object
so if you look at this example over here
I have defined a static method my
defined hello and it basically says
print hello world so it's going to
basically just print this so if you can
see here I created my instance and I'm
going to say dot hello it should
basically pre print print hello world
that's all in this video we will
continue the discussion on Op with
inheritance inheritance is used to
describe the relationship between two
classes wherein one class takes the
methods and properties from another
class in this relationship we have
something called the base class or the
parent class from which we will derive
all our sum of the properties and
methods and the class which actually
derives these properties and methods is
known as the derived class so you can
think of the derived class as a
specialized version of a base class to
explain what inheritance is in a basic
way I will show you an example where I'm
creating a cylinder class which is going
to be a subclass of the circle class
that you might have encountered in the
earlier video on op so what we're going
to do is create a cylinder class that is
a subclassive circle where we're going
to get the attributes radius and get
area from Circle class and we're going
to add the attributes height and get
volume to the cylinder so right off the
start you can see we have our class
Circle that you might have seen in the
earlier video so this class Circle has
the familiar initialization where we are
supposed to enter a value for a radius
that gets stored in self dot radius now
we also have a description string which
basically is a Dunder method that
returns a string when we invoke the
print command on a particular instance
and we have the get area method as well
now if we move on to this cylinder class
you can see that I'm defining this class
with the class keyword with the cylinder
name but you can see that I have added a
parenthesis and within it I have
mentioned the name of the superclass
that I want the cylinder class to be a
subclass of so this is how we actually
Define a subclass in the most basic way
you want two different attributes for
our cylinder instances now if you see
here there's a line which says super dot
in it now this is like um this is a
command which we use to invoke the
superclasses initializer so anytime we
create an instance for cylinder we also
want an initialization for the circle
method as well as a part of our cylinder
instance next you can see that much like
how we store itself I mean the radius
attribute in cell dot radius we're also
storing the height attribute in self dot
height now even this cylinder class has
an Str method to return a particular
stream if we use this print function and
finally we get on to a more a new method
that we have defined only for the
cylinder class called get volume now if
you see the get volume it returns as
basically the volume of the cylinder
that is being described in the
particular instance for which we enter
the height and the radius so if you can
see here what we've basically added
extra is an a height attribute and
another method called get volume and the
other parts of the circle super class
such as radius and get area are also
going to be a part of cylinder even
though you do not explicitly see them
anywhere here and we will see how in uh
in the form of an example that's coming
up so let me just execute these classes
now that that's done I'm going to create
an instance for cylinder I'm going to
store it in cy1 and I'm going to pass
1.1 for the radius and 2.2 for the
height and once that is done let's just
print to invoke the HDR method and as
you can see the Str method basically
tells us the information that it's a
cylinder with radius 1.1 and height 2.2
so now let's print what is the value we
get when we use the get area method now
it's important to note get area was not
explicitly defined in the cylinder
subclass but it's a method that is a
part of the circle superclass and we can
see that we can actually access methods
that are part of the superclass simply
by accessing any other method so if you
use the dot get area you can see that we
get a value for the area of the cylinder
so this basically this area is basically
the area of the circle face of the
cylinder uh the top or the Bottom now
let's use now let's invoke the subclass
specific method which is the get volume
method in a similar manner as you can
see just by doing invoking this method
we get the volume as well now if we want
to see what is the radius in the height
we can just do a simple print statement
followed by cy1 dot radius cy1 dot
height and it gives us both of these
values as you can see here now over here
what I'm going to do is create another
instance of cylinder but I'm not going
to pass anything for radius or high
right so basically it's going to take
the default values for radiation height
which was 1 and 1 respectively so once I
print
um this is this statement is basically
going to print the Str method or
whatever we stored in the Str which is
basically the description of the object
followed by what is its radius and
height this method will give us the area
and this method will give us the volume
so once I execute this as you can see
here this is what we get and this is
what we expect as well so now in this
example what I'm going to show you is uh
now I'm going to go back and I am going
to create another instance for circle
now this is the super class of course
and I'm gonna give it and since the
superclass has only one option uh one
attribute that we can enter which is for
the radius so I pass 3.3 and I'm gonna
print what what happens when I just
print uh this instance it's going to
basically give us whatever was a part of
the HDR method after that I'm going to
print is instance this is basically a
check on whether C1 is an instance of
this class Circle and X I'm going to
check if C1 is an instance of its
subclass cylinder now when I execute
this you can see that well this is what
we this is the Str method that gets
printed but if you see here you can see
that it says C1 is indeed a an instance
of circle when it says true over here
but when we look at the next line is C1
and instance of cylinder it says false
and this is obviously because
um a super class object is never an
instance of a subclass object well as
whereas vice versa it would be true now
in the next part of this video what
we're going to do is look at the
different types of inheritances in
Python so there are basically five types
of inheritance in Python there is the
single inheritance there's multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical hierarchical and Hybrid
inheritance so we will go one by one and
see each of these examples starting off
we have the single inheritance this is
simply where we have one Base Class and
one derived class from That Base Class
so this is a simple single inheritance
and in this example you can see I have a
class called country but I have a method
that I've defined called show country
which is basically going to say print
this is India it's basically going to
print this every time we invoke this
show country method then we have a class
called state which derives uh from the
super classical country where we have a
method called show state which is going
to say print this is state every time so
you can see I created an instance of the
class State and I'm through that
instance I can access the superclass and
the subclass methods over here next we
have the multi-level uh sorry multiple
inheritance and this is when a derived
class contains more than one Base Class
so let's look at an example to
understand this so if you can see here I
have a class called student with the two
methods defined called method one and
Method two in method one we can pass two
attributes Sno or I think is this this
is supposed to be like an ID I guess
like SN number and we have S name so
this is basically two attributes we can
pass that are probably descriptors for
each student and in the next method you
have basically two print statements
which Says student number and then they
will print the student number and it
will also print the student name next we
have a class called marks this is also
um so these these two classes are
basically what our super classes are
going to be and we're going to derive a
third class from these two so this
second class is a class called Marx and
we have two methods again one method is
called set marks which has
um the option of putting in two
attributes M1 and M2 both are
representative of the two marks and we
store them in self.mark1 self.mark2 the
second method is put marks which is
going to print the marks namely mark one
and then it's going to tell us how much
marks are there in the first subject for
example and another print statement
doing the same thing for the second
subject of Mark two finally we have a
third class called a result which
derives from two classes marks and
student as you can see here in my
parenthesis I've passed in marks and
student it both are super classes and
our class result is going to derive from
both of them this is an example of
multiple inheritance and within this
class result I have two methods specific
to this derived class called calc
wherein I'm going to basically calculate
the two the total marks of um uh the the
total marks which is basically the
addition of Mark 1 plus Mark II and I'm
then I'm going to have another method
called put total which is going to print
me what is the total so if you can see
here I have created an instance of this
derived class called result I am storing
it in R then I'm going to access method
one which is obviously a method from the
first superclass called student and I'm
going to store okay so this is name is I
guess lucky and he has 60 marks secondly
then I'm going to do our set marks which
is the method from the second Super
class which is going to set the marks uh
respectively so you have lucky student
and his ID is 60 and he has got 50 and
60 marks respectively in say the first
two subjects and finally I'm going to
access the derived class method called
calc so this is going to do the sum
finally I'm going to also do our method
2 which is I'm going to print our
student number and student name next
we're going to have put marks which is
going to tell us the um what are the
individual marks for Mark 1 and Mark 2
and then finally we're going to print
the total marks with the put total so
once I execute this you can see here it
says student number 60 student name
Lucky Max 1 is 50 as I had written here
Max 260 as I passed here and then total
is 110 which is basically 50 plus 60.
now the next type of inheritance is
called multi-level inheritance now
multi-level inheritance can be assumed
as where you take a super class let's
call it a and you derive a Class B from
net class A now what if we derived a
Class C from B and we kept doing this so
until say a Class E now each of these
steps is in its own an inheritance but
this whole relationship can be described
as a multi-level inheritance so let's
take an example again so after this this
time I've defined a class called student
where I have defined two methods called
set stud and put stud or you can call it
set student and put student in my first
method I have two options of adding two
attributes again this is the story
number this is the student name in my
second method I am going to print what
is the student number and what is the
student name finally uh so sorry next we
have another class called marks which
derives from the first class called
student this has two methods called set
marks where I'm going to again get the
option of adding two integers for M1 and
M2 which is going to represent Mark 1
and Mark 2 and finally I have put marks
the method which is going to print Mark
1 and Mark II
um finally I have another class called
result and this if you see this derives
from marks now if you see this
relationship you'll notice result
derives from marks whereas marks itself
derives from student and this is is an
example of multi-level hierarchy and
even as a part of this third class we
have its own methods called calc and put
total calc will calculate the total as
we had seen earlier and put total will
basically print that total and we're
going to do a very similar operation
we're going to create an instance of
this third class uh result and store it
in R then we're going to do basically
we're going to set the student details
uh his uh student number and his name
they're going to give him his marks 50
and 60. we're going to calculate what
are the total we're going to say okay
now put the details of what is the
student's number and name we're going to
also store enter I mean display his
marks Mark 1 and Mark 2 and finally
we're going to display the total marks
so let's execute this and if you see um
it's basically the similar operation
that we did earlier but the only
difference is in the earlier example I
was uh our third class result was
derived from Marx and student together
so this was an example of multiple
inheritance whereas in this example the
result class derives from marks and
marks itself derives from students so
this is an example of multi-level
inheritance finally we have sorry not
finally penultimately we have as our
fourth example of inheritance called
hierarchical inheritance apart in my Ms
presentation it's hierarchical
inheritance so in this case a base class
basically will contain more than one
derived class so let's see a look at an
example of what we mean here so I have a
class called one where I have defined a
method called display where what I'm
going to do is I'm going to source set.x
is equal to 1000 and sub dot Y is equal
to 2000 then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to print a statement saying this
is the method in class 1 and I'm going
to say after that I'm going to print
another statement saying value of x is a
self.x which is going to be 1000 uh then
I'm going to have another print
statement saying value of y is self dot
Y which is going to be 2000. finally uh
I mean next I have another class called
2 this this is going to derive from
class 1 as you can see here and in this
class too I have defined another method
called add and in this method add what
I'm going to do is I'm going to first
print a statement saying this is the
method in class 2 and then I'm going to
actually print the result of X Plus Y
which is 1000 plus 2000. finally I have
another class called 3 and this is also
deriving from one so if you notice we
have one parent class called one and
from this one uh parent class we're
going to derive two different subclasses
called 2 and 3. so this is an example of
hierarchical inheritance now in this
class 3 what I've done is I've defined a
multiplication method what I'm going to
do is print first of all I'm going to
print this when I invoke this method
that this is the method in class three
finally I'm going to say uh I'm going to
print the result of x times Y which is
1000 times 2000 so if you see I am going
to create an instance of 2 and I'm going
to create an instance of three and I'm
going to store them in T1 and T2 now
since uh T2 I mean T1 is an instance of
2 so I can access its methods add and I
can access this methods display so I'm
going to use t1.display and even into T2
I mean since it's a class uh it's an
instance of class 3 and this also
derives from class 1 I can also access
its method display but now I cannot
access add but I can access multiply so
if you see here I access add through T1
instance since add is a part of Class 2
whereas multiplies is a method in class
3 so I access it in its respective
instance which is D2 so if you see here
now once I execute this what you will
get is basically the results so first of
all it will basically display the method
from class 1 which is the display method
it will display the values of X and Y
and since I've done this twice from two
different instances it will basically
show a repetition over here finally I've
done the addition and since this is a
method in class 2 it is going to say as
much that is the method in class 2 and
then it's going to say X Plus Y is 3000
and now multiply is a method in the
third class so it's going to say this is
a method in class 3 and it's going to
tell me what is the multiplication
result finally we have what is called
Hybrid inheritance and this is a
combination of multiple plus multi-level
inheritance that you saw earlier so
let's again understand this through this
example so we have a class called
student where we have a method called
set student
um again two attributes we can pass here
for student number and student name next
we have a another method part of the
class student called put student so this
will print us the student number and
student name next we have a class called
marks and this marks inherits from
student so we have a method in class
marks called set marks where we can pass
two attributes for Mach 1 and Mark 2
respectively and as we have seen earlier
we also have a put marks which will
display the marks for Marks One and
marks two we have a class called
practical this practical is basically a
another Super class if you see here
since this does not derive from anything
it is super class on its own and what it
does is it it has two methods get
practical and you can pass an attribute
for P1 here and we store that in self.t1
and then we have an attribute for foot
practical which will print us the
Practical Mark whatever we passed for
this attribute in P1 finally if you see
we have a class called result now in
this result we have we are going to
derive from marks and practical but if
you notice here marks itself is a
subclass of student so this is an
example of multi-level inheritance
whereas since result derived from marks
and practical both it is also an example
of multiple inheritance so if you see
notice here this is an example of
multiple and multiple level inheritance
which is basically what we call Hybrid
inheritance and as we had seen earlier
this result class will have a calc
method to do a total of the marks in
this case Mach 1 plus Mark 2 plus the
Practical Mark P1 and we have a put
total method which is basically going to
print us the total so now we are going
to create an instance of this result and
through this instance of result we're
going to first invoke the parent class
method called set student which is the
the second level parent basically the
student the student class set student
method so we're going to set student
here we're going to say 60 is a student
ID and name is Ash then we have set
marks which is again the the second
level parent which is a student class
where we set the marks finally we access
this get practical now if you notice get
practical is part of um the Practical uh
super class so in this we store the
third subject of the the Practical marks
100 then we calculate the total and we
put uh first the student details then we
put the individual marks then we put the
Practical months and finally we enter
what is the total so let's execute this
and if you notice you will see here
student number is 60 student name and
all the basically whatever details we
wanted is shown over here in this video
we will continue our discussion on
object oriented programming with the
topic of polymorphism now the term
polymorphism in oop refers the ability
of an object to adapt the code to the
type of data it is processing
polymorphism is one of the key concepts
of python and it is also a built-in
feature of python an example to get us
started on polymorphism would be how we
use the plus operator we use the plus
operator not only for arithmetic
additions but we also use the plus
operator for stuff like string
concatenations or joining two lists
together this example where we are able
to use the plus operator for different
different operations is an example of
polymorphism to show you what I mean I
have basically done a simple addition
operation here where I'm adding two
variables number one and number two when
I do it on integers it basically adds
one plus two now when I use it on two
strings str1 and str2 which contains
Python and programming to separate uh
strings and when I use the plus operator
on these you can see what it does here
it forms one string containing both of
these individual strings so this is
basically the plus operator showing
polymorphism and is one of the simplest
occurrences and yet most common
occurrences of polymorphism in Python
another example of polymorphism would be
through the lens function the lens
function in Python is something that we
use a lot and over multiple data types
depending on the data type that we use
the length function for we get a
different value or a different sort of
information from the length function now
if you see here from this diagram when
we use the length function on a string
it gives us the length of the string
when we use the length function on a
list it gives us the number of items
whereas if we use the length function on
a dictionary it gives us the number of
keys so this is well another example of
how we have polymorphism in a function
now what we are going to do is look at
the different techniques through which
we can enable polymorphisms in our code
our first example that we are going to
look at is through method overloading
now method overloading in its
traditional sense where we can have a
method with the same name more than one
method with the same name in the same
class is not exactly possible in Python
so if we have multiple methods with the
same name in a class in Python which may
differ in in types and number of
arguments are not allowed and not
supported in by item in fact if we did
something like this where we created a
method with a different uh with
different say types and number and
arguments but having the same name in
the same class then what python will do
is it will only recognize the the last
defined method and it will not recognize
any of the earlier methods with the same
name but we can simulate polymorphism
through method over overloading by using
default arguments in a method now for
example what I'm going to show you here
is an example where I have a method
called sum Now by default it has three
attributes that you can pass through
this method a does not have a default
value B does not have a default value
but if you notice C has a default value
of zero so this is a simple example
where I'm going to show you that the sum
method is going to be used in two
different cases in one case we are going
to Simply add two digits I mean two
numbers and in another case we're going
to use the sum method to add three
different numbers so we have this class
overload demo within it a method sum and
I have three attributes A and B are uh I
have uh are supposed to be given by the
user since they don't have a since they
do not have any default values whereas C
has a default value of zero so if you
see here in my first case I have uh I
first of all created a an instance
called over uh an instance called OD for
the class overload demo and uh I have
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
store the value of the sum of 7 and 8 in
the variable sum now if you see here I
have not passed a third argument so what
this method is going to do is is going
to take the value of C as 0 by default
so it's basically going to do uh 7 plus
8 and it's going to give us the sum for
7 plus 8 and in the next instance I'm
going to give three ad arguments seven
eight and nine so now c will be replaced
by 9 instead of 0 and then I'm going to
get the sum of 7 8 and 9. so in this
this is a not a very used not a very
commonly used thing but it's basically a
method just to show you that we can
actually simulate method overloading in
Python by using default arguments so
I've basically shown you how the same
how the same method sum has been used to
do the addition of two digits and then
in in another instance is doing the
addition of three digits it might look
very similar but you'll basically notice
that by having this third attribute C I
have a default value of 0 I have induced
some form of polymorphism through method
overloading now the next way that we can
induce polymorphism is through
inheritance which is called method
overriding as well now method overriding
gives us the ability to change the way
or the change the implementation of a
method in a child class which is defined
already in one of its super classes now
if there is a method in a super class
the method having the same name and same
number of arguments in a child class uh
then the child class method is going to
override the method in the parent class
so what we do is when a method is called
with the parent class object the method
of the parent class will be executed
whereas if we call the method using the
child class object the method of the
chart class will be executed executed
and it will override the method in the
parent class so the appropriate
overridden method is called uh is called
based on the object type which is an
example of polymorphism so let's look at
an example to understand this so we have
a class called person and we have
defined what we're going to define the
initializer is two attributes which we
have to pass called name and age and
we're going to store them in cell plot
name and self.h now we have a user
defined method called display data where
we are going to print if this display
data has been called through the parent
called person
um if it's going to be called through
the parent class object then we're going
to print in parent class display method
and when we're going to print the name
and age that we have entered now we have
another class called employee which is
going to be a derived class 1 person so
it's going to
um so it's also going to have an in an
initializer and this Constructor will
basically um what what this initializer
will have is it will have an uh
Constructor for the super class where
we're going to do this uh the same
initialization that we do in the super
class but we're also going to store
another attribute called ID in self dot
employee ID and if you see here we also
have another method called display data
which is the same name method from
person but now if you see in display
data I have every I have all the same
almost the same information I'm going to
print the name I'm going to print the
age but if you see the first statement
I'm going to say if I'm going to call
this method from the employee object
then I'm going to say in child class
display data method instead of in parent
class display data method to say that
basically I'm invoking this method from
the child class object and I'm also
going to print on top of the whatever
I'm printing before I'm also going to
print the employee ID so if you see here
I have created an object called person
which is an object of the class person
with the information of name John and
age 40. and then I'm going to display
this now next I'm going to create an
object called amp which is the child
class employee object which is going to
now have the same information of John
for the name and age 40 but now is going
to have an employee ID and then I'm
going to store this uh in amp and I'm
going to display the data for this child
class object and we will see the
difference in how the display data is
differing from the earlier earlier case
so when I execute this you see the in
the first case it says in parent class
display data method so this display data
has been called through the parent class
object and I'm only going to show the
information of name and age whereas when
I invoke this method from the employee
class object it's going to say it's
going to specifically say that it's a in
child class display method and then I'm
going to say the name age and also the
employee ID over here so this is the
difference between how display data has
been used in its parent and its child
class and this is basically the example
of method overriding now our next
example of polymorphism is going to be
through operator overloading and
operator overloading is the ability to
overload the operator to provide extra
functionality in additional to its real
or core operation and operator
overloading is also an example of
polymorphism as the same operator can
perform different actions the earlier
example of where we use the plus
operator for different operations is an
example of operator overloading
polymorphism now when um when when this
operator overloading required well
anytime you want an operator to perform
a different function for you in your
custom objects you would basically do
operator overloading now an example of
this would be what I'm going to show you
below so if you see this class called
point it has an initializer where I'm
going to store two attributes X and Y in
sub.x and Y and instep.x InStep dot y
now I'm going to create one object
called P1 where I'm going to create
point one and two so you can think of
this object as basically like a
coordinate x coordinate one y coordinate
two this is one point and another Point
called uh x coordinate three x one and
four I'm gonna call that P2 now I want
to print P1 plus P2 all right now if I
try to execute this you will notice an
error it says unsupported operand types
for plus point and point this basically
means that plus does not know what to do
when it's given an object of this type
it has no idea what to do whereas what
we wanted to do is add the the the x
coordinate from this point and the x
coordinate from this point so we wanted
to do one plus three and we also wanted
to do this y coordinate plus this y
coordinate or 2 plus 4 and then we want
to print basically like something like 4
comma 6 or the addition of the two
points or the the vector addition of
these two points so this is what we want
this plus operator to do but the python
does not have any inbuilt feature for
the plus operator and we are going to
have to basically do some operator
overloading to create a polymorphism
this so let's see how we can do that so
to do that first of all we have to
understand that all operators in Python
have internally defined methods to
provide functionality for these
operators the operator or the special
method to provide functionality for the
plus operator in Python is the add
method and whenever the plus operator is
used we are basically internally
internally invoking the add method so
these these sort of internal methods
that provide functionality for The
Operators are part of a big a bigger
class of methods known as magic methods
and these magic methods are
automatically invoked whenever it's
corresponding operators are used so we
want to change the or the operation for
the plus operator in this example we are
going to have to use the the add method
in this case and since it's a magic
method magic methods are also are
basically what we saw earlier in the in
the form of Dunder methods so magic
methods are going to be invoked using a
double underscore a prefixed and suffix
to it so similarly to how we defined an
init of an init method or an HDR method
we are going to also invoke the add
method using the same double underscore
before and after its name so now let's
see how we're going to do this so if you
see this class I have now my class point
and I have the same initializer when I'm
going to store X and Y now I am going to
Define on uh these this add magic method
I am going to override the the normal
functionality of plus and I'm going to
give it a very specific function where
I'm going to say
um for two two different objects you're
going to add its uh the first part the
first part or its so called x coordinate
with the other x coordinate and it the y
coordinate with the other y coordinate
and you need to return return this to me
in the form of a similar object so now
when I pass 1 and 2 and 3 and 4 it
should return me 4 and 6 as you can see
here I have basically done what I wanted
to do by operator overloading I have
changed or I have overloaded this ad
this plus operator later using this add
magic method and I have created a new
functionality for this add function for
these two points one and two three and
four now I'm able to add one comma 2 3
comma 4 in the way I want it to so now
that you saw how we did our operator
overloading I'm just going to show you
um a list of similar magic methods for
different operators that we are familiar
with so the plus operator already we've
seen has the add method then we have the
minus operator with the sub method and
similarly we have for all of these
operations such as multiplication
division we have its respective magic
methods these magic methods are again
prefixed with two underscores and suffix
with two underscores and they are
basically they are also called uh Dundas
in Python so this is how we would do
operator overloading in Python for
whatever operator we want similarly we
can do this for like comparison
operators and for unary operators as
well so look at this example now where
I'm going to overload the multiplication
or the Asterix operator so I have again
defined a point uh I mean a class called
point I'm going to Define and
initializer but I'm going to store some
attribute X insert.x now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to overload the
multiplication operator where I'm going
to basically allow the uh this Asterix
operator to multiply two objects uh from
like for example 12 and 5. usually I can
just do a normal 12 times 5 but in this
case my object is slightly different my
12 is being passed through an object of
a class called point and five as well in
another uh instance of the same class
now when I want to multiply these class
instances like the the multiplication
operator does not perceive these class
instances to be integer so by default it
would not be able to multiply what we
want to multiply but when we Define
um or we overload the multiplication
operator within our class it's now able
to understand what to do um using the
attributes of these classes in its
respective class instances so it's able
to say Okay so I want this attribute
from this particular instance V1 12 and
I'm going to multiply it with the
attribute 5 from instance P2 whenever I
say P1 times P2 or P to P1 as 6 P2 so
when I executed it will give me 12 times
5. similarly I can also do this for the
greater than operator over here so I
have a class called person where I'm
going to Define an initializer where I'm
going to pass name and salary and store
them in sub.name server.s salary the GT
method is basically the greater than
method magic method and it's going to uh
we're going to use this to overload the
greater than operator and now again
using this greater than operator I am
able to basically say object 1 greater
than object 2 and I'm basically able to
check through this and if object 1 is
greater than object 2 it will basically
tell us if it is true or false or
basically whatever like we want to know
so this is the the print statement will
check for object1.name and it will say
earns more than objective.name if in
case object 1 is indeed greater than
object two so when I X execute this you
can see here my first information says
John has is earning 4500 some units
Natasha is earning 6000 of some units so
it will say uh John earns more than
Natasha well it's false because object
one is not greater than object two so uh
since 4500 is not actually greater than
6000 and this is the check that I'm
doing by overloading the GT operator
over here where I'm so when I'm
returning the Boolean value of uh what
is greater self or salary or other dot
salary self being the first object in
any comparison so in the if I'm
basically any comparison if I'm doing
say if I'm doing 5 greater than 5
greater than 6 so what the GT will do is
this will be the self object and this
will be the other object so this is what
I'm doing over here I'm checking self
dot salary with other dot salary in in
the form of these objects and it's
basically the same same way that we we
are able to do five plus five through
these class instance objects that you
saw earlier or 12 times 5 that you saw
earlier so this is all examples of
operator overloading in Python in this
video we will be taking a brief
introduction into what is a function so
a function in Python is a group of
related statements that performs a
specific task or tasks now functions
help break our program into smaller and
modular pieces of code and it's very
good and very convenient to use
functions to make our code organized and
manageable especially as our overall
program grows larger it also helps us to
avoid repetition and makes the code
reusable so let's look at the basic way
of defining a function so this is a
basic function that I am calling Fun
underscore name all right now the rest
of the function or whatever the task is
going to be performed by this function
will be my written over here within
indent of course as a standard when it
comes to python so I'm going to Define
this one something in triple uh double
quotes so don't worry about what this is
right now this is a doc string don't
worry about what this means and I
experative just in a short bit all right
now now the rest of the statement the
rest of it uh will obviously be what
this function will do let's include a
simple print statement all right it's uh
done here let's call this so of course
now once you've defined the statement
function to call the function you just
have to use its name like this this is
how you call a function so as you can
see when I call this function it should
print the statement hello now let's go
let's uh look at some of the uh like
what happened over here so we've used
the keyword def to define a function we
give it a unique name which makes it
which with which we uniquely identify
this function and also once we've done
this we
um we can give it we can give this
function a particular header uh it's
called a doc string so what this doc
string is basically something that we
include in triple quotes over here just
after the div the dev keyword and this
is like a brief we can use this to give
a brief uh and give brief information
into whatever function is doing so we
can say this is this function performs
addition this performs
um subtraction or whatever like some
basic thick information as to what our
function does so we can use a doc string
for that of course this is an optional
thing this does not have to be we don't
have to include this as well all right
but for the sake of this let's just keep
it here after that of course rest of the
function uh will contain whatever tasks
we want to do with it and that will be
indented
um finally we can also include a return
keyword and what the return keyword does
is at any point you find The Returned
keyword in a function you immediately
leave the function you go back to where
this function was called okay so now
let's see
um now there's also one more important
component of defining a function and
that's parameter now if you've noticed
over here within these parentheses I did
not include anything this is like an
empty parenthesis opening and closing
what if I said a if I included some A
and B over here so what this means is
whenever I call this function I need to
pass two parameters A and B these can be
like strings or numbers or whatever
um but now it becomes almost mandatory
that I pass these two things for my
function to uh to work so let's define a
function when I'm going to add a and b
so instead of this print statement let's
do this I create a variable C and in
that I'm storing a plus b all right and
then I return C so you can use a return
and you can you you can return certain
like variables along with the return
statement so I'm saying not only return
from this function but also given output
or return an output called C which is
the addition of A and B now how do we
use this well now instead of just
calling the function like this I'm going
to add para I'm going to include
parameters so I'm saying Pass 2 and 3 to
function name where 2 will take the
place of a and 3 will take the place of
B all right what will happen now is
addition will take place and we will get
return the result so let's see what
happens now as you can see two plus
three and I already got the return the
addition of two plus three and it
returned me five so yeah this was like a
basic uh usage of a function and
parameters so of course we can if you
want to know like what a what the dock
string of a particular function does or
says you can use this particular you can
use this like statement so let's say for
so uh it's very important to like just
keep a note in your uh while you're
going through this while you're learning
that uh whenever we use some sort of a
function which has double underscore
right this is like a built-in a built-in
command provided by python
um within the python Library itself so
these are like built-in commands to
check certain details so I want to check
what is a dog string and this is how I
do it so let's do print let's print what
is the doc string over here this is a
doc string so this is basically what I
wrote over here I can change this to
this like this does Edition for example
all right now this will say this does
addition when I execute this line so
this is the way to check what is a doc
string anyways so now that you have seen
a basic basic function two basic
functions that I defined for you and how
we use them what a parameter is let's
look at another concept that we call
scope and lifetime of variables so scope
of variable is the portion of the
program where the variable is recognized
all right now a parameter and a variable
that are defined inside a function are
not visible from outside the function
this is a very key thing so if we Define
something within the function we can
only use it within this function and we
cannot like we cannot use it once the
function has already been executed so as
to speak
um these variables and these parameters
uh have what we call as local scope
since they are only
um recognized within a particular
function now the lifetime of a variable
is the period throughout which the
variable exists in the memory itself and
it's very important to note that
lifetime of variables that are defined
inside a function are as long as the
function executes once we return from a
function uh whatever we have defined
within it are destroyed so when we use a
function it will not remember the values
of a variable from a a previous
iteration of a function call so let's uh
try to understand this example or this
concept using certain examples so out
here I have defined a function where I
am going to create a variable my
underscore VAR my variable and I am
going to store the value 10 in this and
then I'm going to print so whenever I
call this function I will always create
this variable I will store 10 and I will
print the value of this all right now
what I'm going to do is I'm not only
going to create this my VAR inside this
function I'm also going to create a
variable outside so you see there now
you might be confused as to okay how is
the behavior going to be because outside
the function I have created my wire with
a value 20 but inside the phone function
I will always Define my virus 10 okay
now I'm going to print so my first what
I'm going to first do is I'm going to
execute this function that I created
initially where I store the value of 10
in my bar and then I'm going to pray and
print the value of my wire that was
present outside the function let's see
what happens you can see two different
things happening so when I execute this
function it prints the value inside the
function as 10 but when I print the next
line which says
um okay now get the value of my bar it
actually prints a value of 20 and this
is a very key concept because What's
Happening Here is when I initially call
my function within this function it
creates a variable called my wire and it
prints the value as 10 and the moment my
function has been executed it destroys
this variable and the variable which
contain the value 10 is of course now
destroyed and all we have is the my wire
that contains 20 from the outside and
when we print that we get the suspective
value as 20. so you can also think of it
like this the my wire that is present
inside write this function is different
to the myvar that we create outside so
the scope of the my wire within this
function is local only to this function
and once the function is executed that
variable is destroyed all right now
let's look at a another case or the
other side of this case where um say
we're dealing with variables that have a
global scope how do we deal with them so
let's create a variable called my where
all right and I say I stored 100 in this
all right now if I Define a function
I've stored my where let's say I Define
a function define underscore say again
same name where what I'm going to do in
this is I am going to print the value of
whatever is there in my where Okay so
let's do print
um value of variable is value stored in
variable is okay it's uh my where so
let's see what happens when we do this
let's call this function
see what happens here so as you can see
the value I stored a value of 100 in Y
where and I've called it inside the
function and this is because since I've
defined it outside I can use it inside
as well now what if I try to change the
value of this variable inside the
function though so let's see if I did
this and now if I try to print let's see
do is this Allowed no it's not allowed
in fact I get an error it says local
variable my wire reference before
assignment
um and without going too much into
detail what it's saying is that the
variable inside over here is still local
to this function and I have not defined
this my where as a global variable so I
cannot make changes to it within this
function right now and uh to change that
I can use the global keyword what if I
did Global over here so if I did Global
and now if I said okay Global myware and
I declare this variable as a global
variable now if I do this now if I do
the same incrementation now let's see
what happens when I'm trying to do this
you see I get the value 101. this is
exactly what I wanted and that is
because I've defined my variable to be a
global variable within this function so
I can in fact make changes to it within
this function so this is how we use the
global keyword and Global variable uh
also just to make a quick note there are
three types of functions uh the three
types of categories in which we can
divide functions first one being
built-in functions these are the ones
that are built into the standard library
of python the other is user defined
functions that is the ones which we
Define ourselves and the third type is
called Anonymous functions they're also
known as Lambda functions and this is
something that we're going to cover in a
separate video now let's talk about the
arguments that we pass in Python so
there are four types of arguments that
python user defined functions can take
first one being default the other one is
required then there is keyword and then
there is variable number of arguments so
the default argument is when say
um if I Define the function where
underscore sorry fun underscore name and
I'm saying a comma B right but what if
the user has not like save I I want a
default value of a and b each time when
I use this function so in the case where
if say I don't pass a value for A and B
like this will always be used so I can
just say a is equal to 2 by default and
V is equal to 3 by default and then
within this function I will say C is
equal to a plus b and then return C so I
do this and if I say fun underscore name
and in case I don't pass any arguments
here let's see what happens by default I
get the answer 5 because by default a is
2 and B is 3 but this is not fixed and I
can always change this by passing my own
values here 5 and 6 and in this case I
should get 11 as you can see here now
the next type is required arguments and
when we are defining a required argument
we just simply do not use the equal to
sign for the parameters over here and
this basically it makes it so that now
anytime we call this function we have to
pass something over here so now if I try
to pass like this I won't get a oops
Yeah I won't get a default value then
that's because
um that's because well there is no
default value and it needs an AM B so I
have to pass it at 3 and say 4. now it
should give me 7 as you can see the next
type of argument that we'll be talking
about are the variable number of
arguments so let's look at an example
here so what I'm doing in this
particular example is I'm defining a
function called my sum where I'm passing
some parameter called my integers and
I'm doing something out here and what
this does is
um it will take the values of a
particular like collection of objects
and that's called my integers and each
value I'm going to keep adding it to
each other and I'm going to result a
particular sum I'm just going to resolve
the sum of whatever is there so in this
case what happens is I'm creating a list
one two and three which contains one two
and three and then I'm going to print
the summation of whatever is there so it
should give me 6. now the problem in
this case is that each time when I'm
going to perform this function I have to
create a separate list where I'm going
to store these objects but what if I
didn't know I do not know like what
exactly I'm going to pass here what if I
don't know if it's going to be a list of
objects or like what is it going to be
exactly well in that case I can use a
variable variable key variable number of
arguments so it's it's like a variable
keyword argument so what we use here is
um a specific way of passing um keywords
and we do it like this so I say Define
my under underscore name and I use an
Asterix now I give it any name this can
be args this can be integers it doesn't
really matter what this is but it's just
this is the key the asterisks here and
this tells us that whatever we pass here
is now if we're supposed to create an
iterable out of this and then we can
perform whatever tasks we want so let's
just uh since I've already created one
here let's see how I'm going to use it
in this case so as you can see I'm doing
uh I'm creating a particular variable
argument function over here and I'm
doing the same task I'm just going to
keep performing at uh I'm going to add
whatever I pass over here but now when
I'm calling this function I don't need
to create a separate list as I did over
here I'm just passing all the numbers
that I want to in the form of layer it's
pretty much like a tuple so I'm just
passing these numbers here and what this
function is going to do is it's going to
create an iterable out of this and then
we're going to iterate over it as you
can see that's happening over here and I
can keep uh I don't need I I can just
keep like uh so since I've done it for
one two three and seven the summation
should be 13 in this case I can add
another number here just explicitly just
like this and you can see the value will
change and that's because this is a
variable uh this is a variable argument
uh method of creating a function now the
fourth type of function arguments is the
variable keyword uh argument so let's
look at what is the keyword argument now
so I have defined a function here called
the concatenate function and let's see
what I'm going to do with this so in
this I have passed a keyword argument
I've said that okay this is going to be
a keyword argument function and what I'm
going to do in this is I'm going to
create a blank string and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to add or I'm going
to concatenate certain strings that I'm
going to pass to this function so I in
this example I have passed Python and is
and Google and an exclamation mark all
separate strings and what I'm going to
do in this function is I'm going to join
them together
um and I'm going to create one whole
string out of it let's see what's the
result python is cool so this is so of
course like uh if I had to add some
something else like python is a cool and
say I just wanted to say hello and say
one more string I can add I can add it
just like this I don't have to like
Define a fixed number of arguments I can
pass any number of arguments I want and
this works exactly the same as variable
in the only differences instead of
positional arguments we're using keyword
arguments over here hello by like this
it doesn't really make sense but it's to
show you as you can see so this is how
we use keyword arguments in this video
we will be learning about X exceptions
exceptions are errors that are raised
during the execution of a program when
an error occurs python generates this
exception that can be handled which
avoids our program from caching python
has many built-in exceptions uh however
we can create many uh user-defined
errors or exceptions as well to catch
whatever errors we're looking for in our
program so when an error occurs python
interpreter raises an exception and
stops the current process and it passes
it to a calling process until the
exception is handled and if this is not
handled the program will crash some of
the built-in exceptions are like I O
errors in the case when a file cannot be
opened or import error python cannot
find the particular module being
imported and there are so many similar
uh so many exceptions that are built in
Python for the appropriate cases now
before we move on and see how we raise
these exceptions let's look at the
difference between an exception and a
syntax error so for that I will be using
an example where I will be dividing
something by the number zero of course
this is not possible so let's see how
python handles this particular problem
well it raises something that it raises
what we call a zero division error and
this is an exception that is built in in
Python whenever we try to divide
something by zero now let's look at the
difference between this exception and a
syntax error so this is the same
statement except I'm going to add this
extra bracket which does not make sense
syntactically in this now if I try to
execute this as you can see we get a
different type of error known as the
syntax error when it says unmatched
closing bracket so this is what a syntax
error looks like like an extra bracket
or a comma that basically makes the line
unreadable to The Interpreter in the
first place so the The Interpreter
doesn't even get to the point where it
needs to figure out uh that there's
something being divided by zero it
doesn't even get to that point because
it finds this extra bracket and it
cannot execute this line at all so that
is like the difference between an uh an
exception and a syntax error all right
now for our first case of how we raise
or how we handle exceptions let's look
at the keyword arrays so for this
example what I will be doing is I'm
going to take this variable X all right
and I'm going to store a value 10 and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
check for a condition if x is greater
than 5 then I'm going to raise this
exception using the raise keyword like
this and in case this condition is met
if x is actually greater than 5 I want
this particular message to play out in
my uh exception so let's see what
happens when I execute this as you can
see the exception is raised because X is
indeed greater than 5 its value is 10
and the mirror message says so that X
should not exceed 5 the value of x was
10. so this is an example of how we can
raise an exception and as you can see
when a condition was met the program
comes to a halt and an exception was
raised now let's look at another type of
handling exception where we use the
assert statement so when we use base
command we waited until an error
occurred and our program crashed Midway
right what if we want to check if a
condition is met and if this condition
is met then then the program can
continue but if the condition turns out
to be false then we want a particular
error namely the assertion error
exception to be thrown to us so we can
use the assert command in such a case so
in our example we will be checking
whether the system that we are working
on is actually Linux or Windows 32. so
let's see first of all let's import a
library called sys this is the it's a
library which where we can access system
information one of the modules and that
is one of the functions and that is the
platform it basically tells us what
system are we working on so we're
working on a win32 system okay so um
let's now let's use the assert keyword
all right now we're going to check if
Linux is what we are working on and in
case it is not then we want an error
message and this will be the error the
error will obviously be an assertion
error because we are using the assert
keyword so this is how we use the assert
statement and if we execute this as you
can see we get the assertion error
because systart platform contains win32
and not Linux and so we got this
assertion error so if we change this to
check for Windows system we won't have
any error when we execute this as you
can see so this is uh the example where
we use the assert statement another way
of handling exceptions is by using the
try and accept block so this is probably
one of the most common ways of handling
exceptions in Python where we use a try
keyword and an accept keyword now within
the try keyword as you can see here we
have a chunk of code which we're going
to check and if everything is fine in
the try keyword then this is perfect so
we don't need to move on to what we call
the accept part of the try and accept
block but if say there was an error in
the try block then we move on to the
accept block where we're going to run
the part of the code in the case we find
an error in the trial block so first we
check the channel the part of the code
that is under the try block and if if
there is an error we move on to the
accept block and we run that part of the
code over there and where we and in the
accept block where we that is where we
handle our whatever error that might get
thrown our way in the try block okay
let's look at an example at how to use
this technique so I have a basic
function out here all right it's uh
defining a function called Linux
interaction what this is uh basically
doing is that when I call this function
I want to do an assert check I'm going
to check if Linux is the system I'm
working on and if it is not then I want
this error to be thrown okay and so yeah
let's see what happens in the case and
if if the search statement is actually
passed then we will move on to this
statement so you could look at it like
this if when I mean when I call this
function it will first check for this
assert statement in case something wrong
happens and we get an assert error then
we do not move on to this line so we
only get this printed but if this assert
statement passes then we move on to this
line and we get print doing something
okay so let's see I'm going to call this
function out here let's see what happens
here as you can see I get an assertion
error because obviously this is a window
system and not a Linux system and I get
this message okay now let's see what
happens when we use it in a try and
accept block all right so now I have a
try block over here in which I am going
to try the same this function Linux
underscore interaction if in case I find
an error I immediately jump from the try
block into the accept block now you see
the slight difference in how we handle
this like what happens so as you can see
when we use the function explicitly we
directly went to what we called an
assertion error but when we use a try
and accept block we will not use the
assertion error because we are leaving
the try block immediately and we're
going to go into the accept block where
the only thing we're doing is printing
the statement as you can see we are not
on Linux found some error okay now what
if we wanted to catch the error within
this function itself which was the
assertion error and we can do that
explicitly like this so now what I'm
doing is I'm going to try all right and
it's going to catch an error in this
slide so now in the accept block I'm
going to say the assertion error that we
found in this function in the try block
we're going to use that in our accept
block so as you can see we're going to
print that assertion error it will
basically print the statement function
can only run on Linux systems as you can
see here function can only run on Linux
systems function can only run on Linux
systems and the next part of the thing
was the Linux interaction function was
not execute it okay so this is a a very
this is like this is a key there's a key
something very important happening here
when we use this assert statement the
whole program is actually getting
executed right but when we're using the
try and accept block we are immediately
jumping on like the moment we catch an
error we are immediately jumping onto
the accept statement and uh however and
all the handling of the exception is
done in the accept block and not in the
try block anymore so where to uh think
of it like this that the try block is
only check if a particular piece of code
is like does it have any errors or not
and in case it does then every like all
the handling that we do is uh in the
accept block of this particular
statement now let's look at another
example in this example I'm going to try
opening a particular file now this file
does not exist so I will be I will get a
file not found error and this is a
built-in exception and I'm going to
catch that and I'm going to print that
error over here in the accept block all
right so as you can see file not found
and whatever like error I have I printed
over here all right so this is another
like this is a file not found error that
we are going to that we we got in our
try block and we're handling it in the
accept block now let's use let's combine
both of the examples where we use this
Linux interaction and we also try to
open a particular file and we try to do
both things in the try block and since
both of these contain errors let's see
what happens when we try to what happens
when we have like multiple errors in a
travel book so as you can see in my
cryblock I'm not only doing this Linux
interaction I'm also trying to open a
particular file that does not exist
obviously so now you might think will I
get two exceptions well let's see what
happens when we try to uh execute this
so uh it's important to note that in our
accept we have one except for uh
catching a file not found error and we
also have an except for finding um uh
the assertion error that that is part of
this Linux interaction function so so
since both of these are errorness
statements or they will throw exceptions
so now the question is will we get both
of these except blocks or we get both of
these exceptions where we get only one
of them where we get the first one so
let's see what happens so as you can see
my error statement is is very much like
the assertion error that I had that we
had done as part of this Linux
underscore interaction function function
can only run a Linux system the Linux
function will not execute it so as you
can see that that is the one that has
been God and for some reason the file
not found error has not been caught and
this is because this is a very important
feature of the try block the moment we
find the first error in our try block we
immediately leave and we do not execute
any of the further statements and we
jump into the exceptions and we handle
it using the accept blocks so the moment
an error is found in this function we do
not execute this part of the statement
and we directly jumped into the
respective exception that was the
assertion error exception so this is a
key takeaway so some of the some of the
other key takeaways when it comes to
exceptions is a try Clause is executed
up until the point where the first
exception is encountered and in the
accept clause or the exception Handler
we determine how the program responds to
this exception we can have multiple
exceptions and we can differentiate how
the program responds to each of these
and it's also very important to not use
accept clause on its own it's very
important not to use a bare accept
Clause now finally before we conclude
this is a topic of exceptions let's look
at the else and the finally Clause so
the else Clause is used when we want to
execute a particular piece of code in
the case where we have no exceptions or
no errors found so let's look at this
just like we had the Linux interaction
function I'm going to define a win under
underscore interaction and this is going
to check whether our system is Windows
or not in case it is not then we get
this error message all right and in case
it is a Windows it is a Windows system
we print this in the case of when we
call this function so let's again use
our try and accept statement only in
this case we will be using an extra else
Clause so we first try this function in
case there's an error we catch it as an
assertion error and we print that error
but if there is no exception then we
move on to the else statement and we
print this so as you can see our we have
actually moved on to the else statement
and we print this line executing the
else clause and that is because we have
found no exceptions over here so again
it's Keto remember that the else Clause
is used whenever you want to execute a
particular statement in the case where
we do not find any exceptions in the try
block the finally Clause is used when we
want to execute something regardless of
whether we have an error or an exception
or not so no matter if an exception
happens I mean is raised or if it's not
raised we want this finally block to
always get executed and let's look at
how it's let's look at an example of it
being used so I have this block where
I'm doing a lot of things the first
thing that I'm doing is I'm going to
check for this Linux interaction
function which is going to check of
course whether it's a linear system or
not this is I'm doing the try block now
if I catch an error that I want to be I
want to handle it by simply printing the
error over here and in the event that
there is no error then I will move on to
the else statement and I will try this
particular block of my statement which
is again that when I'm trying to read a
particular file that does not exist and
it's very uh it is very important a that
you note that within the else block I
have another try and accept block and
this is perfectly legal and it's
perfectly valid in our program we can do
this so think of it like this I'm first
trying this if I have an error then I do
this and I don't execute this but if I
don't have an error then I execute this
whole statement which contains its own
try and accept block all right but
regardless of whether I get an error
here or not I will always execute this
portion of my statement or under the
finally Clause so let's execute this as
you can see of course the error is
raised in this try try block so we move
on to the exception and that is what is
printed over here and after the
exception is done we move on to the
finally we of course skip this else
block because the exception was actually
raised so after that is done we move on
to the finally block where we print this
particular statement well that was it
for an introduction into exceptions in
Python I hope you learned something from
this and um of course this is just the
beginning exceptions are something that
that you will be that you would probably
encounter a lot especially when you're
beginning and it's something that you
will learn to extensively work with and
that will also help you improve in your
programming in this video we will be
covering the topic of iterators now an
iterator in Python is an object that
contains a countable number of values or
it's a larger object it contains a
countable number of sub-objects an
iterator is an object that can be
iterated upon and what that means is we
can Traverse from each value and we can
manipulate or perform certain functions
or operations and tasks using each of
the sub objects or values within this
larger collection called iterator now
um when we're looking at it technically
an iterator is an object which
implements the iterator protocol in
Python which consists of the methods
iter and the method next so to begin
with let's look at a simple iterator
we're going to see the example of a list
where we're going to Traverse through
the objects of a list using the for Loop
so we have objects one two three four
and I'm going to print each of these
values one by one as you can see here
similarly we can also do the same thing
for another iterable known as the string
where we can go character by character
again using the for loop as you can see
here another example of an iterable in
Python is the dictionary so let's say I
have a dictionary where I have two
values two key value pairs uh key X
which contains a value one and key Y
which corresponds to value 2. now when
I'm going to do a for Loop through this
by default I will be traversing through
the keys X and Y as you can see over
here and of course the other types of
weight troubles in Python are like sets
and tuples as well all right now let's
look at um what this iterating protocol
is in Python so first of all we take an
iterable it's an object that contains uh
it's a collection of objects it contains
sub objects and when we use the eater
function it creates an iterator out of
it so we can one by one we can Traverse
through
um each of the objects and we can
manipulate each of the objects that is
contained in this and anytime we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when we have finally
completed all of the or we've
manipulated or Traverse through each of
the sub objects we encounter the stop
iteration exception which tells us okay
there are no more objects to be
manipulated or uh iterated upon so an ex
as an example I will create a list where
I will store the values some simple
values in teachers one two three four
one three four five okay I'm going to
create an iterator out of this where I
will use iter function and I'm going to
say this is let's say this is called my
my editor okay and I'm going to use iter
function as I had mentioned and I'm
going to pass my list in this
now if you see what is my editor it
should say it should be a list iterated
at a particular memory location now
let's use the next function to keep
going through whatever is there in this
so of course the first object should be
one as you can see now when I look at
the next it should be three then I
should get four and now I should get
five as I use the next uh successively
now since I've reached the last of my
objects in this collection now the next
time I use this next function I should
get a stop stop iteration exception that
is raised as you can see here so this is
the basic iteration protocol in Python
now you might have uh already gone
through the for Loop video and in that I
have spoken in quite a bit of detail as
to how a for Loop performs this um this
iterator protocol and how it creates an
iterative iterable object out of say a
list or a tuple and how we how it
internally performs the next function
and it um breaks out of the for Loop
once it encounters the stop iteration
exception so
um for Loops are like they're very very
similar to your standard iterator and
they use pretty much the same protocol
for its functioning now let's do a basic
comparison of what is a a basic
comparison between a generator and an
iterator in Python so in generator we
use a function we use like we Define it
using the def keyword and we Define it
under one function to create a generator
whereas in the case of iterators we use
two separate functions the iter function
and the next function the generator
makes use of the yield keyword whereas
the python iterator does not in
generators we save the states of the
local variables each time we use the
yield keyword and we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables all
we need is any triple like a list to
iterate upon we may use any number of
yield statements in generators and we do
not use yield statements in editors
generators are not memory efficient
whereas iterators are very memory
efficient so this is like basic
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic of modules in Python
now a module in Python to put it simply
is basically a python file that has
functions and classes written into it
and is saved with the dot py extension
to specify that it is indeed a python
file a Python program can use one or
more modules and modules can have one or
more functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files for several modules
now my modular programming is the
process of breaking a large a large
event or task into smaller and more
manageable subtasks and we call these
subtasks basically modules now
individual modules can be grouped
together like building blocks to create
a larger application there are several
advantages to modulizing code in a large
application and we will be going through
them right now so first of all there is
Simplicity because instead of focusing
on a big big problem a big task we can
break down the problem into smaller
smaller portions or modules now
maintainability of code is much better
through module because they are designed
to create these sort of boundaries or
clear demarcations between different
problem domains there is usability
reusability in the sense that once we
create a module we can use it in
different parts of the code or even
different different applications itself
there is also scoping and what this
means is modules typically Define a
separate namespace and this helps us
avoid collisions between identifiers in
different areas of a program functions
modules and packages are basically all
constructs in Python that promote code
modulus modularization you might have
already come across a coordinate intro
into functions in this video we will be
going through modules and another video
we will also cover the topic of packages
to import a module we use the import
keyword and in this example what I'm
going to show you is a simple function
or a simple operation of importing the
OS module this is short for operating
system and as the name suggests we can
perform a system tasks through the
functions and methods that are part of
this OS module so simply executing the
statement will import this module onto
our program for us to use now if we
wanted to see all the functions that are
present in a module what we have to do
is use the dir function so if we print
the dir OS function it will print us
basically a directory of all the
functions that are present in the OS
module as you can see here that like all
of these are basically names to
different functions that are part of the
OS module finally moving on another
function commonly used with modules is
the getcwd function and what this does
is it will give us the current working
uh directory that we are working upon
right now so if I execute this it will
tell me what is the directory that I am
currently working upon right now as you
can see seed notebook dir stem if you
wanted to see all the files in a
particular directory what we can do is
use the list dir function followed by
giving a path by default if we do not
enter a path inside the parenthesis it
will basically give us all the files in
the current working directory which in
our case is temp so if I were to execute
this it gives basically gives me a list
of all the files that are presently uh
there in the directory that I am
currently working upon now a basic step
is um creating a python module the
simplest way to create a python module
is basically creating a python script
with whatever functions and tasks that
we want and methods that we want inside
uh whatever module and saving it with a
DOT py extension
um so in in my example what I'm going to
do is I have already created a script in
notepad and I've stored it with a DOT py
extension that contains these four
functions add subtract product and
Division I have basically copied I
basically use this code and I've stored
it in a.py script and I'm going to be
using this as my uh as as a test module
for this particular example now how do
we import a module now once that I have
created a script in my example it will
be called my character UI and we've
stated stored it in our directory to
import the module all we have to do is
use the import statement so if I had to
import my calc all I have to do is say
import my underscore calc and now my
calc has been imported
um so we can use the import statement or
if we want to import something
particular from my calculator we can do
from my calc import uh now we can
whatever like for example if we wanted
the ad uh the add function we can
basically just say only add or if we
wanted add and subtract we can say add
and subtract for example so this is
basically by using from we can say that
we want something from something but
only parts of it we don't want
everything we can also use from my calc
import and we can say asterisks to
basically say uh import everything that
exists in my calc right now so this is
another way of importing something from
a module now to access contents in a
module we have to use the dot operator
and I will show you how right now so
what I'm going to do is in my example
I'm going to import my calc as calc so
now what this since this is the original
folder or the original module but I'm
going to give it a shorthand name so
that I can easily use it in my code and
I don't have to type out my underscore
calc every time so now I'm going to
import this as calc so anytime I have to
refer to a particular method or function
inside the script or this module I will
just use this uh this placeholder this
variable name so now I have two
variables A and B and I'm storing 20 and
30 in them so my first func what I'm
going to do is basically four operations
I'm going to print the addition of A and
B then the subtraction multiplication
and the division of these two numbers
and each time to do this operation I am
going to use the add function that is
present in the my calc module so to do
that I have already imported my
characters calc all I'm going to do now
is invoke these functions using the dot
operator that we're already familiar
with so I'm going to say carrot.add and
then I'm going to pass these two
arguments or these two variables to say
that I want to add these two and
similarly I'm going to do it for
subtraction um uh multiplication and
division as you can see these are the
results of my tasks now if I had to do a
directory uh operation on the module
calc it will basically give me a bunch
of inbuilt uh or Dunder methods that are
already a part of any uh python script
by default such as built-ins so if I
execute this just to show you what
happens when I use the dir function it
will basically give me all the functions
that are part of this python script so
these double underscores that you see
are basically uh denoting magic methods
or Dunder methods and these are like
inbuilt methods as a part of the script
and if you see here add division prod
and sub these are the methods that we
have defined earlier on in our script
ourselves now to go slightly deeper or
more detail into what happens when we do
a module search
um let's let's actually look at what
happens so what happens is when for
example we execute the statement import
my calc as calc as we did over here so
the first the steps that actually take
place are the interpreter executes the
above statement and it searches for this
python script in a list of directories
assembled from these following sources
that you see here so it takes the
directory from which the input script
was run or the current directory if The
Interpreter is being run interactively
which is the case right now secondly it
will list all the directories contained
in the python path environment that you
set up uh that you can set up or you can
change later on as well and this format
for python path is OS dependent of
course but it should mimic the path
environment variable that we see in
Windows systems and then the other
source or the other directories is
basically an installation dependent list
of categories configured at the time
python is installed now the resulting
search paths that is accessible in the
python variable system.path
um this is basically obtained from a
module named sys so if I import it this
is and I did sys dot path now these are
all the directories that we are going to
look for when we want to search for any
particular module so if I am doing uh
import my calc or import OS it's not
only going to look at the current
directory that I am working on it's also
going to look at all of these
directories that have been set up as you
could say directories or paths in the
system.path in this video we will be
covering the topic of packages now what
if we developed a very large application
in Python that contains many different
modules and we have so many different
modules that have similar names and
functionalities and they're all kept in
like or dumped in the same location that
it becomes very difficult to track these
modules what if there was a way to
organize and access these in a much
simpler and more organized manner well
packages allow us to do just that
packages are a hierarchical structuring
of the module namespace using dot
notation and this is the same dot
notation that we use when we want to
access methods or functions that are
part of other classes or modules so
let's try to uh let's look at certain
examples to understand what we mean so I
have a directory called PKG this can be
basically treated as what we call a
package now in our package we have two
modules mod1.py and mod 2 Dot V by and
what we're going to store in mod 1 and
mod 2.py are the follows so I'm going to
define a function called Foo and I'm
going to print this particular statement
mod1 and then I'm gonna basically say
Foo and then I'm going to say in class
Foo I'm gonna have an empty pass command
similarly I'm going to define a function
called bar in mod 2 dot py where I'm
going to print this statement so
basically mod1.py has a simple function
where I'm going to print this statement
and mod 2.py has a simple function then
I'm going to print this statement
um and I'm going to store them in mod 1
and mod 2. Ty respectively and these two
modules I'm going to store in the
directory tkg in my local folder now
I've already done this so we can already
get to working with this now if I wanted
to access these particular modules from
the PKG folder I can simply use the
import command and use the dot notation
so I can say PKG dot mod1 so this will
invert in this will import the mod 1
module from PKG folder similarly I can
do the same thing for the mod 2 module
from the PKG folder in the same line so
now that it's been imported just simply
execute this and this Imports whatever
you needed now if we wanted to perform a
function that was a part of
mod1.py we can just extend the dot
notation and use the function as over
here as you can see it performs this
print command whatever it was supposed
to do similarly I can invoke the
function that was part of the mod 2
module by extending the dot notation to
it in the same way now another way that
I can invoke I can import a package is
by directly importing the package Itself
by using import pkz and not accessing
any of the specific modules within it
now let's see what happens when we do
this so just for this example what I'm
going to do is I'm going to restart the
kernel so that the PKG modules that were
already imported get cleaned away so we
see what happens when we execute this on
its own now if you see I haven't
imported this now let's see if I can
access my mod 1 and mod 2. now if you
see here it's throwing me an error and
this is because using simply using the
import command on a particular package
only Imports
um you could say the package name space
but it does not actually import any of
the modules and files that were part of
this package so if I wanted mod 1 from
this package I would have to actually
say import pkz dot mod1 directly and I
cannot simply say import PKG and python
will not import everything that is part
of a package on its own I have to
specify it myself specifically now I'm
going to create and I'm going to I mean
I'm going to show you another type of
importing from a package using the star
operator so I have this package PKG once
again now I'm going to store
um three I mean four different modules
within this package
mod11.py mod 222.py and I've already
done this you don't need to bother about
seeing me doing it right now because
I've already created these files and
what I'm have done is within mod11.py I
have defined I've passed I've written
this statement and I've stored in the
python script similarly I've created
another Python scripts script called
mod22.py and I have basically written
this in the code and I've similarly done
this for mod 333.py and I've done
another for mod 4.py now once I have
done this I've stored these Python
scripts into my uh into my package or
PKG package so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create I'm going to
execute this command if you see this
from pkg.mod 333 import start so once I
execute this now I'm going to say print
directory and print directory basically
will tell me all the functions that
exist in my current directory if you see
here there's this bias function that was
a part of mod 333 module now if I change
this and if I imported mod11 and if I
did the same thing you will see Foo has
now been added as a part of this
direction directory and these are all
functions that are part of these
different modules where I am importing
from and that is what the star function
does what the star function will do is
it will basically tell python okay so
the statement is saying from pkz dot
mod11 so it's saying that okay look into
this directory or this uh package and
find this module and in this module
import everything that exists inside it
up until this point so this is another
another way of basically importing uh
files or functions from a particular
package and a particular specific module
within that package so yeah this was a
very brief video on packages in Python
uh the conclusion being that packages
are basically a an organized way of
storing many different modules that we
might have created in a very large
application and these modules can be
accessed using the familiar.net notation
that we have used in other examples such
as methods when we were working with
classes and objects in this video we
will be taking an introduction into the
concept of generators so python provides
a generator which is like a function
where we can create our own iterator in
a generator function we use the yield
statement instead of the return
statement that we use for standard
functions so let's look at a simple
Generator First of all so out here I
have defined a generator called my
generator where I'm doing uh like the
three uh like three
functions or three tasks that I'm doing
uh first one is when I'm printing the
first item and I'm yielding a value 10
then I'm printing second item yielding
20 then I'm printing last item using 30.
so let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator is the
function it uses the yield keyword every
time we use the next keyword we will
keep getting what is next in this
function so let's store the generator in
my gen
so now we have stored the iterator in
this function variable called gen or gen
now let's see when we do next
and we use gen
what happens so the first task is
performed or the first iteration is
performed where we get this the first
year command is done all right let's see
what happens when we do next again
next gen
now
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20. let's do it for the next so
let's do it once more since there is one
more task team uh there's one more
iterable inside
you can see this now a very question is
what will happen if we do next gen again
since there is nothing after this
well let's see what happens
we should get an error as you can see
stop iteration error this is another uh
built-in exception
um that happens when we have like
reached the last object of an iterable
so we get a stop iteration error
so now a key difference between a
generator and a function is that when we
execute a function the moment we hit the
return statement in a function or any
execute a function like whatever
variables are stored inside are lost and
they are destroyed unless they were
defined as Global and the function is
completely done executing and we leave
the function completely whereas when it
comes to a generator when we hit the
yield function we don't actually
completely leave this function so the
first time the yield is found we get 10
but the generator remembers its position
inside this function so the next time we
use the next we actually move on to the
next iterable and then we move on to the
next hit Triple so you can think of a
generator as it sort of has memory if
that makes sense it's a way to like
create iterables in python or create
iterators in Python so to understand a
what the difference between the yield
command and the return commanders let's
take the same function all right
and let's put it return over here
after this particular the second yield
okay let's do the same thing we say gen
is equal to my generator
and
let's start uh yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing what's there
so the first year will be standard first
item 10 the next one is again it's going
to say second item and then 20 but now
if you notice there was a return I put
over here
so technically when I did the second
next it's not only yielded 20 but it's
also executed this return function or
this return statement so let's see what
happens if I do next again
as you see I have gotten the stop
iteration seemingly earlier than I did
before and that's because I have used
the return function and while in return
statement and what that's done is that
um if we've completely left this
function so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
these top iteration and that's uh the
difference between yield and return
now in the next example I'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of the for Loop or for a for
Loop so let's take this whatever over
here and I have defined a function
called get sequence up to X and what
this will do is basically it will keep
printing the printing numbers up until
uh whatever we have entered in place of
X over here so if I said say sequence is
equal to Let's uh
copy this all right and say I want um I
want sequentially I want every number up
until 10 well not including 10 of course
because python starts with 0 right
so let's do this and um
now let's see so the first number will
yield 0
and now if I
did this again
it should give me one
two and I can keep going
until I will stop at the value 9. as you
can see here
so 8 9
now I should get the stop iteration
error because that we have reached the
end of our iteration so this is a way of
using generator functions for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator is
um in the case of Fibonacci numbers so
let's use it let's see how we can
generate a Fibonacci series using
generator so I've defined a Fibonacci
function called Fibonacci where I'm
passing Max so max is basically the max
value that I want
um yeah like up until where I want the
sequence right so this is basically the
code which will uh give return me the
subsequent values of my Fibonacci
Sequence so let's pass this to fib
and see I want all the Fibonacci numbers
until 10.
so once I will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with zero then when
we
do this again we get one then we do 0
plus 1 it should be one next number
should be one plus one which is 2 then
we should have two plus one three and
then three plus two five and three plus
five should be eight now eight plus five
is thirteen and since 13 is greater than
what we pass for our max value here now
when we try this we should get the stop
iteration error as you can see
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of list comprehension
Now list comprehension is it's a neat
way of creating a new list based on
values that are already there in an
existing list so you can think of it
like creating a new list using a much
shorter and cleaner syntax compared to
what you might traditionally be thinking
so let's go through some examples and
through those examples we will see how
list comprehension makes creating these
new this much simpler and much easier
for us
so in our first example we will be
creating a new list which will contain
fruits that contain the letter a in
their name so we already have a list of
fruits over here as you can see it has
Apple it has banana Cherry kiwi and
mango now we want to create a new list
which has only the fruits that have the
letter A inside them so Apple would be
one of them banana would be one of them
and mango will be one of them so
traditionally
if you look at this piece of code
this would do what we want to do but
this contains a few extra lines but yeah
it does it does do what we want to do
now what if there was a way of doing the
same thing by just writing one simple
line of code and that exists as you can
see here
so I take the same
list now this is where you need to
follow so now my new list is equal to so
I'm creating a list over here as you can
see now within this list you have this
line this is what we call a list
comprehension so as you can see it says
each fruit for each fruit in fruits if
now it's checking for the letter or the
character a inside each fruit and what
this each fruit is that we're checking
each object in this list one by one so
first in the first iteration each fruit
will contain the string Apple then in
the next iteration it will contain
banana and in each each iteration we're
going to check if it contains the
character a and if it does then we store
that each fruit in the new list
as you can see here so if I execute this
line you see my my result is the same I
have my whatever I wanted and this was a
much cleaner way of writing or creating
this new list let's look at some other
examples though
so my next example what I'm going to do
is I am going to iterate through a
string so I have a string it can be
anything in this case I am using a
string called human
all right so I have a string called
human right now I want to store each
character of this string into a list
that we call H underscore letters so if
I use the for Loop this is how we would
do it if I execute this as you can see
the list contains H and then u m a and
then n now what if I wanted to do the
same thing but uh by using list
comprehension so what I would do is
let's create a list over here H
underscore letters
and
um so as we know let's com so list
comprehension will uh it's it's a it's
you just basically need one line in this
case it'll just be like this
now this is my string
now let's see when I check what's in h
letters
let's see what is the output so as you
can see I have the output as uh what I
needed so this is a much cleaner way
let's go through some more examples now
now we can do more list comprehensions
um we can even use so we've already seen
uh one case where we checked for the
character a we've seen a case where we
uh went through where we we did a sort
of a loop through a string we can also
use this comprehensions in conditionals
so let's uh look at an example where we
use the uh this comprehension with an if
statement
so what if I wanted to store say the
first
10 even numbers so this is this is an
example that I'll be using so in my list
I want to store the first 10 even
numbers so this would be a way to do it
so I have in range 20 so what this is
going to do is X is going to take the
value of 1 2 3 4 and so on until 98 that
actually take it from 0 1 2 3 4 until
19. so when we do range 20 we're
creating an iterate in iterable where uh
we're going to look through our iterate
through the value of 0 to 19. so if I if
I do this and this what this statement
does is basically uh it checks if it's
divisible by two
so if this is equal to equal to 0 that
means we have an even number and if this
condition is met if this condition is
met that means we store the X into our
number list so let's see what happens
when we execute this
should contain uh 0 2 4 6 until 18. so
this is the first 10 even numbers as you
can see so this is a an eight way of
using IF statement we can also use an if
else statement
so what if I I'm checking um each okay
so I'm going to create another list and
in this list I'm going to basically see
if um
each of my num numbers either even or
odd the first let's say 10 natural
numbers
so let's write this statement down
so I want it to be even
in case
the I that I'm checking I being every
number between so like say the first 10
natural numbers as I said
let's check if um if it is divisible by
because if it is divided by 2 of course
it's going to be even right else
we say that it is odd
and then we checked for I in say the
first let's say the first 20.
okay
so now when we do this and we check who
you check what's in the list so as you
can see the list contains like even or
even orders basically saying the number
uh zero is even then the number one is
odd then number two is even and so on
and so forth so this is a an example
where we used the list comprehension
with if else statements so another neat
thing that we can do with the list
comprehensions is that we can use it
along with functions so let's look at
this function in this example we have a
function called double X where we Define
this double X this double function to
take an input to take an argument X and
what we return is the square of the
argument so let's use this in uh in our
left list comprehension so what we do
over here is that we are we're checking
what we're doing is for every X bit in
range 10. so we're taking the value of 0
1 2 3 until 9 and we're passing it to
this function double X and we're going
to get the square of them and we're
going to store that in a in a list as
you can see here let's call this list X
so just call this list uh let's call it
y so now let's see what's in y and we
check it should be 0 1 4 9 and so on so
wait this let's check again does this
Square now this is actually two times so
let's make it square
as you can see
so you can see zero one four nine uh for
the first uh 10 numbers 10 natural
numbers now what I've shown you is
obviously list comprehension
um but we can also do set and dictionary
comprehensions in fact set
comprehensions work exactly the same way
as list comprehensions the only
difference is the set comprehensions
will make sure that there are no
duplicates inside the set so you can't
have like duplicate items which you can
in the case of list comprehensions so
let's uh let's like let's take a look at
an example so here this example what
we're doing is we're going to check so
we have this string that we're storing
in the variable text and the string is
something like live finds a way so
whatever this is now what we're going to
do is we're going to
iterate through this string character by
character and we're going to check if uh
there are we're going to check for
vowels essentially so uh we're going to
see if the character a e i o or U is
present in the string and if it is we
will pass it into our set now if you if
you look you will find there are
multiple I's right and there are
multiple A's as well so if we did this
through a list comprehension each time
that we fire found find a vowel it would
be added to our list but since this is a
set and sets do not allow duplicates so
you will only have one copy or one
particular object for each of the
verbals so uh of course now uh set
comprehension is defined using curly
braces so let's keep that in mind so now
if I check what's in this I will see a e
i and U even though there are multiple
A's or multiple E's or I's and U's since
this is a set we don't have duplicate
copies of any copies of any of these uh
so this was just a small example for
showing you set comprehensions similarly
we can do the same thing uh this this
comprehension uh for dictionaries and if
we call the discrete dictionary
comprehensions the only thing the that
we have to worry about when it comes to
dictionary comprehensions is that we
have to define a key when it comes to
this so let's let's look at an example
in this what we're doing is again
dictionary comprehensions are also
defined using curly braces just like
sets except in this case we will Define
a key and that separates it from a set
comprehension so in this case what we're
doing is that I'm checking I'm going
through the a list of numbers from 0 to
9 right so what the range 10 function
does and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a key which is going to
be like 0 1 2 3 and the value of each
key would be its Square as you can see
here I'm doing I times I or just to
make a little more clearer as you can
see I'm doing I Square over here for
every value from 0 to 9 so what I should
get is like a dictionary where the first
key is 0 and the value of that key
should be 0 as well because 0 square is
zero then for one it will be one and
then for two four and then 3 9 4 16. so
let's see what happens as you can see
here this is the the result that I
wanted
so just to summarize let's go through
some key points uh to remember when it
comes to list comprehensions
um so it's obviously An Elegant way uh
to Define and create lists based on uh
existing lists uh it's more Compact and
faster than normal functions and Loops
but we should also keep in mind that we
shouldn't write like very complicated uh
list comprehensions because the idea of
a list comprehension is to be user
friendly and also it's important to note
that every list comprehension can be
written in the form of a loop but uh
every Loop cannot be written in the form
of a list comprehension and that is a
probably a very key point to remember in
this video we will be learning about the
concept of regular Expressions now a
regular expression is simply a sequence
of characters that defines a search
pattern for example if you see this
example here you can see a symbol called
the carrot followed by P and then five
periods then an n and a dollar sign and
what this this regex pattern does is
it's searching for a seven letter string
that starts with B ends with n and has
five characters in between
let's look at this example now this is a
regex pattern that is looking for a five
character string that starts with a ends
with s and has three characters in
between now if we had to match this with
this string with these strings as an uh
as uh i o test strings the first one
would not match because it's a three
letter string and we're looking for a
five character string the second one
would match because it's a five
character string that ends with an s
starts with an A and has three
characters in between this will not
match because whatever pattern would do
is it would find the first s and it
would find that the string itself starts
with an A and it would say okay there
are only two characters between this
first s and this a and you would assume
that this is actually just a four
character string to actually Identify
two consecutive s's we would have to do
something special and what we would have
to do is what we will see later on so
again this is the same example since
this is case insensitive capital a uh is
perfectly fine when we're searching for
this and it will also match this is
um this is obviously two words and it's
not a five character string so this will
not be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in Python can be
imported using this statement import Rd
now once we've done this we can actually
use the our regular expression tools and
methods to do a pattern recognition
character recognitions and to identify
different sequence of characters in our
strings let's try to understand uh a bit
more in depth about regular Expressions
now so what you're seeing here is one
variable called pattern which stores
something that looks like a regex
and another variable that stores our
test string called a Biz now what we're
going to do is we're going to use the
match method of this module re and we're
going to check whether this pattern or
whatever we are trying to search using
this reg X is in fact does it match with
our test string and what we're trying to
look for is if you see here very similar
to what I just showed you a 5 character
string that starts with a and ends with
s
so if you see our test string it induced
is a match and when we use this uh this
command we should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that search is successful if I execute
this and this is what it does
now if I change the test string to this
now you will see that now this is no
longer what we're looking for a five
character string with a and starting
with a and ending with s and you will
see that the search will be unsuccessful
as you can see here now let's try to
understand what exactly do we mean by uh
when we use these different cert these
special symbols like for example this
carrot or this dollar symbol
um these are by the way known as meta
characters and now we're going to look
into all the uh or most of the different
meta characters that are used in Rec X
so put to put it simply meta characters
are simply characters that are
interpreted in a special way by the
regex search engine now here's the list
of meta characters
let's go through them one by one
now the square brackets square bracket
simply specifies the set of characters
that we wish to match so we want to
match some combination of a b and c it
can be one a two a is Three B's four C's
we are not looking at a specific pattern
we just want to know if a b and c exists
in any form in our string so if we used
it on a the string a simply we would
find one match because the letter a is
found here AC would match twice because
we have a and C present here in this
string Hey Jude we will have no matches
because a b and c none of them are found
here and in this weird string we will
have actually one two three
four and five matches so we would have
five matches for this uh this bigger
string because we have five instances of
a b or c
now let's use re dot match to do to
actually search for this and to uh see
if we have our particular whatever
patterns that we're looking for now in
this input string this is just some
example string
um I'm going to test this I'm going to
match whether my pattern that um a any
of a b and c is it actually found in
this so let's see what happens when I
use Rd dot match for this
so the the format uh the syntax is
simply the regex pattern and then comma
whatever test string that we have
so
let's see what object gets created when
we try to do this as you can see it's
none even though you might be wondering
like I can see an a over here I can see
a c over here re dot match actually
gives us the result none
now
if I try to do it on this test string
which is slightly different instead of
the film Titanic was at least in 1998
what I'm saying here is all film Titanic
was released in 1998. now let's see if
the r match works or not
as you can see it actually does give a
turn when I execute this it returns as
an object called re.match object with a
span 0 1. the span 0 1 is basically
telling us that we have found a match
between the zeroth and the first
character which is basically this
character a which is what it has found
and it's saying that the match is indeed
the character a uh from amongst these
options
so what this is basically telling us and
what this means actually is that the re
dot match method will only find matches
if they occur at the start of the string
being searched once there is a space in
in our bigger string it will not search
for whatever comes after it so
what happened in the first instance was
it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word in my
largest string and since it found no
match it basically gave us the result
none which was not the case in the
second example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter A
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be using is
the re.search as you can see here the ID
dot search method will actually check
the whole string and it will return us
the first instance where it finds a
match now let's see this is a test
string now and we're searching again for
AR we're searching for a b and c any any
of these in our test string but we're
going to use re.search and not match so
now if you see it returns us when I
execute this it returns us a match
object again but this time it's saying
the span of 9 and 10. now the spine
panel 9 and 10 actually exists over here
this is the ninth character and a itself
is the 10th character over here so what
this basically is telling us that the
10th character is where we found a match
which was the letter A which was the
first instance of either A or B or C in
this whole string and this is basically
how re.search works it will not only
search the beginning of the string but
it will search the whole string and
return us the first instance of where
whatever we find now what if we wanted
to find out all the instances wherever a
b and c were found and not just the
first instance well in that case we
would be using the method find all over
here so when we use find all it will
actually return us each and every case
where it found a b or c and you might
not it won't tell you the exact position
but it will tell you like
um so if I execute this you can see it
gives us a a list with AAC a and a and
what this basically means is it was
looking for the characters A or B or C
and it found a first and hence this for
the first item in the list then it found
a c and then it found two is
successfully so this is exact this is
actually how find all works where it
will actually find all the instances of
our regex pattern now that you've seen
how the square brackets work and how the
re dot search and re dot uh match and re
dot find all methods work now we're
going to go through all the other meta
characters that we saw above so the
period now now period matches any single
character except the new line new line
is basically slash n or a break now if
you look at this picture what it's going
to do is
um a this expression basically saying
that uh do we have
um two characters like sets of two
characters in our string so this is a
single character string and obviously a
single character string is not a double
character string and this expression
this double dot is basically asking us
do we have two characters present in our
string so if I had to match it with this
a it will obviously be a no match
because a is one character if we checked
it with AC it is a match because A and C
are two characters a c and d will also
give us only one match because it will
find AC and then it will leave d as a
single character but when we check AC d
and e or this string in particular it
will find two matches because it will
consider a and C as one of the matches
and d and e as one of the matches So
Below is basically what we are doing
basically the same thing we're just
using Rd dot search for each of these
different examples so if I if you see
when I use find all on acde and when I'm
searching for a two character match you
will see that it will return me a c and
d e as you can see here and similarly
for something like this it will return
me again uh whatever like two character
patterns it finds successively
so the next symbol the next meta
character is the carrot symbol that
you've seen earlier then the correct
symbol is basically used to check if a
string starts with a certain character
so if you look at these two this picture
if you have two two expressions that
we're going to check over here one is
the uh one is checking if a is the
beginning of a string and the other one
will check if a uh
is the beginning of the string but is it
followed by b or not
so when we check this what you can see
is the first string will be a match
because it's the only the character a
and it will match here as well because
this string starts with a but it will
not match here because this string
starts with B now if I look at this
particular expression you can see that
um this is going to search for if the
string starts with a and is followed by
a b so it will match in this case
because a does start with a and is
followed by a b but it will not match in
this case even though it starts with an
A because it's not followed by a b so
out here is basically us using the re
dot so it's to basically find these
patterns
the next symbol that we will come across
is the dollar symbol so the dollar
symbol that you can see here is used to
check if a string ends with a certain
character and we've already seen how
this is used in one of the uh one of the
earlier examples so this is going to
check basically if so this expression
will check if the string ends with a so
this uh this string is basically the
character a so it will match this also
ends with a so it will match and this
particular string does not end with a so
it will not match and we are going to do
that using the re dot search over here
so as you can see it finds a match in
the first character itself here in this
case it finds a match in the last
character but in cab there is no match
so it returns I say none another example
is of the meta characters is star so
this is the symbol for star and this
what the star basically is used is for
checking if there are zero or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it so now if you see here what this
will check for is
um is there any form of M and A
that occurs before n and it's very
important to note that the N has to
follow the a in this case so let's look
at these examples and what will happen
so if I checked it with M and N this is
actually a match because n is followed
by zero occurrences of M and A which is
if it might seem a little weird but it
is technically the truth because uh the
the star symbol checks for not doesn't
check for the Existence it just checks
for with n occurs it must occur after an
A or the a should not be there itself in
this particular string so as you can see
here the N occurs after an m and it's
fine because there is no a now you will
see when it will not work so M A and N
is obviously fine m a uh M Triple A N is
also fine because n follows an A and
there's an M here
this however main will not match now why
even though we have m in a and we have
an N you see the N is immediately
followed by an i is n follows an I
immediately or the N is preceded by an I
immediately and this is a no match
because our the strict condition in the
search is that n must uh proceed then a
if the a exists
again in women it will match because n
follows an a over here we're just going
to use the re dot search for these
examples that we saw over here in terms
of code using the Rd dot search as you
can see here finally we have the next
meta character which is the plus symbol
yes so the plus symbol matches one or
more occurrences of the pattern left to
it now this is very similar to what we
saw earlier in terms of the star except
now in the plus the key difference is
we're looking for one or more
occurrences instead of zero or more
occurrences that we were looking for in
the case of star
so when we say one or more occurrences
now we need what is there to the left of
the plus sign a zero uh no occurrence of
it will not be allowed or will not cause
a match so let's see now what we're
going to do here we're going to use the
same expression except we're going to
replace the star with the plus sign so
now what we're going to say is okay we
need M and A at least one occurrence
followed by an N the all of these
conditions have to be met so again if
you took the first example M and N this
time it will be a no match because there
is no occurrence of an a over here for
preceding the N so it's a no match M A
and N is a match because well this is
per this is perfectly fine M Triple A
and N is also perfectly fine but if you
look at m a i and N much like earlier
the N is uh preceded by an i and not an
A so there is no match and again woman
is perfectly fine and we basically
execute the same thing through the
search function in this piece of code
the next meta character is the question
mark the question mark symbol matches 0
or 1 occurrences other pattern to the
left of it so let's see what this does
so now we saw the star the star which
was zero or more occurrences of the
pattern to the left of it we saw the
plus which is one or more occurrences of
the pattern to the left of it now we
will see the question mark which is 0 or
1 only 0 or only one and not zero or
more of one or more which was the
previous cases only zero and one or one
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it again we're going to see the same
expression except we're going to replace
the meta character with the question
mark So now let's see what what happens
when we match so if you see here M and N
is a match because there is zero
occurrence of a and one occurrence of M
preceding n so this is fine
this is also fine because there is one
occurrence of A and M and then it's
followed by an n this will not be fine
because now we have three occurrences of
a
which is followed by an N we're only
looking for 0 or 1. this again main will
be a no match for the same reasons that
we have already gone through and women
will be a match again for the same
reasons
and we do the same things using the
search function in this piece of code
the next meta character is the braces
character now the braces character is
interesting because what we're going to
do is we're going to see if there are so
uh this is the typical Syntax for
abrasives is an uh brace followed by
some integer n comma integer M and then
close braces so what this means is we're
looking for at least n and at most M
repetitions of the pattern left of the
braces let's see through an example if
you see this expression we're looking
for at least two and at most three
occurrences of this the character a in
our test strings so let's see what
happens in the first case we have no
matches in this case because this part
of the string contains only one a and
even this part of the string only
contains one a we're looking for at
least two and Atmos three this part will
contain one match the second the second
example because the second part of the
string actually contains two is for one
two
and in the third example you can see
both the strings actually contain
matches so we get two matches because as
you can see here there's two A's here
followed by Three A's here
now when we look at this particular
string let's look at what happens now so
what we're going to find is that this
thing is perfectly fine so we have two
occurrences of a but now we have four
occurrences of a but what the search
engine is going to recognize is these
first three A's and it's going to see
okay so there are three occurrences of a
and I already have a match it's not
going to consider this fourth a in the
search it will just look at the first
three and say okay there are uh Three
A's and my my match is fine so again
there are two matches in this case again
if you're going to use the search
function initially and you can see each
in each of the cases there is a match
except for the first case which is this
case now let's see the find all option
and see what happens when we do the same
thing using find all
so when we use find all it basically
gives us each of the instances where the
match has occurred in each of these
lists
now let's try to use a slightly more
complicated example where we combine
different let's say different meta
characters and we create a a more
sophisticated expression that we want to
search in our test strings so if you
look at this expression what we're
looking for is 0-9 now a dash symbol is
valid in Python using regex because what
this basically tells it is that it's
looking for either 0 1 2 3 4 so on until
nine basically any of the digits you're
looking for any of the digits from 0 to
9 and we are going to check if at least
two and at most four occurrences of
digits if they are there or not in our
particular code so let's see what are
the matches that happens when we use it
on test strings so if you use it on this
string you can see it will find one
match this basically this particular
part of the string where it says one two
three so this is uh three occurrences of
Digit so it's fine now when we look at
this whole string 12 and whatever this
is you will see this will not find a
match here this obviously will not
because these are characters but if you
look at over this part it will find
matches in the in terms of the first
four and then seven and three the next
two one and two again there are no
matches because there's only single
occurrences of digits we're looking for
at least two and at most four so if I
use a find all
you will see like what all it will
return so for the first test string what
is going to return me is it's going to
return me one two and three as you can
see here but now if you look at this
test string it's going to return me 12
it's going to return Me 3 4 5 and 6 is
going to return Me 3 4 1 and 2 but not
seven because we are looking for at
least two and then it's going to return
me four five six and seven followed by
eight and eight as you can see in this
list over here now if we use curly
braces with only one digit it's
basically telling the search engine that
we want exactly so many repetitions of
the preceding uh whatever expression
that we have so when we do this example
for uh for example we are basically
saying that we want X
followed by a dash and the dash has to
occur at least three times in our
particular expression and then it should
be followed by an X again which will not
match in this case because there are
only two dashes and it will match in
this case because there are exactly
three dashes and it will again not not
match in this case because there are
four dashes
as you can see here none followed by an
object match followed by none
next we move on to the alternation
um the alternation meta character and as
the word suggests alternation is
basically looking for some alternate
form of A and B so a should be followed
by a b and uh basically this pattern has
to keep going on so in the first string
over here this pattern will not match in
the second string over here we will have
a match because we at least find an a
even though there is no B but this is
still considered a mass because we did
find an a at least over here we'll have
three matches because we have a followed
by a b followed by an a again so if we
did a regular expression for this we
would basically find these many matches
for each of these examples
the next meta character is the group now
a parenthesis is basically used to group
sub patterns so let's look at an example
to understand what we mean now if you
look at this complicated expression what
this means is that I want some form of x
and z the x and z have to occur together
but before that what I want is some form
of a following B following C some sort
of alternation between a b and c so this
part as you can see here is kept in a
parenthesis because I want this whole
condition to basically occur before I
find an x and z so let's look at what
happens here in the first case we don't
have a match because uh there this
basically this parenthesis condition is
not being met we x and z is preceded by
a space or basically the A and B is
preceded is followed by a space so there
is the space didn't occur we would
actually find a match as you can see in
the next example here you can see A and
B occur basically this uh initial
condition is met followed by x and z so
that is be a one match so it's fine for
us now if you look at this uh slightly
more a trickier one what you can see is
we have two matches in this case first
in a followed by x and z and then we
have C A and B now this is perfectly
fine because we we are looking for a b
followed by an x and z we are looking
for either of these things we're looking
for some form of alternation of these
things followed by an x and z and we can
get that over here we get B followed by
an x and z so you'll get two matches in
this case now let's go through the
concept of grouping constructs now that
we've seen many meta characters you've
seen how parenthesis Works let's look at
grouping constructs so grouping
constructs break up a regex in Python
into sub expressions or groups and this
serves two purposes one is the grouping
part which basically says that a group
represents a single syntactic entity and
any additional meta characters apply to
the entire group as a unit and then
there is a capturing part which
basically tells us that some grouping
constructs also capture the portion of
the search string that matches the sub
expression in the group you can retrieve
captured matches later through several
different mechanisms so let's look at
basically what we mean by this example
over here so if you see this this
expression has a plus sign so we're
looking for uh as you know a plus looks
for one or more occurrence so this will
basically check for one or more
occurrence of the the character are only
because there's no parenthesis as in
this example so this plus is next to an
r and it's going to check for basically
whether one or more occurrence of R
happens uh preceding b and a but if we
actually put B A and R in a parenthesis
followed by plus it will actually check
for the entire string bar and it will
check one or more occurrences of bar
together so if you look at these two
examples when we use this uh on these
examples you can see that these are fine
like these matches are fine but if I
used this parenthesis then these would
be the acceptable matches and like b a
triple R would not be a match if I use
parenthesis as you can see here
so this is how grouping constructs work
and how parent thesis work so let's look
at some other examples so what this will
do is Foo has to be optionally followed
by bar and bar must exist together and
um this is because we have a question
mark here this question mark symbol
tells us that it should be zero or one
occurrences
similarly this particular completed
expression is checking for one or more
occurrences or whatever we saw earlier
basically this whole thing is followed
by a plus so we're looking for this
whole sequence for one or more
occurrences of it c o w is simply just c
o w we're looking for this pattern and
this is going to check for 0 or 1
occurrence of cow because of the
existence of the question mark for uh
preceded by the parenthesis
in this video we're going to continue
our discussion on regular Expressions
now that you know the basics of regular
Expressions let's continue our
discussion with special sequences now in
an earlier video on strings you might
have encountered what is an escape
sequence and how we use the backslash
character to generate these Escape
sequences and in escape sequence is
basically if you remember
something that we use to either
gives a certain special meaning to
characters that are otherwise ordinary
or it is used to remove the special
meaning that are inherently present in
certain characters that we call Meta
characters so let's look at what special
sequences are in relation to regular
expressions
so the first one we're going to look at
is the backslash capital A which is used
to match if specified characters are at
the present are present at the start of
a string so out here if you can see we
are checking if the word d is present in
these two strings so we would get a
match in the first case over here
because this starts with the word the
but in the second case we won't get a
match and this is how we're going to
check it for the same thing using the
find all function
so if you see in the first case it gives
us it returns us an object because we do
find D in the beginning of the string in
the second case we get us empties list
because this string does not start with
the word t
now the next one that we'll look at is
backslash B small B now this is used to
match if specified characters at the
beginning or at the end of a word so
when you use backslash small B and then
you follow it up with whatever you're
looking for it will look for the that
particular those particular characters
or that pattern if it exists in the
beginning of a word in a string so if
you look at the first example it starts
with f double O and in the second
example you see this portion of the
string or this word is actually also
starting with f double O so it will also
match however in this string which is
very similar to the second one we don't
have a space between a and F and it's
basically one word so this does not
start with f double O but it actually
starts with afo and it won't match as
you can see here now similarly if we
wanted to check if something exists in
the back of a string at the end of a
string we type what we want to search
for first and then we follow it with a
backslash small B and then if you see
here it will match in this first case it
will match in the second case because
this part of the string ends with f
double O but it will not match in this
case because well we remove the space so
now this whole thing becomes a uh the
string that we're looking for and it
does not end with FW anymore this is
basically us just checking it through
the find all function now the next SK
the next special sequence that we will
be looking at is the slash capital B
which is basically the opposite of what
we just saw this matches only if the
specified characters are not at the
beginning or the end of a word so if you
see here this is checking if F double O
is not at the beginning of these strings
so in this case there'll be a no match
in this case also it will be a no match
and this third case there will be a
match similarly if we wanted to see if
something does not end with a particular
string we would type type that whatever
pattern we're looking for followed by a
backslash capital B and then we can use
the find all function to generate as
lists wherever we find such objects find
such matches in our particular test
strings like we have done over here so
the next one that we're going to look at
is the backslash small D and this
matches any decimal digit which is
equivalent to doing a square brackets
0-9
as you've seen you must have seen
earlier so if we did a square bracket
0-9 and we did a search or refined all
or a match it would look for any of the
digits between 0 and 9. so a similar
thing can be done using a special
sequence backslash small D so as you can
see there will be three matches in this
case because one two and three digits
exist whereas in this case for the word
python there will be no matches so these
are certain examples where we are doing
the same thing using the backslash d
now we have another one which is the
backslash capital D and this just
basically the opposite it matches for
any non-decimal digits it's also
equivalent to typing a carrot inside uh
square brackets with 0-9 which if you
remember from the previous video is
basically asking us to check for
anything that is not the digit 0 to 9.
so this is basically we're going to
check these two strings if there is no
digits and no non-decimal digits so if
you see here we will we will find three
matches a b and the uh double double
inverted commas and in the second string
we will find no matches because this is
fully just digits next we have backslash
small s now this matches where a string
contains any white space character so
this is equal to doing a check for all
of these so this is like backslash small
T is uh check for tab space backslash
small N is a check for break line and
then backslash R backslash F backslash V
uh are their own uh checks for uh
different sorts of white space
characters that you can see by just
looking it up honestly but yeah so if
you simply do a backslash s it would
actually be the equivalent of searching
for any of these uh whites Place White
space characters that we generate
so if you see here when we do a
backslash s on this string you can see
that there is one space over here so it
will match it will give us one match
because there is one white space which
is just the normal space here and in the
second example there is no match because
there is no white space here
similarly slash capital S now as you
might have noticed is basically checking
for a string which does not matches in a
string wherever there is no white space
characters so it's basically the same as
doing carrot slash T slash n slash r
slash F slash V in a square brackets so
this is basically a simpler way of doing
uh the same thing using square brackets
and a carrot symbol so if you see this
expression backslash capital S now we're
looking at uh a space b so over here if
you see it will match for all the
non-spaces so it's going to match for a
and b so we're going to get two matches
here whereas an empty string does not
contain well it does not contain any
non-white space character since an empty
string is basically a white space
character on its own so this would be
this will give us a no match so the next
special sequence that we're going to
look at is the backslash small W uh this
matches any alphanumeric character which
is the equivalent of doing a to z in
small and then capital A to Z and 0 to 9
follow and also an underscore check in
square back packets it's important to
note that the underscore is considered
an alpha memory character hence why we
included over here but yeah this is this
uh backslash W uh small W which
basically checks for uh any alphanumeric
character and matches it in a string so
if you see in this first case
um it will find three matches at one two
and also at the letter c these others
are not alphanumeric characters whereas
in this string none of these are
alphanumic characters we will get no
match again much like the other examples
there is a capital there's a backslash
capital W which will check for any
non-alphanumeric character and it's the
equivalent of doing whatever we did
before in uh in the square brackets just
with a preceded by a carrot sign so if
you see here we have the string where we
have a bunch of characters well yeah
only one of them this uh this percentage
symbol is a non-alphanumeric character
so we will get much one match over here
but in this case in the string python we
will get no matches because they are all
alphanumeric characters which is doing
the same thing here with a bunch of
different examples using the find all
function now the backslash capital Z
matches if the specified characters are
at the end of a string now don't confuse
this with the backslash small B plus the
back is a small B checks for a string
and it checks each and every word in the
string individually and checks if so if
any of the words ends with a particular
thing or or starts with a particular
thing but it checks each word
individually but in this case the
backslash capital Z will check the
string only and not each word so if you
see the difference here in an um when
you use Capital backslash capital Z it
will match in this first example but it
won't match for the next two but if you
used a backslash small B over here it
would actually match and not only in the
first example here but it will also
match in the second example because it
would check this word individually and
it will find out that yeah there is a
match here as well so it would actually
match in the second example as well in
this video we will be covering the topic
of closures now before we understand
what a closure is we have to understand
what is a nested function and non-local
variables
now a function which is inside another
function is known as a nested function
nested functions are able to access
variables of the enclosing scope so if I
Define this function called outer
function where I pass some argument
called text and I store that in a
variable called text again and if I
create a function within this collinear
function and I want to print whatever
this variable is in text when I execute
this it will be able to access this
variable because it's within the
enclosing scope so if I set out a
function here this gets stored in the
variable text and then the inner
function will print that variable which
is basically the string here
as you can see here
now inner function can easily be
accessed inside the outer function body
but not outside of its body so here
inner function is treated as a nested
function which uses text this this
variable text as the non-local variable
now a closure is a function object that
remembers values in enclosing Scopes
even if they are not present in memory
it is a record that stores a function
together with an environment it's a
mapping basically that Associates each
free variable of the function which are
basically variables that are used
locally but are defined in enclosing
scope with the value or reference to
which the name was bound when the
closure is created a closure which is uh
which unlike a plane function allows the
function to access those captured
variables through the closures copies of
their values or references even when the
function is invoked outside the scope so
let's look at an example to emphasize on
what uh what was just said so again I've
created devdify this function outer
function where I'm doing the same thing
now I've defined the same inner function
where I'm going to print the same thing
now it's very important that when I
return over here what I'm going to
return is inert function but it's not
going to be a function call this is
important to create our closure so we
return in our function but with without
using the call as we do over here
and what this return will do is
basically to create the enclosure sorry
the closure where the inner function
will remember the values of the
variables stored in the enclosing scope
so now I'm going to store this outer
function in an object called my in a
variable called my function now when I
call this my function
um you can see there there'll be two
things that are happening here so once
I've defined this and I've executed this
what happens out here is this function
is already executed and then I'm storing
it to this but because I've done return
inner function without parenthesis I've
created a closure basically and this
closure allows the inner function to
remember the values that were stored in
text at any point at and at every Point
even after the execution of this fun
time so when I execute this again for
the second time over here it will
remember the value that was stored in
the variable text which is hey which was
which was given over here
that's why you see when I execute it for
the second time over here the first time
being in this line when I'm storing it
in my function when I execute in the
second time again it will give me the
result of hey
as you can see the closures have to
invoke functions outside the scope the
functional function has a scope only
inside the outer function but with the
user closures we can extend its scope to
invoke a function outside the scope so
now let's look at this code so this code
don't worry about what's going on here
just know that what we are doing here is
we have two functions which we Define
called add X and Y which will return X
Plus Y and the subtract function which
will subtract X and Y so now we're going
to execute these once we are going to
execute the add over here in add logger
and we're going to execute the subtract
function and we're going to store it in
sublogger so technically we have already
executed these two functions but now
since I've created an X an enclosure
basically uh if you see here this is the
enclosure that I have created now what
happens is
when I access this function from outside
its initial scope which is basically
over here this was the initial Scope
when I access it outside you will see
that it it is it still has access to
these variables X and Y so if you see
here I I first of all I've allowed this
uh this the enclosing function to accept
uh arguments of any numbers so I can
pass X Y I can pass x y z also but if
you see here I will I only have a thing
for X and Y so
when I want to access any value of X and
Y even after the execution of this code
initially I have access to these
variables X and Y and that is because
I've created a closure out of that so if
you see if I do add logger 3 and 3 over
here I am able to get the result 6. if I
do add logger four and five I'm able to
get the result nine similarly for
subtraction logger 10 and 5 I will get 5
here and 20 and 10 I'll get 10 here and
I can keep doing this I can keep saying
ad logger in fact if I say 4 and 7 so if
I executed this and now I'm going to say
let's say for example add logger if I
set 4 and 7 here
so this still has access to my variables
X and Y because I've created the closure
and it should give me 11. similarly if I
did sub logger say 30 and 15 it should
give me 15 because 30 minus 15. so let's
say 30 minus 16 right so it should give
me 14 because again I have created the
closure and it has access to these
variables already in this video we will
be learning about the concept of Lambda
functions now a Lambda function in
Python is an anonymous function without
a name we usually use Lambda functions
whenever we want to create a a function
type object for for a short period of
time a Lambda function is defined using
the Lambda keyword like a normal
function is defined using the def
keyword we Define a Lambda function
using the Lambda keyword also the Lambda
function can take any number of
arguments but it can only accept one
expression as a part of it so think of a
Lambda function like a sort of a a
temporary function object that you
create whenever you want to perform a
particular object but you don't want to
give it a name or you don't want to
define a full full-blown function and
give it a name like that so over here
I'm going to give you an example of a
Lambda function let's say that this
Lambda function takes in let's call it X
and so you define the function let's
call it X let's call it a Lambda
function using this keyword now we want
say two parameters right
we're saying say A and B or two
arguments A and B so we're going to pass
two arguments A and B whenever we call
use this function and we're going to
perform some sort of an expression now
let's write down a simple arithmetic
expression for this once you've defined
your arguments
you just use the colon now over here we
have our expression so let's call it a
plus b so now we've created a Lambda
function called X where uh we will pass
two arguments and the result will be the
expression a plus B A Plus A and B being
the arguments we pass
so now let's print the result of let's
say we pass one and three so now we
should get the result 4 right because a
plus b is equal to 4 so we passed a as 1
B is 3 now let's execute this as you can
see the result is for similarly you can
pass any number of arguments so we want
to call some function X
um let's say Lambda function
maybe say um a
B and C the same and we want to do the
product of these three arguments
so now when we do when we check the
result let's say we're doing the product
of two four and six so this should be 48
and when you execute this you get 48 as
you can see here so these are two simple
examples of a Lambda function
now I could have done this um in a
different way where I could have defined
some function X and over here I Define
that it takes in three parameters and
then you can Define
um some say return the function
basically returns you a product B
product C but many a times you don't
need to define a full function called X
you don't you don't want to assign some
function with this name you just want to
create a temporary or a short time
Anonymous function with some name just
to perform a simple expression and in
that case we can use Lambda functions
that's an example by the way you can use
Lambda functions in multiple places so
let's move on now
now uh for the sake of this video what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
how the sorted function works and we're
going to learn how the Lambda function
uses this sorted function how they work
together so this will give you a clearer
understanding of how we use the Lambda
function in our code so to start off
sorted function returns a sorted list
from the items in an interval so you can
have a bunch of for example numbers and
the sorted function by default will give
you will return you the list of numbers
in an ascending order of course you can
also using a parameter called reverse
you can you can you can return a list of
numbers in the descending order you can
also do this for Strings I mean
characters so if you give it a bunch of
characters say a e f g in the uh in the
alphabet it will give you if you use a
sorted function it will give you the
characters it will return it and
ascending or descending order depending
on the parameter you give so basically
this uh the sorted function the syntax
is you use the keyword sorted then you
pass the iterable which is basically
some sub list or some Tuple then you
give it a key so this key sometimes we
don't need to give by default if the
iterable is does not contain um multiple
uh multiple items per object for like if
it's not a tuple of multiple objects
um if it's not a list of tuples for
example you don't need to give it a key
if it's a simple list of numbers you
don't necessarily need to give a key if
you want to sort it but yeah a key is
basically the parameter which we use to
tell the sorted function that we want to
sort based on something which is going
to be the key in this case finally the
third parameter is reverse which
basically just tells us that if we want
to sort in the default ascending order
or if we say reverse true then we will
sort in the descending order now let's
look at some examples so I have this
list over here and I'm going to print
this list
so uh this list is obviously a bunch of
vowels
e-a-u-o-i and this is not in the
ascending order of the the alphabet
right like we we know it as a e i o u if
I print the sorted form of this list it
should give me a e i o u a list with
aeio in the ascending order
sorry yeah so now as you can see
um it's given me this list as you can
see here similarly if um I gave it a
string a string as you know is an
iterable it's a collection of characters
so if I use a sorted function on this
interestingly it will give me a list of
these
um individual characters like p y t h o
and n but in the order that we want it
to be in which is the ascending order of
course so if I print this you can see it
returns me the list with each character
in the order that we wanted it to be in
now you might notice why does p come
before H that's because this is in
uppercase so what this does is first it
uh sorts all the uppercase characters
since there's only one so it just places
in the first object of this list and
then it sorts all the lowercase
characters that you see here so yeah
moving on now now what if we wanted to
say um short distance descending order
so we have this list now we want to sort
this in a descending order so in that
case we have to give the parameter
reverse and we have to assign the value
true so once we do this now when we
execute this you can see we have the
return as the same list but in the
opposite order so that's how the reverse
parameter works now let's uh try to
understand how we use the key function
or the key parameter in the sorted
function now of course if you if you
want to sort something based on some key
that we want to Define we use the key
parameter so let's take an example now
so in this example what we have done is
I've defined this function called take
second so what this does is it it simply
it takes the second element of a list of
tuples so what is this list of tuples
well this is random you can see this
random this is a list of tuples so this
is one Tuple this is the next Tuple and
what I'm going to do is in this example
I'm going to create a key out of every
second element in each Tuple so I'm
going to create a key out of 20 40 10
and 13 and based on these in an
ascending order I will sort this whole
list so my what my result should be is
that since the smallest of the uh every
second object in these tuples is 10 so
this will be my first object in the my
sorted list then it should be the one
with 13 because this is the next highest
number so then this will be the next
object similarly this will be the next
object then this will be the whole next
object so you see I'm using every second
element of the Tuple as my key and for
that to create a key basically
um I'm creating this function which will
basically return every
um it will iterate through all of these
and it will return uh each of these
second elements so um let's actually uh
let's actually do this now so what I
have here is I am going to create a
sorted list which is going to use a
sorted function on this iterable which
is a bunch which is a list of tuples
it's called random now my key is going
to be take second so this sorted
function is actually very dynamic in the
sense
um I don't I don't exactly have to
create a list directly each of these
objects present in the tuples I just
have to Define if I can even pass a
function in the parameter for key and it
will apply this function on the interval
that we pass over here which is random
namely and it will use this function to
generate Keys uh generate a key out of
each second element and based on that it
will do the sorted it will perform the
sorted function so now
if I check
what's my um sorted list
you will see
that as I had mentioned now it's using
the second object so the second uh each
each second object of the Tuple as the
key so since 10 is the smallest this
whole object is the first object then 13
so we have this object here and then so
on and so forth so this is how we've
used a key to do the Sorting function a
key that we've defined on our on our own
now similarly we can use multiple Keys
as well so just to quickly go over
through this uh we have this
um some some list where a bunch of names
a bunch of tuples you can see right
tuples with three objects each within it
each first one is always always a string
denoting someone's name some students
name
um the second is the marks out of 100
and the third is their age so what we
have here is what we want to do is we
want to sort this uh these tuples uh in
the order of first marks and in case the
marks are clashing or they are the same
basically we will sort by the age so
what we want to do is we want to First
sort by these marks as you can see here
but in case the Clash for example like
say this 75 and 75 they're the same
marks in that case we want to sort it by
the age which is 12 and 20 which is
different so in this case we're going to
use two keys one the first key will be
given the highest priority and then if
there is a clash then we use the second
key so how do we do this now let's
define some function like uh how we
Define this take second function here
this will be our function that we will
pass to the key this function basically
what it does is it gives us uh who has
the highest marks now since we are
creating and since the key works in an
ascending order so um the smallest
object in a key is the first object that
gets returned right so what we're going
to do is we're going to return the error
which is basically the difference
between
um 100 which is the total marks and the
marks the student gets so this is how we
obtain a ascending order in our list
which is what we which which basically
is what we want because we want the
highest marks to be first so we do 100
minus item one item one is basically the
first object or whatever it will be pass
in this case it would be the the first
objects of each Tuple which is the marks
secondly We performed age age is the
item two which is yeah each second
object of each Tuple now what we return
in this function is uh like this is
going to be our key now a list of errors
and the list of age error being the
marks error the difference between 100
and the marks you obtain so now what
it's going to do is it's going to take
the marks as the first key and the age
as the second key when we pass this to a
sorting function
so uh if you skip this you don't have to
look at this but if you look at this now
we have the sorted list which is going
to be the result of the sorted function
on top of what we pass which is the
participant list now we're going to use
the key we're going to use the key as
the sorter function so we're going to
use this order function as a key and
when we print if you see
we get let me just execute all of this
so if you see here in this section what
you can see is we have the highest marks
first then the second then the third but
if you see here there's a clash this guy
and this guy have the same Mark 75 so
now what we want to do is the guy who
has a younger age should be in the first
in the object so that is how this has
happened because we've passed two keys
error and the age so when The Clash in
error key happened we went to the ah key
and then we did ascending order on that
and then finally the rest of the objects
that you can see here so now that we
have seen how the sorted function works
now let's look at how the Lambda
function Works using this sorted
function which was the main goal of this
video right so let's see
so now some of you might have figured
out where this Lambda function will be
used right so whenever we were using the
key in the sorted function we had to
define a function and then we would pass
that function as the key so as some of
you may have figured this out what we're
going to do using the Lambda function is
we're going to skip that process of
defining a function with a new name and
all that and we're going to pass a
Lambda function we're going to use a
Lambda function as the key so let's see
how we do it so initially what we've
done is we've created this list this
list is a list of dictionaries that you
can see so this first object is a
dictionary second object is a dictionary
each dictionary contains two keys the
name and the age and the values are
something like nandini the values for
age is like 20 20 and 19. so we have
three dictionaries in a list so what
we're going to do is we want to print
what we what we want to do with this we
want to print the these objects or these
dictionaries
in an ascending order of age so we want
obviously we want this to be first and
then this and this because 19 is smaller
than 20. so let's see how we do this
so if you go here
what we're going to do is we're going to
print the sorted the sorted function or
the uh the result of the sorted function
being applied on this list so this is
available now if you see here in the key
the key parameter we don't we don't
predefine a function and pass it over
here instead we use the Lambda and this
Lambda function is defined in such a way
so we say Lambda it will take one
argument I and then it will return
basically the age index for some I and
this I is we're going to presume an i to
be some sort of an iterable which has an
index called age and which is uh which
is the case in our case right we have a
bunch of dictionaries where there is a
key in each of these dictionaries called
age so we're going to use that and now
you're going to ask like what is I well
when we use the Lambda function in the
sorted function this I will basically be
each object that we get when we iterate
upon this list so if we are going to
iterate first on this so it's going to
take this dictionary and is going to
search for the age then it's going to
take this it's going to search for the
age then it's going to take this and
it's going to search for the age and
each of the time it will pull out what
is the value for each of these age
keywords or these age indexes or age
keys and out of these objects so 20 20
and 19 or these values we're going to
create a key with which we're going to
sort each object in this whole list okay
so this is how the Lambda function will
work here so let's do this so as you can
see our sorted list now contains this
object first because a 19 is small stage
and then this and this now you might see
that there are two twenties so how do we
control which one comes first well by
default it will um it will just give us
the result in the way we passed it in
the original list so since nandini came
before manjit in the result also nandini
will come before manjit but what if we
wanted to sort it even more what if we
want to sort it in such a way that first
we go by age and the second key will
tell us that if there is a clash in ages
we have to go alphabetically by the name
so in this case we will create a second
key and how we do that
well if you go to this step
over here what we're doing is we're
doing the same sorted function but now
the Lambda will again take one parameter
which is I which is going to be each Ito
which which is going to be each object
in this uh iterable list and we're going
to take two keys so the first key will
be the H key and the second key will be
the name so it will first sort on age
and then on name so now if you see
um the result should be that manjeet
will come before nandini even though the
ages are 20 because M comes before n in
the alphabet as you can see this is the
result
now if we wanted to do the same thing
but in a descending order all we have to
do is after this key parameter we have
to give another parameter called reverse
and we have to give it true
so if we did this now you see this this
uh or if we do it on this one
to be more clear
now if I execute this basically this
whole uh whatever result we get will be
backwards now
oh wait I did not enter it in the sorted
function
so this should come within the sorted
function over here
so now if we execute this you will see
nandani comes first manjit comes second
and then nickel comes third because
we've done the reverse I will use the
reverse keyword as true uh reverse
parameter is true in this video we will
be covering the topics of map filter and
reduce functions in Python now python
provides several functions that enable
functional approach to programming and
since functional programming is all
about Expressions some of these
expression oriented functions of python
are Lambda functions list comprehensions
map filter map filter and reduce now
we've already covered the topic of
Lambda and list comprehensions now let's
cover the topics of map filter and
reduce
so to start off let's look at the map
function the map function takes in two
attributes a function and a sequence a
function is basically some defined some
user defined function or any function a
sequence is basically an iterable object
like a list or a tuple for example or a
bunch of lists and tupacles as well so
let's look at an example so one of the
most common operations that we do with
something like a list is doing an
operation on each of the elements in the
list and then outputting a new list with
the the values as whatever we have
modified to the original items of the uh
list so we what if we did the square of
all of these items in this list and we
we want to create a list based on that
so we can basically iterate through it
and we can do a square function and then
append those values to a new list called
squared and when we do this for example
over here you can see when we print
squared
we should get the list of whatever
Square values we have for the original
list so this is uh slightly a bit
tedious and what if we had a method that
or a
what if we had a technique wherein we
could
basically pass a function that we have
that we want to do and a sequence on
which we want to apply this and we pass
it to a function and this function
basically takes care of
um applying whatever operations we want
to do on each element of a sequence so
as this is where the map function comes
in use so let's look at how we use the
map function over here so if you look at
this I have defined a square function so
the square function basically returns or
takes an argument X and Returns the
square of it and I have a map function
which takes the square function as one
of the arguments and the I the list or
an iterable as the second argument so
this map function creates a map object
if you see here so let's just do it one
by one so I'm creating my list and I'm
going to create my function called
Square and I'm going to
send this to the map function so I'm
sending this uh the first argument as
the function that I want to do and the
second argument as the list that I want
to apply it on now let's list out all
the items that are in this map object
so if you see it creates me a list with
basically the squared items and this is
exactly what we needed and another way
of doing the same thing would be just
going through a for Loop in each of the
map objects and printing each which
would give me the same results so if you
see here I found a very neat way of
passing a function and an iterable and
using the map function to apply each
operation that is part of the function
or applying the function on each item in
the iterable so as you've seen we
basically passed in a user defined
function and we applied it to each item
in the list then the map calls the
square function on each list item and
collects all the return values into a
new list and because map expects a
function to be passed in it also happens
to be one of the places where Lambda
functions are appearing a lot so let's
look at the an example where we do the
same operation using a Lambda function
so if you see here I have a Lambda
function where I am passing it as the
function argument and what this Lambda
function takes is some variable X or
some argument X it does its square and
it returns at X and this x is basically
going to come from each element that is
present in this list called items and
when we list down these you will see it
basically does the same thing for us it
creates this list with squared items now
we can also pass instead of passing an
interval itself we can actually pass a
sequence of functions and use the Lambda
function to perform a sequence of
functions on particular items so let's
look at a new example a slightly
different one so we're going to use a
numpy module for this don't worry we're
just using it to use the square root
function that is present in the numpy
primary module we will be learning about
number in a later section so we're going
to import this first and now I'm going
to Define three functions cos Square
Cube and square root
so once I've defined this basically they
are returning the square the cube root
the cube and the square root of some
integer X and now I'm going to create a
list of these functions that you've just
seen and we're going to use a for Loop
and we're going to iterate through a
range from 0 to 4. so and we're going to
pass this
and we're going to say that we're going
to apply
some some function we want to apply some
function X and we want to return that
using this Lambda function now what
values this x will take is based on
whatever functions we've stored in this
variable called Fu NCS or funks and in
funcs we have a bunch of functions
called Square Cube and square root that
we have defined earlier so what we're
going to do is we're going to apply each
of these functions to R and R will take
the value 0 to 4 and now let's see when
we print this what values we get so if
you see here we get a list of square
root squares cubes and square roots for
integer 0 1 2 3 and 4. so this is
another way of using the map function
and Lambda functions together to apply
multiple different operations to a bunch
of iterables
now for our next example what we're
going to do is we're going to create a
function that basically what it does is
it creates the uppercase of some string
that we pass to it right so that's what
we've done here in this function called
two uppercase so if let's first Define
this function now we have a print
function basically which is going to
print each object in a particular which
is going to prevent each element of a
particular object and it's going to at
the end of it and the end of printing
we're going to give a small space for
printing a new line basically so let's
create this also this print it editor
object now what we're going to do is
we're going to pass a string with the
letters a b and c to this function and
we're going to map and we're going to
apply the uppercase function to this
string now if you remember string is
also an iterable where it's a sequence
of one character strings so this whole
string is basically a sequence of one
character string a one character string
B and C so we're going to so we can pass
a string as a as an iterable to the map
function because it will apply the
operations on each of these characters
so let's see what happens when we do the
uppercase function uh we apply the upper
uppercase function using the map using
mapping to this string a b and c
so if you see it's created me a list
with a capital a capital B and capital c
as we had expected because we have
applied the list function to the map
object now in The Next Step what we're
going to do is we're going to do a very
similar thing we're just going to
instead of Simply mapping and creating a
list out of it we're going to store the
map object in a variable called map
iterator we're going to print what type
of object it is and then we're going to
print out each of the elements using the
print iterator function that we defined
here so let's do this now if you see the
class the type of object is of class map
and the objects elements inside the
object are a b and c Moving On Let's uh
let's look at now an example where we're
going to pass multiple arguments so
instead of one iterable we're going to
pass multiple iterables now and we're
going to apply some sort of an operation
so if you see here what we have done is
we've created Tool uh two two sequences
one is a list of some numbers and
another is a tuple of some numbers so
just to show you let me first copy this
here
um yeah so if you see here I have a list
and a tuple and I'm passing both of
these if you see to this map function
and before that I have defined a Lambda
function as the operation that I'm going
to apply and what this does is it takes
two arguments X and Y and it Returns the
product of both of these uh where does
it get X and Y from so the X it gets
from this uh this sequence which is a
list and it takes y from this sequence
which is a tuple so what it's going to
do is going to take X as 1 and then Y is
5 in the first step and it's going to
return the product S5 and then the next
step is going to take 2 as X and then y
as 6 and it's going to return the
product of that and we're going to get
12 and so on we're going to get 21 and
then 32. um when we read it and this is
these values are going to be stored in
the map iterator which is a map type
object and when we use the print Rotator
function it's basically going to print
out whatever results we got through this
mapping so let's execute this and as you
can see this is the result we got 5 12
21 and 32 which is what we wanted so the
next part the next function that we're
going to discuss is the filter function
now now my filter function is basically
again it takes two two arguments a
function and a sequence and a function
basically tests if each element of a
sequence is true or not now a sequence
the sequence so this filter function
will basically take two arguments so one
is the function and this function is
basically going to test if each element
of a sequence is true or not and it's
going to take another argument called
sequence and this argument sequence is
the list or the Tuple or basically any
sequence and or iterable that needs to
be filtered and it can be as I mentioned
it can be sets less tuples or containers
of more iterators and what this function
will return is an iterator that is
already filtered um so let's look at an
example now so we have this list R which
you generated which is basically numbers
from -5 to 4. so if I create this list
here you can see it will create a list
of minus five to four now if I wanted to
extract only the values that are lesser
than 0 well I can use a for Loop and use
a if condition to check this right so if
I did this over here you can see it
gives me it returns me some list called
result which contains only the values
lesser than zero which is basically
check through this condition what if
there was a uh neat or a more convenient
or a more organized approach to doing
the same thing instead of creating a
loop ourselves what if we defined a
function where we are going to do the
test or we are going to create the
condition and we're going to pass this
to a particular function and then apply
that particular operation on every
object of some sequence well just like
mapping we have a filter function to do
this and in this example what we're
going to use is the Lambda function
which takes an argument X and it checks
for some condition X lesser than 0 and
where it's going to get the X from if
some sequence R which which in our case
is the numbers from minus five to four
and the filter will basically create a
filter object type which contains only
the objects from r that meet this
condition that is X is lesser than 0 and
when we use the list operation on top of
it it you will see it creates it results
in a list with the values that have met
my condition so for a second example
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a list which contains a bunch of
letters and we're going to only extract
the vowels from these bunch of letters
so let's look at what we have here we
have some letters d a t j k o p l and we
only want the vowels from this so we
want to filter only the vowels so we can
use that using the filter function by
first of all defining a function that
returns true if a check is met that um
one of the letter matches one of these
letters in this list called letters and
if it doesn't it returns false so this
is in our condition that we've created
once we create this condition uh this
function that checks this we can pass
this function and the sequence into the
filter function and then we can list out
whatever we get so you can see our
filtered list contains only a and o
which is basically the only vowels that
are present in our original list
finally we have the reduce function this
reduce function is basically a func
tools it's in the funk tools module of
python 3.0 and what the reduce function
does is it applies a function of two
arguments cumulatively to the elements
of a iterable and it optionally it
starts with an initial argument and it
returns a single result so let's first
import this function
and once we've imported it let's use it
in this example that we have here so in
this example what we're going to do is
we have some list called numbers right
what if we wanted to get the sum of each
element in this list well we can iterate
over it and store it in some variable
called total in each step right
um this is what we would typically
typically do and in this step what you
can see is the loop basically iterates
over every valuable in numbers and
accumulates them in total the final
result is the sum of all the values
which is the value of 10 over here in
this example the variable total is what
we call an accumulator and we can apply
the reduce function to do the same task
so how do we do it let's first of all
create a function called my ad where
we're going to take two variables two
arguments and we're going to return the
sum of it okay so let's define this
function and now we have we have our
list called numbers right which contains
one two three and four now let's do
reduce my add to numbers
now when I do this when I use this
function what it will do is it will
apply the function of my ad it will take
basically each and every element uh in a
sequence so it will take 1 and 2 then
add them together and then it will
create basically what it will do is
it'll take one and two add them together
then we'll have three so it'll take
three and then the next element which is
three again so it will create the sum
which is 6 and then it will take 6 and
then it will take the value 4 and it
will give us the result 10. so this is
how the reduce function would work so
this is how it will give us the result
of 10. as you can see here I've simply
used I've passed this function where
I've defined that I want to argument to
be passed to a function and then the
return should be basically the sum and
then a fastable list of like four
numbers and I've used the reduce
function to basically do this process
for four numbers in a step-by-step
manner by taking two at a time
subsequently and my result is as you can
see is correct as you can see here so
let's use the Lambda function now to do
the same topic just do the same task so
what I'm doing now is I'm going to
define a Lambda function and that's the
function I'm going to pass to this
reduce so when I pass this Lambda
function which basically takes two two
arguments X and Y and it's going to
return the sum of that as X Plus y now
where it's going to get X and Y from is
in a very in a very neat manner so it
will take first the first two elements
one and two it will then do the sum and
we get three then it will take the same
three and then take the next object
which is three again and then give us 6
then it will take six and then the next
element which is 4 and then give us 10
and then the reduce function will output
the the single result which is 10 to us
as you can see here
in this video we will be covering a sort
of a project side type of scenario which
is basically going to be a problem case
for you and it's going to be slightly
slightly difficult slightly tricky but
what we're going to do is we're going to
tackle a particular problem and we're
going to what I'm going to do is also
show you a solution to that problem
so let's start with this so this
question that we have is we have this
program
um that we have to write where we
compute the frequency of words that
exist in some input okay uh the program
should output after sorting the key
alphanumerically now this input can be
and it's basically a block of text right
so in our example we have um for example
if this was our input right what we want
to see is an output which is basically
saying that uh the word python has
appeared say well in this example it's
appeared five times and then the word
read has appeared one time and so on and
so forth like for each of these words we
want to see um how many times have they
appeared in this project particular
block of text so let's look at a
particular example now where we have
done this so let's um let's see here
so first of all I'm going to create a
dictionary so why am I creating a
dictionary is because I'm going to use
each unique word as a key and the number
of times they have appeared in a block
of text as the value to that key so um
I'm going to use a sample string which
is basically this long string that you
can see here which is stored in line so
this large chunk of text is what we're
going to be analyzing so how are we
going to do this it's pretty simple so
we have this now what we want to do is
um when we find what we one way of
tackling this problem that we're going
to do here is we want to
um check word by word first of all we
want to see if it's a unique word and if
this word is before I encountered it for
the first time then we need to store a
new key here in our dictionary called
frequent table or frequency table and if
it has already if there is a key already
with that particular name then we just
want to increment the count or the value
by one so let's see how we do this over
here so if you can see it might this the
solution is as simple as this but if you
see what's happening it's basically what
uh what it's doing is we're splitting up
this string uh using the split function
what this will do is it will split up
the string at every white space so it'll
take this as one part I'll take this
part as another part it will create an
iterable with each word as the um each
iterable object in that container so
it's going to be a list of words like
python is one so on and so forth and
we're going to go one by one so we're
going to say forward in line dot split
now if this word is if it exists in
frequency table as a key then what we're
going to do is we're just going to
increase the count of the value of that
key by one but if it does not exist then
we're going to actually create a key
with the word as that unique word and
we're going to create its value
um initialize its value to 1 foreign so
let me execute this
now if we want to once you've done this
we can sort it by the count of the words
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a another Tuple called sorted
tuples where we're going to use the
Lambda function out here uh to sort the
dictionary in terms of its values so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the key the key being the Lambda
item item with index one index one is
basically the value so a particular key
has a value so the word python appears
so many times the word say scientist
appears so many times so we're going to
check which words have the highest
number of occurrences and we're going to
sort it in a descending order so that
that is basically what the reverse is
equal to True does so when we're going
to sort this when we're going to use the
sorted function when we say reverse true
it tells the sortic function to sort
this dictionary this dictionary
frequency table uh in terms of value
by the the descending order so whichever
word appears highest that would be the
first word in our uh sorted Tuple so
that's what we do in this slide and once
we execute this we're also going to
print so if you see the result of this
activity that we've done you can see
that the word machine appears six times
learning appears six times then python
appears 510 and so on and so forth so
we've created a sorted Tuple where the
first object of the Tuple we've created
a list of sorted tuples where the first
object of the two each Tuple is the
unique word the second one is the number
of times it has appeared in this
particular example or this particular
string so yeah this was the first basic
project that we have tackled in this you
might have seen some examples of how we
do list operations and how we use the
Lambda function in sorting the
dictionary by the values of the key in
this video we will continue with what we
started in in terms of our project
number one what we're going to do is
um we're going to tackle another
slightly complicated
um
uh a question or a situation
um we're gonna try to arrive at a
solution so in this what we have is some
sort of a robot a moving robot which
moves on a Cartesian plane a two
coordinate plane
um is going to move uh in terms of up
down left and right okay and each each
time it moves up or down or left or
right it takes a certain number of steps
in that direction
um integral steps of course so what we
need to do is from a starting position
whatever its starting position is which
we are going to take as 0 comma 0 in
this example we're going to make it move
to a particular location with the
commands up down left and right followed
by certain steps and we're going to uh
ask what we're going to do is we're
going to calculate the distance between
these two points
um and we're going to calculate
different types of distances so you
might be introduced to New Concepts
um you know distance Concepts in this
video as well so what we're going to be
using for distance calculation is the
minkowski distance and that is we're
going to take so the minkowski distance
between two variables is basically the
absolute difference between these two
variables of these two points and we
take it to the power of something so if
we want to say uh calculate the
minkowski distance with in terms of the
quadratic main cause citizens with
basically P2 so we are going to do x i
minus y i absolute difference to the
power 2 and then we're going to take the
second root of it after summing each and
every point so when we take p is equal
to 2 we we say the minkowski distance
behaves like the euclidean distance and
this is probably one of the most common
distances uh in case you've done basic
uh Cartesian geometry when you are asked
to find the distance between two points
on a plane
um we can also take the absolute
distance where we take p is equal to one
so in this case we're just basically
summing the absolute distances between
each point no roots no power is nothing
basically p is equal to one and we call
that the Manhattan distance so we're
going to take p is equal to 1 2 and 3 in
each case and we're going to find the
distance between two points based on
these
measures so
this is just a visual representation
this is basically the Euclid resistance
basically the estimate of the value
between these two points if um since
this is a two coordinate system whereas
the Manhattan distance would be the
absolute distance in terms of um if we
go up and then we go right between these
two like say if this was and this was
another point so yeah let's move on to
the problem in this particular example
we are going to start from the starting
position 0 and 0 on a on a graph and we
are going to give the commands of up
five down three left three and right two
so first of all what we want to do is we
initialize the starting position as 0
and 0 and we also just for the sake of
this example we initialize the end
position as 0 and 0. so what we're going
to do first of all is let's execute this
much now we have this list list of
tuples
um it's we're going to call this actions
and this is the actions that we're
performing so the this the each Tuple
contains an action and the number of
steps in that direction so it contains
four actions up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps right by
two steps so now we're going to iterate
over this each Tuple and we're going to
get the direction first of all in this
line
um for each step uh and we're going to
calculate the number of steps it takes
so for each action it's going to first
tell
um it's going to check what is the
direction which is done by this line and
we're going to find out the number of
steps in that direction which is stored
in this line so
once you've gotten this for each action
we have to update the end position right
so what happens is if you go up by a
particular direction so you are
basically changing the y y axis right
the the y-axis so we're going to change
end position and the first index which
is basically this part of the end
position coordinate point so we're going
to say if it's moving by up then we're
going to uh update by adding uh the
y-axis by the number of steps so
um and and if the direction is down
we're going to do the same thing for the
y axis but we're going to decrement it
similarly if we move left or right by
moving the x axis right so we take n
position in the first index so we take
the x axis and if you're moving left
it's a negative uh it's a decrement and
if you're moving right it's an increment
so if there's any other like action like
any other action for example that was
given here we say pass so basically the
only valid actions that we can pass is
um up down left and right otherwise we
we just skip that particular action so
this is what the this particular Loop
will do it will update our final
position
so once we've done this if we if I
execute this what will get stored in the
end position is basically my end
position so now that I have my starting
position and my end position
um just to show you what the end
Position will look like right now let's
just do this so if you see here after
I've moved up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps and then
right by two steps my final end position
is minus one and two
um my start position on the other hand
was
as you remember it should be 0 and 0. it
is 0 and 0. so now we're going to find
the distance between 0 and 0 and -1 and
2. so we're going to first of all create
a function called minkowski distance
which which does the basic function of
just calculate the uh the difference
between the what do you say the end
position x coordinate and the N position
y coordinate times uh or to the power of
a root and we're basically going to do
this operation that you saw here we're
going to do this and um we're going to
use this root variable to specify to
like P is equal to one two or three like
what P value we want to take for this
minkowski distance so once you've done
this what this function will do is
basically store uh this much and it will
wait for us to uh it will basically wait
for us to give us a root so when we give
root 1 it will create these it will
check the distance between the end and
starting points
um with the p-value of one if you give
it two it will calculate euclidean
distance with p-value 2 similarly for
three and we can calculate for any Roots
so we're going to calculate for one two
and three roads and we're going to see
what values we get in each case
so when root is equal to 1 I print the
statement saying minkowski distance with
root 1 is something and then root 2 it's
something root 3 is something let's see
what results we get
so if you see here the minkowski
distance with root 1 is actually 1.0 but
the euclidean distance between these two
points is 2.23 whereas the uh the cubic
minkowski distance with basically the
with root 3 is 1.91 so you see these
three different uh distance measures for
the same distance between two points so
in this video you basically so in this
basically by doing this activity you
might must have you will learn how to um
basically how to iterate through loops
and perform these distance calculations
which you will find pretty handy in many
activities related to data science and
machine learning in this video we will
be continuing tackling different
problems and problem cases in terms of a
project called project three where we're
going to be using regular Expressions to
validate whether certain passwords that
have been entered do they match certain
criterias or not so let's look into our
particular question we have a website
that requires users to input username
and password to register now we have to
write a program to check the validity of
passwords input by the users now the
criteria is that the passwords have to
follow are that there's at least one
letter between a and z and one number
between 0 and 9. the third criteria is
that uh there's at least one letter
between capital A and capital Z so this
first and third Point basically is
saying that there should be one
lowercase letter and there should be one
uppercase letter now there should be at
least one character from dollar sign
hash or the add simple it should have a
minimum length of 6 and the maximum
length of 12. so when we whatever
passwords we enter into our example they
must be comma separated so if we're
going to have an input they're going to
ask us for an input where we're going to
have to input the different passwords in
a comma separated way so let's look
let's look at how do we tackle this so
for my example I'm going to use these
examples in terms of these are my
password examples if you're going to
check if these are valid passwords or
not so let's copy this first of all
and now let's import the re which import
re is basically the regular expression
module now in this step is going to ask
us to input the passwords as you can see
here so I will just Ctrl V so since this
is comma separated what it will do is it
will split up each of these by the comma
and it will store them in a list so it
will take this as one password this has
another password this has another
password and this has another password
once I press enter
now if I want to check what's in list I
mean what's in items what I can do is
just check over here what's in items
it's a list of whatever passwords I had
entered each object is separately
treated now in this list now I'm going
to create a an empty list called value
first of all once I've done that I'm
going to move on to the next step
so once I've created my list called
value what I'm going to do is now I'm
going to search and I'm going to check
for each condition using regular
expressions for whatever criteria that
we have initially so if you see here
what I'm going to do is first iterate by
each item in this to check for each
password now my first check will be a
basic check for the length of the
password if it's lesser than 6 or
greater than 12 then our basically our
password is illegal so we can't be using
this and we will just continue and we
won't check for anything else but if it
is within 6 and 12 the length 6 and 12
then we can continue with our check so
we can do we'll do an else statement for
pass which basically moves on to this
next block
now once you've done this what we will
do is this this first statement what
this is going to do is it's going to do
an re.search and re dot search as you
know is going to look for at least one
instance of um
a letter occurring between a and z so
this ire dot search followed by this now
this is the regular expression that we
have passed and what this does is
basically the square in the square
brackets we're looking for anything
between uh A and Z in terms of small
letters so if this condition is not met
then again we continue and we leave this
particular search because one of our
criterias is not met all right but if it
is met then this if not statement will
not uh like we won't enter this block
and we can move on to the next check so
now now we move to L if not now again
we're using if not statement so this is
basically checking for uh a negative
case so anytime one of these cases have
been met it basically means that our
password has been invalid because these
conditions are not being met so we're
trying to eliminate all conditions all
of these conditions so that we get a
valid password so again we move on to
the next statement which is basically
going to do the search for numbers once
again if we find a case a password
without any numbers we continue and we
don't
um check this password no more because
we already know it's a it's a an illegal
password now next check will be for
capital letters a to z and the next
check again will be for uh these
particular symbols the dollar the hash
and the ad one of these three symbols uh
we're going to search for a white space
character so if we actually do find a
white space character in our password
um that's an illegal password and we're
not going to continue checking for those
cases
so um so this is basically all our cases
lowercase letters numbers capital
letters these one of these three symbols
and the existence of a white space so
once you've done all these checks if
none of these have been passed we move
on to this else statement where we just
pass and what we can do is we append the
value P to the uh the list called value
so basically what happens is
um just to go through it again if this
condition is not met and this condition
is not met this is not met this is not
met this is not met and if this is also
not met then we're fine so basically as
long as we have small letters as long as
we have a number as long as we have a
capital letter as long as we have one of
these three symbols and as long as we
don't have any uh White space characters
we can append e to this otherwise it
would continue and it will break out of
this for Loop completely that's what the
continued thing the continue statement
at the end of each of these blocks
checks any time this condition is met
this if not condition is met then we
break through we break through this
whole for Loop and we don't append P to
the value but uh if you actually get to
this stage then what we can do is simply
append uh P to value now finally what we
are going to do is uh we are going to
print out all the valid passwords so
just by a quick look you can see here
this is a valid password right so let's
execute this and let's see uh what we
get if you see here we only get one
valid password and let's look at why
some of these do not turn out to be
valid so if you look here all of the
conditions are met it has a capital
letter it has a small letter it has at
least one number and it has one of the
symbols either dollar sign or the hash
sign or the AD Sign In this case we have
two white spaces one over here and one
over here so this is an illegal password
similarly in this case also we have an
illegal password because it begins with
a space in this case it's the same thing
we begin with a space and also it does
not have any of those symbols that we
were looking for the dollar or the hash
or the ad so again so these three are
illegal passwords and they do not get
appended to Value however this does get
appended to Value and that's why we get
the result for only one password which
is the only legal password welcome to
web scraping with python my name is
Richard kirschner with the simply
learned team certainly there are many
reasons to be able to go online and
scrape different websites they range
everything from pulling out different
links to pulling data off of websites
it's a data scientist you might need to
get some information off a website that
doesn't have a direct API to pull that
information and in Python we have a
wonderful tool when you talk Python and
you talk web scraping we're talking
beautiful suit which is a package you
add into your python that you're running
and we can come over here to the website
www.crumi.com software beautiful soup
you can actually read a little bit about
it currently beautiful soup 4 is the
current version if you don't remember
the full website for you can always do
what I do which just go over and do a
search for beautiful soup official site
it almost always comes up right at the
top and you click on there and it'll
take you to the crummy.com software site
for beautiful soup now we're going to
use our whatever python interface you
want IDE I'm going to use Jupiter lab
which is built on Jupiter notebook
through Anaconda so when I open up my
anaconda Navigator you'll see that I
have my different tools available again
you might be using a different editor
and that's okay you might be in pie
charm or something like that we don't
need to do this and Jupiter lab is
Jupiter notebook with added tabs and
some added features it's basically in
beta testing so it's got a few little
glitches when you're saving things and
moving between projects but for the most
part it's a great upgrade to the jupyter
notebook and you can use them together
so you don't have to I mean it's built
on jupyter notebooks anything you do in
jupyter Notebook you can open up in
Jupiter lab and the first thing we need
to do is we need to go ahead in this
case I'm going under my environments
since it partitions the environments out
and I'm going to open up a terminal when
though we have to install some packages
in here to work with now there's a lot
of choices on this I because of the
Simplicity we'll be using conda install
now you can use pip install for the same
thing and we're going to install our
beautiful soup 4. you have to type out
the whole thing beautiful soup four and
you can use a pip install if you're
using a different environment and I am
using python version 3.6 although
according to beautiful soup they also
work on three seven all the way from two
seven through all of 3x now according to
the beautiful suit website the Beautiful
4 works on anything you can install
anything from python 2 7 all the way
through any of the Python 3 versions
this just happens to be python36 because
they do it there's a lot of other
packages that don't work on three seven
yet and we'll go ahead and run this
install on here and let it go through
its environmental setup and of course
with con it goes in there and finds all
the dependencies PIP doesn't do as much
as far as finding dependencies but you
know exactly what's on there with Pip so
if you're doing a huge distribution you
probably want to use your pip install so
you can track what's going on there with
the conda I like to just let it take
over since this isn't a major
distributed package going out another
quick note between pip and conda is that
if you start on a project in one of
these environments and you're using pip
in there stick with Pip if you're using
conda stick with conda they track the
packages and you can run into some
issues where they're not tracking the
same packages and something gets
overwritten so it's important to stay
very consistent with your install on
your environments and we'll also need to
go ahead and install all our numpy
environment and our pandas on here so go
ahead and do that if you haven't added
those packages in go ahead and install
those into your environment that you're
working in and of course pandas is just
simply install pandas and let's just
install a couple more packages in this
case let's get our install our map plot
library because we're going to plot at
the end since we're going to be
collecting data and for this project
that will be all the packages we'll need
so we can go ahead and close out of our
installer or whatever setup you have and
we'll go back to home and we'll just
launch our Jupiter lab and that will
open up in our browser window now if
you're coming from Jupiter notebooks the
first time in lab we can go ahead and
just create our first notebook python3
you can also do it under a file launcher
and you'll see new notebook it
automatically opens up and we can just
click right on there it'll pop open on
the left and I'll right click this and
we'll rename this we'll rename it just
beautiful and it is a ipin file on there
so I should look for familiar because
that's the Jupiter notebook file this is
a new one now I have multiple tabs and
in the past I usually hid this on the
other computer all my notes for the
lesson today but this is my notes going
down and we'll go ahead and just start
going through this and see what it looks
like to do a data pull from front to end
and see how that works as a data
scientist pulling that information in
from the website and the first thing I
want to do is I want to go ahead and
close the side window that way it looks
get the nice full screen and we can also
up to size a little bit one of the
wonderful things about working in a
browser window just do that control plus
thing the packages we talked about is
pandas so we imported our pan as if you
haven't already that's our data frame if
you haven't done our pandas tutorial
definitely worthy of the time to go
through there and understand pandas
because it's such a powerful tool this
basically turns your data into a
spreadsheet data frame our numpy is our
number array so it kind of works with
pandas very closely as far as
manipulating data in arrays map plot we
want to go ahead and bring that in our
PLT so that we can plot the data at the
end and this line right here that says
matplot Library inline is for the
Jupiter notebook specifically it tells
it to print that on this page a lot of
the newer versions don't actually
require to have that line they'll still
print it on the page we should still
include that if you're in the Jupiter
lab setup and then we have our URL
library.request we're going to import
URL open for opening up the website and
then we have our bs4 that's your
beautiful soup 4 we're going to import
beautiful suit and then our last one is
our re that is for manipulating our
regular Expressions so when you get to
that part of importing our data we have
to do a lot of reformatting so it's
something we can use and the re is one
of those tools we'll go ahead and run
this and just bring all that in so this
is all imported all these packages are
now into our web scraping program we're
going to run now if we're going to dive
in and pull data we should have a nice
website to pull from and and let's go
ahead and we'll use the hubbertiming.com
results for the 2018 Martin Luther King
race and if we take this you can
actually just take this where did we get
this from well you can go in here and
find the website you're going to scrape
from and you'll see right here it says
you just copy that link right in there
that HTTP and this is the website that
we're looking at you can see right here
all the information that we're looking
at let's say we wanted to run some
statistics on this it sure would be nice
to be able to pull it off of here and if
they don't have a direct API that means
we need to pull it from their website
some of these will have a download
although if you've ever done it we have
a download click and maybe you're paging
through a hundred websites in one case I
was pulling all the different United
States bills that are passed to track
who voted on them for a project and you
can imagine that there's you know
hundreds and hundreds of those thousands
of these documents that they voted on
who voted on it goes to the Senate goes
back to the Congress so I opened up a
website pull all the links on Alpha
there that matches certain criteria and
we'll look at that in just a minute how
we go through the HTML and then I had to
reformat them or I could hand download
each one one at a time which would just
be a nightmare so it's nice to automate
it in this case we're going to be
pulling up this chart we want to figure
out how to pull this chart off of this
website and so we go back into our
jupyter notebook I've got my URL just um
our name for it and it's just a string
that's all this is nothing fancy there
you'll notice that on the slashes we now
have forward forward slash you can do a
single forward and HTTP is a double
forward this is just how you have to
switch it to match setup in there and
then it's going to go ahead and use the
HTML equals URL open URL and that's from
our URL Library request so it's opening
a link to that website or at least
pointing to it and if we run this this
just sets it up so this is all set up
and then once we've done our setup let's
go ahead and create an object called
soup this will be and if you remember up
here here's our beautiful soup that we
imported from the bs4 and this is the
package that we're working with and so
we're going to do our beautiful soup on
here and on this we need to go ahead and
send it our HTML so it knows what it's
opening and then the second part is we
have to tell it how the format is coming
in and the most common one for your HTML
polls is an L XML setup and so almost
all of them you'll end up using the lxml
there's a few other options and because
this is so common in the newer versions
a lot of times they just leave it out
just because it's already on the default
we'll go ahead and leave it in here just
to remind us that it's there we'll go
ahead and run that and on the newer
versions uh they actually default it to
the XML setup and the HTML we'll just
leave it out and call it HTML so it's
just going to pull from this URL and
when we run that on here we've now
created an object soup that has pulled
the website into it so soup contains the
information along with information on
that website and what's going on so
let's just go over what we did real
quick before we start digging into the
actual suit before we start scooping out
stuff we imported our different modules
that we're going to use with our package
specifically the beautiful soup we did
install the beautiful soup remember
correctly you have to call it beautiful
soup four specifically so it knows what
you're bringing in and this line right
here is very key from bs4 because that's
how it installs the module we're
importing our beautiful soup and then we
found our URL in this case we're going
to go pull information from The Martin
Luther King dream run and then we set
our HTML to our URL open URL and you can
see right here we imported that so
here's our url.request import URL open
so we're requesting a connection and
once we send that connection into the
beautiful soup it creates an object
called suit and then this one of course
we chose soup just because it goes with
beautiful soup I guess we could have
chosen beautiful and now we can start
extracting information from our website
because we've pulled it down onto our
computer under soup now we can start by
looking at the title of the website soup
dot title total and if we print title
dot text you'll see this a lot in
beautiful suit because title contains
all kinds of information and if we want
just the text from that title you add
the dot text on the end and you can see
right here we have our 2018 MLK dream
Run 5K race results if you look at the
tab that's the actual title up here 2018
MLK dream Run 5K race that's what the
title is on the website and then you
might be curious what's in title what's
the whole title that it's storing up
there well let's go ahead and print it
out here's print title and print
title.txt and we run that you can see it
has the HTML tags title on it and then
the forward slash title to end it and so
we're really just pulling off this piece
of the HTML code and then we look at the
text inside that particular part of the
HTML and earlier I mentioned links what
if you want to get all the links off
this page well that would fun we could
do soup Dot and we'll do find underscore
all put this in bracket and then
quotation marks we're going to put a a
is the key find and you'll start seeing
a div and all the different options you
have for finding these entities in a
website and then let's go ahead and just
print our links and you can see here
that it now shows all the different
links in here that are marked by eggs we
did a find all a and then we can also
because this is a little bit hard to
pull off the H reference so we can also
add in our find all fine tune that in
this case the H reference equals true
will actually filter that out and then
finally we might do a four link in links
and we can simply do something like this
for each link we want to actually find
the H reference because we know there's
an H reference in it and if I run this
you can see it just comes through and
prints them out one at a time some of
these are really useful so you might be
looking for something that has https in
it and you know that's a link running to
something else or you might be looking
for for the male 2 tags you know that's
all the mail addresses but either way
you can easily find all the links in
your HTML document that you're paging
through and of course any packages that
have evolved over time you can also do
link dot get H reference which should do
the same thing as our other format and
you can see it certainly does we get the
same print out up here in this
particular case we really want to get
the data off the page so let's go ahead
and do that let's see what that looks
like and in data let's call it all rows
there we go equals and then we have our
soup dot find underscore all there's our
brackets and then if we're looking for
each row in a database you'll remember
your HTML code we're looking for the tag
TR so we want to find all TR and we can
take this let's go ahead and just take
all our rows and do a print all rows and
about this time you're going to guess
that we're going to get a huge amount of
information just dumped onto our page
and sure enough we do if you look at
this it just kind of goes on forever but
this is an array each row is considered
an array so because of that we can do
something simply as putting brackets and
just print the first let's do the first
five rows so from beginning to five and
you can see here's our first five rows
on here I sometimes like to just do
let's just do row zero and we see that
row zero is finishers finisher is 191
and just out of curiosity which if
that's zero what's Row one male okay so
we're starting to see titles going
across here so if we come up here and we
do rows we did what up to ten let's just
take a look and see what 10 does again
and just take a look at that information
that comes across Place uh bib name
gender age city state chip chip paste
gender and so on so it comes all the way
down here we kind of have an ending
right here and then we have one and then
we actually it looks like we start to
have information so we have our one our
one 1191 Max Randolph that must be the
name male 29 and so on you start seeing
how they come information starts getting
displayed going down so the next thing
we want to do with this I'll go back up
here and just edit the space we're in so
it starts to make a little bit more
sense keep it all together and so we
want to do for each row in all rows
we're looking at what information are we
looking at well we have our th up here
that's the header our TD down here which
looks like the individual information
and we really are looking for the actual
data so we're looking for our TD tags in
the rows and we can do that because when
remember when it stores the row it also
stores the tags underneath that so all
rows have all the different tags in it
and you can see right here as you print
each one of those out and so we look at
each row we can create another variable
and we'll call it row list and we'll set
this equal to in this case row because
we've already pulled all the rows out of
soup so now we want to find for each row
and in there we want to find our TD and
if we go ahead and just print I'm going
to do it if you notice I changed the
indent so I'm just going to print row
list what this does is the last value to
go into row list our last row is going
to print now and of course make sure you
have an underscore instead of a period
when you're typing so row dot find
underscore all TD and if we print the
last row you can see I have all the data
coming across here we have our 191 our
1216 Zuma Oak choa I hope I said that
right female I believe that's age 40 and
so on and then we can take our row list
and there's a lot of things we can do
with the row list but we'll do for let's
do object or let's just do cell in row
list and so we're going to look at each
cell because this is if you look at this
they have commas separated between the
different objects and then we're going
to go ahead and print cell dot text
let's just take a look and see what that
looks like and we can see here for each
row we get 191 there's our 191 there's
our 12 16 12 16 our individual who's in
the race and so forth all the way down
for those different settings and let's
go ahead and create a new variable up
here we'll call this all let's just call
it data we'll keep it simple so here's
our data and then we have our row we
take our row we break it up into
individual cells so we'll call this data
row we'll set this empty to an empty row
and we're going to take our cells to
have this we know that each cell
generates a text and so what we want to
do is I want to take my data row let's
just replace that let's take our data
row and let's append our cell dot text
so I'm going to add the each row is
going to be a row of the different text
on here and then once I create each row
I want my data which is going to be
everything to append each row and here's
our data row and then if we go ahead and
come down here and let's just print data
now if we were working with large data
we'd be very careful about just throwing
all our data on the page but you can see
here we throw the data on the page and
we get finishers 199 male 78 female 113
one and so on and if you look at this
this is the headers on the file we have
finishers uh male females just like some
general statistics on the first one and
then we have actually
an empty data set and then we have our
data that continues which actually the
actual information we're looking for so
we have 1 1191 Max Randolph Mill 29
Washington DC runtime one of 78 and so
on on here so we could really quickly
get rid of that a number of different
ways to do that one of them is just to
do we're going to set we do data two on
we should get rid of everything but we
want to keep Rand off so make sure
Randolph is in there oh we lost Randolph
let's try one on there we go there's Max
Randolph on there so we can just simply
do redo our data on here and we can do
data probably want to do do it in all
rows from one on but I'm just going to
do my data equals data one on down here
there's reasons to split it this way in
data science sometimes you don't want to
touch the original data in case you need
it in case we do need the first row so
we'll put it down here and maybe we'll
just call this titles titles equals data
of zero and so we could do something
here where we print we'll print up our
titles and we'll print our data in this
case instead of one on let's go minus
two let's look at the last two rows of
data so here we have our titles and for
some reason just put in finishers of 191
I was expecting a little bit more up
there and we have our last couple people
and they look like the data on these
looks just fine on here turns out this
is just some generic statistics up here
so we'll get rid of titles completely it
doesn't really do us any good but we
know that data comes in here and we can
look at our data and look at the very
end of the data too the minus 2 to the
end and we can see it pulls the data in
pretty good it we don't have anything
too funky in here we're looking at it
looks pretty clean they got to be a
little careful because at some point we
might have to come back here and clean
up the data if we get an error if we're
running data analysis we might find out
there's some unusual characters or
something is missed set in the data
itself and you also notice that
everything is a string so when we're
bringing it in we might have to do some
conversions to test it out and convert
them to whatever kind of data format
we're working with so at this time we
want to go ahead and bring in our pandas
and let's go ahead and call this DF for
data frame we'll set it equal to and if
you remember correctly we imported
pandas as PD and that's standard you'll
see that in most code examples where
they call it they import pandas is PD
and it is capital D capital F for data
frame and we're just going to bring in
our data that's what we called it on
here and let's take this and we'll print
now when you're working with data frames
you're usually talking large amounts of
data and so you almost never want to
print the whole data frame out we're
going to go ahead and do that anyway
just so we can see what that looks like
and you can see in here brings in our
data frame coming in here and we just
have a mess of information this is our
data let's go ahead and print DF and see
what that looks like in the data frame
and this is nice because it organizes it
into a very easy to read table and we
have they set the label 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
and so on and then we have each row we
have Mel 78 none none going across when
we get all the way down here we'll see
Max Randall about number three and the
first thing this does is this Flags me
that I brought in a bunch of information
up here that we really didn't want it's
from 3 on that we want and we can clean
this up in one of two ways we can try to
clean it up under the data or we can
clean it up under the data frame
depending on what it is we're trying to
do and so to fix this I want to go ahead
and just change it up here in the actual
data pull in we don't need that
information so rerun it reload our data
from for on and then when I run this we
see we have Max Randolph is right at the
top of the list like he should be and we
have all the data going down now with
the data frame remember I said we don't
usually print the whole data frame we'll
go ahead and do df.head and this prints
the first five rows and you can see that
we have 13 columns here's Max Randall
all the way to Theo kinman and I use the
also print DF tell and the reason I like
to do these particular two setups I'm
going to change it just to two rows
because you can do that you can put as
many rows as you want is this good to
look at the first part and the end
because those are usually where you have
extra data brought in something's messed
up and you can also see that we have 190
rows in here and it comes in with our
Zuma Alicia and they're both on here on
the list so now we have a nice data
frame columns and rows we can easily
look at it we can see the setup button
here and we can look at the names and
everything now at some point you might
be looking at these individual columns
and find different information that
needs to be re-edited if you can you try
to do it with the whole column under
pandas you can up in the upper part of
the code where you went from cell to
cell or row to row you could look at
individual cells maybe find a marker in
that cell that's something specific like
remove all colons or semicolons or
something in there are brackets so
there's a lot of options in there but
you'll find that this one actually comes
in pretty clean on here all the way down
and the next thing we really want to do
is we want to look at the headers I
don't know about you but doesn't make
any sense to me when I have column one I
don't know what 1191 is or 1080 need
name Kaiser Runner I'm guessing that's
column two as names third one it looks
like male or female probably age but I
don't want to guess I want this to bring
in my column so I know exactly what I'm
looking at so how can we make beautiful
soup do that for us well let's take our
column headers and we're going to set
that equal to our soup find underscore
all and then we're going to look for our
headers our th files and since we're in
Jupiter lab in this case Jupiter
notebook I can just type out column
headers if it's a last variable I have
listed it will automatically print it so
it's kind of a shorthand and we can see
right here we have place I'm guessing
that's bib name gender age city state
chip time chip pace and so on so we have
all our headers right there I shouldn't
have to type them all in and we'll go
ahead and do it before we'll go ahead
and do a header list equals our empty
array and then we can do for a column in
column headers and we can take our
header list in just a pin and what do we
want we want the text from the column so
we'll just do column dot text and then
if we come down here and we print our
header list let's see what that looks
like if we did it right we should get a
nice list of all the different column
headings we want so we have placebib
name and so on and then pandas just
because pandas is so cool we can simply
do DF columns equals our header from our
header list we can simply set DF columns
set to DF headers and then if I print
df.hit we'll take a look at that and
we'll see right here it has nicely
placed our values on here Place bib name
gender age and so on so very quickly
we've created this nice data frame we
have the data displayed in nice rows and
columns and easy to read and then as a
data scientist the first thing we want
to know is the info what is in these
columns and rows and headers and you see
right here they all come up with
non-null object there's a big flag so if
I want to do anything with this these
are all coming through as strings or an
object I usually mean strings in this
case that they're a string variable and
we have you can quickly read through
this 191 entries date columns total 14
columns there's a total of 14 columns in
the data and it shows you all the
different names and what type of column
they are and it's probably good also to
look at the shape of the data df.shape
we'll go ahead and just run that you see
it's 191 by 14 14 columns 191 entries
this is more like a we look at a numpy
array 191 by 14 for the shape and
remember this is a variable so if I put
it on if it's a last variable or last
value in the set of cells Jupiter
automatically prints it out so if you're
in a different IDE you want to go ahead
and use the print statement on here and
then one of the things you'd want to
also go through we'll create a second
one df2 equals DF dot drop in a now the
axis is automatically equal to zero so a
lot of times you'll see something like
X's equals zero comma How equals any
axis equals zero is default that means
we're looking at going down the rows you
could look at the column going across
let's remove the how index that's just
going to confuse you the axis is is
whether you're going down the columns or
if you're looking at a row by row by row
by row or you could be looking at it by
column by column by column this would
drop any column and it would drop off
the N A in any column and how equals and
we want any I always confuse all in any
because they both start with a all means
that all of them have to be non-value
where any means that any of them can be
there to drop it so this would drop any
column with a null value in it but we
want zero and it'll drop any value with
an null value and then because 0 is
always the default we'll just leave it
out and then as curious as to what the
shape is now did we lose anything was
there any null values in our df2 that we
draw from the DF and we'll go ahead and
run that and we see 191 and 14. so we
didn't really drop anything but it's
always good to check there's other ways
you can also do are there let's see any
Nas you can detect Nas in here no values
infinite values that's another one you
got to watch out for we're working with
data that we're going to do something
with here in a minute so you got to be a
little careful also in the conversions
are you going to convert something where
people typed in weird characters to
describe the data a certain way so now
we've got to this point where we have
all our different columns we have our
different data and at this point maybe
you're asking or maybe the shareholder
the company is asking hey can we look at
the based on the chip time here's our
chip time can we plot that versus gender
how does gender versus chip time compare
and so we can do that we can take that
and the first thing we look at is we say
hey well chip time came in as a string
and that's going to be an issue now
there's a number of ways you can change
this one of them is we could go all the
way back up here where we created the
data and find a way to tag it and say
Hey whenever this cell text maybe
instead of appending this I notice that
anytime there's two colons in it that's
probably a time signature and let's uh
convert all the time signatures to date
time filled or whatever A lot of times
you don't get that you don't get that
option and that's always a question in
bringing in data whether you convert the
data coming in at the beginning or do
you wait till you have it open it up and
then convert it when you go to use it
we're going to go ahead and convert it
after we got it into our data frame so
we have our df2 here we've dropped all
of our Nas we dropped our we have a
shape in fact let's do this since
there's no difference between DF and df2
well we'll just go ahead and use df2 so
let's go ahead and take our df2 and we
want to take those that specific field
and convert it into some kind of
numerical value we can use and let's add
another column A lot of times this is
something you want to do is where you
want to go ahead and keep all the
original columns and just add a new
column in there and this new column is
going to be based on the if you remember
correctly we had chip time that's what
we're going to look at okay we want chip
time versus gender if we go into our
pandas we find out we have uh pandas two
Delta and this is actually time Delta
and then we just want to take our df2
and we're going to use the chip time
column so this is going to say hey let's
look at let's convert everything in df2
chip time into a Time Delta format
that's the data type we're going to put
it as let me go ahead and just run this
and if we go in here and we do info df2
and we'll keep our we're going to look
at this particular column but we want to
keep it as a data frame so this is a
list of all the columns we want to look
at and we'll just do that info on here
and run that and we do an info on that
you can see it's now a Time Delta 64
nanoseconds well we really don't want
nanoseconds we actually probably want to
do it in minutes so let's take a look at
that and let's take this whole thing TF2
let's just set the df2 we have our df2
this is a column we're working with here
and we can use the as type property in
pandas and so we can set this equal to
df2 we'll take our same column in here
and we'll set it as type time Delta
second so it's still a Delta time here
so if I run this you'll see that it
still comes up as where is it oh it
turns it into a float so we're now at a
float 64 so it's the number of seconds
in that Delta time and then finally we
want to go ahead and turn that from
seconds to say minutes and you know
there's 60 seconds in minutes and so now
we divide by 60 we still have a float we
have our info it shows us it's a float
and then we can go ahead and just do a
print df2 and let's just keep it small
we don't want to look at all our data we
just want to do the head of it and we
run this and you can see right here
where we go to it'll be the last one
here's our chip time in minutes and a
lot of times just to make life easy for
viewing we're only looking at this
particular element we can do chip time
in minutes and now we just see that oops
we tick off we'll go ahead and take off
our info done with that and we'll run
this and you can see we have our minutes
16.8 minutes 17.51 minutes and so on
it's a float number now keep in mind
this is 0.8 that's not a 16 minutes and
80 Seconds they can always throw you if
you're going through so many numbers you
forget it's important to remember that
and we're also going to look at the
other one we're looking at is what
gender you want to look at gender to
chip time in minutes and so we can see
here under the head we get mail mail and
a number of different setups and this
switch this to tail real quick and just
look at the end of it and here we have
female female male female female so we
have two different genders and we have
our chip time in minutes and if you
remember we brought in our PLT if you
haven't used the plot Library the
matplot library you have a drawing place
you're putting stuff on so we have our
PLT we're going to do a bar graph and we
just want to Simply use our Di to gender
and df2 Chip time in minutes so that's
going to plot the two bars and to make
it pretty we'll go ahead and give it the
X label gender the Y label chip time
minutes and that simply is remember it
always plots X and the plots Y and we
have our gender our chip time give it a
nice title a comparison of average
minutes run by male and female and if we
go ahead and run this with the correct
titles in here and everything matches
you'll get a nice graph we can see here
the comparison of average minutes run by
male and female here's our chip time in
minutes the men seem to be Slackers in
this particular case and it's actually
uh there's a number of studies that show
that women team tend to have as far as
doing cross-country there's a lot of
women who have a longer endurance than
men so it's not too surprising we can
see here the average chip time around 70
and for women over a hundred minutes and
then another really cool thing we can do
is we can describe the data so
df2.describe this again is a pandas
function just like info is and we're
going to include a NP number the numpy
number and if we run that you'll see
here comes up it says chip time in
minutes a count it gives you the average
or the mean standard deviation the
minimum the maximum all the different
descriptive information you're going to
want from your data set on there and
just because there's all kinds of fun
ways let's do a box plot to display your
information we can do a box plot where
the column equals chip time in minutes
and let's go ahead and run that keep
mistyping my chip time in minutes you
can see it puts out a nice box plot
showing you the information we have our
different values and floaters this is
always interesting because this is a
nice way of seeing where we have these
floaters one up here and there's two up
above and of course here they're a nice
spread on the box plot and we can also
modify this a little bit and we can add
in buy equals gender and then we'll give
it a we'll just give it a blank title I
don't know why we're gonna get a blank
title uh we'll just add a y plot y label
on there for runtime and if we run this
you can see here box plot Group by gen
inner chip time in minutes and now we
have our female and male two different
areas and you can see how they vary you
have your two different your outlier up
here and you can also see how there's
such an overlap between the two
different values so if I was looking at
this I'd be like wow you know I really
could not draw a conclusive thing on
this saying that Women's Run time was
more in general because they overlapped
too much that would be one of the
conclusions I'd have to come up with on
here and then we get to maybe the
partners come in from the company and
say hey we'd like to know the age versus
chip time in minutes that'd be something
worth knowing on the statistics on this
and the first thought is we can simply
plot it and we can do this we can
actually plot the scatter plot chip time
versus a df2 of H those are X Y
coordinates but if you remember from df2
we did the info let's go way back up
here we're looking at a data object as
far as our chip time on this and our age
now we converted the chip time but we
also need to convert the age and if we
do it right here we just plot it and
it'll actually let us plot it it
shouldn't it should give us an error but
it does let us plot it you'll see the
Ages come up a mess over here because
they're converting it to weird float
numbers and all kinds of things so what
we want to do is we want to take our age
and we'll just call this H underscore I
so we're going to take our age and we're
going to create another column for df2
age underscore I and the I is just going
to stand for integer it's our own choice
of values there is a number of ways to
do this but we're going to do pandas to
Merrick is the best way in pandas and
the reason we're doing this is that
numeric creates a float value so right
off the bat we want all our stuff
converted converts it to the least
common denominator so if they're all
integers already you'll get integers as
you can see from here it's doing some
kind of conversion that converts it to a
float value the other thing that numeric
does is if there is a null value or they
put in like a blank line or a dash to
represent no information it'll convert
it to a null so it goes from like a
string to a null versus just having some
kind of made up number that python
somehow created for the graph we have
below and then we want to add our df2h
because that's what we're converting to
numeric and then we want to coerce it
and there's a couple different options
on this like you can have it where it
just doesn't process it in pandas but
coerce means that if it gets a weird
value that is a null value now and since
we're dealing with errors this is what
happens when you get an error converting
it we want to coerce it there we go and
put the end bracket on there and then
finally we want to go and round this off
so we'll put brackets around all the way
around it and this rounds off everything
in this series so we've done here is
I've taken df2h which is a d-type object
which in this case is mostly strings
with a couple of blank ones in there and
we're going to convert it to a numeric
which will automatically go to float and
then we're going to take wherever
there's an error wherever it says hey
this doesn't convert and usually that's
a blank screen like I said I've worked
with so many databases where they
someone puts down none someone types in
space sometimes into Dash to mean none
and you get this really weird conversion
coming up this covers all of that in
pandas so it's really a nice way of just
coercing it and saying hey if we don't
have a number in there let's make it a
null value and then we're going to round
it off and then finally let's go ahead
and take our df2 here's our df2 and
let's drop those null values drop in a
and we want how how equals any so that
means if there's any null values in the
data set now you can be this might get
you in trouble because you might have no
values in a different column and so you
might lose data that way at this point
we could also do like certain parts of
like Drop just certain columns with null
values there's all kinds of other
options in here but we're just going to
do how we're going to just drop any and
we want to do it in line equals true so
that means it's going to reassign it to
df2 so df2 now has rounded out so it's
rounded to the integer we didn't do any
places the age and it's going to be age
I and then we've dropped all our null
values that way we're not going to get
any errors and we try to plot a null
value and it also makes sure sure that
data by deleting out the rows because
that's what this does it automatically
does axis0 which is your rows axes one
is your columns by doing this it
automatically removes all the rows with
null values so it just cleans out the
roles and then when we go ahead and plot
this we see we have a nice clean data
and we have age all the way up to 70. so
we have our chip time set and then our
age going across and it makes a nice
plot that you can easily show for
display and for the the and you can
easily show that to your shareholders or
whatever group you're working on it
makes it really nice and quick easy
display in this session we will discuss
the top tips and tricks in Python that
you can use to solve your problems first
let's understand what python really is
so python is a high level open source
programming language developed in 1989
by Guido van rosu
it has simple easy to use syntax
python can run on different platforms
such as Windows Linux and Unix
it has a large collection of libraries
and can be integrated with other
programming languages such as C C plus
plus and Java
companies use Python for web development
software development statistical
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
python tips and tricks will help you
optimize the code and reduce your time
and effort while writing codes for
solving problems
these tips and tricks are usually sought
Snippets or python code with simple
illustrations to tell you how you can
perform a complex task easily
it can also serve as examples that allow
you to dive deep into understanding and
exploring how each concept works and
where it can be used
so in this video we'll be covering the
tips and tricks based on python lists
tuples sets and dictionaries we'll also
see how to effectively use loops
iterators and collections in Python
so let me take you to my jupyter
notebook where I'll show you the
different tips and tricks
so here is my jupyter notebook
so let's begin with our first trick
if you want to initialize a list or a
tuple filled with repetitive strings or
numbers written in the form of a string
we can do that using the multiplication
operator
so let me show you
so first I'll declare a list suppose a
is equal to within square brackets I'll
declare a string suppose
India
and now if I use the multiplication
operator and suppose I say 10
then I'll print a
so this will print India 10 times if I
hit shift enter it will run that cell
you can see we have printed India 10
times
similarly
let's add another element to our list
or another item to our list
say India and then we have
friends
I'll use the multiplication operator and
apply 10 so let me print my list again
for hit shift enter you can see India
and France have been printed 10 times
also
you can use
an integer as a string
and print as many times as you want
suppose I am printing 20 five times
I'll use the print statement
you can see we have printed 25 times
but if I pass an integer as my first
operand
it will result in the product of the two
numbers so for example if I use c equal
to
20 into 5
and if I print C
it will give me the product of 20 and 5
that is 100.
next let's see how you can reverse the
elements in a list for that we'll use
the list slicing method
let me first show you how you can
reverse a string
I'll declare my list as list 1 is equal
to
and inside this list I'll
pass in a few country names such as
India then we have
USA
let's say we have friends
and then
Germany
and finally we have Spain now if you
want to reverse the order of this list
you can use the slicing method inside
the print statement so I'll write print
and I'll pass in my list that is list
one
and I'll use
double colon
followed by
-1 so this will read my list from the
end
so if I hit shift enter you can see we
have reversed our original list so now
this pane comes first then Germany
France us and India
likewise you can also reverse
a list of numbers
so
let's reverse a list of numbers
suppose this time I'll use list 2 is
equal to
I'll pass in few integers say 100
200 300 and 400. now if I
print
my list
to
using colon colon -1 it will reverse
list two
you can see we have reversed our
original list two so now 400 comes first
then 300 200 and 100.
now let me tell you how you can print
the elements in a list in any order that
you prefer suppose I have a list that
has values like 1 comma two three and
four
then I'll print this list
after that I'll use four variables
such as e comma B comma C comma d
and assign it to our list
after that let me go ahead and print
any order that I want for example I'll
use B comma e comma D comma C
and hit shift enter you can see we have
printed our list in the order that we
wanted
so basically what this cell does is
we have assigned the value 1 from list
to a 2 to B 3 to C and 4 to D and we are
printing in an order B ADC
so this is the result you can see
now suppose you want to print in some
other order like
say I want C first
then I want B
a and then d
so this is the output
up next
we will discuss list comprehensions in
Python so list comprehension is an
effective way to define and create new
lists based on existing lists
so suppose you want to extract and
separate all the letters from the word
simply learn and add letters as items of
a list ideally you would use a for Loop
to do this task
so let's see how you can perform this
task using a for Loop I'll assign an
empty list say letters
is equal to I'll use square brackets to
assign my empty list
then
and declare a for Loop so suppose for I
in
I'll pass in my string that is simply
learn
and
I'll append the letters
using the append function
now let me go ahead and
print the letters
if I hit shift enter you can see
this will print all individual letters
present in the word simply learn
but the same job
you can do it easily with the help of
list comprehensions
so let me show you how to do that
first I'll declare a variable say
letters
is equal to inside square brackets I'll
write
I for
I in my string
simply learn
then I'll just
print the letters
you can see we have extracted all the
letters from the word simply learn
so this is how we use list comprehension
now similarly
if you were to find the square of
numbers you would like to create a user
defined function or use a for Loop to do
it so let me show you how you can
proceed
so
we were to define a function so first
I'll import
the math module present in Python
and then let's see I am defining a
function called Square
and I'll pass in a parameter as a
then I'll write e is equal to
I'll use the power function so I'll
first give in my module name that is
math and use the power function that is
pow
and I'll pass in my parameter that is a
and since we want to find the square
I'll give in 2
and I'll return my parameter that is a
if I hit shift enter now we have
successfully run our user defined
function now let me call that function
if I write
square of a
does given me 1 by default
so suppose I want to find the square
of integer 5
you can see it has given us the square
of 5 that is 25
now to find the square of a number you
can also create an empty list and use a
for Loop to iterate through a sequence
of numbers and append the square of
numbers to that empty list
so let me show you how you can do with
this process suppose I
declare an empty list called squares
I'll pass in my empty list
and then I'll use a for Loop say for
example for
I in
range
I'll give 10 as my range
and then
I'll append my Square value so I'll
pass in my empty list that is squares
Dot
append
so I'll use Quest dot append
and pass I into I
and then
I'll just
call my empty list squares if I hit
shift enter you can see
from 0 to 9 that is a range of 10 values
it has printed all the squares of those
integers
now these two methods that we just
discussed need at least three to four
lines of code but by using a list
comprehension you can find the square of
numbers in just a single line of code
so let's use a list comprehension to
find square of five whole numbers
between 0 and 20 having an interval of
4.
so I'll use
squares
is equal to
I'll say X
double multiplication operator
into 2 for
X in
say range
I'll pass in my range that is from 0 to
with an interval of 4.
now I'll
print squares
if I hit shift enter you can see it has
printed the square of values so first
the number is 0 so 0 square is 0 then
the number was 4 so 4 square is 16 8
square is 64. then 12 square is 144 and
then 16 square is 256.
moving ahead in the next trick
I'll show you how you can keep track of
the index positions and the items in a
list
so for that we will use the enumerate
function to print the item values along
with the index positions
so let's say I have a list
that has items
say
294 I am taking random integers
450 and say 243
and now if I
user print statement suppose
I'll write using the
enumerate function
then I'll use a for Loop say for example
for
index comma
element
in
enumerate
I'll pass in my list that is list
underscore items
after that
I'll use a print statement
I'll pass in index
and then I'll give
a list and that will have my
index
followed by
the value
I'll use another comma and pass in the
element
now if I hit shift enter you can see we
have printed the index position as well
as the item value so at index 0 we have
310 at index 1 we have 294 similarly for
index 2 and 3
now moving ahead
let us understand how we can convert two
less into a dictionary so a dictionary
as you must be aware comes with a key
value pair
you can use the dictionary method and
pass the zip function with our list as
parameters
so let me Define our two lists say item
number and names
so I'll use item number
and give him some random whole numbers
and let's say 321
and I'll use my second list
that is names and let's say this list
has
some string values like phone
next is laptop
and then we have say tablet
now
I'll
assign a variables item
dictionary
is equal to I'll use the dict function
and then pass in zip
and I'll pass in my parameters item
number and names
finally I'll print
my newly created dictionary that is item
dictionary
now let me run it
so you can see we have a dictionary
created out of the list
so our keys are 102 410 and 321 and the
item values are phone laptop and tablet
now you can check that in the following
way so I'll
pass in my dictionary
and then I'll use the keys function to
get the keys from the dictionary so you
see we have all the keys printed
similarly if you want to print the
values from the dictionary
I'll use the values function
so that will print all the values you
can see we have phone laptop and tablet
now we look at how you can find the
common elements in two lists
so let me declare my first list as list
underscore e that will be equal to
Davis
then let's say we have Karen
then we have John
we have Frank next and then let's see we
have another person say Steve
and let me declare my list B so list
underscore B
is equal to I'll take care in
next we have Davis
then suppose we have Jack
up next we have
George
and then say we have Steve again
now to find the common elements I'll use
variable let's say common
and I'll again
use a list comprehension say a for
e in
list a
then use for
B in
list B
then I'll use an if Clause so if E
equals to equals to B
then
I'll
print the common variable
if I run this you can see we have the
common elements printed from both the
list A and B so Davis kerin and Steve
are present in both list A and B
next let's see how you can remove the
duplicate items in a list such problems
you would often come across while doing
data analytics so the idea is very
simple just need to convert the items in
a list into a set
so that will remove all the duplicate
items in a list
so suppose I have a list of numbers
let me take random whole numbers 20 22
24 so 26
then we have 28 repeated twice
and then again suppose we have 20
then we have 22
and let's see we have 30.
now
let me go ahead and print my list
so I'll say original list
equals to
and then I'll pass in my
list that is list numbers
after that
I'll convert my list that is list
numbers
into a set
so I'll first use the list function and
then inside of that I'll pass in my set
function and then declare
my list
that is list numbers
finally I'll
print my new list so I'll type list
after
removing duplicates
that will be equal to
I'll give a comma and then pass in my
variable
that is list numbers
if I run it you can see our original
list has all the elements that has
duplicate values and the final list the
output you can see we have only the
unique elements printed
moving on
now let's have a look at how you can
merge two dictionaries
so there are two methods to do this
before that let's see how the code would
have looked like had you merged the
dictionaries using python 2 version or
Python 3.4 version and below
so let's see I have two dictionaries say
team a
I'll use curly braces to declare my
dictionary
I'll give my key as 1 and I'll take
Davis
I'll give my second key
and see I have Andrew in my team
and then let's say I have my
third key and let's see I have get in
similarly let me declare my
Team B dictionary
I'll take
the next key as 4
and the next person would be
say John
and then
I'll use my fifth key
we have Angela
and let's see I have my final member in
the team the sixth member
who is Suzanne
now
if you do it in Python 2 or Python 3.4
version and below I have to define a
function so let me say Define
merge underscore teams it will be my
function name and I'll pass in two
parameters see dick one
and dict 2
then I have dict three
indict three
I'll use the
copy method so I'll
use dit one
dot copy
then
let me go ahead and
use my dict three
Dot
update
I'll pass in my
dick to
and then
see I'll
return
my dict three
finally
I'll print it so I'll use
merge underscore teams
then pass in my two parameters as team a
comma
TMP
if I run it oops there is a mistake I
have made so this should be dipped to
actually
so let me run it once again you can see
we have merged both our dictionaries
now you can see it has around six to
seven lines of code or even more
now if you want to do this task using
python 3.5 version and above you can use
the update method so let's see how we
can do
I have CE
is equal to
I'll pass in my dictionary
as
a has value of 1.
say B has a value of
let's say B also has a value of 1
and my second dictionary would have
key B again
and it has a value of 2
and Key C
will have a value of 1. now if I write e
Dot
update B
and if I print a
let me run it you can see we have merged
both the dictionaries here
now there's one more method which you
can use let me show you
so I'll copy paste my teammate and Team
B again
and then
let's see I'll declare
another variable called final team
that will be equal to
I'll use curly braces and then say
I'll give two star and then team e
comma
two stars again
and then Team B
then I'll print my
final team if I run it you can see we
have merged both our team A and B and
this is our final team that has
six elements
now before moving to the next trick if
you have enjoyed watching this video so
far then please consider subscribing to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss an update
also if you want to get the source file
I am using in this live session then
please mention your email IDs in the
chat section we'll share the source code
with you over email
now let's move on
similar to a list comprehension you can
also create a dictionary comprehension
let me show you the trick
suppose I want to find the square of
numbers so I'll pass in my variable that
is square
and I'll use my dictionary comprehension
say x comma X
star star 2 this will find the square of
a number
for X in range
C5 so I want the square of the first
five numbers
then let me just call it
you can see it has printed
a dictionary that has the square of
numbers from 0 to 4 that is 5 numbers so
0 square is 0 1 square is 1 2 square is
4 3 square is 9 and 4 square is 16.
now let's see the trick to check if all
the elements in a sequence are true or
false based on a condition
you can do this with the help of all
function all function in Python returns
true if all the items in an iterable are
true otherwise it returns false
so I'll directly use my all function so
I'll say all
now let's see I'll use a variable e
percentage 2 if it's equal to equal to 0
and I'll say for a
in
range
between 0 to 10 with an interval of 2
if I run it
it gives me true
because I have defined my range from 0
to 10 and an interval of 2 so the
numbers will range from 0 to 4 6 8 and
so on
so all these numbers are divisible by 2
and the remainder is 0 so it gives us
true
now if I change the third parameter in
my range function see I'll make it 3 and
I run it it gives me false
up next we look at a common programming
question that you often get to see in
any interview or programming test that
is swapping two numbers
let's see the trick to swap two numbers
in a single line of code
so I'll
declare two numbers c x and y
let's say we have xs10 and by s20
I'll use a print statement
say it before
swap
give a comma and I'll declare my
variables X comma y
now to swap to variables I can simply
use x comma y equal to
y comma X
and then I'll again use a print
statement C
after swap
and I'll write X
equal to
say
X
and
y
will have the variable
if I run it
you see before swap X had 10 and 20 and
after swap you can see we have
X as 20 and bias 10 so we have swapped
the values of the two variables
successfully
now moving on
the next trick I am going to show is how
you can concatenate a list containing
strings so we'll use the join function
for this
let's say I have a list characters
and it has a list of strings
CP comma y
comma
t
comma h
comma o
and we have the final string that is n
now if you were to concatenate all the
list elements
I'll declare a variable called word and
double quotation marks
and then I'll use the dot operator and
join function
I'll pass in my list that is
character
then I'll
print my variable word
below you can see the resultant output
so we have successfully combined or
concatenated each element or item in the
list character so we have python printed
now let me show you how you can find the
most frequently occurring values in a
list
so
I'll declare a list called test and
suppose it has some random whole numbers
C1 comma 2 comma 3
2 comma 2 then we have 3 comma 1 comma
4 comma 4 comma four
I'll use
print statement
and pass in my Max function
then I'll convert the list into
a set
give a comma and then I'll use key is
equal to test dot count
so what it basically does is it will
first count
the number of times each element is
occurring and then
find the maximum value out of it if I
hit shift enter you can see it has given
me 4 which means
the item 4 has occurred the most number
of times in my list you can see we have
four four times
moving forward the next step is how you
can use the if else statement using
ternary operators
ternary operators are commonly known as
conditional expressions in Python these
operators evaluate something based on a
condition being true or false
so I have my two variables e comma B
and it has values
10 and 20 respectively
now if I
use a print statement say both e
and B
are
equal
if
a equals to equals to B
else
a
is
greater than b
if
a greater than
B
else
is
greater
than he
so first I am evaluating this condition
if a
is equal to equal to B then we'll print
both A and B are equal
else if a is greater than b we'll print
a is greater than b
if both the conditions are false we'll
print B is greater than a
so let me run this
we have the output B is greater than a
because
our B value is 20 and a is 10 so B is
greater than a
now let me create a numpy array and find
the cumulative sum in a sequence of
numbers for this you can use the sum
function
first I have to import my numpy library
so I'll write
import
numpy as NP
then
I'll declare a variable
say res which is for result
I'll use a list function
and then
pass in my come sum function
and let's say I'll give a range of 10.
finally I'll print the result
if I run this
you can see we have calculated the
cumulative sum of the numbers ranging
from 0 to 9
so the first element is 0 then the next
element is 1 so 0 plus 1 is 1. the next
element is 2 so 1 plus 2 is 3 then 3
plus 3 is 6 6 plus 4 is 10 10 plus 5 is
15 and so on
let's Now understand how you can use
either Tools in Python either tool is a
module in Python that implements a
number of iterator building blocks it
provides several functions that work on
iterators to produce complex iterators
we will see an example to find the list
of matches to be played between the
teams in a league here we consider each
team will play against all the other
teams in the league
so to use the iter tools I'll first
import it so I'll write import
iter tools
and then let me go ahead and declare a
list see
football
underscore clubs
let me take
a few Club names say Manchester United
then we have
Real Madrid
I'm taking the top clubs from Europe
the next club we have is say arsenal
followed by
Chelsea
then we have say Liverpool
and finally we have
Barcelona
then
I'll use my list function and
use another function that is present
inside the itel tools library that is
combination
so it will give me all the possible
combinations
I'll pass in my
list
name that is football underscore clubs
and I'll give another parameter that is
r equal to 2
if I run it
you have all the matches that would be
played in the sleeve
as I mentioned each team will play
against all the other teams
now we will see the trick to print the
total permutations in a given set of
numbers using the iter tool and its
functions
now to do this I'll use a
for Loop so I'll use for p in
either tools
Dot I'll use permutations function
so
permutations
and then let's see I'll pass in my
list that has values 1 comma 2 comma 3
and 4
I'll print it
I'll use print
then I'll use the
join function
convert it into a string
four
X in p
if I run it you can see below we have
all the permutations listed
up next let me tell you how you can
print all the false values present in a
list now to do this we can use the
filter false function present in the
itata tools module
so I'll use list
and then
use my iter tools
Dot
filter false function
I'll pass in
Bool as mine
data type
let's say we have a list containing none
then we have false
we have one comma 0 comma 10.
if I run it
it will print all the false values
present in the list so we have none
false and zero
so if you have liked watching this video
so far then please subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon to
stay updated with all the trending
Technologies also if you want to get the
source file that I am using in this live
session then please mention your email
IDs in the chat section our team will
share the source code with you over
email
again if you have any questions related
to the tips and tricks we have discussed
so far then please put your queries in
the chat section our team will answer it
in the chat
up next let me show you the trick to
perform certain mathematical operations
inside a list containing pairs of tuples
first we look at how to add elements in
a list of tuples
so for that I'll import my iter tools
you can skip this step because we have
already imported a writer tools module
and then I'll import operator
we have
a list of tuples say E2 comma 5
then we have 10 comma 4
we have another pair says 60 comma
now I'll use
list function and inside of it I'll use
my itel tools module
so I'll write iter tools Dot
star map function
and
I'll use my operator
add
comma
I'll pass in my list that is a
knife I run it
we have the addition of the pairs of
tuples present in the list so first pair
is 2 comma 5 so the addition
is 7 then 10 plus 4 is 14 and 60 plus 3
is 63.
similarly you can also multiply the
pairs of tuples in a list
and just copy paste this code and here
instead of ADD
I'll use
mul to multiply
if I run it
we have the output below
so 2 into 5 is 10 then the product of 10
and 4 is 40 and 60 and 3 is 180.
now let us explore a bit about the
collections module in Python so the
collections module implements
specialized container data types
containing alternatives to Python's
general purpose built-in containers such
as list Tuple dictionaries and set
I'll show you how to change the order of
the keys inserted in a dictionary using
the ordered dict function
so first I need to import the ordered
dict function from the collections
module
so I'll write from
collections
import
ordered
dict function
then
I'll say d is equal to
ordered
Dot
I'll use the from keys
and let's see
I have my key as e b c d e
then I'll
use another function called move
to
end
and let's say I want to move my key B to
the end
then
I'll use inverted commas
and pass in my join function
and inside that I'll say d dot
keys
if I run it you can see we have shifted
the key B to the end
now if you want to move the key B to the
beginning
you can do something like this so let me
copy the last two lines of code from the
above cell
I'll paste it
now here I can give another
parameter that is last
and I'll say
false
if I run this
you can see we have the key B in the
beginning now
now the final trick I am going to show
you is how to perform mathematical
operations using a Lambda function in
Python
so Lambda is an anonymous function that
does not have a name
it can have any number of arguments but
only one expression
the expression is evaluated and the
result is returned
so let's see how to add and subtract
numbers in one line of code using the
Lambda function
so first I'll declare a variable say
function
is equal to
and I'll assign a dictionary
I'll pass in my
sum and then
use the Lambda function
I'll pass in variables X comma y
and I'll add X Plus y
similarly
I'll now
subtract
I'll use the Lambda function again
pass in my variables X comma y
and I'll write x minus y
now
let me run it
so if you want to find the sum of two
numbers
so I have to call this first so I'll use
funk
and using square brackets I'll give my
sum
and then pass in my values say 10 comma
3 this will add 10 plus 3 and return the
result as 13. similarly
if you want to subtract two numbers
I'll just write subtract here instead of
sum
and it will return the result that is 10
minus 3 that which is 7.
I think with that we have covered all
the important tips and tricks that you
should know in Python welcome to python
interview questions certainly the
questions we're going to ask in here are
very general with a few specifics
towards data science and sets the main
direction that Python's going in and
you'd want to expand your questions for
your interview depending on the domain
that you're using the python in
specifically let's dive in and get
started with some python interview
questions number one what is the
difference between shallow copy and deep
copy and you can see with shallow copy
we have object one which has child one
child two child three and so on and
object two which has child one child two
child three a deep copy creates a
different object and populates it with
the child objects of the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is not reflected in the copy copy dot
deep copy creates a deep copy shallow
copy creates a different object and
populates it with the references of the
child objects within the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is reflected in the copy copy.copy
creates a shallow copy and you can look
at this if we make a change to child one
it's only a pointer so if you make it in
object one and change the channel one
and object one it will also make that
change in object two number two how is
multi-threading achieved in Python oh
this is a good one with multi-processing
and multi-threading this question is
actually asking you do you know the
difference between multi-processing and
multi-threading and how multi-threading
Works multi-threading usually implies
that multiple threads are executed
concurrently the python Global
interpreter lock doesn't allow more than
one thread to hold the python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading and python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi-processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the Django
architecture so the Django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
Django is is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so we look
at the architecture you can see here we
have a nice model drawn out where the
user initiates the Django which
initiates the URL which initiates the
view what they're going to view and you
have your model and your template so the
model of data whatever data model you're
pulling goes into the template and then
goes back up the pipeline to the user
and the important thing to note is
there's a template the front end of the
web page this is what they're going to
see there's a model the back end where
the data is stored so you can keep the
template and the looks and everything
looks the same but you can swap out the
underlying formation that goes into that
template then you have your view which
interacts with the model and template
and Maps it to the URL and then the
Django serves the page to the user so
your Django grabs it and says okay thank
you for the URL and here you go user
what advantage does numpy array have
over nested list so numpy's a module you
import almost always see numpy import
numpy as NP numpy is is written in C
such that all its complexities are
backed into a simple to use module lists
on the other hand are dynamically typed
therefore python must check the data
type of each element every time it uses
it this makes number arrays much faster
than lists I would also add in that
numpy has a lot of additional
functionality that you don't have in
lists there's a lot of things you can
automate in the numpy quick flip over to
our Jupiter notebook any IDE will work
if you're going to do a set of these of
interview questions taking a quick look
at code is always important we have our
import and of b as NP we'll go ahead and
import time here's our list list sub for
Iron Range of 100 and what we're doing
is we're going to time it so we're going
to create a list then we're going to
create a numpy zeros array and you can
see here look how quick you can create
this numpy zeros array here we are
appending one zero at a time for a
regular python list and here we are with
numpy they're all zeros and they're all
of type integer I believe it's either
float or integer on this I'd have to
actually do a type upon it and then so
if we take in and we create a tl1 time
equals time and then we do for I and
range of 100 for J in range of 100 L of
I J equals L of i j plus 5. so we're
just doing a simple calculation on our
array and sub arrays this is an array of
rays and we'll do the same thing with
tl2 tl2 time dot time tl1 equals so here
we have our final time on that and then
we'll do this with an array array op and
this is what I really love a equals a
plus 10 and then you can just print it
right out so you can see right here with
the numpy array I'm doing the same thing
if I run this our time is significantly
different here we have 0.09 and 0.003 so
you can see that the time drops
significantly when you're running this
on a numpy array versus a list array
also important to note these times
aren't going to be they'll change each
time I run it depending on what I have
running in the background so there we go
number five what is pickling and
unpickling Macy's me how many times I
pickle and unpickle something converting
a python object hierarchy to a byte
stream is called pickling pickling is
also referred to as serialization
unpickling converting a byte stream to a
python object hierarchy is also called
unpickling unpickling is also referred
to as deserialization so if you just
created a neural network model you can
now save that model to your hard drive
pickle it and then you can unpickle it
to bring it back into another software
program or to use at a later time how is
memory managed in Python number six
python has a private Heap space where it
stores all the objects the python memory
manager manages various aspects of this
Heap like sharing caching segmentation
and allocation the user has no control
over the Heap only the python
interpreter has the access you have a
nice little diagram here here's your
program there's your interpreter we have
our Heap memory management on the
garbage collector going off of there
number seven are arguments in Python
passed by value or by reference
arguments are passed in Python by
reference this means that any change
made within a function is reflected on
the original object so you can see here
def function of l l of zero equals three
L equals one two three four function L
print L and you're going to get three
two three four because we've passed l in
there so it's a pointer here we have def
function l l equals three two three four
L equals one two three four function of
L print L because in this function I
have assigned instead of operating on a
piece of L the list I've consigned a
whole new value to that list or L it
then at that points will create a new
object so if I make changes to the
object it's going to change it in the
outside the definition if I use a
variable and I assign it a completely
new value like L equals three two three
four that will not show up when you're
outside the function number eight how
would you Generate random numbers in
Python to Generate random numbers in
Python you must first import the random
module the random function generates a
random float value between 0 and 1. the
random range function generates a random
number within a given range and you can
see here one is the lower end times the
upper end and step two so it'd be one
three five and so on as far as the
options in the random generation number
nine what does the double forward slash
operator do in Python the forward slash
operator performs Division and Returns
the quotient in float for example five
over two returns 2.5 to do a double
forward slash operator on the other hand
Returns the quotient in integer for
example 5 double slash returns two five
divided by two and you drop the 0.5
number ten what does the is operator do
the is operator compares the ID of the
two object
and you can see in here where list one
equals brackets around one two three
list one equals list two equals true and
you have the double equals in Python of
course and you can do list one is list
two where list two equals one two three
is false list two is not the brackets
one two three it equals it but it's not
the brackets and if we do list three
equals list one then list one is list
three equals true number eleven what is
the purpose of pass statement the past
statement is used when there's a
syntactic but not an operational
requirement for example the program
below prints a string ignoring the
spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learned we've added two
spaces in it for I and variable so it
goes through each eye if I equals space
do nothing else print I and then we'll
have the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out Simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
I does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need to place holder for
that first logical set or that first
area you can also do a function like
this you could do function whatever your
def function name brackets colon pass so
it goes into the function and does
nothing but it's a placeholder number 12
how will you check all the characters in
a string are alphanumeric python has an
inbuilt method is all number which
returns true if all characters in The
String are alpha numeric and so you can
see here A B C D one two three is all
number output equals true and the second
line a b c d the at symbol one two three
the pound symbol is all NuMe output
equals false so really just want to know
about is all new all numerical
alphanumerical number 12 how will you
check if all characters in a string are
alphanumeric so here we go if you know
is all number which returns that the
characters in The String are
alphanumeric one can also use rejects
instead and so we have Boolean re math
which what's important about this is to
note your capital a dash to capital z a
lowercase to dash to Z 0 to 9 means that
that array includes all of those the way
they have it written out plus a dollar
sign and then we have what we're
comparing it to the string we're
comparing to the abcd123 and so we can
do an re dot match and if it matches if
all these things if all the different
entities in that array matches the first
one we'll get an output true and if not
an output false number 13 how will you
merge elements in a sequence sequence
there are three types of sequences in
Python there's lists tuples and strings
python equation makes this easy if we
have a list one and list two and list
one is square brackets one comma two
comma three list two is four five and
six we can simply do list one plus list
two and our output is one two three four
five six if we have tuples your Tuple is
the curve brackets designates it and
again just add them together same thing
with strings we have simply learn S1
plus S2 equals simply learn number 14
how will you remove all leading white
space in a string python provides the
inbuilt function L strip to remove all
leading access from a string and you can
see here space space python dot L strip
leading strip Python and you can also do
strip which relieves leading and ending
of course there's also the ending set
number 15 how will you replace all
occurrences of a substring with a new
string the replace function can be used
with strings for replacing a substring
with a given string syntax string dot
replace old comma new comma count
replace returns a new string without
modifying the original string hey John
how are you John question mark replace
John with capital j o h n one and then
you can see right here hey John how are
you and since we designated with the one
just says we're only going to replace
one of these 6 16 what is the difference
between Del and remove brackets on lists
Del for delete Dell removes all elements
of a list within a given range syntax
Dell list start to end remove remove
brackets removes the first occurrence of
a particular character syntax list
remove element and we see a nice example
over here if we delete the list one to
three it will delete the first in this
case b one two it doesn't do three
remember that one two so it will delete
B and C and you end up with a d where if
we do remove B from the list and we have
an a b b d it's only going to remove the
first B number 17 how to display the
contents of text file in reverse order
open the file using the open function
store the contents of the file into a
list reverse the contents of the list
run a for Loop to iterate through the
list number 18. differential between
append and extend append adds an element
to the end of the list you can see right
here we have a list one two three four
and we have pinned four and we end up
with an output one two three four and
extend adds an element from an interval
to the end of the list and we have here
list equals one two three list dot
extend four five six output is one two
three four five six so if you want to
append an array to the end of another
array you want to use the extend number
19. what's the output of the below code
justify your answer this is a great
interview question because these are the
kind of things that come up when you're
proofing code def add to list value and
list so we have value in and a listent
Or List equals an empty in this case an
empty list list out of pin value return
list list one equals add to list one
list two equals add to list one two
three empty bracket list three equals
add to list a and then we want to print
them list one equals and you can see the
formatting we have a placeholder list
one list two and list three so when it
prints list one we to get 1 comma a and
what you want to notice here is that
list one and list three are equal why
are they equal well when we passed the
information to the add to list we passed
value without passing the list equals
brackets without passing a second value
what this means is that list as we have
it if you don't have a list it'll start
off with empty list which we append the
one to the second one list two we
appended a value to an empty list so
we're only going to be one two three it
doesn't matter what the list was before
we've already assigned an empty list and
then list three here's the tricky one
we're adding a to the list but because
we didn't designate the list list is a
shared value in other words it doesn't
reset it and we end up with list one
equals list three one comma a default
list is created only once during the
function and not during its call number
20 what is the difference between a list
and a tuple lists are mutable while
tuples are immutable and you can see an
example down here where I have list
equals one two three square brackets
denote it's a list list of two equals
four and I print it out I now have one
two four if I do the same thing with the
two bolt I get an error because you
can't change the Tuple one two three
into one two four you have to completely
reassign Tuple to a new value what is
Doc string in Python doc strings are
used in providing documentation to
various python modules classes functions
and methods and so you can see here we
have def for a function add a b and this
is a doc string we have the triple
brackets on there you can add carriage
return in that so that you can go
multiple lines and it says this function
adds two numbers and then sum a b
returns some and so we have down here
two different ways of accessing this
function output accessing docstring
method one this function adds two
numbers accessing dockstring method two
help on function add in model main this
function adds two numbers and so you can
see the code down here has two very
different in values the second one is
basically a help menu there's our help
menu number 22 how to use print without
the new line the solution to this
depends on the python version you are
using in Python version 2 you can do
print Hi and then you add a comma
afterwards print how are you and you
have Hi how are you in version 3 print
hi comma end equals and it'll add a
space on the end there you can put
different characters in there but
generally just want to put a space put a
space on the End Print how are you and
now we get Hi how are you number 23 how
do you use the split function in Python
the split function splits a string into
a number of strings based on a specific
delimiter so we have string split
delimiter comma Max the maximum number
of splits the character based on which
the string is the split by default is
space so here we have an example we have
a variable red blue green orange and we
want to split it by commas and we only
want to do the first two so if we print
the list now you'll find it has red blue
and only spread it split it the first
two times and it gets to the third one
and just groups them all together green
and orange if you leave the two off
you'll split the whole thing number 24
is python object oriented or functional
programming python follows object
oriented Paradigm and you should really
know in depth what they mean by
object-oriented Paradigm if you're doing
any interview for scripting languages
python allows the creation of objects
and is manipulation through specific
methods it supports most of the features
of oops which as inheritance on a
polymorphism so you have an object and
you can inherit all the traits of that
object and then add new traits in or
alter some of those traits that's what
object oriented means python follows
functional programming Paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object python supports Lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
Paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes variable number of
arguments here we have def function name
list so we could have in this case
whatever the list is Def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and we
can do for I and VAR print I so if you
send function of one you'll end up with
a 1 function one two five six it'll
actually print those out one at a time
the first one just prints out a one
because it only sent one variable the
second one will print one another line
25 another line 6. number 26 what is
asterisk args and asterisks quarks args
used in function prototype to accept
varying number of arguments it's an
iterable object death function arcs and
you can imagine it's just a basic list
so if I send add the numbers a comma b
or a comma B comma C it doesn't really
matter it will have that number of
objects in it whatever I send to it and
there's other uses for it but that's
very basic quarks I can actually tell it
what I want to send so using a function
prototype and to accept varying number
of keyworded arguments it's in both our
iterable objects so you can go through
them one at a time and the def function
chords you can now set like color equals
red units equal two so you'll see that
especially in machine learning there's a
lot of like they'll have inline equals
true that kind of thing number 27 in
Python functions are first class objects
what do you understand from this this
means I could return a function if you
went from another function I could
create a function and treat it just like
an object I can assign it to a variable
I can pass them as arguments to other
functions number 28 what is the output
of print nay underscore underscore name
justify your answer the double
underscore name double underscore is a
special variable that holds the name of
the current module program execution
starts from main or a code with zero
indentation thus double underscore name
double underscore name has a value
double underscore main double underscore
in the above case if the file is
imported from another module then double
underscore name underscore double
underscore holds the name of this module
number 29 what is a numpy array and we
briefly touched numpy array compared to
a list early in processing speed now
let's go ahead and look at some of the
more specifics a numpy array is a grid
of values all of the same type so if
they're either all float all integer all
string and is indexed by a tuple of
non-negative integers the number of
Dimensions is the rank of the array and
the shape of an array is a tuple of
integers giving the size of the ray
along each Dimension number 30 what is
the difference between matrices and
arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and is a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set of mathematical operations
that allow you to manipulate the data in
interesting ways now arrays an array is
a sequence of objects of similar data
type an array within another array forms
a matrix like we said here
two-dimensional so if you have an array
of three by four that would be a matrix
number 31 how to get indexes of n
maximum values in a numpy array of
course the first thing to do is to
import your numpy as NP you don't
necessarily have to use MP but that is
the most standard use of numpy we create
our array equals an NP dot array of one
two three four five and then if we want
to get our indexes of n at maximum
values in an empty array we can do one
way to do it is to take our array sort
it then do minus in colon that means
we're going to do once you've sorted it
you can do minus in in would equal then
the number of indices so it's not the
actual the letter N colon and really
this is about understanding this
notation that we can sort it so it goes
from lowest to biggest and then we can
get the top values for n indexes and
then we have our final set of brackets
with the minus one on there number 32
how would you obtain the resulting set
from the train set and the test set from
below and let's go ahead and look at the
two different variables we have train
set equals an array of one two three
test set equals a numpy of Ray of arrays
we have zero one two one two three
what's important here is that one it's a
numpy so that leaves a out and then
we're stuck with three other options and
I'm going to say d is out none of these
and let's look at NP dot concatenate
versus NP dot v stack concatenate would
put one set after the other so you would
end up with probably give you an error
because one set is one two three and
then we're going to concatenate array 0
1 2 and 1 array one two three the array
of arrays onto the end of that what we
really want to do is stack and by the
way you can actually switch there's
variables you can put into concatenate
obviously that can change this so you
could use the concatenate with a lot of
fudging around but really we're looking
for is v-stack v stands for vertical
versus the H stack which is horizontal
and if we do a v-stack we can simply do
train set comma test set and stack them
together and so we have C resulting set
equals np.vstack train stack test set
both option A and B would do horizontal
stacking but we would like to have the
vertical stacking option she does this
again you could add the axes in and use
the concatenate to stack it the correct
way number 33 how would you import a
decision Tree classifier in sklearn We
have
sklearn.decision tree import decision
tree classifier from sklearn Ensemble
import decision tree classifier and we
look at these and they're all import
decision tree classifier that actually
last part happens to be correct and it's
really just a vocabulary knowing where
is the decision tree class Sapphire
stored what module is that a part of and
it is of course part of the sklearn.tree
number c number 34 you have uploaded the
data set in CSV format on Google
spreadsheet and shared it publicly how
can you access this in Python what's
important here is to know that we can
read stuff with pandas so we don't show
it here but you can there's actually a
number of ways to do this what's
important here is to know a couple
things one we have our link generated
from the Google Docs and spreadsheets
and then we can do a string IO dot
string IO request get link dot content
so there's our source and then finally
we know that pandas can read a CSV
there's obviously many ways to read a
CSV but data equals pd.read underscore
CSV Source number 35 what is the
difference between the two data series
given below below we have DF name and DF
location colon comma brackets around
name comma where and then we have DF
equals PD data frame a b b x x u u comma
21 1650 33 columns equal name and age so
let's take a look and see what they're
looking at we have just glancing at the
questions they want to know is it the
original data frame or is it the copy of
the data frame and you can see here that
one is view the original data frame and
two is a copy of the original data frame
two is a view of the original data frame
and one is a copy of the original data
frame both are copies both are views and
if you're working with pandas you know
that unless you specifically in certain
things tell it to do it in line and a
lot of functions don't allow you that
you're always taking a slice and it is
always a copy so C both are copies of
the original data frame number 36 you
get the following error while trying to
read a file temp.csv using pandas which
of the following could correct it so
here's our error Trace back most recent
call last file input line one in module
Unicode encode error ASCII codex can't
encode character oh I hate it when that
one comes up and we have four different
entries we'll go ahead and just pretend
that D doesn't exist unless we really
can't fit it into one of the other
answers and the first one is PD read CSV
has our file compression equals gzip
well gzip is just an unzipping and you
actually get a zip error on there the
second one is dialect equals string
again not an encoding or coding setup
and then we have encoding equals utf-8
well that would be the encoding error
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is Unicode that's
the most common two that goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
unit code and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number c
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to set a line with in a plot given below
so looking at this we have import
netplot Library Pi plot is PLT and you
should know your way around this how to
do a plot in there
plt.plot1234 plot equals show and so
this is a little bit of a vocabulary
test the vocabulary is at width equals
three line width equals three LW equals
three or something else and the
vocabulary word that we're looking for
is LW equals three which stands for line
width in pi plot Library Pi plot Number
38 how would you reset the index of a
data frame to a given list so this is a
vocabulary Challenge and understanding
what re-indexing is re-indexing as we
have the different values here we have
the first one which is reset the index
well we're not really resetting the
index re-index number b means we're
double checking our indexes to the
column into the main index and so the
values match correctly where re-index
like now brings in a new index outside
of our data frame to a given list so
this is coming from external and thus
the vocabulary word like is our key word
that it's external and we have a data
print to a given list number 39 how can
you copy objects in Python the functions
used to copy objects in Python we have
copy copy for shallow copying and copy
deep copying for deep copy number 40
what is the difference between range and
X range functions in Python well this is
a good one we have matrixes and arrays
with a matrix the range returns a python
list object X range returns an X range
object and with arrays an x-ray returns
an x-range object X range creates values
as you need them through yielding the
key here is that X range Returns the
values as you need them so it actually
processes it post like if you have for x
or for a variable in X range it is
processing them as you need them zero to
nine it doesn't create an array zero to
nine it just hands you zero then one two
three four one at a time number 41 how
can you check whether a pandas data
frame is empty or not the tribute DF dot
empty is used to check whether a panda's
data frame is empty or not and so you
can simply create a we have down here
importer pandas is PD we create our
pandas data frame equal to an empty
array and is DF dot empty comes out as
true one of the catches you got to
remember with these vocabularies is with
empty along with some other pandas set
up whether you need the brackets or not
at the end number 42 write the code to
sort an array in numpy by the N minus 1
column this can be achieved using ARG
sort function let's take an array X then
to sort the N minus one column the code
will be X to X to colon n minus two dot
args sort so let's see what that code
looks like we import numpy as NP we'll
create our array our numpy array which
is uh one two three zero five two two
three four so we have three different
entities with three different columns in
there and we go X of X and so we take X
of all the rows first entity well in
this case it's actually the second one
because it's zero one two dot ARG sort
so that would be the second entity or
minus two would also be the same you
could also do instead of one you could
also do minus two there instead of the
one our sort and then we get an output
of the array one two three zero five two
two three four number 43 how to create a
series from a list numpy array and
dictionary so we'll go ahead and input
import our numpy or pandas and have my
list and you and you can see here we
have my list equals list of ABCDEFG over
all the way through so my list now makes
a list of that for array we have NP dot
a range to 26. my dictionary will create
a dictionary with a zip my list my
arguments so I'll just use the numpy
array we just created with my array to
go into the dictionary and the solution
is simple with the PD dot series my list
pd.series my array PD dot series my
dictionary so it's all about knowing the
dot Capital s-e-r-i-e-s don't forget
that capitalization number 44 how to get
the items not common to both series a
and series B and you can see here we
have instead of series A and B we have
series one and two and we have one two
three four five four five six seven
eight the solution is we take a panda
series we have a series U equals a panda
series NP Union one dimension series one
series two so we can now make a union of
them we now have series one Panda series
with an intersection and then we can
remove one from the other series U is
series U dot is in series one so if the
union is not in the intersection then
you know it's a unique value a little
bit of logic going on there playing with
three different terms to get the answer
we want 45 how to keep only the top two
most frequent values as it is and
replace everything else as other in a
series so again we're working with
pandas because if we're talking series
and data frames that means we're working
with pandas so we're going to import
pandas as PD we'll go ahead and create
our Panda series we're going to do that
by creating a numpy random random State
100 so 100 in the numpy one and then we
have our Panda series you can see here
where random integer numpy random random
integer one comma five by twelve and so
the solution for this is we go ahead and
we've created a PDF remember the capital
S Series solution we're going to print
the top two frequencies and that is our
series dot value counts and then we take
series values count dot index of up to
two so we're going to take everything up
to two and then we'll do the series is
in so if it's not in the first two then
it's going to equal other and this would
be something you'd want to write down on
paper if you're if it looks confusing
take a moment pause the video write this
down and see if you can figure out how
the logic came together and try to throw
yourself a couple other little logic
puzzles like this number 46 how to find
the positions of numbers that are
multiples of three from a series and in
here we're actually going to use a numpy
to solve it the first part series lets
you know it's going to be a panda series
and if we come down here we have
np.org where this is a vocabulary
question series with remember the
percentile 3 is the remainder so if the
remainder equals zero then we're going
to generate that ring where the object
divided by three equals zero has no
remainder so then we know it's a
multiple of three number 47 how to
compute the euclidean distance between
two series and this one's really cool
because we have our Panda series uh p
and Q and what I like about this one is
they give us two solutions you can go
with and really you should kind of know
both the first one would be yes you know
what the euclidean distance is and that
is we can take the first series minus
the second series squared and then sum
them up and then we do the square root
which is the same as taking the power to
0.5 doing the power to 0.5 is easier
than doing the square root so a lot of
times you'll see that as a switch but
you could have also done the square root
and use the math in there so there's
solution one you should know your
euclidean distance and then solution two
is the numpy solution so we have
npa.linal.norm that's how we're going to
computer our euclidean distance
P minus Q very elegant and very
straightforward and easy to compute
number 48 how to reverse the rows of
data frame so here we have our data
frame we're going to create a numpy
array by 25 reshape it 5 minus one when
this creates a 25 by 25 data frame and
so our solution is to do the DFI
location and this is just understanding
how steps work the steps you have your
colon colon -1 so we're taking all the
rows all the columns minus one so our
stepping minus one going the reverse
Direction and then we're just going to
use across all the different columns on
there let me say that again the first
colon is going to be your row starting
row stopping row step minus one that's
all this is about is that step minus one
comma and then all the columns 49 if you
split your data into train test splits
is it possible to overfit your model and
the answer is yes is definitely possible
one common beginner mistake is retuning
a model or training new models with
different parameters after seeing its
performance on the test set my favorite
example of this is you have your script
put together and you keep hitting the
rerun button until you get the answer
you want not taking the answer it first
gave you or running it over an array and
recording all the answers to see how
they vary number 50 which python library
is built on top of matplot library and
pandas to ease data plotting the answer
this is Seaborn Seabourn is a data
visualization library in Python that
provides a high level interface for
drawing statistical information
informative graphs we're going to cover
mathematics for machine learning
data in its types data denotes the
individual pieces of factual information
collected from various sources it is
stored process and later used for
analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information a lot of tech stuff money
dollar signs numbers and then you have
your performing analytics to drive
insights and hopefully you have a nice
share your shareholders gather it at the
meeting and you're able to explain it in
something they can understand
so we talk about data's types of data we
have in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
and you think nominal or ordinal and
then you have your quantitative or
numerical which is discrete or
continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary always people's
favorite is the vocabulary words okay
not mine
but let's dive into this what we mean by
nominal nominal they are used to label
various label our variables without
providing any measurable value
uh country gender race hair color Etc
it's something that you either mark true
or false this is a label it's on or off
either they have a red hat on or they do
not uh so a lot of times when you're
thinking nominal data labels uh think of
it as a true false kind of setup and we
look at ordinal this is categorical data
with a set order or a scale to it and
you can think of salary range as a great
one movie ratings Etc you see here the
celery rains if you have ten thousand to
twenty thousand number of employees
earning that rate is 150 20 000 to 30
000 100 and so forth some of the terms
you'll hear is bucket uh this is where
you have ten different buckets and you
want to separate it into something that
makes sense into those 10 buckets and so
when we start talking about ordinal a
lot of times when you get down to the
breastbones again we're talking true
false uh so if you're a member of the 10
to 20K Reigns so forth those would each
be either part of that group or you're
not but now we're talking about buckets
and we want to count how many people are
in that bucket
quantitative numerical data falls into
two classes discrete or continuous and
so data with a final set of values which
can be categorized class strength
questions answered correctly and runs
hit and Cricut a lot of times when you
see this you can think integer and a
very restricted integer I.E you can only
have 100 questions on a test so you can
it's very discreet I only have a hundred
different values that it can attain so
think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open end or anything
like that
uh so discrete is very solid simple to
count set number continuous on the other
hand continuous data can take any
numerical value within a range so water
pressure weight of a person Etc usually
we start thinking about float values
where they can get phenomenally small in
their in what they're worth and there's
a whole series of values that falls
right between discrete and continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still discrete
but it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from
525.33 to
580.67 cents there's a lot of Point
values in there it'd still be called
discrete which you start looking at it
as almost continuous because it does
have such a variance in it now we talk
about no we did we went over nominal and
ordinal almost true false charts and we
looked at quantitative and numerical
data data which we'll start to get into
numbers discrete you can usually a lot
of times discrete will be put into it
could be put into true false but usually
it's not uh so we want to address this
stuff and the first thing we want to
look at is the very basic which is your
algebra so we're going to take a look at
linear algebra you can remember back
when your euclidean geometry we have a
line well let's go through this we have
a linear algebra as the domain of
mathematics concerning linear equations
and their representations in Vector
spaces and through matrixes I told you
we're going to talk about Matrix is
so a linear equation is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10. very
linear 10x plus 12.4 y equals z and now
you can actually solve these two
equations by combining them and that's
we're talking about a linear equation
and the vectors we have a plus b equals
c now we're starting to look at a
direction and these values usually think
of an x y z plot so each one is a
direction and the actual distance of
like a triangle a b is C and then your
Matrix can describe all kinds of things
I find matrixes confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because of the magnitude
and the different things are used for
and a matrix is a chart or a you know
think of a spreadsheet but you have your
rows and your columns and you'll see
here we have a times b equals c very
important to know your counts uh so
depending on how the math is being done
what you're using it for making sure you
have the same rows and number of columns
or a single number there's all kinds of
things that play in that that can make
matrixes confusing but really it has a
lot more to do with what domain you're
working in are you adding in multiple
polynomials where you have like uh a x
squared plus b y plus you know you start
to see they can be very confusing versus
a very straightforward Matrix and let's
just go a little deeper into these
because these are such primary this is
what we're here to talk about is these
different math mathematical computations
that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of one
is called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have ax plus b equals c which is
a one variable
we have two variable ax plus b y equals
c a X plus b y plus z c z equals D and
so forth but all of these are to the
power of one you don't see x squared you
don't see X cubed so we're talking about
linear equations that's what we're
talking about in their addition if you
have already dived into say neural
networks you should recognize this ax
plus b y plus c z
setup plus The Intercept which is
basically your your neural network each
node adding up all the different inputs
and we can drill down into that most
common formula is your y equals MX plus
c
so you have your y equals the M which is
your slope your X Value Plus C which is
your y-intercept they kind of labeled it
wrong here
threw me for a loop but the the C would
be your y-intercept so when you set x
equal to 0 y equals c and that's that's
your y-intercept right there
uh and that's they they just had a
reversed value of y when x equals zero
equals the y-intercept which is C and
your slope gradient line which is your M
so these are y equals two X plus three
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems and then
of course the uh one of the most
important takeaways is the slope
gradient of the line uh so the slope is
very important that M value in this case
we went ahead and solved this
if you have y equals two X plus three
you can see how it has a nice line graph
here on the right
so matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking M rows by n columns
here a11 is denotes the element of the
first row in the First Column similarly
a 12 and it's really pronounced a11 in
this particular setup so it's a row one
column one a 12 is a of Row one column
two first row and second column and so
on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
I've seen these as like a capital letter
a smaller case a for the top row or I
mean you can see where they can go all
kinds of different directions as far as
the value
you just take a moment to realize there
needs to be some designation as far as
what row it's in and what column it's in
and we have our basic operations we have
addition so when you think about
addition you have uh two matrixes of two
by two and you just add each individual
number in that Matrix and then when you
get to the bottom you have in this case
the solution is 12 10 plus 2 is 12 5
plus 3 is 8 and so on and the same thing
with subtraction
now again your counting Matrix is you
want to check your dimensions of the
Matrix the shape you'll see shape come
up a lot in programming so we're talking
about Dimensions we're talking about the
shape if the two shapes are equal this
is what happens when you add them
together or subtract them
and we have multiplication when you look
at the multiplication you end up at the
very a slightly different setup going
now if we look at our last one where
we're like why this always gets to me
when we get to matrixes because they
don't really say why you multiply
matrixes
um you know my first thought is one
times two four times three but if you
look at this we get 1 times 2 plus 4
times 3 1 times 3 plus 4 times 5
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five if
you're looking at these matrixes uh
think of this more as an equation and so
we have if you remember when we back up
here for our multiple line equations
let's just go back up a couple slides
where we were looking at uh two
variables so this is a two variable
equation ax plus b y equals c
um and this is a way to make it very
quick to solve these variables and
that's why you have the Matrix and
that's why you do
the multiplication the way they do and
this is the dot product of one times two
plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little uh 14 23
21 and 33 over here which then can be
used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs uh and then in
Matrix operations when you're dealing
with a lot of matrixes now keep in mind
multiplying matrixes is different than
finding the product of two matrixes okay
so we're talking about multiplication
we're talking about solving for
equations when you're finding the
product you are just finding one times
two keep that in mind because that does
come up I've had that come up a number
of times where I'm altering data and I
get confused as to what I'm doing with
it
transpose flipping the Matrix over its
diagonal comes up all the time where you
have you still have 12 but instead of it
being a 12 8 it's now 12 14 821 you're
just flipping the columns in the rows
and then of course you can do an inverse
changing the signs of the values of
process main diagonal and you can see
here we have the inverse a to the minus
1 and ends up with uh instead of 12 8 14
12 is now minus 22 minus 12. vectors
Vector just means we have
a value and a Direction
and we have down four numbers here on
our vector
in mathematics a one-dimensional matrix
is called a vector so if you have your X
plot and you have a single value that
value is along the x-axis and it's a
single Dimension if you have two
Dimensions you can think about putting
them on a graph you might have X and you
might have y and each value denotes a
direction and then of course the actual
distance is going to be the hypothesis
so that triangle and you can do that
with three dimensionals X Y and Z and
you can do it all the way to nth
Dimensions so when they talk about the K
means for categorizing and how close
data is together they will compute that
based on the Pythagorean theorem so you
would take the square of each value add
them all together and find the square
root and that gives you a distance as
far as where that point is where that
Vector exists or an actual point value
and then you can compare that point
value to another one and it makes a very
easy comparison versus comparing 50 or
60 different numbers and that brings us
up to I Gene vectors and I Gene values
uh hygiene vectors the vectors that
don't change their span while
transformation
and hygiene values the scalar values
that are associated to the vectors
conceptually you can think of the vector
as your picture you have a picture it's
um two Dimensions X and Y
and so when you do those two dimensions
and those two values or whatever that
value is
um that is that point but the values
change when you skew it and so if we
take and we have a vector a
and that's a set value uh B is your is
your you have a and b which is your I
Gene Vector 2 is the I Gene value so
we're altering all the values by two
that means we're maybe we're stretching
it out One Direction making it tall if
you're doing picture editing
um that's one of the places this comes
in but you can see when you're
transforming uh your different
information how you transform it is then
your hygiene value and you can see here
a vector after line Transit transition
we have 3A a a is the I Gene Vector
three is the iodine value so a doesn't
change that's whatever we started with
that's your original picture and three
is skewing in One Direction and maybe a
b is being skewed in another Direction
and so you have a nice tilted picture
because you've altered it by those by
the hygiene values
so let's go ahead and pull up a demo on
linear algebra and to do this I'm going
to go through my trusted Anaconda into
my Jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new uh notebook
called linear algebra
since we are working in Python we're
going to use our numpy I always import
that as NP or numpy array probably the
most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series I'm
not going to go too much into numpy we
are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10 15 and b 29
. we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see there's our two arrays 10 15 29
and I went and added a space there in
between
so it's easier to read
and since it's the last line we don't
have to put the print statement on it
unless you want we can simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when I run this we
have 10 15 29 and we get 30 24 which is
what you expect 10 plus 20 15 plus 9 you
could almost look at this addition as
being
um
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do a DOT t
plus b dot T remember that t flips them
and so if we do that we now get them we
now have 30 24 going the other way we
could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
uh as far as a plus b I can also do a
plus b dot t
and you're going to see that that will
come out the same the 3024 whether I
transpose A and B are transpose them
both at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors I can go a minus B
and we run that and we get minus 10 6.
now remember this is the last line in
this particular section that's why not
to put the print around it
and just like we did before
we can transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main setup and
then we get a minus 10 6 going the other
way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do a scalar
multiplication
and just put down the scalar so you can
remember that
and what we're talking about here is I
have this array here U and if I go a
times U
H we'll take the value 2 we'll multiply
it by every value in here so 2 times 30
is 60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way
so in numpy uh we have what they call
Dot product
and uh with this this is in a
two-dimensional vectors it is the
equivalent of two matrix multiplication
remember we were talking about matrix
multiplication uh where it is the
well let's walk through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6 or
our U and our V and then we're going to
go ahead and do if we take
the values and if you remember correctly
an array like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6. we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go
and then we'll go ahead and do the NP
dot dot of U comma
V
and we'll find when we do this we go and
run this we're going to get
370. so this is a strain multiplication
where they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here but for this we get a nice
value for our Dot multiplication
and we did addition earlier which is
just your basic addition and of course
the Matrix you can get very complicated
on these or in this case we'll go ahead
and do let's create two complex matrixes
this one is a matrix of
um you know 12 10 4 6 4 31. we'll just
print out a so you can see what that
looks like here's print a
we print a out you can see that we have
a
two by three layer Matrix for a and we
can also put together always kind of fun
when you're playing with print values we
could do something like this we could go
in here
there we go we could print a we have it
end with equals a run and this kind of
gives it a nice look here's your Matrix
that's all this is comma N means it just
tags it on the end that's all all that
is doing on there and then we can simply
add in what is a plus b and you should
already guess because this is the same
as what we did before there's no
difference when we do a simple vector
addition we have 12 plus 2 is 14 10 plus
8 is 18 and so on
and just like we did The Matrix addition
we can also do a minus B and do our
Matrix subtraction
and we look at this we have what 12
minus 2 is 10 10 minus eight uh where
are we
oh there we go 8 minus ah
confusing what I'm looking at I should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course 10 10 minus 8 is 2 4 minus 46 is
minus 42 and so forth so same as its
attraction as before we just call it
Matrix subtraction it's identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar Edition where we're adding just
one number
to a matrix you can also do scalar
multiplication and so simply if you have
a single value a and you have B which is
your array we can also do a times B
when we run that you can see here we
have 2 times 4 is 8 5 times 4 is 20 and
so forth you're just multiplying the 4
across each one of these values
and this is an interesting one that
comes up a little bit of a brain teaser
is Matrix and Vector multiplication
and so we're looking at this
we are let's do a regular arrays it
doesn't necessarily have to be a numpy
array we have a
which has our array of arrays and B
which is a single array and so we can
from here
do the DOT
a b
and this is going to return two values
and the verse value is that it's you
could say it's like uh we're doing the
this array B array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it splits it up so you have a
matrix of vector multiplication and you
can mix and match when you get into
really complicated uh back end stuff
this becomes more common because you're
now you've got layers upon layers of
data and so you you'll end up with a
matrix and a set of Bolt Vector matrices
do you want to multiply
now keep in mind that if you're doing
data science a lot of times you're not
looking at this this is what's going on
behind the scenes so if you're in the
site kit looking at sklearn where you're
doing linear regression models this is
some of the math that's hidden behind
the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and manipulate
the data around so it fits right and
then you go back in and you run it
through the psy kit and if we can do
um
up here we did a matrix and Vector
multiplication we can also do Matrix to
matrix multiplication and if we run this
where we have the two matrixes you can
see we have very complicated array that
of course comes out on there for our DOT
and just to reiterate it we have our
transposer Matrix which is your dot t
and so if we create a matrix a and we do
transpose it you can see how it flips it
from 5 10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15 25 10 20
30. rows and columns
and certainly with the math this comes
up a lot it also comes up a lot with X Y
plotting when you put it into Pi plot
you have one format where they're
looking at Pairs and numbers and then
they want L of x's and all y's so you
know the transpose is an important tool
both for your math and for plotting and
all kinds of things
another tool that we didn't discuss uh
is your identity Matrix
and this one is more definition
uh the identity Matrix we have here one
where we just did uh two so it comes
down as one zero zero one one zero zero
zero one zero it creates a diagonal of
one and what that is is when you're
doing your identities you could be
comparing all your different features to
the different features and how they
correlate and of course when you have a
feature one compared to feature one to
itself it is always one where usually
it's between zero one depending on how
well correlates so when we're talking
about identity Matrix that's what we're
talking about right here is that you
create this preset Matrix and then you
might adjust these numbers depending on
what you're working with and what the
domain is and then another thing we can
do to kind of wrap this up we'll hit you
with the most complicated uh piece of
this puzzle here is an inverse a matrix
and let's just go ahead and put the um
that's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the uh the website for
numpy so given a square Matrix a here's
our Square Matrix a which is two one
zero zero one zero one two one keep in
mind three by three it's Square it's got
to be equal it's going to return the
Matrix a inverse satisfying dot a
um a inverse so here's our matrix
multiplication
um and then of course it equals the dot
uh yeah a inverse of a with an identity
shape of a DOT shape zero this is just
reshaping the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
uh we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see what we end up with is we end up
with an array 0.5 minus 0.5 and so forth
with our two one one going down two one
zero zero one zero one two one
um getting into a little deep on the
math understanding when you need this is
probably really is is what's really
important when you're doing data science
versus uh handwriting this out and
looking up the math and handwriting all
the pieces out you do need to know about
the linear algorithm inverse of a so if
it comes up you can easily pull it up or
at least remember where to look it up
you took a look at the algebra side of
it let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side of what's going on here
with the machine learning so calculus oh
my goodness and differential equations
you got to throw that in there because
that's all part of the bag of tricks
especially when you're doing large
neural networks but it also comes up in
many other areas the good news is most
of it's already done for you in the back
end so when it comes up you really do
need to understand from the data science
not data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into actually
solving these math equations in a neural
network is just a giant differential
equation
uh so we talk about calculus uh we're
going to go ahead how and understand it
by talking about cars versus time and
speed
uh so it helps to calculate the
spontaneous rate of change
so suppose we plot a graph with the
speed of a car with respect to time so
as you can see here going down the
highway probably merged into the highway
from an on-ramp so I had to accelerate
so my speed went way up
stuck in traffic merged into the traffic
traffic opens up and I accelerate again
up to the speed limit and maybe Peter's
off up there so you can look at this as
as
the speed versus time I'm getting faster
and faster because I'm continually
accelerating and if I hit the brakes it
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect to time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating the acceleration is the
area between the start point of X and
the endpoint of Delta X
so we can calculate a simple if you had
X and Delta X we could put a line there
and that slope of the line is our
acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but I don't want to know
it just for that line in those two
points I want to know it across the
whole of what I'm working with that's
where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between X
and Delta X it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the acceleration
so the idea is that instead of I mean if
you ever did took a basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up let's go back
up a screen you divide this area up of
this time period up into maybe 10
sections and you'd use that and you
could calculate the acceleration between
each one of those 10 sections kind of
thing and then we just keep making that
space smaller and smaller until Delta X
is almost
infinitesimally small
and so we get a function of a equals a
limit as H goes to 0 of a function of a
plus h minus a function of a over H and
that is your Computing the slope of the
line
we're just Computing that slope under
smaller and smaller and smaller samples
uh and that's what calculus is calculus
is the integral you can see down here we
have our nice uh integral sign looks
like a giant s and that's what that
means is that we've taken this down to
as small as we can for that sampling
so we're talking about calculus we're
finding the area under the slope is the
main process in the integration similar
small intervals are made of the smallest
possible length of X Plus Delta X where
Delta X approaches almost an
infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up all the links
together so we're summing up all the
accelerations from the beginning to the
end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times D of x
equals a plus c
that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations
change in W over change of time equals
change of w over change of Z the
differential of Z to DX the differential
of x to DT it gets pretty complicated
and it really translates into the
multivariate integration using double
integrals and so you have the the sum of
the sum of f of x of Y of D of a equals
the sum from C to D and A to B of f of x
o y d x d y equals the sum of a to B sum
of C to D of f x of y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing the math is use the calculus one
calculus two and differential equations
so you're talking about three full
length courses to dig into and solve
these math equations what we want to
take from here is we're talking about
calculus we're talking about summing of
all these different slopes and so we're
still solving a linear uh expression
we're still solving y equals m x plus b
but we're doing this for infantismally
small x's and then we want to sum them
up that's what this integral sign means
the sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
multivariate differentiation using the
chain rule when we come in here and we
have the change of w to the change of T
equals a change of w DZ uh and so forth
that's what's going on here that's what
these means we're basically looking for
the area under the curve which really
comes to how is the change changing the
speeds going up how is that changing and
then you end up with a multiple layer so
if I have three layers of neural
networks how is the third layer changing
based on the second layer changing which
is based on the first layer changing and
you get the picture here that now we
have a very complicated multivariate
integration with integrals
the good news is we can solve this
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks in Reverse
propagation so the nice thing is that
you don't have to solve this on paper
unless you're a data analysis and you're
working on the back end of integrating
these formulas and building the script
to actually build them so we talk about
applications of calculus it provides us
the tools to build an accurate
predictive model so it's really behind
the scenes we want to guess at what the
change or the change of the changes
that's a little goofy I I know I just
threw that out there's kind of a meta
term but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our Target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables
so there's our multiple variables going
in there if one variable is changing how
does it affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local and Global Maxima
and this is really big we're actually
going to have a whole section here on
gradient descent because it is really I
mean I talked about neural networks and
how you can see how the different layers
go in there but gradient descent is one
of the most key things for trying to
guess the best answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent and before we open up
the code let's just do real quick
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go error uh hard to read
there and I want to make the error as
low as possible
and so when I'm looking at it is I want
to find this line here
which is the minimum value so we're
looking for the minimum
and it does that by sampling there
and then it based on this it guesses it
might be someplace here and it goes hey
this is still going down it goes here
and then goes back over here and then
goes a little bit closer and it's just
playing a high low until it gets to that
spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error in
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best output of it that's simply
minus the value so if you're looking for
where the peak is this is the same as a
negative for where the valley is I'm
looking for that Valley that's all that
is this is a way of finding it so the
cool thing is all the heavy lifting's
done I actually ended up putting
together one of these so while back as
uh when I didn't know about sidekick and
I was just starting boy it's a long
while back
and uh is playing high low how do you
play high low not get stuck in The
Valleys uh figure out these curves and
things like that while you do that and
the back end is all the calculus and
differential equations to calculate this
out the good news is you don't have to
do those
uh so instead we're going to put
together the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so uh guys in the back put together a
nice little piece of code here which is
kind of fun uh some things we're going
to note and this is this is really
important stuff because when you start
doing your data science and digging into
your machine learning models you're
going to find these things are stumbling
blocks the first one is current X where
do we start at keep in mind
your model that you're working with is
very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it the first question is where
do we start and we started at this
because the algorithm starts at x equals
three so we are arbitrarily picked five
learning rate is how many bars to skip
going one way or the other I'm in fact
I'm going to separate that a little bit
because these two are really important
if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about well
here's our here's the function we're
going to use our gradient of our
function 2 times X plus five keep it
simple so that's a function we're going
to work with so if I'm dealing with
increments of a thousand point one is
going to be a very long time and if I'm
dealing with increments of 0.001
0.1 is going to skip over my answer so I
won't get a very good answer and then we
look at Precision this tells us when to
stop the algorithm so again very
specific to what you're working on if
you're working with money
and you don't convert it into a float
value you might be dealing with 0.01
which is a penny that might be your
Precision you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size Max iterations we want something to
cut out at a certain point usually
that's built into a lot of minimization
functions and then here's our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go while previous
step size is greater than precision and
itters is less than Max and Max itters
say that 10 times fast
um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our Precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper and then we also don't want to go
past a thou or whatever this is a
million or 10 000 running that's
actually pretty high I almost never do
Max iterations more than like a 100 or
200 rare occasions you make up to four
or five hundred if it's uh depending on
the problem you're working with uh so we
have our previous equals our current
that way we can track time wise uh the
current now equals the current minus the
rate times the formula of our previous X
so now we've generated our new version
uh previous step size equals the
absolute current previous
so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
so we know to stop if we get too far and
then we're just going to print the local
minimum occurs at axon here and if we go
ahead and run this
uh you can see right here it gets down
to this point and it says hey
um local minimum is minus
3.322 for this particular series we
created and this is created off of our
formula here Lambda X2 times X Plus 5.
now
when I'm running this stuff you'll see
this come up a lot
in with the sklearn kit and one of the
nice reasons of breaking this down the
way we did is I could go over those top
pieces those top pieces are everything
when you start looking at these
minimization toolkits in built-in code
and so from
um we'll just do it's actually Docs
Dot
scipy.org and we're looking at
the scikit
there we go optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value you have
the function that's going in this
function can be very complicated so we
used a very simple function up here it
could be there's all kinds of things
that could be on there and there's a
number of methods to solve this as far
as how they shrink down and your X
naught there's your there's your start
value so your function your start value
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds some of this it does
automatically but you really the big
thing I want to point out here is you
need to have a starting point you want
to start with something that you already
know is mostly the answer if you don't
then it's going to have a heck of a time
trying to calculate it out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
ah so statistics well I guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an adult
class so a bunch of stuff going on
statistics statistics concerns with the
collection organization analysis
interpretation and presentation of data
that is a mouthful
um so we have from end to end where
where does it come from is it valid what
does it mean how do we organize it how
do we analyze it and then you got to
take those analysis and interpret it
into something that uh people can use
kind of reduce it to understandable and
nowadays you have to be able to present
it if you can't present it then no one
else is going to understand what the
heck you did
so we look at the terminologies
there is a lot of terminologies
depending on what domain you're working
in so clearly if you're working in a
domain that deals with
viruses and T cells and and how does you
know where does that come from and
you're studying the different people
then you can have a population if you
are working with
um
mechanical gear you know a little bit
different if you're looking for the
wobbling statistics to know when to
replace a rotor on a machine or
something like that that can be a big
deal you know we have these huge fans
that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit
uh an interesting project that came up
for our city a while back so population
all objects are measurements whose
properties are being observed uh so
that's your population all the objects
it's easy to see it with people because
we have our population in large but in
the case of these sewer fans we're
talking about having the fan units
that's the population of fans that we're
working with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied you don't want to do
them all because then you don't have a
if you come up with a conclusion for
everyone you don't have a way of testing
it so you take a sample sometimes you
don't have a choice you can only take a
sample of what's going on you can't
study the whole population and a
variable a metric of interest for each
person or object in a population
types of sampling we have a
probabilistic approach selecting samples
from a larger population using a method
based on the theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified and then you have
non-probabilistic approach selecting
samples based on the subjective Judgment
of the researcher rather than random
selection it has to do with convenience
trying to reach a quota or snowball
uh and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
it says biased uh so you gotta be very
careful on that
so probabilistic sampling uh when we
talk about a random sampling we select
random size samples from each group or
category so we it's as random as you can
get uh we talk about systematic sampling
we're selecting random size samples from
each group or category with a fixed
periodic interval
uh so we kind of split it up this would
be like a Time setup or our different
categories and you might ask your
question what is a category or a group
uh if you look at I'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying
economics of different of an area
we know pretty much that based on their
culture where they came from they might
need to be separated and so uh and when
I say separated I don't mean separated
from their their place where they live I
mean as far as the analysis we want to
look at the different groups and make
sure they're all represented
so if we had like an 80 uh of a group
that is uh say Hispanic and or Indian
and also in that same area we have 20 20
who are let's call our expatriates they
left America and they're nice and uh
your Caucasian group we might want to
sample a group that is representative of
both uh so we're talking about
stratified sampling and we're talking
about groups those are the groups we're
talking about and that brings us to
stratified sampling selecting
approximately equal size samples from
each group or category
uh this way we can actually separate the
categories and give us an insight into
the different cultures and how that
might affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of depends on what you're
working with as far as your data and
what you're studying and so we can see
here just a little bit more we'd have
selecting 25 employees from a company of
250 employees randomly don't care
anything about them what groups are in
which office they're in nothing
uh and we might be selecting one
employee from every 50 unique employees
in a company of 250 employees and then
we have selecting one employee from
every branch in the company office so we
have all the different branches there's
our group or our categories by the
branch and the category could depend on
what you're studying so it has a lot of
variation on there you see this kind of
grouping and categorizing is also used
to generate a lot of misinformation
uh so if you only study one group and
you say this is what it is then
everybody assumes that's what it is for
everybody and so you've got to be very
careful of that and it's very unethical
thing to kind of do
so types of Statistics we talk about
statistics we're going to talk about
descriptive and inferential statistics
there are so many different terms and
statistics to break it up so we so we're
talking about a particular
setup so we're talking about descriptive
and inferential uh statistics the base
of the word describe is pretty solid
you're describing the data what does it
look like with inferential statistics
we're going to take that from the small
population to a large population so if
you're working with a drug company you
might look at the data and say these
people were helped by this drug they did
80 better as far as their health or 80
percent better survival rate than the
people
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people so
that's where you get your inferential so
we are predicting how it's going to
affect the greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative analysis
of data
so we have a measure of central
Tendencies we have your mean median and
mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance in your standard deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second but one
of them you can think of is
how the data difference
differences you know what's the max Min
range all that stuff is your spread and
anything that's just a single number is
usually your central Tendencies measure
of central tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of
whatever's going on
and then your median separates the
higher half and the lower half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points so your mean might
have some a couple really big numbers
that skew it so that the average is much
higher than if you took those outliers
out where the median would by separating
the high from the low might give you a
much lower number you might look at and
say oh that's that's odd Y is the
average so much higher than the median
well it's because you have some outliers
or why is it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value this is really
interesting if you're studying economics
and how people are doing you might find
that the most common
income like in the U.S was at one point
twenty four thousand a year
where the average was closer to 80 000
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that way up so the
average person is not making that kind
of money and then you look at the median
income and you're like well the median
income is a little bit closer to the
average so it does create a very
interesting way of looking at the data
again these are all uh Central
Tendencies single numbers you can look
at for the whole spread of the data
and we look at the measure of central
Tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a student's in a classroom so here we
have the mean some of the marks of the
students total number of students and as
we talked about the median if we have 0
through 10 and we take half the numbers
and put them on one side of the line
half the numbers on the other side of
the line we end up with five in the
middle and then the mode what Mark was
scored by most of the students in a test
in a simple case where most people
scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out uh not so easy when you have
different areas where like you have like
the um oh let's go back to economy a
little bit more difficult to calculate
if you have a large group of scores that
makes 30 000 and a slightly bigger group
that makes twenty six thousand so what
do you put down for the mode uh
certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually a
different variations depending on what
you're doing so now we're looking at a
measure of spread uh range what's the
difference between the highest and the
lowest value first thing you want to
look at you know it's uh we had
everybody in the test score between 60
and 100 percent so we got 100 or maybe
60 to 90 percent it was so hard that a
lot of people could not get a hundred
percent
um you have your interquartile range
quartiles divide a rank ordered data set
into four equal parts
very common thing to do is part of all
the basic packages whether you're
working in uh data frames with pandas
whether you're working in Scala whether
you're working in R you'll see this come
up where they have range your Min your
Max and then it'll have your
interquartile range how does it look
like in each quarter of data variance
measures how far each number in the set
is from the mean and therefore from
every other number in the set
uh so you have like how much turbulence
is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation it is a
measure the variance or the dispersion
of a set of values from the mean
and you'll usually see if I'm doing a
graph I might have the value graphed and
then based on the the error I might grab
graph the standard deviation in the
error on the graph as a background so
you can see how far off it is so
standard deviation is used a lot
so measurement of spread marks of a
student out of 100 we have here from 50
to 63 or 50 to 90 so the range maximum
marks minimum marks we have 90 to 45 and
the spread of that is 45 90 minus 45 and
then we have the interquartile range
using the same marks over there you can
see here where the median is and then
there's a first quarter the second
quarter and the third quarter based on
splitting it apart by those values and
to understand the variance and standard
deviation we first need to find out the
mean so here's our you know calculating
the average there we end up
approximately 66 for the average and
then we look at that in the variance
once we know the means we can do equals
the marks minus the mean squared Y is a
squared because one you want to make
sure it's you don't have like if you if
you're putting all this stuff together
you end up with an error as far as one's
negative one's positive one's a little
higher one's a little lower uh so you
always see the squared value and over
the total observations and so the
standard deviation equals the square
root of the variance which is
approximately 16. and if you were
looking at a predictable model you would
be looking at the deviation based on the
error how much error does it have that's
again really important to know if you're
if your prediction is predicting
something what's a chance of it being
way off or just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the tools as
far as some of the basics for doing your
statistics and what we're talking about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
Python code so you can get some little
Hands-On here for that let's go back
into our Jupiter notebook in Python now
almost all of this you can do in numpy
last time we worked in numpy this time
we're going to go ahead and use pandas
and if you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns let's just go ahead and do a
print df.head
and run that
and you can see we have the name Jane
Michael William Rosie Hannah sat in
their salaries on here and of course
instead of having to do all those hand
calculations and add everything together
and divide by the total we can do
something very simple on this uh like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
I go ahead and do this print DF pick our
column salary because we want to find
the means of that calorie
we want to find the means of that column
and we go ahead and print this out and
you can see that the average income on
here is 71
000.
and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is very similar
except it actually is just median we're
used to means in average it's kind of
interesting that those are they use the
two different words
there can be in some computation slight
differences but for the most part the
means is the average and then the median
whoops let's put a
medium here do you have salary that way
it displays a little better we can see
the median is 54
000. so the halfway mark is
significantly below the average why
because we have somebody in here who
makes 189 000. darn you Rosie for
throwing off our numbers but that's
something you'd want to notice this is
this is the difference between these is
huge and so is what is the meaning
behind that when you're studying a
populist and looking at the different
data coming in and of course we also
want to find out hey what's the most
common
income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at fifty thousand
so this is this is very telling that
most people are making 50 000 the middle
point is at fifty four thousand so half
the people are making more than that
what that tells me is that if the most
common income is way is below the median
then
there's a few there's a you know there's
a lot of high salaries going up but
there's some really low salaries in
there and so this trend which is very
common in statistic and when you're in
analyzing the economy in different
people's income is pretty common and the
bigger difference between these is also
very important when we're studying
statistics and when you hear someone
just say hey the average income was you
might start asking questions at that
point why aren't you talking about the
median income why aren't you talking
about the mode the most common income
what are you hiding and if you're doing
these analysis you should be looking at
these saying hey why this discrepancies
why are these so different and of course
with any analysis it's important to find
out the minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply uh
um dot min
so pull up your minimum and then dot Max
pulls up the maximum pretty
straightforward on as far as
translating it and knowing what you're
you know put the your lowest value and
what your highest value is here which
you'll use to generate like a spread
later on and real quick on no mode uh
note that it puts mode zero like I said
there's a couple different ways you can
compute the mode
um although the standard one's pretty
good we can of course do the range which
is your max minus your Min so now we
have a range of 149 000 between the
upper end and the lower end and you
might want to be looking up the
individual values on all of these but
turns out there is a describe
feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do DF
salary describe and if we do this you
can see we have that there's seven
setups here's our mean our standard
deviation which we didn't compute yet
which would just be a DOT STD and you
gotta be a little careful because when
it computes it it looks for axes and
things like that we have our minimum
value and here's our quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary uh so these are these are
the basic statistics you can pull them
up and like just describe this is a
dictionary so I could actually do
something like um
and here I could actually go uh count
and run and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information and
then split it up depending on what you
need now if I just walked in and gave
you this information in a meeting
at some point you would just kind of
fall asleep that's what I would do
anyway
um so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here we'll go ahead and put
it into a histogram and plot that graph
on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here so
we do our matplot inline remember that's
a Jupiter's notebook thing a lot of the
new version of the matplot library does
it automatically but just in case I
always put it in there import matplot
library pipelot is PLT that's my
plotting
and then we have our data frame I guess
I really don't need to respell the data
frame maybe we could just remind
ourselves what's in it so we'll go ahead
and just print
DF that way we still have it and then we
have our salary DF salary salary.plot
history title salary distribution color
gray
uh plot axvline salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet line style Dash this is
just all making it pretty
uh what color dash line line width of
two that kind of thing and the median
and let's go ahead and run this just so
you can see what we're talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
so here's the data here's our our data
frame printed out so you can see it with
the salaries we'll look at the salary
distribution and just look at this the
way there the salary is distributed
um you have our in this case we did
Let's see we had red for the median
we have violet
for our average or mean and you can just
see how it really here's our outlier
here's our person who makes a lot of
money here's the average and here's the
median
um and so as you look at this you can
see wow based on the average it really
doesn't tell you much about what people
are really taking home all it does is
tell you how much money is in this you
know what the average salary is
so some of the things you want to take
away in addition to this is that it's
very easy to plot
um
an axv line these are these up and down
lines for your markers
um and as you just display the data I
mean you can add all kinds of things to
this and get really complicated keeping
it simple is pretty straightforward I
look at this and I can see we have a
major outlier out here we can definitely
do a histogram and stuff like that but
you know pictures worth a thousand words
what you really want to make sure you
take away is that we can do a basic
describe which pulls all this
information out and we can print any of
the individual information from the
describe because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
the mean value we can also do describe
means if you're doing a lot of
Statistics being able to
doesn't have the print on there so it's
only going to print the last one which
happens to be the mean you can very
easily reference any one of these and
then you can also if you're doing
something a little bit more complicated
and you don't need just the basics you
can come through and pull any one of the
individual
um
references from the from the pandas on
here so now we've had a chance to
describe our data uh let's get into
inferential statistics inferential
statistics allows you to make
predictions or inferences from data and
you can see here we have a nice little
picture movie ratings and
um if we took this group of people and
said hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say and then you ask
just a random person who comes out of
the movie who hasn't been in the study
you can infer that 55 chance of saying
liked 35 chance of saying disliked or a
10 or 11 chance of can't say so that's
real basics of what we're talking about
is you're going to infer that the next
person is going to follow these
statistics
uh so let's look at Point estimation it
is a process of finding an approximate
value for a population's parameter like
mean or average from random samples of
the population let's take an example of
testing vaccines for covid-19 vaccines
and flu bugs all that it's a pretty big
thing of how do you test these out and
make sure they're going to work on the
populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population so here's a protected there's
our small group up here where we've
selected them we run medical trials on
them and then the results work for the
population a nice diagram with the
arrows going back and forth in the very
scary covet virus in the middle of one
and let's take a look at the
applications of inferential statistics
very Central is what they call
hypotheses testing and the confidence
interval which go with that and then as
we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem
hypothesis testing hypothesis testing is
used to measure the plausibility of a
hypothesis assumption by using sample
data now when we talk about theorems
Theory
hypothesis keep in mind that if you are
in a philosophy class theory is the same
as hypothesis where theorem is a
scientific uh statement that is
something that has been proven although
it is always up for debate because in
science we always want to make sure
things are up to debate so a hypothesis
is the same as a philosophical class
calling a theory where theory in science
is not the same theory in science says
this has been well proven gravity is a
theory so if you want to debate the
theory of gravity try jumping up and
down if you want to have a theory about
why the economy is collapsing in your
area that is a philosophical debate very
important I've heard people mix those up
and it is a pet peeve of mine when we
talk about hypotheses testing the steps
involved in hypotheses testing is first
we formulate a hypothesis
we figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test and we
make a decision and so when you're
talking about hypothesis you're usually
trying to disprove it if you can't
disprove it and it works for all the
facts then you might call that a theorem
at some point
so in a use case let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves they
did so by making four chits which has
their names on it and the name that gets
picked up has to do the cleaning for
that day Rob took the opportunity to
make chits and wrote everyone's name on
it so here's our four people Nick Rob
imlia imlia and summer
now Rick Emilia and summer are asking us
to decide whether Rob has done some
Mischief in preparing the chits I.E
whether Rob has written his name on one
of the chit for that we will find out
the probability of Rob getting the
cleaning job on first day second day
third day and so on till 12 days the
probability of Rob getting the job
decreases every day I.E his turn never
comes up then definitely he has done
some Mischief while making the chits so
the probability of Rob not doing work on
day one is three out of four there's a
0.75 chance that he didn't do work uh
two days three fourths times
three-fourths equals 0.56
three days you have three fours three
four three fours which equals 0.42
uh when you get to day 12 it's 0.032
Which is less than 0.05 remember this
.05 that comes up a lot when we're
talking about certain values when we're
looking at statistics Rob is cheating as
he wasn't chosen for 12 consecutive days
that's a very high probability when on
day 12 he still hasn't gotten the job
cleaning the room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies we have null hypothesis
a general statement that states that
there is no relationship between two
measured phenomenon or no association
among the groups
alternative hypothesis contrary to the
null hypothesis it states whenever
something is happening a new theory is
preferred instead of an old one and so
the two hypotheses go hand in hand uh so
your null this is always interesting in
in when talking about data science and
the math behind it it's about proving
that the things have no correlation null
hypothesis says these two have zero
relation to each other where the
alternative hypothesis says hey we found
a relation this is what it is
we have p-value the p-value is a
probability of finding the observed or
more extreme results when the null
hypotheses of a study question is true
and the T value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error the greater the
magnitude of T the greater the evidence
against the null hypothesis and you can
look at the T values being specific to
the test you're doing
where the p-value is derived from your T
value and you're looking for what is
called a five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so digging in deeper let's assume that a
new drug is developed with the goal of
lowering the blood pressure more than
the existing drug and this is a good one
because the null value here isn't that
you don't have any drug then null value
here is it is better than existing drug
the new drug doesn't lower the blood
pressure more than the existing drug
now if we get that that says our null
hypothesis is correct there is no
correlation and the new drug is not
doing its job the alternative hypothesis
the new drug does significantly lower
the blood pressure more than an existing
drug uh yay we got a new drug out there
and that's our alternative hypothesis or
the H1 or ha
when we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trials showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis and again they're
looking for a 0.05 or 5 percent and the
T value comparing all the positive test
results and finding means of different
samples in order to test hypothesis so
this is specific to the test how what
percentage of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals a confidence interval is a
range of values we are sure our true
values of observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of food
do you buy for your per year for your
dog
through calculations you've got to know
that the on an average around 95 percent
of the people bought around 200 to 300
cans of food hence we can say that we
have a confidence interval of 2 300
where 95 percent of our values lie in
that data spread and this the graph
really helps a lot so you can start
seeing what you're looking at here we
have the 95 percent you have your peak
in this case it's a normal distribution
so you have the nice bell curve equal on
both sides it's not asymmetrical and 95
percent of all the values lie within a
very small range and then you have your
outliers the 2.5 percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis and we're
going to move into probability uh so you
have your hypothesis once you've
generated your hypothesis we want to
know the probability of something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence so any
event cannot be predicted with total
certainty can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence score
prediction how good you're going to do
in whatever sport you're in weather
prediction stock prediction if you've
studied physics and Chaos Theory even
the location of the chair you're sitting
on has a probability that it might move
three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh I think we calculated as under one in
trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability that we don't see them so we
talk about random variable a random
variable is a variable whose possible
values are numerical outcomes of a
random phenomena so we have the coin
toss how many heads will occur in the
series of 20 coin flips probably you
know the on average they're 10 but you
really can't know because it's very
random how many times a red ball is
picked from a bag of balls if there's
equal number of red balls and blue balls
and green balls in there how many times
the sum of digits on two dice results
are five each
um so you know there's how often you're
going to roll two fives on your pair of
Dives
so in a use case let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y you can
take values two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice and instead of
looking at how many times both dice for
roll five let's go ahead and look at
total sum of five and you have in as far
as your random variables you can have a
one four equals five four one two three
three two
so four of those roles can be four if
you look at all the different options
you have four of those random roles can
be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
uh you can see that we have four out of
36 chance every time you roll the dice
that you're going to roll a total of
five you're gonna have an outcome of
five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means but you could think of
that at what point if someone never
rolls a five or they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating we'll look a little closer at
the math behind that but let's just
consider this is one of the cases is
rolling two dice and gambling
there's also a binomial distribution it
is the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial so passing or filling an exam
winning or losing a game and getting
either head or tails so if you ever see
binomial distribution it's based on a
true false kind of setup you win or lose
let's consider a use case and let's
consider the game of football between
two clubs Barcelona and Dortmund the
teams will have to play a total of four
matches and we have to find out the
chances of Barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches let's say that the winning
chance for Barcelona is 75 or 0.75 that
means at each game they have a 75 chance
that they're going to win that game and
losing chances are 25 or 0.25 clearly
0.75 plus 0.25 equals one so that
accounts for 100 of the game probability
for getting K wins in in matches is
calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games uh and you want to know if I
play
um how many wins in those five games
should I get what's a percentage on
those and the probability for getting K
wins and in matches is calculated by p x
equals k equals nck P to the k q to the
N minus K here p is a probability of
success and Q is the probability of
failure and so we can do total games of
n equals five where k equals zero one
two three four five P which is the
chance of winning is 0.75 Q the chance
of losing equals 1 minus P which equals
1 minus 0.075 which equals 0.25 the
probability that Barcelona will lose all
of the matches can then just plug in the
numbers and we end up with a point zero
zero zero nine seven six five six two
five so very small chance they're going
to lose all their matches
and we can plug in the value for two
matches probability of Barcelona will
win at least two matches is 0.0878 and
of course we can go on to the
probability of the Barcelona will win
three matches the 0.26 and of course
four matches and so on and it's always
nice to take this information
um and let's find the accumulated
discrete probabilities for each of the
outcomes where Barcelona has won three
or more matches x equals three x equals
four x equals five
and we end up with the p equals 0.264
plus 0.395 plus 237 which equals 0.89
in reality
the probability of Barcelona winning the
series is much higher than 0.75 and it's
always nice to uh
put out a nice graph so you can actually
see the number of wins to the
probability and how that pans out with
our binomial case
continuing in our important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean value and
this is some very important things so
much of the data we look at and when you
start looking at probabilities almost
always has a normalized look like the
graph in the middle
uh but you do have left skewed where the
data is skewed off to the left and you
have more stuff happening out to the
left and you have right skewed data and
so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed it's really important to take a
closer look at that mostly you end up
with a normalized set of data but you
got to also be aware that sometimes it's
a skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out and if the standard
deviation is small then most of your
data is going to hit right there in the
middle you can have a nice Peak and so
being aware of this that you might have
a probability that fits certain data but
it has a lot of outliers so you're if
you have a really high standard
deviation
if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money where
if you have a very small deviation you
might be right on Target and set to
become a millionaire which leads us to
the z-score z-score tells you how far
from the mean a data point is it is
measured in terms of standard deviations
from the mean around 68 percent of the
results are found between one standard
deviation around 95 percent of the
results are found between two standard
deviations and you read the symbols of
course they love to throw some Greek
letters in there we have mu minus two
Sigma mu is just a quick way it's that
kind of funky you it just means the mean
and then the sigma is the standard
deviation and that's the o with that
little arrow off to the right or the
little waggly Tail Going Up deal with it
with a line on it some U minus 2 Sigma
is your 95 of the results are found
between two standard deviations Central
limit theorem this goes back to the skew
if you remember we were looking at the
skew values on this previous slide have
left skewed normalized and right skewed
when we're talking about it being skewed
or not skewed the distribution of the
sample means will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed if you take large random
samples from the population with the
mean mu and the standard deviation Sigma
with replacement
and you can see here of course we have
our mu minus two Sigma and the spread
down here the mean the median and the
mode and so you're talking about very
large populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value if you
do that's a flag that something's wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from and
the math behind it and if you're going
to do all this we've got to jump into
conditional probability
the conditional probability of an event
a is a probability that the event will
occur given the knowledge that an event
to be has already occurred and you'll
see this as Bayes theorem b-a-y-e-s Bays
and this is red
I mean you have these funky looking
little p brackets a b this is the
probability of a being true while B is
already true
and you have the probability of B being
true when a is already true so P B of A
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of B being true
and we talk about Bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important formula and it's really it's
not if you actually do the math you
could just kind of do
um
um x y equals J K and then you divide
them out and you're going to see the
same math but it works with
probabilities which makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
uh eight or nine different studies going
on in different areas different people
have done the studies they brought them
together
if we look at today's covet virus the
virus spread certainly the studies done
in China versus the studies the way
they're done in the U.S that data is
different in each of those studies but
if you can find a place where it
overlaps where they're studying the same
thing together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of one group and you want to find
out more about it so this formula is
very powerful and it really has to do
with the data collection part of the
math and data science and understanding
where your data is coming from and how
you're going to combine different
studies in different groups
and we're going to go into a use case
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease due to smoking and
this is kind of interesting the way they
word this let's say that according to
medical report provided by the hospital
states that around 10 percent of all
patients they treated suffered long lung
disease so we have kind of a generic
medical report they further found out by
a survey that 15 percent of the patients
that visit them smoke
so we have 10 percent that are lung
disease and 15 percent of the patients
smoke and finally five percent of the
people continued smoke even when they
had lung disease not the brightest
choice but you know it is an addiction
so it can be really difficult to kick
and so we can look at the probability of
a uh prior probability of 10 people
having lung disease
and then probability B probability that
a patient smokes is 15 percent
uh and the probability of B if B then a
the probability of a patient smokes even
though they have lung disease is five
percent
and probability of a is B probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke and then when you put the
formulas together you get a nice
solution here you get the probability of
a of B probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a 3.33 percent chance
hence there is a 3.33 chance that a
person who smokes will get a lung
disease
so we're gonna pull up a little python
code and we're always my favorite roll
up the sleeves
keep in mind we're going to be doing
this
um kind of like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create
um we'll get into another demo which
shows you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this
let's start by creating a set so we're
going to create a set with curly braces
this means that our set has only unique
values so you have a list you have your
tuples which can never change and then
you have in this case the the set so
four seven you can't create a four seven
comma four it'll delete the four out so
it's only unique values and if you use
dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary where you
have a value and that value is assigned
to or that key is assigned to a value
uh so you could have a key value set up
as a dictionary so it's like a
dictionary without the value it's just
the keys and they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a set of four
seven
we can also take a list of regular setup
and I'm going to go ahead and just throw
in another number in here four
and run it and you can see here if I
take my list one two three four four and
I convert it to a set and here it is my
set from list equals set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and print here is my set my set
three is in the set and then if you do
three in my set
that's going to be a logic function uh
and one in my set 6 is not in the set
and so forth if we run this
we get three is in the set true one is
in the set false because three five
seven is another one six is in the set 6
is not in the set so not in my set
you can also use this with a list we
could have just used 357 and it would
have the same response on there is three
and usually you do if three is in but
three in my set is still works on just a
regular list
and we'll go ahead and do a little
iteration we're going to do kind of the
dice one remember
um uh one two three four five six and so
we're going to bring in an iteration
tool and import product as product
and I'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values uh
you can only have one value for each one
that's why they put it in a set and if
you remember from range it is up to
seven so this is going to be one two
three four five six it will not include
the seven and the same thing for our
dice B
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product
of A and B so what's a plus b
and if we go ahead and run this it'll
print that out and you'll see in this
case when they say product because it's
an iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two so we've now created a tuple of
all possible outcomes of the dice where
dice a is one two three one to six and
dice B is one to six and you can see one
to one one to two one to three and so
forth you remember we had a slide on
this earlier where we talked about
um the different all the different
outcomes of a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit uh we can do in dice equals two dice
faces one two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space where we have a set which is the
product of the dice faces repeat equals
in dice and we're going to just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here and print them all out like
we had before we can just go through
four outcome and event space outcome and
equals
so the event space is creating
uh sequence and as you can see here when
we print it out it Stacks them versus
going through and putting them in a nice
line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print
since we have the End Printing with a
comma that just means it's just gonna
it's not going to hit the return going
down to the next line and we'll go ahead
and do the links
of our event space uh I'll be a
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course they get carried away with
my typing of length I will print it
twice it'll give me an error so we have
36 different possible variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like what about the multiple of three
what if we want to have
the probability of the multiple of three
in our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space of X Y
equals outcome if X Plus y
remainder three so we're going to divide
by 3 and look at the remainder and it
equals zero
then it's a fable outcome we're going to
pop that outcome on the end there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set not necessary
because we know it's not going to be
repeating itself but just in case we'll
go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
multiples of three one plus two is three
five plus four is nine which divided by
three is three and so forth
and just like we looked up the links uh
of the one before let's go ahead and
print
the length
of our F outcome so we can see what that
looks like
there we go
and of course I did forget to add the
print in the middle because We're
looping through and putting an end on
the on the setup on there so we're going
to put the print in there and if I run
this you can see uh
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
we have 12 that are multiple that add up
to a multiple of three
and we can easily convert the
probability of this by simply taking the
length of our favorable outcome over the
length of the event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there probability
last lines we just type it in we end up
with the 0.33333 chance
and it's roughly a third
and we might want to make this look nice
so let's go ahead and put in another
line there the probability of getting
the sum which is a multiple of three is
0.33333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it you can see we just have a
huge amount of choices so just goes on
and on down here and we can look at the
length of the event space
and we have over
776 choices that's a lot of choices
if we want to ask the question like we
did above uh what is the sum where the
sum is a multiple of five but not a
multiple of three
we can go through all of these different
options and then you can see here D1 D2
D3 D4 D5 equals the outcome and if you
add these all together and they're
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero but the remainder is
also of a division by three is not equal
to zero so the multiple of five is equal
to zero but the multiple three is not we
can just append that on here and then we
can look at that uh favorable outcome
we'll go ahead and set that and we'll
just take a look at this what's our
length
of our favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
6 and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll a multiple of five
when you add them together
but not a multiple of three
and so we're just going to divide those
two numbers and you can see here we get
0.116255 or 11.62 percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not really complicated in
math right here on probabilities it's
just how many options do you have and
how many of those are you possibly going
to be able to come up with with the
solution you're looking for and this
leads us to a confusion Matrix
a confusion Matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the True Values are known
and so you'll see on the left we have
the predicted and the actual and we have
a negative false negative positive true
positive
and then we have false positive and true
negative and you can think of this as
your predicted model what does that mean
that means if you divided your data and
you used two-third of us to create the
model you might then test it against an
actual case for the last third to see
how well it comes out how many times was
it true positive versus uh false
positive again a false positive response
and you can imagine in medical
situations this is a pretty big deal you
don't want to give a false positive so
you might adjust your model accordingly
so you don't have a false positive say
with a covet virus test it'd be better
to have a false negative and they go
back and get retested then to have
thirty percent false positives where
then the test is pretty much invalid so
in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example where a cancer
prediction model is put to the test for
its accuracy and precision actual result
of a person's medical report is compared
with the prediction made by the machine
learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a false positive
I mean a false negative in other words
you don't want to have it tell you that
you don't have cancer when you do so
that would be something you'd really be
looking for in this particular domain
you don't want a false negative
and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of pieces of data
that come in there's a real famous case
study where they have the imagery and
all the measurements they take and
there's about 36 different measurements
they take and then if you run the a
basic model you want to know just how
accurate is how many negative results do
you have that are either telling people
they have cancer that don't or telling
people that don't have cancer that they
do and then we can take these numbers
and we can feed them into our accuracy
our precision and our recall
so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted
and this is your total true where you
got the right results you add them
together the true positive the true
negative over all the results so what
percentage of them were accurate versus
what were wrong
we're talking about Precision is a
metric to measure how many of the
correctly predicted cases are actually
turned out to be positive
uh so we have a Precision on true
positive again if you're talking about
like uh coveted testing with the viruses
uh you really want this to be a high
number you want this true that to be the
center point where you might have the
opposite if you're dealing with cancer
where you want no false negatives
uh so this is your metric on here
Precision is your test positive uh true
positive plus false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model uh so
test positive is the test positive plus
the false negative on there and we'll
want to go ahead and do a demo on the
naive Bayes classifier before I get too
far into uh naive Bay's classifier
because we're going to pull it from the
SK learn or the PSI kit let's go ahead
kind of an interesting page here for
classifiers when you go into the SK
learn kit there's a lot of ways to do
classification and I'll just zoom up in
here so you can see some of the titles
uh there's everything from the nearest
neighbor linear
but we're going to be focusing on the
naive Bayes over here and this is just a
sample data set that they put together
and you can see how some of these have a
very different output the naive Bayes
remember is set up as probably the most
simplified calculator or setup sections
out there and so what we've been talking
about with the true false and stuff like
that where there's a
an A belief that there is a independent
assumption between the features where
the features are very assumed to have
some kind of connection then we can go
ahead and use that for the prediction
and so that's what we're using is a
naive Bayes classifier versus many of
the other classifiers that are out there
for this we're going to use uh The
Social Network ads it's a little data
set on here and let me go and just open
that up the file
here we go it has user ID gender age
estimated salary uh purchased and so we
have you can see the user ID mail 19
estimated salary 19000 and purchase zero
so it's either going to make a purchase
or not so look at that last one zero one
we should be thinking of binomials we
should be thinking of a simple naive
Bayes classifier kind of setup
so if we close this out we're going to
go ahead and import our numpy as NP
would be nice to have a good visual of
our data so we'll put in our matplot
library
here's our pandas our data frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the data set and the data set is
going to be we're going to read it from
the
socialnetworkads.csv then we're going to
print the head just so you can see it
again even though I showed you it in the
file and x equals the data set I
location two three values and Y is going
to be the 4 column four let me just run
this so it's a little easier to go over
that you can see right here we're going
to be looking at 0 1 2 is age and
estimated salary so 2 3
and that's what I location just means um
that we're looking at the number versus
a regular location a regular location
you'd actually say age and estimated
salary
and then column four is did they make a
purchase they purchased something
uh so those are the three columns we're
going to be looking at when we do this
and we've gone ahead and imported these
and imported the data so now our data
set is all set with this information in
it
and we'll need to go ahead and split the
date up so we need our from the SK learn
model selection we can import train test
split this does a nice job we can set
the random state so it randomly picks
the data and we're just going to take 25
percent of it's going to go into the
test our X test and our y test and the
75 percent will go to x train and Y
train that way once we create our model
we can then have data to see just how
accurate or how well it has performed
with our prediction
the next step in pre-processing our data
is to go ahead and do feature scaling
now a lot of this to start to look
familiar if you've done a number of the
other modules in setup you should start
noticing that we bring in our data we
take a look at what we're working with
we go ahead and split it up into
training and testing
uh in this case we're going to go ahead
and scale it scale it means we're
putting it between a value of minus one
and one or someplace in the Middle
Ground there this way if you have any
huge set you don't have this huge setup
if we go back up to here where salary
salary is 20 000 versus age 35. well
there's a good chance with a lot of the
back end math that 20 000 will skew the
results and the estimated salary will
have a higher impact than the age
instead of balancing them out and
letting the calculations weigh them
properly
and finally we get to actually create
our naive Bayes model
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the gaussian naive Bayes
and the gaussian is is the most basic
one that's what we're looking at now it
turns out though if you go to the SK
learn kit they have a number of
different ones you can pull in there
there's a
um Bernoulli I don't know I've never
used that one categorical
um complement and here's our gaussian so
there's a number of different options
you can look at gaussian when you come
to the naive Bayes is the most commonly
used so we're talking about the naive
Bayes that's usually what people are
talking about when they when they're
pulling this in and one of the nice
things about the gaussian if you go to
their website to sklearn the naibes
gaussian there's a lot of cool features
one of them is you can do partial fit on
here that means if you have a huge
amount of data you don't have to process
it all at once once you can batch it
into the gaussian NB model and there's
many other different things you can do
with it as far as fitting the data and
how you manipulate it
we're just doing the basics so we're
going to go ahead and create our
classifier we're going to equal the
gaussian NB
and then we're going to do a fit we're
going to fit our training data and our
training solution so X train y train
and we'll go ahead and run this and it's
going to tell us that it ran the code
right there
and now we have our trained classifier
model
so the next step is we need to go ahead
and run a prediction we're going to do
our y predict equals the
classifier.predict X test so here we fit
the data and now we're going to go ahead
and predict
and now we get to our confusion Matrix
so from the SK learn Matrix metrics you
can import your confusion Matrix
just as saves you from doing all the
simple math that does it all for you and
then we'll go ahead and create our
confusion metrics with the Y test and
the Y predict so we have our actual and
we have our predicted value
and you can see from here this is the
chart we looked at here's predicted so
true positive false positive false
negative true negative
and if we go ahead and run this there we
have it 65 3725
and in this particular prediction we had
65 or predicted the truth as far as a
purchase they're going to make a
purchase and we guess three wrong
and then we had 25 we predicted would
not purchase and seven of them did so
there's our our confusion Matrix
at this point if you were with your
shareholders or a board meeting you
would start to hear some snoozing if
they were looking at the numbers and you
say hey here's my confusion Matrix
so let's go ahead and visualize the
results
we're going to pull from the matplot
library colors import listed color map
and this is actually my machine's going
to throw an error because this is being
um
because of the way the setup is I have a
newer version on here than when they put
together the demo and we need our x set
and our y set which is our X train and Y
train
and then we'll create our X1 X2
and we'll put that into a grid and we
set our xset minimum stop and our xat
Max stop and if we come all the way over
here we're going to step 0.01 this is
going to give us a nice line is what
that's doing and then we're going to
plot the Contour plot the X limit plot
the Y limit and put the scatter plot in
there let's go ahead and run this uh to
be honest when I'm doing these graphs
there's so many different ways to do
that there's so many different ways to
put this code together
to show you what we're doing it's a lot
easier to pull up the graph and then go
back up and explain it
so the first thing we want to note here
when we're looking at the data
is this is the training set
and so we have those who didn't make a
purchase we've drawn a nice area for
that that's defined by the naive Bayes
setup and then we have those who did
make a purchase the green and you can
see that some of the green Drops Fall
Into the red area and some of the red
dots fall into the green
so even our training set isn't going to
be a hundred percent we couldn't do that
and so we're looking at our different
data coming down
we can kind of arrange our X1 X2 so we
have a nice plot going on and then we're
going to create the Contour
that's that nice line that's drawn down
the middle on here with the red green
that's where that's what this is doing
right here with the reshape and notice
that we had to uh
do the dot T if you remember from numpy
if you did the numpy module you end up
with pairs you know X X1 X2 X 1 X2 next
row and so forth you have to flip it so
it's all one row we have all your X ones
and all your x2s so that's what we're
kind of looking for right here on this
setup
uh and then the scatter plot is of
course your scattered data across there
we're just going through all the points
that puts these nice little dots onto
our setup on here and we have our
estimated salary and our age and then of
course the dots are did they make a
purchase or not
and just a quick note this is kind of
funny you can see up here where it says
xset yset equals x train y train which
seems kind of a little weird to do
this is because this is probably
originally a definition so it's this own
module that could be called over and
over again
and which is really a good way to do it
because the next thing we're going to
want to do is do the exact same thing
but we're going to visualize the test
set results that way we can see what
happened with our test group our 25
percent
and you can see down here we have the
test set and it if you look at the two
graphs next to each other this one
obviously has 75 percent of the data so
it's going to show a lot more
this is only 25 percent of the data you
can see that there's a number that are
kind of on the edge as to whether they
could guess by age and income they're
going to make a purchase or not but that
said it still is pretty clear it's
pretty good as far as how much the
estimate is and how good it does
now graphs are really effective for
showing people what's going on but you
also need to have the numbers and so
we're going to do from sklearn we're
going to import metrics
and then we're going to print our
metrics classification Port from the Y
test and the Y predict
and you can see here we have Precision
Precision of zeros is 90 there's our
recall
0.96 we have an F1 score and a support
and we have our Precision the recall on
getting it right and then we can do our
accuracy the macro average and the
weighted average so you can see it it
pulls in pretty good as far as how
accurate it is you could say it's going
to be about 90 percent is going to guess
correctly
um that it that they're not going to
purchase and we had an 89 chance that
they are going to purchase and then the
other numbers as you get down
have a little bit different meaning but
it's pretty straightforward on here
here's our accuracy and here's our micro
average and the weighted average and
everything else you might need and if
you forgot the exact definition of
accuracy it is the true positive true
negative over all of the different
setups Precision is your true positive
overall positives true and false and
recall is a true positive over truth
positive plus false negative
and we can just real quick flip back
there
so you can see those numbers on here uh
here's our Precision here's our recall
and here's our accuracy on this and with
that we have reached the end of day one
in our data science Journey on day two
that is tomorrow we are going to learn
about our programming for data science
thank you all for watching this live
session I hope this was useful and
informative goodbye and keep learning